in this massive course you will go from
having no coding experience to having
the essential skills of a front-end
developer you will learn various
front-end technologies and build a few
projects along the way zach golwitzer
teaches this course
zack is an experienced software engineer
and full stack developer hey everyone my
name is zach and today in this 20 plus
hour course i'm going to take you
through the core foundations of
front-end web development
now before i get into what that actually
entails i wanted to spend a minute to
thank free codecamp for having me on the
channel it's always a privilege to share
my content with such a broad audience
reach so many different people and i
genuinely hope that you find this course
helpful
if you do be sure to give them a big
thumbs up and a subscribe they're an
awesome channel contributed to a lot of
my early learnings as a web developer so
without further ado let's get into it
the first thing that i wanted to start
off with is some background context
because a lot of the content within this
course was obviously not filmed all at
once it's quite long
it's something that i worked on over the
course of a year
pieced it together lesson by lesson
and a lot of the content is on my
youtube channel
just separated out into different videos
i wanted to compile it all together
as it does follow a very logical
sequence from start to end
and it's perfect for the complete
beginner
so this should take you from never
having written a single line of code in
your life to having at least a solid
grasp of what coding languages are
particularly javascript and what is web
development particularly front-end web
development you should be able to build
basic web pages and understand basic
fundamentals of coding after this course
is complete while this course is mainly
geared for the complete beginner some of
the later chapters of it where we get
into css flexbox and stuff like that
could actually be more intermediate
level and be useful to anyone so be sure
to look through the chapters below and
you can skip around to what interests
you so
basically the structure here is the
three main tenets of front-end web
development and those would be html css
and javascript now oftentimes you'll see
tutorials kind of start with html and
css and then move into the more
complicated more challenging javascript
i've actually reversed that a little bit
we will be starting with javascript
which is going to be the biggest section
and i think it's useful to do that
because number one if you're going to be
a front-end web developer you have to
know all three anyways
and also i think there's a lot of
concepts
uh that you'll pick up learning a
general programming language like
javascript that will kind of help you
catch on to the html and css and bring
it full picture for you
my goal with this course is to be the
course that i needed when i was starting
out and what i'm really trying to do
here is connect all of these concepts
together
html css and javascript are not
born in isolation they all work together
to build a web page and i'll talk about
this analogy a little bit later but you
can think of these three core tenants of
front-end web development just like you
would building a house so when you build
a house you've got the you know the
framework the structure which is the
concrete foundation all of the two by
fours that go up and the roof that would
be your html
then you get in there you put some
wiring in there you put some plumbing
all the other stuff that would be your
javascript which makes it actually
functional and then finally you put the
finish on you put you know the roof
tiles you put paint on the outside the
inside you just make it look good and
that will be the css if you walk away
with anything from this course i want
you to understand most importantly the
relationships between these three and
have a pretty firm grasp of each of them
in isolation as well the last thing
before i actually get started is to let
you know that in the video description
there's going to be a link and that link
is going to lead you to a page that
gives you all the resources that you
need for this course we'll have some
time stamps some chapters
so you can navigate around the course
and then i will leave code snippets
solutions to any of the challenges and
even some additional resources and next
steps for certain topics if you want to
take them a little bit further so that's
it without further ado let's jump into
front end web development foundations
i want to start here with a quick win i
want you to see the power of code and
see what we can do with it very early on
so that you can kind of have that
confidence to know that you don't have
to go through you know download a bunch
of crazy things onto your computer and
and write a bunch of crazy lines of code
in a terminal to actually do something
cool since we're going to be jumping
into code here in the first lesson
before you know anything about it you're
going to be confused and that is very
okay don't worry about that i promise
we'll go back through everything that we
talked about in this video and couple
videos from now you will probably be
able to actually do what we're going to
do in this video so if you're a fan of
the netflix series stranger things you
might remember in the first season the
kids were talking to their professor
about this thing called the upside down
and basically what the professor was
talking about was a lot of physics
concepts and stuff like that but
basically he was talking about this
tightrope where there's a human on the
tightrope and then a flea on the
tightrope and the flea can actually go
around this tightrope and see all
different sides of it but the human
cannot
and that's ultimately what we're going
to be doing throughout this series we're
going to be looking at something that
you've spent a lot of time with already
and actually go to the other side of it
and understand what's going on behind
the scenes and the first thing that
we're going to touch on is something
called browser developer tools now you
might have seen
something like this before this is
called a web browser and you probably
use it every day of your life
but have you ever right clicked and
clicked inspect element
and gone into this
tool on the right
where there's all these different you
know applications that you can go
through to see what's going on on this
web page as a full stack web developer
or more particularly a front-end
developer which is kind of a subset of
full stack development you're going to
be using these developer tools a ton
and you're going to get very used to
them in this video i actually want to
walk you through the most common parts
of these developer tools and actually
write some code within them to give you
an idea of what this is all about the
first thing i want you to do though is
download the firefox web browser so just
type in firefox download go to the
download and get that onto your computer
i want to be working with the same tool
across the board although you have
developer tools within any other browser
whether that be edge or chrome
or firefox you have these developer
tools there but i want to make sure that
you're looking at the same thing that
i'm looking at and firefox is actually a
great web browser for
developers because it has some really
advanced developer tools and in my
opinion has probably some of the best
developer tools of any browser so get
that downloaded and then once you have
it downloaded go to google.com
and take a look at this pane on the
right and if you don't remember i just
right clicked anywhere on the page and i
clicked inspect element now the first
thing we're going to talk about here is
the
inspector now the inspector is probably
the portion of developer tools that you
will become most familiar with
and the reason is it allows you to
basically as you might expect to inspect
the page that you're looking at or the
web page so as i'm scrolling over these
different lines of html code you'll see
that different parts of the web page are
actually highlighted and i can click
down and drop this down and get more
specific at what i'm selecting
so i can basically see what's going on
in this web page and then if i go to the
bottom here these are all these stylings
or the css styles that go along with the
html
again don't worry about this we're going
to get into these you know languages
later into the course but for now i just
want to show you the landscape and to
really show you what's going on let me
open up
another tab here go to google.com slash
images and let's just type in dog
let's grab any dog here i like this one
here and we want to open this in a new
tab so let's say copy link location now
we come back here to the page and let's
click this button up here this is kind
of our selector
for different elements of the page and
let's click on this image here you can
see at the top there well i can't show
you but there's an img or image html tag
let's click that and then let's go into
this source attribute and paste in that
link that we just
grabbed of the dog photo
once we press enter you'll see that our
web page has actually updated and we can
close the developer tools and google.com
just got a makeover
now this is not permanent changes
obviously this would not be permanent
changes but we can uh right click
inspect element again let's click on the
image
and let's make this a little bit uh
smaller so let's put a width of a
hundred and now you can see
that the dog is a little bit more styled
on google's home page but as i said this
is not permanent these developer tools
are great because they allow you to make
very
temporary changes to your web page so
you might have the code that you're
writing you know on the back end and in
your terminal or your code editor and
those are the live changes but you can
come here to just make little changes
like you saw how the picture was too big
so i went in and changed it to a
different dimension and i can kind of
test out these different changes
and the power of this is just it allows
you to do things in real time but the
second that we click refresh on the page
you're going to see that it goes back to
the original web page
so you are the only one seeing these
changes within the inspect utility
nobody else sees them and the changes
are not permanent like i said we're
going to be spending a ton of time here
so don't worry if none of this really
made sense
but as you can see we're clicking
through we can click on different
elements so let's maybe click this
little icon down here and you'll see how
powerful this is once we get into this
stuff in the bottom right where we can
see the box model and we can actually
look at the document object model or the
dom we're going to get into all of these
things but the next thing i want to show
you is this thing called the console now
the console is probably the second
most popular tool within developer tools
or at least in this series we're going
to be using the console quite a lot and
what the console is it's actually called
a reple and that stands for
read evaluate print and loop now you
don't really need to know that what i
want you to remember about this console
is two things number one it allows you
to write javascript and number two it
allows you to actually modify the
document object model or the dom and
we're going to talk about that a little
bit later in the series but these are
the two main things that the console
allows us to do and to show you i'm
going to just give you a short example
of how we can use the console to make
some of the changes that we are also
making here in the inspector so if you
remember we kind of changed the image
within the inspector we can also do that
within the console so let's grab a
different dog picture here just for fun
grab this uh this one here like this and
copy the image location and all that's
doing is just copying
the actual
file that we're looking at from here we
can go back to our our page
and what we want to do is actually
select the image tag on this page so all
we have to do is say document.query
selector and then type in img and you
can see that when i do this this little
element here that we were editing
earlier is highlighted and down here
it's actually printing out what we're
going to get
when we press enter so when we press
enter we get this image but we actually
have to save that in a variable real
quick so let's say
our image and again don't worry about
what's going on here we'll talk about
all of this later
but we'll say document.query selector
img
we'll save that so now our image is
actually representing this element on
the page
and then we can say our image dot set
attribute and what i want to set is the
source and i want to set that equal to
the link that we just copied from that
dog photo and when i press enter it's
actually going to change this on the
page
and i can also resize this just like we
did earlier so our image dot set
attribute
or actually no it's not set attribute
it's style
dot
width
equals let's say 100
i'm sorry it's actually not it is an
attribute so let's set the attribute
sorry i'm doing this in real time here
so let's go with width and we'll go for
100 here
and you can see that it goes down
resizes accordingly so this is just a
short example of how we can use the
console to actually edit
the document object model or we can just
think of it as the web page for now not
only that but we can also write pure
vanilla javascript within this repel or
this console
and to show you that i've actually
already showed you that because i saved
our
element in
a variable a javascript variable but we
could also write a function so we could
write a function that says
change image or something like that and
it takes a url
and then it's going to actually change
the image so let's go ahead and make
that function
and what that's going to do is going to
say document
dot query selector img
dot set attribute
and we're going to say source and then
we're going to pass in the url
once again don't worry about what i'm
doing here this is just examples
and then i'm going to say enter down and
that's our function so now i can execute
this function and i can paste in that
url
and click enter and i guess it's already
there so it's not going to change but if
we went over to a different dog picture
and run this function
you'll see that it changes the image in
the browser so we can write javascript
we can modify the webpage all that stuff
within the console we're actually going
to be learning a lot of the initial
concepts of javascript here in the
console because it is so easy to set up
and get going all you have to do
is as we showed you just right click
inspect element click on the console and
boom you're ready to write javascript so
it's a great place to start so that we
don't have to set up all this elaborate
stuff just to write basic javascript
there are a couple of other features
within developer tools that i want to
show you here but they're less important
than the first two that we looked at so
the inspector and the console
now just to remind you right click
inspect element
and from here i want to go up to the
network tab so this network tab is
something that you will be using a lot
later on and if we refresh the page
you're going to see that there's some
activity here and what the what's
happening here in this network tab is
you're actually seeing all the resources
that are being transferred to and from
over the network to this web page so
google's backend servers are actually
require sending resources to the front
end and you're actually seeing all these
resources displayed in the browser so an
example of that would be this google
image right here and if we click on the
images part you can see that the
december holidays
in the response is actually the image
that we're looking at here
and if you wanted to see other things
about this such as the timings how long
it took to load
you know you can look at the http
headers all that kind of stuff this will
be very useful for us as we get into
more the back end development where
we're talking about api request
and you know http and all that kind of
stuff so we'll come back to this we'll
spend some time here a lot later in the
series but i wanted to expose you to it
initially so you can see that this is
something that we will be using now
another thing we will be using if you
click this little arrow over here is
storage
and storage is useful for a couple of
things storage is going to be useful for
tracking user behavior on a site so
not to to play the blame game here but
when we talk about facebook and all the
cookies that facebook puts on uh your
web browser on your mobile phone all
that kind of stuff this is where this is
being stored so you can see google is
storing these cookies about us
as the user and although these probably
won't mean a whole lot to us as people
using the site these have specific ids
and
all sorts of identifiers that
allow google to know things about the
user this is also great for
authentication this is how we're going
to actually log in and register
people to our app and when we build our
backend dashboard for editing our blog
for our personal website we're going to
need authentication because we don't
want just anyone coming and editing our
blog so this storage tab is what we're
going to use to actually do that
and while it's a very advanced topic
that comes later down the road i also
wanted to show it to you everything else
that you see here whether it be the
inspector console debugger network style
editor all this kind of stuff
everything else is not quite important
enough for us to cover here so i'm just
going to leave it there for now you
probably won't even use anything outside
of what i talked about for at least
several months or even years or maybe
even ever as a web developer all right
so i think i've covered
mostly what these developer tools are
about just to review
right-click anywhere on a web page
inspect element and you'll get to these
developer tools
now
the last thing i want to do in this
video is actually show you what coding
is all about and
have you write your first javascript
program well you probably will not
understand the concepts behind the code
we're about to write i want to get you
in the habit of actually writing code
and you know get you
feeling comfortable in this console that
we talked about earlier so open up a web
browser hopefully the firefox browser
you just downloaded put this video on
the side open up the console so right
click inspect go to the console
you can even type clear with
two little parentheses to clear the
console
and we are ready to get started now the
goal of this program is going to be
every time we click on google's web page
so when i click it i'm actually clicking
right now
um i want the background of the page to
actually change color and i want that
color to be a random color we can do
this with javascript code and i'm going
to walk you through line by line how
we're doing it and kind of explain
what each line does just to give you a
feeler again don't worry about how
everything's working we're going to go
into the details of the javascript
language in future videos the first
thing we have to do is save the body
html tag in a variable so when i say
body html tag
every web page that you're going to go
to has this thing called the body
and this represents kind of the
container
for the entire web page aside from of
course the topmost
container which is called html so we
want to select this body and this is
what we want to actually change the
background for so we can actually do
this manually and we can come down here
and right now you see on the body the
background is
hashtag fff which is just the hex code
for the color white now we can type in
green
and you can see that the background
actually changes in our web browser now
what i want to do is do this in vanilla
javascript and do it every time we click
the screen so in order to do that the
first thing that we
have to accomplish is saving that body
tag so let's type clear to get a clean
space
and then let's type in a variable
so here's our javascript variable we
want to set that equal
to document.queryselector
and then we want to get the body tag
so when we press enter that's going to
be the html body you can actually print
that out and see that we have
successfully retrieved that and stored
it in that variable
from here we actually need to create a
function now this function
we're going to save in a variable and i
know this is getting a little bit
confusing at this point but bear with me
and type along as i'm doing this
so we're going to go through this
function and we're going to assign
something called an array
so this array is going to contain
various colors of our choice so you can
put as many as you want in here
separated by commas i'm just going to
put in a couple random colors here that
i've saved so
2942 these are just hex codes so you can
actually go
hex codes something like that
you can go to google and you can see all
the different hex codes here there's
various tools that you can use for this
but anyways we're going to save these as
a comma separated array
and let's go add a few more
and then you can also
a valid css value would be something
like red blue or green so we can also
type in red
blue
green
yellow
orange
maybe even
purple
alright so we have saved this colors
array now the next thing that we have to
do
is get a random index from this array
and when i say index each of these
values are at a certain index within
this array and we'll talk more about
this later again but this one would be
the zeroth index this would be the first
index the second third so on and so
forth to get this random index we have
to actually use a built-in javascript
library called the math library
and we need a random random index
between 0 and let's see
1 2 3 4 5 six seven eight
uh there's eight items within this array
so we want a index between zero and
seven because uh arrays are zero index
they don't start at one
so we'll get a random index here
that'll be equal to math.floor
and we're going to pass in math.random
please don't worry about what's going on
here this is just an example
and this will give us our random index
and i actually pressed enter a little
bit too early so
we actually have to rewrite this
function
okay i've kind of returned to where i
was before i pressed enter and screwed
this all up
but basically we're getting a random
number between zero and seven and the
way that we do that is actually get the
length of the array by typing
colors.length
so let's not make that mistake again
let's enter down a couple times
and now we have to actually grab the
random color and save that in a variable
so we'll grab the random color
that'll be equal to colors and then
we'll insert our random index that we
have generated
then we are going to actually style the
body so all we have to do is grab this
uh variable that we saved up here called
html body
and then we want to go to the
style and then background
color not clip
background color and then we want to set
that equal to our random color here
so that's going to actually do what we
showed earlier and change the background
color
and then the last thing i want to do is
just print to the console
a confirmation that this worked so we'll
do something like this we'll say
the user clicked
and set the color to
and then we'll concatenate this string
in here and say random color
okay our function is done hopefully it
works here
and the way that we see if it works is
by running it or executing it so we'll
do random click function
and it looks like the user has clicked
and changed the color
now to finish this program off the last
thing we have to do is set an event
listener on the html body element
now this is a little bit advanced but
it's kind of a cool feature
of you know javascript and all that kind
of stuff so all we have to do is go to
html body and say on click so it's
saying
when the user clicks i want to execute
this random click function all right so
once i press enter now we have wired it
up so that every time we click it's
going to change the the color so i'm
going to click a couple times
since it's random we might get a couple
duplicates here but then we can even
close this and keep clicking and
get all sorts of different results here
so it's actually a pretty cool program
that we just wrote and you can see you
know even you who have never written a
line of code before were able to kind of
follow along and type what i was typing
and write your first little program in
other words you just did something that
almost everyone in the world does not
know how to do and will never know how
to do your brain is probably in utter
confusion right now but don't worry in
the next couple videos we're going to
actually be deep diving
into this javascript programming
language and we're going to be learning
how i wrote this program what are all
these different symbols that we're
typing into the console and all that
kind of good stuff so don't worry if
you're completely confused this video
was mainly to give you an introduction
to the developer tools that you can have
within any browser we're using firefox
but it just gives you that introduction
and also just some exposure
and some comfort levels actually writing
real javascript code and that's it for
this first video be sure to hit the
subscribe button and also that little
bell so you're notified when new videos
are posted to this series and thanks for
watching
today we're going to be talking about
what is javascript and why do we use it
let's see what wikipedia has to say
because we know that's going to be
simple javascript often abbreviated as
js is a programming language that
conforms and i think i'm going to stop
right there because this is not a useful
definition especially for most people
watching this
what you can remember javascript as is
just a programming language and more
specifically it's a programming language
that is made for the web you have other
languages like c plus plus python php
ruby
c sharp all these different languages
and they all kind of have their unique
characteristics and javascript's unique
characteristic is that unlike these
other languages that cannot run in a web
browser javascript can't this has been
the case for quite some time but
recently as you can see the 1.0 version
of webassembly
has been released in four different
browsers which does let you write all
these other programming languages to run
within the browser but for now just
think of javascript as the programming
language of the web because it's the
easiest to write in the browser and even
with web assembly there's a lot of
complicated steps to get all of that set
up so you say javascript is the
programming language of the web but is
that all it can do well the answer is no
but if you asked that question 20 years
ago you might have been laughed at
since that time though javascript has
gained a lot of traction in development
communities and was the most used
language in the stack overflow developer
survey of 2020
and to name a few things that you can do
with javascript let's pull this up here
you can create web applications so
there's lots of front end frameworks
like angular here you've also got react
i think this is the most popular one at
the moment
you can do back-end
pieces of your web application or
back-end servers with things like nest
js
you can also create desktop applications
if i pull up my visual studio code which
is a code editor this is actually a
desktop application that was built using
this tool called a framework called
electron so you can build desktop
applications for various operating
systems
you can also create mobile apps with
react native and native script and then
finally you can do ai and machine
learning data science projects with
tensorflow.js and a couple other
libraries so to say that javascript is
not a powerful language is a bit of a
miss here because javascript has many
different applications
the next question that you might ask is
can javascript get you a job and the
answer to that is a resounding yes but
javascript alone is not going to do it
you have to actually learn frameworks
such as the ones that i've gone through
here angular react nest gis electron
react native all of these frameworks
that are built around javascript are
what you get hired for
and speaking of frameworks what is a
javascript framework or any framework
for that matter well the way that i
think about it is the framework is
something on top of a programming
language so it's an abstraction on top
of javascript that enables a developer
to do something more efficiently in less
time facebook is created largely with a
framework a front-end framework called
react and this is a very popular
framework we just went over it
and facebook could definitely have been
built without a framework it could be
built in just javascript
html and css
but the reason that it wasn't is because
the developers there decided hey this is
getting really repetitive and we have
certain things that we do over and over
and over again that we want to kind of
automate and therefore react was born
react is something that the developers
at facebook kind of created in order to
make their jobs easier and more
efficient we can use a little bit of a
construction analogy to think about
frameworks if you're trying to build
some commercial real estate building are
you going to use a shovel and a ladder
to create this whole entire building and
you know drive all the materials back
and forth and pick up trucks the answer
is no you're going to get huge trucks
you're going to get bulldozers you're
going to get cranes you're going to get
all sorts of
big materials in order to build this
huge building and it's the same thing
with building web apps or honestly
anything that you would build with code
if you're trying to do it with just a
language like javascript and you're
you're not using some of the popular
frameworks that have been built on top
of that you're basically showing up to a
construction site with a shovel and a
pickup truck so you don't want to do
that in order to be employable you need
to understand how to use these different
frameworks like angular or react or even
a framework like electron which is
enables you to write desktop
applications like visual studio code all
right i think that's enough on
frameworks for now could do a whole
video on it let's go to the next
question which is is javascript the same
as java or at least similar and the
answer to that is no if you search
enough on the internet you'll probably
stumble upon
the analogy of a car versus a carpet
they both have car within the word but
they're nothing alike
and that's kind of the story with
javascript and java now java was
actually the inspiration for javascript
way back in the day and javascript was
meant to be a companion to java so they
do have some similarity but when you're
writing each of the languages they could
not be more different the next question
is javascript better than python or
honestly insert any language there the
answer to that is always going to be it
depends and the reason that i say that
is because
all these different languages that
you're choosing between have different
unique use cases and while they can all
kind of do the same thing they all are
programming languages
some of them are better for certain
types of industries than others so if
you're asking me to build
an app like facebook
i'm probably going to go with javascript
and use some javascript frameworks
because that's what those are made for
they're made for creating apps like
facebook but if you wanted me to do some
machine learning
and do you know build out the computer
that sits in a tesla i'm probably not
going to use javascript i'm probably
going to use python because python has a
much
more mature ecosystem around this topic
of machine learning ai data science all
that kind of stuff so when you're asking
whether you should go with javascript or
another language it really depends on
what kind of industry you're getting in
what you're trying to build all that
kind of stuff if you're trying to build
a web app like facebook javascript is
great if you're trying to do some
machine learning python is great if
you're trying to create an extremely
efficient uh we'll say banking
application or something like that a
language like c plus which is much
faster in execution than a javascript
would be a good choice there's no right
answer here but there are
different ecosystems around each of
these languages and you'll kind of
notice as you study them that certain
types of developers kind of gravitate
towards different languages
another question that you might have is
html and css required to work with
javascript and the answer to that is yes
and no it kind of depends on where
you're actually running that javascript
now let's start with the front end
because this is a little bit easier to
explain and then we'll move on to the
back end if you don't know the
difference between those i actually made
a video on the difference between
front-end and back-end development
anyways let's go over to my browser here
on the left side of my screen i have an
html file that is actually open in
notepad here on the right not doing any
fancy editors here just want to get a
few points across so let's create a
basic html document here i know i
haven't actually gone through how this
all works yet but we will get there i
promise at some point here
in the body of the html i'm just going
to create a button that says click me
so when we refresh the page we should
see
all of this reflected on our web page
and you see that we have a very unstyled
button which is just click me so this is
a
example of a web page this is no
different than you know the home page of
facebook
except for the fact that it is not
including both css and javascript so
this is html alone now if we add css to
the picture we're actually going to be
able to style this now we can add some
styles to this button so let's do that
right now we'll add a background color
of
transparent
and then i want to say
the border is going to be 1 pixel
solid navy
then i want to add some padding to it so
we'll say 20px
we want the font size to be 1.4 rem just
somewhere in that range
and let's go ahead and close that
bracket off save it and refresh the page
you can see that we have a much better
style button here we can also add some
hover styles to it so
let's go down here and say button
hover and now i want the background
color to be navy and i want the
let's see the border
to be none
i want the color of the text to be white
so that it stands out on that navy
background
save this refresh and you can see that
we have a styled button
that changes styles when we hover over
it so this is the power of css but if i
click this button
if i click this button it's not going to
do anything does nothing it's just a
static element on the page and while it
looks like it's changing looks like it's
doing something that's only being done
with css in html now in many web
applications you have various buttons
and forms that users can click on in
order to do things within the app so i'm
sure you've been to
a login page before where you enter your
email and your password and you press
login well that is actually being
triggered by javascript and while you do
need the html and preferably css if you
want a web app that people are going to
visually like
you need javascript to actually react to
different
interactions on the page by the user if
you just have html and css your login
form is going to not do anything and
you're going to have a useless app to
kind of give you an idea what i mean
obviously this is not realistic but
i added some javascript to this html
document that also has css
and you can now see that every time i
click on this button it's going to add
an element to the page
so i'll click it and you can see that
i'm adding a p tag
with the text clicked the button every
time i click it
and this is just to demonstrate how once
you add javascript to your html in css
you can actually interact with the page
rather than just looking at a static
website well in this case all i did was
add some stupid text to the page you can
see that how every time we click the
button we can fire an event and maybe
send in the login credentials to our
backend server authenticate get the
response back and then redirect that
user to a different page of our site
when we're working with javascript on
the front end or in the browser html and
css are pretty much required for
javascript to run now yes it could run
without them but it would be completely
useless you'd just be running it in the
console like we did in the previous
lesson so it has to have something to
actually interact with now on the back
end since javascript is both a front-end
and back-end language
we can actually run javascript without
any html in css and it can be extremely
useful when we're working with
javascript in the browser html and css
are required to make this javascript do
anything useful because ultimately the
javascript in the browser is all about
taking those html elements and modifying
them and interacting with back end data
all that kind of stuff so html and css
are required in the front end on the
back end if we're using the node.js
runtime which is the way that we can run
backend javascript we don't need html in
css let's write a simple node.js program
to demonstrate that we don't need html
and css in order to do that once again
we have not covered this in this series
yet so bear with me
but we need to create a
sample.js file and then we'll open this
up with vim
which is going to allow us to edit this
so once we have this again haven't
covered this either
but we can make a
do math function something like that
where we can enter in two values and get
some you know result so let's do a
multiplication problem so we'll just
we'll say return
x
times y
and close the braces and then in order
to actually run this program we are
going to actually store it in a result
variable so do math and we'll say 5 and
80 something like that big enough where
we can't necessarily do it in our head
we'll do like 87 or something
and so it's going to store that in the
result
and then we want to print the result to
the console so from there we can save
and quit and then we can clear the
console and run this sample
dot js program and you'll see that it
did that multiplication for us so
obviously this is very useless and you
wouldn't ever do such a simple function
but think about back when we were
working on the front end and when we
clicked that button
so let's say that it was a register form
you add your email and your password you
click the button the javascript in the
front end is going to say okay the
button was clicked i need to do
something and so what it's going to do
is grab all that data the email and
password it's going to send it over to
your backend server and your backend
server is going to run the node.js
you know version of javascript and it's
going to say okay i got an email and a
password let me look up this email in
the database
hash the password and compare the hashed
password to the one within the database
and then i'm going to send some data
back to the front end in order to tell
it whether the user has successfully
authenticated so you can see how these
different
sides of javascript work in different
ways but the point is no you don't need
html and css on the back end but yes you
need it on the front end and the last
question that i'm going to cover is what
is the difference between something like
es5 or es6 and javascript well there's
actually an organization called
ecma international not even sure if i
said that right
but this is just a standards
organization and in order to really
visualize this i want to go into a quick
example of something that's not related
to javascript well not entirely
and that is the iso 8601 date standard
so we're going to go through this
example and then i think everything else
is going to make a little bit more sense
so if i open up the console like we did
in the first lesson of this series
and i run let me save
a date into a date variable
and then i want to print this date
as an iso string
and you can see that i have this
uniquely formatted date and it looks
very standardized and that's because it
is and it's actually standardized by
this you know
organization called iso which is i think
the international standards organization
and there's actually organizations like
this across the world for various you
know different standardized things and
the same thing applies for javascript
and that is where ekma international
and the ecmascript specification or in
other words you might hear this as es5
or es6 all different versions of this
spec
this is where these have originated
and so javascript is actually an
implementation of this specification
and the reason this is so important is
because of browser compatibility among
other things so if you go to this mdn
web docs article you can see a grid of
all the javascript apis that are
supported within different browsers and
the reason that this ecma standards is
so important is because the
specification just needs to be updated
and maintained in one place and then all
of the different browser developers
you've got different teams for each of
these different browsers they can look
at that specification and implement
their browser knowing that all of these
specifications are not going to just
randomly change when you know say
someone working on the javascript
language decides that they want you know
a new api feature so just remember
javascript is an implementation of the
es6 or es5 or
whatever version you're working with
it's an implementation of that
specification all right i think that
does it for this first rapid fire uh q a
session that was not very rapid fire
whatsoever but this last part of the
video is totally optional it's for the
people who really want to
learn the ins and outs of web
development and want to continue on
with this series here and what we're
going to be talking about in the last
part of the video is just the question
of
what is a programming language so we
talked about how javascript is a
programming language and it's kind of
unique because it can run on the backend
and the front end and a browser
but we didn't really cover what is a
programming language and i think that
this is a very important question to ask
because if you're going to be writing a
lot of code you probably should
understand what's happening behind the
scenes at least at a high level so for
this last part what we're going to call
a programming language is a group of
tokens or symbols that when combined
together in a very very specific way
can be translated by something called a
compiler into machine code or ones and
zeros that all computers know how to run
you can think about it like this
um let's let's take a spoken language
something that i don't know which is
pretty much every language except for
english
but we'll call it i don't know something
like portuguese if you started speaking
portuguese to me
my brain would not be able to comprehend
what those words and symbols and
expressions
actually mean semantically although i
can't understand portuguese
what i can understand is the body
language of someone speaking it so if
you've got someone speaking portuguese
and they have a very you know sad
demeanor to them i can understand
generally that what they're saying is
not a happy thing
and it's the same thing with computers
well a computer cannot understand
javascript it cannot understand python
it cannot understand c plus it can't
understand any of these languages but if
we use something called a compiler
which is just another program more code
that actually
reads other code and compiles it down
into ones and zeros that a computer can
actually understand so it's taking a
language and it's compiling it down into
ones and zeros or we can think of them
as body language because
all computers understand ones and zeros
now this is where it gets really complex
and i'm not going to actually dive into
it during this video
once we start talking about compilers
then we have to get into the topic of
operating system theory
and which you know what is our target
runtime that we're dealing with like
where are we actually executing these
ones and zeros because each computer is
going to have a slightly different cpu
slightly different alu or
arithmetic logical unit all of these
things matter when we're compiling code
down and for each different language and
kind of each different operating system
you have to have slightly different
compilers
and other tools that i'm not mentioning
here in order to do that now if you're
someone who really wants to understand
this in a great level of detail
something that was very important to me
then i recommend reading this book right
here which is the elements of computing
systems and you'll see within this book
you know i'll see if i can show like a
little page here but we actually get
into things like the arithmetic logical
unit and how these ones and zeros are
actually
translated into commands for the
computer
now i will say if you're going to read
that book i will warn you right now it's
going to take you months and it's very
difficult to get through
that said i came out of it learning in a
ton and i was really happy with what i
learned from that book but if you're
trying to get a job quickly you're
trying to become employable as fast as
possible do not read that book it's
going to take you too long it's going to
distract you from
actually writing web applications now if
you're someone who wants to understand
this stuff but doesn't have time to
build a computer from scratch which is
what you'll do in that book
i recommend a book called code by
charles petzl and this is going to give
you all that information it's going to
teach you the ones and zeros compiling
all that kind of stuff but it's going to
do it a little bit quicker and you're
not going to be quite as hands-on with
it and the final question of this video
is where does javascript actually run
and the answer to that is very similar
to the question that i asked earlier
which is
is html and css required to run
javascript and i said well it depends
whether you're running it in the front
end or the back end and what we're
asking here is where does javascript run
and this is where we get into the topic
of something called a run time and a
runtime is basically
uh an environment where code is run and
it gets into those topics that we just
talked about with compilers and how do
we target different platforms and
compile down to ones and zeros
and there's actually two run times for
javascript and that would be the node.js
runtime and then the browser runtime
and
believe it or not the
browser runtime within google chrome
uses something called the v8 engine and
this is going to actually do all of that
compilation that i was talking about
and it's going to get into a bunch of
other stuff some optimization
using the just in time compilation
method all that kind of stuff it's going
to basically take your javascript code
and convert it to something the computer
can read
and node.js which is kind of the backend
version of javascript or the runtime
that we're going to use for our backend
javascript servers and stuff like that
that also uses the v8 engine which is
similar to chrome so you can kind of
guess that the creators of node.js and
the creators of the v8 engine that runs
in chrome and node.js to kind of become
good friends here over the last couple
years
but this is not the only way that we can
run javascript you know you have node.js
which is probably which is the most
popular way to run
javascript on the back end and google
chrome which is one of the most popular
browsers but in this course we're using
firefox as our web browser because i
think the developer tools are a little
bit better there and with firefox we're
not actually using the v8 engine in
order to compile the javascript down
we're using something called
spidermonkey which is the original
engine for javascript that was built
within the netscape browser
way back in the day and as a side note
if you really want an interesting
podcast to listen to
look up browser wars i think it's by the
podcast called business wars and it's a
really cool story about netscape and how
all this all these browsers gained
market share really worth checking out
in my opinion so in summary javascript
can be run on the back end or the front
end and if it's run on the back end in
node.js it's being compiled down using
the v8 engine if it's running on the
front within google chrome it's also
using the v8 if it's running in firefox
it's using spider monkey if it's running
in safari it's using some other
compilation method and that i can't
think of off the top of my head
but ultimately these are all different
run times and you do have to be aware of
you know where you're running your
javascript code because it's going to
run differently there are things that
you cannot run within the node.js
runtime if i tried to let's say open up
the node.js runtime here all i have to
do is click
type node and it'll bring me into the
the console if i tried to say
document.query
selector and then grab the body
tag of the html and i press enter it's
going to say uncaught reference error
document is not defined and that is
because in the node.js runtime the
document object model does not exist
like it does in the browser so you have
to be aware of these different runtimes
and understand that certain types of
code can run
in the different run times it's all
javascript but you kind of get what i'm
saying here and at this point per usual
i've uh droned on way too long longer
than i ever thought that i would but you
have reached the end of the second
lesson of my full stack web developer
roadmap series
and while we haven't written any
javascript yet well i guess we did in
the first lesson but we haven't actually
learned javascript yet we do have a lot
of context around it now which was the
purpose of this video i really wanted to
put this video together in order to give
you that context so that when we start
getting into the details you know
variables and data structures and
functions and loops all that kind of
stuff you have a little bit of a
background to understand it from if you
liked this video please give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel if you
want to follow along with this series
and series in the future
and with that hope you enjoyed the video
and i'll see you in the next lesson
[Music]
in this video we're going to be talking
about javascript variables and data
types and be sure to stick around till
the end of the video because i have some
challenges and some practice questions
that you can use to apply the skills
that you learned in this video before we
start talking about variables and data
types i just want to mention that as we
go through this series i'm not going to
be covering everything that there is to
know about the javascript programming
language there are a lot of different
features within javascript a lot of
built-in
functions and
you know syntax shortcuts and all sorts
of things like that that you can do but
they're not absolutely necessary for you
to write javascript code for example let
me create a basic array here so we'll
say
my array and then we'll put some numbers
in it and this is actually what this
video is all about so don't worry if you
don't understand this quite yet
but javascript has some built-in methods
that we can use on this array
so we could say myarray.push
and then we can add a number to the end
of this array so just return the length
of our new array and if we print it out
you can see that there's the number 50
at the end of it now that is an example
of a very useful and commonly used
built-in javascript
prototype method that we're going to be
covering in this series but there are
other methods and there are a lot of
them that we will not so for example we
can say
myarray.reverse
now this one's pretty simple all it does
is it reverses the order of the items
within that array as you can see
but this is not critical for you to
learn to write good javascript code and
be a web developer so i'm going to
selectively exclude things like that and
try to focus in on the most important
things of javascript
likewise there are also some very
complex topics that we can discuss
around
the internals of javascript and how it
works behind the scenes and how
prototypes work and why it's technically
not a class-based language and all these
things are important for you to
understand later down the road but when
trying to get you from you know xero to
deploying your first full stack web
application they're not
completely essential per se and believe
it or not a lot of web developers that
work full-time jobs and are employed
getting paid lots of money
don't fully understand the internals of
javascript and that's why this series
called you don't know javascript written
by kyle simpson or his github username
is getify
and he's written this wonderful series
or book series on javascript and how it
works and you can go to each of the
series on github and actually read all
about
you know how javascript works under the
hood and he has a tremendous
understanding of this language and
explains it in great detail but i would
say that you would use this as a
reference and personally i think it's
geared towards someone who has written
javascript for some amount of time and
it's something that i reference back to
even now after writing javascript for
about four plus years it's still a great
resource to look back on so just know as
we go through this series i'm not going
to be covering absolutely everything and
if you have questions be sure to just
google it or go to this you don't know
javascript series and
pick the section you want to learn about
and kind of read a little bit more about
it and finally if i can get through this
long intro we'll finally get to
variables and data types but i want to
show you one thing real quick
and that is the console.log statement so
when we're working within the javascript
console in our firefox dev tools you can
print a variable
by using the console.log statement and
this is built into javascript you can
use it on the front end in the
javascript console or the end and the
node.js console
and we can print something like
hello world we've done this already once
in a previous video but this is how
we're printing we print different
variables so if i just say my first
variable
and set it equal to 20 and then
console.log
that first variable
you'll see that it prints it to the
console that's going to be used heavily
within this series so i want you to be
familiar with it the next thing is the
concept of comments so if you put two
forward slashes before your code and
then you write something this is
obviously invalid javascript and you
press enter it's not going to throw an
error on you well if you type it like
this it's going to say that there's a
reference error because we haven't
commented it out
there's another way to write comments
let me clear the screen here
and you can put a forward slash and then
a star
and then you can enter down
write whatever comments you want and
then you just have to close it out by a
star and then a forward slash and when
we press enter it's not going to yell at
us with any sort of error because we
have written a comment so i just want
wanted to basically introduce those
concepts the console.log the single line
comment and the multi-line comment
you're going to see them a lot and
they're very useful for
you know marking up your code and
remembering things about the code that
you've written
a big congrats if you're still watching
this video it means that you are
dedicated to learning how to code and
for that reason let's jump into
variables and data types in javascript
so when i think of a variable in
javascript i just think of a data
container
and a good analogy for this is the
amazon warehouse so they've got these
big vertical yellow
stacks of containers with different
products in them and then on the bottom
they have little robots that kind of
drive these containers around according
to when the item
items in the containers are meant to be
shipped
and i like to think of this as an
analogy because javascript variables are
very similar
in that amazon warehouse each container
is registered
and all the robots know exactly where to
find the container and the products that
are within that container same thing
goes for javascript variables your
computer knows exactly where to find all
of these javascript variables that you
declare and assign values to and it's
able to retrieve them instantly so you
can think of javascript variables as you
know you write them and then they are
basically like little amazon products
that get put into these containers and
put in the back of the warehouse but the
computer at all times knows exactly
where to go in that warehouse to find
the values of these variables in
computer language we wouldn't really
call it a warehouse we would just call
it memory but it's a good analogy to go
by and i think it'll help you remember
what variables are all about just like
amazon's containers can have various
types of products stored within them so
can javascript variables and we can look
at this here we're going to just go
through a couple examples of variables
the first one will be we'll say your
first
variable
and we'll say learning to code
gives you super powers or something like
that
so that would be one example of a
variable and that is actually a string
variable we'll go into that a little bit
later
now you can have your second variable
which will be equal to a number this
time so equal to 10
and finally we'll say your third
variable and that'll be equal to
an object and we'll say
that this object has a property that
says something like hello world
and this is also a valid variable and to
print these variables once again we can
use this console.log statement and we
can print your first variable something
like that and you can see that it prints
it out to the console so these are just
examples of writing variables and now i
want to go into each component of these
statements so as you can see we have
this keyword called const we have a
little space here then we have what
seems to be our variable's name
then we have this equal sign
then we have some sort of data and a
semicolon at the end these are all
really critical parts to writing
javascript variables because when the
compiler goes to basically interpret
um the code that you have written it
reads it in a specific order and it
looks at every single
what we call token within the code so
for example if i tried to define
a new variable
and this time i'll just say
another hello world
something like that this would be valid
but if we took out just even this single
little quotation and pressed enter it's
going to give us a syntax error and
you're going to get a lot of these
syntax errors when you first start out
because
they basically say hey you haven't
written this javascript program
correctly you've missed a specific token
within your code
now a lot of times you don't have to
actually worry about these syntax errors
what i have pulled up here is visual
studio code which is a code editor we're
going to work with a little bit later in
the series we're not there yet but what
i want to show you is that if we tried
to say new variable and then we define
hello world with a semicolon at the end
it's going to look fine but if we go
over here and delete this little uh
quotation you're going to see that
visual studio code picks up on the fact
that there's an error in this syntax so
a lot of the times when you're writing
code we're not going to see it you know
here in the console which is what we're
using right now but once we get into
code editors it's going to point these
things out and you don't really have to
worry too much about getting everything
right
as you're writing your code the next
thing we have to talk about with
javascript variables is the concept of
declaration and assignment
to properly use a variable you have to
do that
sequence of steps in order so you first
have to declare the variable then you
have to assign a value to it now if we
typed in
you know something like new variable and
i'm going to actually refresh the page
so we clear out all of the
variables that we had already written
so if i say
new variable something like that
and we say hello world
that is going to not only declare but
also assign this variable at the same
time so in many cases we're doing it
simultaneously
but we can also break it out into
individual steps and we can do that by
using the let keyword and we'll say
let
another variable equal
we'll say 20 this time
or actually no we need to just put a
semicolon at the other end of it
and by doing that we have actually
declared the variable and now we have to
assign a value to it and we don't have
to put the let keyword at the beginning
we just assign a value
and we can print this to the console by
saying another variable
and you can see that it equals 20. so in
the second example i declared it then i
assigned it and it's important to
understand this concept you don't
necessarily have to
you know think about this while you're
coding but i wanted to point this out
and it brings up another good point
about this const versus let versus var
keywords at the beginning of your
variable expressions let me go ahead and
write the same
variable per se in three different ways
so first we can say variable one equals
and that's using the const keyword then
we can say let variable
we'll say 2 this time
equals 10 that's valid and then we can
say var
variable 3.
can't type here equals 10. and you can
see that all three of these ways of
writing a javascript variable are valid
so you might ask the question well how
do we decide between const let and var
you need one of them at least to
create a variable if we just tried to
say
um you know
random
random keyword and then variable
4 equals 10 it's going to give us an
error because random is not an assigned
keyword such as constellat or var let's
go ahead and start with var and that is
the only keyword that i would recommend
against using it's kind of a legacy
keyword within javascript
it's something that existed in the old
versions and standards of javascript and
nowadays we have the constant let
keywords which will pretty much cover
every situation that we need to now the
reason var is not used anymore is
because it can be
redeclared so if we say
var
my variable equals 10 and then we say
my variable
equals
i'm sorry i can't type today equals 20.
it's going to actually update the value
of that variable
without yelling at you at all but if you
use a keyword like const so we'll say
another
variable equals 10
and then we say const
another variable
equals 20 it's going to say that there's
a syntax error and it's going to yell at
us for re-declaring a constant variable
with the var keyword being able to
re-declare a variable seems convenient
and it actually is when we're working
within the console but when you're
actually writing code it can be kind of
dangerous and you can have some unwanted
side effects
by being able to redeclare a variable
the next keyword i want to talk about is
let and let is something that you will
use whenever you expect to reassign a
variable at some point in your code so
we just kind of talked about
re-declaring a variable and that's very
different from reassigning a variable so
if you remember you first declare the
variable which is basically saying
go back to our amazon analogy where
we're talking about you know the
containers and the robots have to
remember where those containers are in
the warehouse well your computer has to
first register or declare these
variables and then once it's declared it
kind of allocates some memory space
on the hard drive or something like that
or in ram to basically remember where to
retrieve that variable from so that's
the declaration step and then the
assignment step is where we take an
actual value and we say okay put put
this value in this variable and so the
computer will go find that variable that
was declared into memory and assign your
new value to that you know little memory
slot so we will always use let when we
expect to reassign a variable so let me
show you what this
basically looks like so let's say that
we have a counter and we start that
counter at zero
and then we want to actually increase
the value of that counter so we can say
counter equals counter plus one
and we can also say counter plus plus
that will do the same thing as the
previous line that i just wrote so now
we should have it equal to
and you can see that it is now equal to
2 and you can see that we are
reassigning the value of this variable
multiple times now if we tried to
let me refresh the page real quick so
that we can use this variable again
and if we tried to say counter equals 0
with the const keyword and then we tried
to say plus plus it's going to say that
we have a type error because we can't
assign or reassign a value to a constant
variable
so that's when you want to use constants
is basically when you expect the value
to never change
so a good example of that is say we have
a program that calculates some sort of
i don't know income statement you want
to put in a tax rate for this individual
so you might program in something like a
tax rate and that will be equal to
0.08 for eight percent
and you press enter and now this
constant variable is never going to
change your tax rate's never going to
change and that is the best use case for
a constant variable so just remember you
use let when you expect the value to be
reassigned to a variable and you use
const when you
expect the variable to never change
values
now the the concept of a constant is
pretty universal in programming and it
spans across many languages
oftentimes you'll see constants written
something like this so we'll say tax
rate equals
0.8 percent
and you can see that the variable has
been written in all caps and separated
by an underscore
now you'll see this very often
but this is just a semantic difference
and it's functionally the same as what
we had written before and that actually
leads us into our next discussion which
is about variable naming conventions i'm
going to paste a couple different
versions of variables in here
and we'll press enter and you can see
that all of these are actually valid in
javascript they're all written slightly
differently
but they're functionally kind of the
same
so these are all saying your first
variable but javascript recognizes them
as different variables that's why we're
allowed to declare all of these at once
and they all functionally operate the
same but there are a couple of these
that are more preferable in the
javascript programming language than
others
so for example the first variable that
we have here
is written in something called camel
case and that is basically where the
first letter of your variable
is lowercase and then each successive
word or
logical separated word within your
variable is going to be capitalized
so this is called camelcase and then
there's another version down here which
is called pascal case
which is basically where it's the same
thing as camelcase except the first
letter is capitalized the second
variable here where we have underscores
in between lowercase letters is called
snake case
then you have this one right here that
we just talked about which is called
constant case
and then finally you just have a totally
lowercase
variable
and these are all different semantic
styles that you can put on a javascript
variable or any programming language
variable
and oftentimes these indicate to other
programmers something about your code
i'll talk about what these mean in just
a second but first i want to talk about
what makes these valid
so
you can really think of a variable in
javascript
kind of like a twitter hashtag so if you
were to write a twitter hashtag and
we'll say the full stack
roadmap which is the one that we have
for this series this would be a valid
twitter hashtag because it's all one
word
now if i
put a space here at the end then
twitter's only going to recognize that
first part or full stack and then it's
going to treat roadmap as just normal
text and that's exactly how javascript
works with variables if we tried to
define this as a variable so let's say
const full stack roadmap
equals 10
it's going to give us a syntax error
because we have a space in between
these two words to have a valid
javascript variable you have to put
everything in one word and use one of
these conventions up here at the top now
there's also a few things you can't do
so we we cannot do something like this
where we say full stack
equals 10 you can't have these little
quotes here this is not going to work
and then you also cannot start
a variable with a number so you can see
that i put 1 at the beginning of this
variable it's going to throw an error
but if i put full stack 1 at the end so
now we have our number at the end of the
variable that works just fine so these
are just some of the things to watch out
for it's fairly intuitive and you'll get
the hang of this
really quickly and if you don't get the
hang of it the javascript debugger is
going to yell at you and it's basically
going to give you a bunch of syntax
errors all right so now that you know
how to validly declare and assign a
variable
let's talk about something called a
style guide and this goes back to the
concept that we see up here where we
have all these different semantic ways
to write a variable they all work but
some of them are more preferable than
others depending on what language you're
writing in and what you're trying to do
with the individual variable that you're
declaring if you type in javascript
style guide into google you'll find a
couple different style guides by
different companies so this is google's
javascript style guide and here would be
airbnb's javascript style guide so
basically what these are are
specifications for the employees of
these different companies that says here
is how we want you to write your
javascript for our company and what this
might entail is different naming
conventions different
use cases of different javascript
features
all that kind of stuff there's a
plethora of things that you'll find
within these style guides but the one i
want to look at is naming conventions so
we can find this within
each of the style guides kind of have to
look for it here real quick so here is
naming for google so we have the naming
style guide for google and airbnb
and you'll see that
each of them recommend camel case so we
can see
package names need to be lower camel
case
class names are upper camel case let's
go down to
normal variables so non-constant field
names should be lower camelcase
local variables lower camelcase you kind
of get the point they're all pointing
towards this lower camel case
convention and if we go to airbnb you'll
see here that it says use camel case
when naming objects functions and
instances
this is a bad example this would be a
good example
so you'll see within these two different
companies they're both recommending
camelcase and that's actually a
recommendation across all of the
javascript community so you'll see a lot
of javascript code written in this camel
case as we saw here with our first
variable and this is what i would
recommend you do as you're starting to
learn how to write javascript the last
thing i want to talk about with naming
conventions for variables
is what we're actually naming them so
you'll see here that these are very
descriptive um this is clearly
indicating to the programmer that you're
practicing you're writing your first
variable but there's also going to be
programs where you're going to have
multiple variables within a single
function or a class
and you need to identify between these
different variables so tell me would
this be an appropriate way to name a
variable if we just said q equals 20
well the answer is no because how are
you going to ever know what that q is
supposed to represent maybe it
represents a counter in a for loop uh
maybe it represents
i don't know
the
the tax rate on something you know
whatever it means you need to
name your variable accordingly so if
this 20 represents a 20 tax rate or
something like that we need to call it
tax rate
for
net income or something like that where
you're clearly specifying what this
value represents
now there's also the the case where you
can get too complex with this and write
out a variable that's way too long and
in that case it gets hard to write that
code because you're constantly having to
type this super long variable and it
takes you longer so you want to find
that middle ground where you're not
being so vague where it's just saying
the the variable's name is q and you're
not so specific that you can't you know
write your variable within 10 seconds
the next thing we have to talk about is
the left side of the variable
expression and the right side of the
variable expression so let's write our
first variable
javascript
gives you
super powers
something like that we'll press enter
and let's take a look at this
so on the left side when i say the left
side i'm talking about everything
left
of this little equal sign in the middle
and when i say the right side i'm
talking everything right of this little
equal sign in the middle so it's very
important to make a distinction between
the left and the right because
depending on what you're putting on each
side you're going to get different
behaviors the left side of the equal
sign is always going to include two
things it's going to include either
const or let and you could use var but i
don't recommend it and then it's going
to have a single space right here and
then it's going to have your properly
constructed
variable name and then i
always use another space this is just
good
code formatting after that and then an
equal sign and everything left of the
equal sign is considered the target or
that container that you're trying to put
some sort of data or value
into so this is where you're storing
your container now on the right side of
the equal sign you have the actual value
that you're assigning so the right side
could be one of many different things
and this is where we get into the
concept of data types
in this case we have a string on the
right side of our equal sign
and then followed by a semicolon that's
to indicate the end of the
variable expression so i want to touch
on that real quick let's say that we had
one variable
equals 20
and then const
second
variable
equals
30. this would be a valid expression we
wrote them on the same line but we ended
each statement with this semicolon now
if we were to pull this up again all i
did was press the up arrow key to get my
last statement in the console that's a
quick shortcut for you
and if we were to take out this
semicolon here
and let's go ahead and
i don't know rename these variables so
that we can actually experiment around
with them
so one and second and then press enter
it's going to yell at us because we
don't have a semicolon at the end of our
first variable declaration and that's
why that semicolon is so important it
kind of indicates the end of an
expression just for an example here's a
bunch of code that i wrote that is
demonstrating that we can have multiple
different things on the right side of
our expression so you can see in each
line we have our basic variable
declarations but on the right side we
have anything from a number to another
variable to a string to an object to an
immediately invoked function to a
combination sorry it keeps disappearing
a combination or addition of variables
and if we were to console.log
variable
6 here you're going to see hello my name
is zach and basically what that's doing
is it's taking the value derived from
variable 5 which is returning us
this hello my name is and then it's
adding to variable 3 which is zach so
you can see how we have a lot of
different options on the right side and
this is always going to equal the value
which could
come from a function or a specific data
type it can come from a lot of things
and that is assigned to the target
container on the left side of the equal
sign all right let's go a little bit
simpler here again i'm going to paste in
three variables the first one we have is
a number the second is a string and the
third is a boolean so let's talk about
these different data types a little bit
there are a couple different data types
in javascript and the three most common
are sitting on the screen right now
these are kind of the prim primitive
data types now you might notice that as
we have declared and assigned these
variables we didn't really mention what
data type we are specifying here and in
a lot of languages such as c or c plus
plus or java they actually require you
to specify what type of data you are
assigning to this variable
another example of that would be
typescript which is actually a superset
of javascript that we might talk about a
little bit later in the series but
basically it's a it's a language that
compiles down or it's actually
transpiled down to javascript and it
allows for type uh checking or static
typing
so this is how you would declare a
variable within typescript so we would
say the variable 1 equals a number and
that is equal to 10. so in this
declaration and assignment we are saying
okay we have this variable one this is a
number and here's the value which is a
number assigned to it and this is what
we would call a statically typed
language and when we say statically
typed all we mean by that is the fact
that you are
before you run your code telling the
compiler what types of data to expect
now javascript is what we would call a
dynamically typed language and you can
see this above where
this variable 1 the compiler is going to
have no clue what type of variable this
is until it actually evaluates
the assignment value that you've given
it and figures out what type it is and
you can actually see the type of each
variable so if we typed in variable 1
using this built-in type of function
we can also say variable 2 and variable
3 to see the different types of the
variables so you might say well if
javascript is dynamically typed
and we don't really need to specify the
data type that we're assigning to the
variable then why should we even care
well that is exactly the reason you
should care because if you're writing
code like this and you're assigning all
sorts of different values to
these variables it's really important
that you always recognize what types of
values you're assigning to your
variables so that you know you don't try
to do something like this where you say
variable 1
plus variable
and then it will say 10 some value so
clearly something happened here you
tried to
add a number in a string together
but javascript has magically coerced the
first variable which is a number into a
string and it has combined those or
concatenated those strings together into
a single string
so without understanding the different
data types that you're assigning to your
variables
things like this are going to get very
confusing and you might try to add
things together or combine variables
together and you don't know why they're
combining in the way that they are this
right here is actually called implicit
coercion of a variable type we're not
going to talk about this quite yet but
basically what's happening is it's
taking variable 1 which is of type
number and variable 2 which is of type
string and it's saying i want to coerce
this number into a string and then
combine the values together so you can
have a variable such as
number 1
will equal to will be equal to 10 as a
string
and then we can say number
equals
20 as a number and if we said the type
of number one it's going to give us a
string and the type of number two is
going to be a number but what we can
actually do is explicitly rather than
implicitly coerce these two
variables together so if we implicitly
do it and say number one plus number two
it's going to give us 10 20 because it
is basically coerced this number of 20
into a string and concatenated together
with this
first string which is 10. but if i
wanted to add these two together as
numbers all i have to do is use the
built-in math function
to
or not math i'm sorry
number function to
put the number 1
which is a string into a number and then
i can add that to number 2 which is
already a number and now it's going to
give me the correct answer
which is 30 and that is the addition of
those two numbers so you can see that if
you're not paying attention to the types
of data that you're working with you
might have unexpected results as we saw
right here when we added a string and a
number together all right so now that
we've talked about the importance of
data types let's go through each of them
and just get an overview of what they
look like
so let's clear this out
so the first one we're going to do is a
string value
and there are actually two ways that you
can declare a string value you can first
say
something like hello world with these
single quotations and that would be
valid you can also say another string
value and specify with double quotations
hello world and that's going to work
just the same there's no better you know
way to do this but i would say just like
we use lower camel case for
writing javascript variables the
convention within the industry is
generally going to converge on these
single quotes and a lot of
code linters which actually
a code linter is something that will
take a big style guide like the ones we
looked at before and it'll actually
write these rules into code and then
while you're typing your code within a
code editor like visual studio code it
will take all those rules and it will
apply it to the code that you're writing
as you're writing it
so a lot of these code linters are going
to specify that they want your code
written with these single quotes rather
than the double quotes
that you can also write a string as
moving on to numbers these are a little
bit easier all you have to say
let's say number values are variable all
you have to do is specify a number and
there's nothing nothing to it here now
the one thing that you might mess up on
at some point let's just make this a
different variable you might try to add
a comma in there to specify a larger
number and when you press enter here
it's going to give you a syntax error
because this is not a valid way to write
a number you always have to just write
the number as one big number there's no
commas or anything that you can put in
it booleans are also pretty simple so if
we want to write a boolean
boolean value
is going to either be equal to true or
it's going to be equal to false so
that's pretty simple there's only two
possible values that you can put in
there
that's booleans now the next one is
arrays and this is where we start to get
into a little bit more complex data
types
so let me clear the screen to work on
this real quick
and if we wanted to say
first array
and then we want to put in some numbers
here
we can do that
and you can see that an array is
specified by these opening enclosing
brackets and then values here that are
separated by commas
so you can think of an array and i know
computer science
people would yell at me for saying this
but you can think of this array as just
basically a list
and this list is separated by commas and
within this list you can actually put
any data type that you want so we have
numbers in this first array but we could
also put in a variety of data types so
we can put in a number
a string here we can put in an object
we're going to get to that in
a second
and we can also put in another array so
we just put in another array within this
array so these are all valid things you
can put in an array and you can kind of
mix them together you probably won't do
this very often where you're mixing data
types but just wanted to
say that you can do that and that's part
of javascript's dynamically typed
language feature now the important thing
to understand about arrays is that
they're indexed and when we say index
each of these values separated by commas
are
uh identified by a single index and
these indexes start at zero so they
don't start at one as you would think so
in this first array you might say oh
this value 10 is represented by the
index of 1. well no that's not the case
this is represented by the index of 0
and then you just count up in order so
10 would be represented by 0
20 would be represented by 1 30 by 2 and
40 by 3. and we can retrieve these
values from the array
by saying first array so you type out
your array variable and then you use
brackets just like you
did to write them but this time you pass
in the index so if we wanted to grab
this value of 10 from the first array we
just type in the zeroth index
and press enter and it's going to give
us that value from the array now we can
also retrieve
these other values so say from the
second array let's say that we wanted to
get this last value which is actually
another array we could say console.log
second array
and then we can use brackets and we'll
count this is zero this is one this is
two and then this would be the third
so we can say three
and that's going to give us this array
we can even tack on another set of
brackets and we'll say we want the third
or the actually the second value
i'm sorry i'm misspeaking totally here
we want the fourth value from this array
by using the index of three and then
let's say we want the zeroth value or
this value of one from the the array
that we've grabbed there and now you can
see that we can grab
values from nested arrays so that's the
important thing to know about arrays you
have to pay attention to the indexes and
then you use bracket notation to
retrieve those values from their
respective indexes
the next thing we'll talk about is
objects and in javascript these are very
important you might even hear the phrase
that everything is an object in
javascript
and that that is true i don't want to
get into the subtleties of it today but
it is very important nonetheless to
learn how these objects work in
javascript because you're going to be
using them in every single program that
you ever write to understand objects
just think of them as a complex
container so going back to that amazon
analogy where you have those carts of
different containers and then within the
containers
let's say that you have other containers
that have the amazon products so let's
say that you have some sort of jewelry
product
that is sold on amazon you might have a
big container and then you might have 30
different little containers within that
big container
and then within each of those
30 little containers you have
different pieces of jewelry so that is
kind of what a javascript object is all
about
you can make it infinitely complex
infinitely nested
there's just so much you can do with it
so let's jump in and see what a basic
object looks like
so we'll say
object variable
and then this is indicated by these
little curly braces
this is what you enclose an object in
and then within an object you have to
give it properties so these properties
are written just like a javascript
variable and you can kind of think of
them as variables contained within the
object so we might say prop 1 and then
you use a little colon to say okay that
variable i want to assign the following
value to so we'll say we want to assign
uh the number 20.
and then to create another property you
have to put a comma
after the first property so it's sort of
kind of like an array where you have
a bunch of different values separated by
commas but in this case you kind of have
to think of it as a key value pair so
this is the key which would be the prop
1 or the variable and then this is the
value right here on the other side of
the colon if you want to say prop 2 and
then we want to set that to 50 you can
do so like that then you put your
semicolon at the end press enter and now
we have the object variable with prop 1
and prop 2. now to access these
properties within the object we use
something called dot notation so unlike
the array where we would say object
variable and then you put little
brackets and say
0 or something like that we can't do
that that's not going to work but if we
said object variable dot
prop 1
like that then we're going to get the
value of 20. so we access the properties
using dot notation and this can be
infinitely nested so let's construct an
object right here
we'll say it's a nested object and it'll
be equal to
we'll say layer 1
and then layer 2
and we're just making a bunch of objects
nested within each other and then we'll
say target value will be 20. and so this
target value is simply a property
nested within
several other properties within this
object
so we'll press enter and then to get
that value you just say nested object
dot layer 1 dot layer 2 dot layer 3
and then dot target value and you get
the value of 20. so you can see how this
dot notation allows you to basically
grab the
values of the properties off of
the object and notice how when i'm using
this dot notation
i'm specifying the property so we could
also do this um so we're going back to
our object variable right up here
so we can also like i said you can't use
this zero here but what you can do
is you can use this bracket notation you
just have to define the property that
you want to grab
in that bracket notation so that's
another way to retrieve a value from an
object
i prefer the dot notation usually but in
some cases you might need this because
maybe you know the name of the property
so you know the name of the property is
property one so instead of explicitly
writing this
property as a string you might store it
in another variable and then pass
the property value variable into your
object
i don't want to get too far into that
because that's going down a little bit
of a rabbit hole but you may need both
of these in certain situations
the last thing we'll talk about is
functions and we're not really going to
talk about them much
but i did want to say that functions are
valid
things that you can assign to a variable
and this goes back to the concept of
everything is an object in javascript so
let me just show you a brief example
we'll say
function container
variable just to be descriptive here
and then we can write a function like
this
and this function will maybe return the
value of 20. so we are storing that
function in this variable and then we
can actually uh call this function like
this and get the value of 20 that was
returned from it but we haven't learned
how functions work return values all
that stuff so don't worry about this i
just wanted to show you that this is a
variable and we can actually assign a
function
to that variable so that's a valid thing
to put on the right side of that equal
side all right if you're still here huge
congrats you're probably one of very few
people that
have the patience to sit through a video
of mine
that goes into sometimes excruciating
detail about things
but thank you for watching i just want
to go through a quick summary of what we
learned here and then offer you some
exercises that you can
use to actually practice the concepts we
learned in this video so just to
summarize when using variables we first
have to declare it and then we have to
assign it a value
and these are often done in the same
line of code the same step
when we are using the different keywords
so let const and var
we probably never want to use var but
when we use let it's because we want to
reassign the value of a variable and
when we use const it's because we expect
the value of this variable to not change
within the program
next up the left side of the equal sign
represents the variable that will hold
the value that you're assigning so it's
kind of the target for that data
the right side represents the actual
value
there are many ways to write a
javascript variable but camelcase is the
preferred way you'll see this most often
in the javascript community
and then there are five main types of
variables you have strings numbers
booleans arrays in objects
and those functions that we just talked
about kind of fall into that object data
type
so the final thing is that a semicolon
represents the end of a javascript
expression you always put that at the
end except if you're using an object in
which case you can enter down onto
multiple lines and you actually have to
use commas to separate those different
object properties that's it for the
summary now let's move on to the
challenges and practice for this video
so like i said you're not going to be
able to just watch these videos and
learn how to code you have to actually
apply them
and at the end of each video i want to
at least give you a few challenges to
work through to apply your knowledge
so i'm going to just put these
challenges on the screen here for a few
seconds
and you can go ahead and work through
them in the console within the firefox
dev tools that we talked about in the
previous
lesson and how to use that and the
answers are going to be on my github
account and i'll link to those in the
description so that you can see if you
got them right all right on to the
challenges for today good luck and i
will see you in the next video
[Music]
today we're going to be talking about
javascript operators and be sure to
stick around till the end because i have
a handful of challenges for you to try
out and solve on your own to practice
the skills that you learn in this video
before we talk about javascript
operators i want to do a little review
of what we talked about in the previous
video which was javascript variables and
data types because they're going to
actually come into play during this
video so if we right click anywhere in
our firefox web browser and click
inspect element
let me make this a little bit larger for
us so that we can see
and then you go to the console you're
going to
get into a repl or i think that stands
for read evaluate print and loop which
basically allows you to execute
javascript without setting anything up
so we're going to be using this to
code in this lesson but also to review
what we did last time so last time we
talked about javascript variables
and the way that you declare and assign
a variable is one of three ways we can
say
const and then a space and then the
variable name we're just going to call
it a here
and then you give it some sort of value
this is a valid way to define a variable
we can also do it with let a equals 20
and we could or not we can't use a
actually because we already declared
this up here with the const so we need
to do something like b
and then we can also use var but i don't
recommend using this because it's kind
of an outdated legacy feature of
javascript but nevertheless it still
works we can still declare and assign a
variable that way
now we also talked about how
you cannot reassign
something that you
assigned as cons so if you wanted to say
value will not change
as the variable name and you set that
equal to 20 and then you try to say
value will not change equals 30 it's
going to give you an error because you
assigned it with const but if you say
instead of const you say let and then
value will change
equals 20. then you can come down here
and say value will change equals 30 and
it lets you do that so that's the
difference between const and let again
we don't use var because it's kind of a
legacy
keyword in javascript now we also talked
about the different data types that you
can use so i'll just use the const
keyword for our variables here we'll say
my string equals hello world so we can
define a string value which is
represented by these little
quotations the single quotations
and declare that as a variable now we
can also again i just press the up arrow
on my keyboard to get that last command
that we typed and we can kind of circle
through all of the commands that
i have typed along the way
but anyways we can declare a string so
we'll say the second string
this is basically just a different
variable and we can use double quotes to
do the same thing so these are
functionally equivalent some style
guides would recommend that you use
single quotes others would recommend
double quotes it doesn't really matter
you just got to pick one
so that's how you define a string and if
we wanted to define a number so
my number we just give it a number
that's pretty easy we also have booleans
which are going to either be true or
they're going to be false so that's
pretty easy there's only two answers
that you can possibly have there and
then finally we have arrays and objects
let me clear some space here
so we'll start with my array
and we can fill that with pretty much
anything so we can do some numbers right
here so that'll be our first array and
then maybe we can say our second array
will be
something like string one
and string two
and if you remember we can access the
properties from these arrays by using
bracket notation so we just look for the
index
this would be the zeroth index the first
index the second and the third so we use
that here to identify
different objects or different
values within that array and then
finally we have objects which are going
to be a little bit more complex and
they're kind of the the cornerstone of
javascript
but we can say
property1
equals some value and then so that's a
string value and we can access that by
just saying using dot notation so we
just say myobject dot and then property
one and that's going to give us some
value we can also with objects use
bracket notation
and if we pass in the string version of
that property it will still give us some
value so that's just a quick review of
how javascript variables work and all
the different data types now we're going
to take these concepts and extend them a
little bit further in talking about
javascript operators so the first thing
we got to basically resolve is what is
an operator well an operator is
something that exists in all coding
languages not just javascript the one
we're working in you'll see these
operators in anything from javascript
python
you know java c c plus plus all of these
different languages have this concept of
operators and there's not a really great
way to explain it without just jumping
in but basically how i'd summarize it is
an operator is something that allows you
to
either compare two values or more than
two values
you can modify values modify variables
you know combine them together it just
allows you some more flexibility in kind
of to test the
different equalities of different
variables so i know that's a kind of a
tough explanation but let's just jump in
you'll see what i mean now there are
four main types of operators we're
looking at arithmetic assignment
comparison and logical operators you'll
see how these kind of fit in in just a
second when we jump into them we'll
start with some of the easiest ones
which would be arithmetic operators so
this would be plus
minus or addition subtraction
multiplication
and division so you can see how this
works it's pretty easy
we can have a series of numbers and and
remember we're using a javascript
console which basically
reads the value of a javascript
expression and then prints it back to us
once we start writing code in files
later in the series we're not going to
be able to
like let's just say some random
variable here equals 20
and you can see that all we have to do
is type in some random variable and
press enter and it's going to evaluate
what the
variable actually has stored in it we
don't actually have to use this
console.log statement that we have been
looking at in prior videos you know you
definitely can and it's going to print
20 but you don't have to you can just
type it the variable so this is going to
be very useful when looking at these
operators here so in any javascript
console you can just take numbers like
this so we'll say 20
plus 50
and that will equal 70 and it shows how
it evaluates those and this plus sign in
the middle is considered a javascript
operator so you can already start to see
what these
operators actually represent you can
also do something like 50
minus 20 i'm trying to space it out here
for us but
we can say 50 minus 20 equals 30. and we
can also do some division so 20 divided
by 2 is 10
as well as multiplication
2 times 2 is going to be equal to 4. so
these are all what we call operators
this plus operator the subtraction
operator division and multiplication and
these are the most basic arithmetic
operators at this point you might be
wondering well what are we doing here
i've never seen this
syntax written before
well this is not actually valid
javascript code
it works here in the console but if you
try to write it in a file it's not going
to work out so well
generally you're going to be doing these
operations and assigning the value to an
actual variable
so let's say that we want to
do a result variable
and we want to say 20 plus 50
divided by 2 or something like that and
we save that and now we print out the
result and it's going to be 45 because
we did 20 plus 50
is going to be 70 divided by 2 is 45 and
then it stores it within this result
variable so what we call the right side
here and this is going back to the prior
lesson we talked a little bit about the
left side of the equal sign and the
right side of the equal sign
so this equal sign right here so we've
got left and then right
everything on the right side is what
we're going to be calling a javascript
expression and so we're using all these
different values along with the
operators to create some sort of
expression that is going to be evaluated
in full and then once it's evaluated
it's going to take that single value
that it
came up with and assign it to the
variable on the left side of that equal
sign there are actually a couple more
arithmetic operators as well so we can
use something called a modulus operator
so let's do a hundred and then a little
percent sign and then we'll say 50 and
that's going to equal zero and basically
what this is doing is doing a division
problem so 100 divided by 50 and then
it's figuring out what is the remainder
of that division problem in this case 50
is a factor of 100 it goes into 100 two
times with no remainders so we're going
to get zero but what if we said a
hundred
modulus i don't know 77 well
we're going to get 23 because 77 goes
into 100 one time with a remainder of
23. so this may not seem very useful to
you right now but i promise you there's
going to be times when you're coding
where this modulus operator will come in
handy moving on we also have the
exponent operator so if we wanted to say
i don't know eight
to the power of two so generally you
would see it written like this
well this is not actually what the
exponent operator looks like we would
have to put in 2 stars here
and we'll say 8 to the power of 2 is
going to equal 64. 8 times 8 is 64. and
that's how we use the exponentiation
operator so that's two little stars you
can remember that where the
multiplication is going to be
1 star so 8 times 2 is 16 and then if we
do 8 double star 2 that's 8 to the power
of 2. so that's the exponent operator
and then finally there's a couple
operators that are not going to kind of
fit into this
this schema that we've been looking at
so far it's going to be a little bit
confusing but i'll try to explain it
best i can
one of those is going to be the
increment operator and then the next
will be the decrement operator so let's
say that we have a variable i'm going to
intentionally mess this one up so let's
say that we have a starting
number and that will be equal to
zero now notice what we used here we
used the const
keyword here so we cannot reassign this
value
so the operator that we're trying to use
here is called the increment operator
and the way that it works is you take a
variable or some value and you put two
plus signs at the end and when we press
enter you're going to see that it's
invalid because we have a const
declaration or a value that cannot
change now if we wanted to declare this
with the let operator
so we'll say start number this is a
different
uh actually let's just clear the whole
screen so that we're we're very clear on
what we're doing here
so we'll say let
starting
number
equal zero
now this value can be reassigned so all
we have to do is say starting number
plus plus
and when we press enter it's going to
say zero but the actual value of the
starting number variable is actually
equal to 1 and we can see that by
printing it out once more and if we do
this increment operator again
and then we print out starting number
again we're going to get 2. so you can
see how it's adding 1 to the variable
and this is actually equivalent to
saying
starting number equals starting number
plus 1. so you take the previous value
and you add 1. so if we press enter now
you're going to see that the starting
number is equal to 3. now we can also do
this with a decrement operator so we can
say starting number
actually let me clear the screen real
quick we'll say starting number which is
currently at three and put two little
minus signs at the end and it's going to
now equal two and we can do it again
a couple minuses and now it's equal to
one so you might say well why is this
useful
in many cases when you're going through
loops which we're going to talk about in
a future video this is going to come in
handy so we just made it through the
arithmetic operators but now we can move
on to something called an assignment
operator and believe it or not we've
actually already covered this so when we
write a variable
my variable equals 20
we're actually using an
operator already so this equal sign that
we've talked about so much is actually
an assignment operator
and believe it or not this is the only
assignment operator that you're ever
going to need although this is all
you'll ever need um pretty much forever
i want to show you some of the other
assignment operators that we can use
just so that you know that they're out
there but once again these are not
required and quite honestly i don't even
use these a lot of programmers that have
been coding for 20 30 years will never
use these so they're just this is just
for educational purposes
honestly i would recommend just writing
your code out long form i'm going to
show you what i mean in just a second
let's say that we had a value we'll
assign a variable equal to 10. notice
how we use this let keyword so we can
reassign this variable and what if we
wanted to add 5 to it well this would be
pretty simple all we would have to do is
say x equals and then we want to take
the previous value of x which is
currently equal to 10
and we add using the addition operator
5. so that's the end of our expression
press enter and now x is equal to 15.
well there's actually a shorter way to
write this and all we have to do is use
a different assignment operator so the
way that we would do this let's start
over i'm going to refresh the page
clear out all this nonsense up here and
let's say that we have our variable
again equal to 10 well we can also write
it like this we'll say plus equal
5 and when i press enter this is
actually going to reassign that variable
of x from 10
to 15. so add 5 to it
and you can see that if we print out x
it's now equal to 15. so you can see
this little operator here the plus and
then the equal sign this is an
assignment operator
which works the same as just our normal
equal sign but instead it's going to
take whatever's on the right side of it
and it's going to add it to the variable
on the left side we also have this for
every different operation so we have the
plus equals so let's let's just start
with x we'll use this as an example here
again
so we'll say plus equals 5 this should
turn it into 20.
we also have
x
minus equal to 5 which should bring it
back down to 15.
we have
x
divided by equals and then we'll say 3
so that should equal 5
and then finally we have x multiply
equals
we'll say 2 and that's going to equal
10. so you can see how we have several
different assignment operators that are
just shortcuts for us to do something
that we could already do
writing it out long hand and what i want
to say about this like i said
you don't need these operators all you
really need is this one right here and
that's the equal sign
and the reason being is
sure you could save a few characters of
code but it's just a lot more clear if
we wanted to take
our value so let's get x this is
currently equal to 10.
it's much more clear in my opinion if we
just say x equals x plus five
rather than saying x plus or equal to
five and it just eliminates the need to
memorize a bunch of stuff
you really just don't need these and i
would recommend just not worrying about
them so just to do a little recap we
have our arithmetic operators so let me
just write this out in a comment
so we have our arithmetic operators and
this is going to be plus
minus
multiply
divide
modulus
increment
decrement and i believe that covers all
of it
i apologize if i missed one here but
these are all arithmetic operators and
they allow us to basically
modify
different variables
we also have assignment operators so
assignment
operators
and this is going to be the equal sign
that we're very familiar with
the plus equals minus equals
multiply equals and divide equals these
are all valid assignment operators but
once again i just recommend learning
this one and being done with it now the
next sort of operators that we can talk
about are comparison operators and in my
opinion these are the hardest to
understand because
it introduces a concept that we haven't
really looked at a lot yet let's go
ahead and start with a basic example
so let's assign a result variable and
we'll assign it equal to the following
javascript expression
and when we
print out this result variable it's
going to equal true
and if you can just kind of logically
think through this
not to be confused with logical
operators
but if we can just think through this 20
is greater than 18 this is actually the
greater than operator we're going to
talk about all of these in a second
but you can basically figure this out
intuitively
this is bigger than this so the result
should be true right
well let's bring in something a little
bit more complicated so
let's say something like
i don't know
constant result
2 is going to be equal to
equal sign three times and then 20.
so in this case it's a little bit harder
to understand what we're doing here
we've got an equal sign here and then we
have three more over here and this has
probably got you thinking like well
what's going on here the answer to this
expression is going to be true and that
is because 20 does equal 20
but we have to understand what's going
on here on the right side of the equal
sign before we can really think through
this
so to really understand this we have to
get super super clear when we're talking
about the left side of the equal sign in
the right side of the equal sign we
talked about this in the last lesson but
we're going to go into this even deeper
now
so if we look at this second expression
that we did
this is the assignment operator and we
have to be clear what we're looking at
here so the left side is going to be the
variable that we're assigning the right
side over here too so this right side as
i talked about a little bit earlier is
going to evaluate to some value some
single value and this is what we call a
javascript expression and in this case
we're using a special operator
which is the triple equal sign and this
triple equal sign behaves in a certain
way that basically says well
is the left side of it and the right
side of it or maybe this a little bit
confusing is 20 equal to 20 in both
value and type so we talked about data
types before and this is where that all
comes into play
so as we go through these make sure that
you're being clear about what you're
looking at so the left side versus the
right side these equal signs over here
are not doing the same thing as this
equal sign right here think of this as
kind of like the master equal sign that
kind of determines
everything about this whole javascript
statement and then any other equal sign
that you see are actually going to be
operators that are doing some sort of
comparison when we're talking about
comparison operators in javascript there
are four main comparison operators that
have to do with equality so we have the
triple equal sign
we have the double equal sign
we have the
not equal sign with two right there and
then we have the not equals with one so
you can think of these two so this this
one right here and this one right here
these are kind of opposites while the
double equals and the single exclamation
and single equals are kind of
functionally opposite now what do they
actually do well to find out we need to
start playing around with a few values
so once again just like we could do 20
plus 20 and get 40 we can also evaluate
different expressions using these
comparison operators so if we said 20
double equals 20 that's going to
evaluate to true we could also say 20
triple equals 20 is going to evaluate to
true so what's the difference between
the two well the difference is it has to
do with the data type that we're working
with so if you remember from the last
lesson
20 written like this is going to be very
different from the 20 written like this
in the first case we're looking at a
number in the second case we're looking
at a string and you can see that the
expression evaluates to true but we're
not quite there yet so let's say
we want a number value and that'll be
equal to that 20
and then we also want a string
value which is going to be equal to i
don't know we'll say 50. but notice how
we have these single quotations we could
also have done
double quotations here
doesn't really matter it's just another
way to write it and so now we have a
number value and a string value and if
we use the type of operator this is
actually one that will
we've we've already used a little bit
but this is actually an operator itself
and then we put the number value it's
going to evaluate to number and we can
also put in the string value and that
will be a string so we know that this
number variable in the string variable
are of number and string types but we
can try to compare them
with each other using the double equals
and triple equals equality so i kind of
messed up here i meant to say that this
string value should be equal to 20. so
let me just go ahead and redo this once
more
so we'll say string value equals
and then we'll say number value equals
20 and we're back to where we started
here and now what we can do is we can
say string value double equals
number value and this is going to be
equal and it's going to return a value
of true which is a boolean
and the reason being is because while
these are not the same data type
they are the same value so if we were to
convert
this string value into a number so we
can use the built-in javascript number
function
and pass in the string value
we're going to get 20 which is a valid
javascript number and what's happening
here
when we compare the string value
to the number value using the double
equal sign what it's doing is it's first
converting them to the same data type so
it might convert the string value to a
number and then compare it to the number
value so it's comparing apples to apples
and then it checks whether the actual
values are going to be equal to each
other in this case they're both equal to
20 so we have a resultant
expression
of true now if we tried to do this with
triple equals so string value triple
equals number value
we're going to get false because this
time if we do triple equals it's not
going to convert the types to match each
other so basically what it's saying is
um well yeah the numbers the actual
values are the same but the data types
are not so therefore this expression
evaluates to false so when we're looking
at these different the double equals and
the triple equals the double equals does
not care about the data type well the
triple equals does care about the data
type
and in almost all cases i would
recommend using triple equals because
we're just being a lot more explicit
about what we're writing in our code
that way well you can see that string
value does
resolve the true when we compare it with
the double equal sign
this is only because it is implicitly
coercing the data type
of these values now if we did it with
the triple equal sign it's obviously
false because they're different values
but like i said we could do the number
string value so this is explicitly not
implicitly like javascript does with the
double equals but we are explicitly
coercing this string into a number and
then we can triple equals compare it to
this number value
and it's going to equal true like i
mentioned these comparison operators are
probably the most difficult of all the
operators to kind of grasp your head
around
nevertheless hopefully this makes sense
when we're talking about double equals
versus triple equals and then
furthermore
if we were to set a
result variable equal to the value of
string value triple
or double equals
number value which we know equals true
right here then what's going to happen
even though we have these equal signs on
the right side remember right side
versus left side we have these this
expression this entire expression on the
right side of this equal sign
and therefore what javascript is doing
is it's saying okay first let me look at
this is this expression let me evaluate
it and see what it results in
in this case it results in true so now i
have a true value on the right and now i
want to assign this into the result
variable so we press enter and we're
going to get the value of true in that
result variable now moving on to the
not equals or this little exclamation
point with the double equals or the
exclamation with a single equal sign
these are basically the opposite of what
we were doing with the double
and triple equal signs so let's try this
once more we'll say
we want a number value of 20
and then we want a string value of also
20 but this is in string form
so these are not going to be equal if we
use the triple equal sign
because that cares about the value and
the type
but it will be equal if we use the
double equal sign now if we just plop in
this exclamation part point it's going
to reverse everything so if we do the
exclamation point with a single equal
sign and then we say string value that's
basically saying um is the number value
not equal to the string value and in
this case it is equal to the string
value because we're using only one equal
sign
so the answer is false i know that's a
little bit tough to wrap your head
around but if you think about it long
enough it'll make sense
now if we plop in this double equal sign
and put in the string value
this is going to evaluate to true
because remember if we have the uh
in in the case of let's say hold on one
second
triple equals this is going to carry
care about the value and the type so
it's the same deal with this
exclamation point in the double equals
so basically it's saying the number
value is not equal to the string value
because the types are not equal
and it evaluates to true because no
they're actually not equal to each other
so just try to reverse it in your head
don't think about this too much
when the time comes you'll figure out
how to use these but i just wanted to
briefly go over them and show you that
they're just the exact opposite of
double and triple equals
now with these equality operators it
gets a little bit tricky when dealing
with different data types so
thus far we've only compared numbers and
strings so if we said 20 triple equals
20 that equals true because it's
a number
in comparison to a number and they're of
the same type we can also say 20 double
equals 20 because you know that's kind
of saying the same thing it doesn't care
about the types the types are the same
doesn't care but the values are the same
so it equals true we can also compare
strings so we can say hello world
and that is going to be triple equals to
hello world and that's going to equal
true and we're also able to remove one
of those equal signs and it's going to
give us the same answer because
the values are the same the types are
the same it doesn't really matter there
so we can use it with numbers and
strings we can also do booleans so if we
said true
triple equals true that's going to give
us true now i know that's a little bit
of a
tongue twister there but we're saying
that the value of true which is a
boolean
is equal to another value of true so
that expression evaluates to a truthy
value and it prints true so i've said
true about 50 times the last 30 seconds
so let me stop doing that
but basically we can do strings numbers
and booleans with our equality operators
now if we try to do arrays and objects
the game changes a little bit so let's
say that we have an object which is
equal to
we'll say
property1 some value
and then we'll we'll go down
actually i needed to hold shift down
while i did that so let me redo this
real quick
so starting over we have my object and
this will be equal to
property
which is equal to some string value and
then we have we'll say property 2
is going to be equal to a number
and there's our object we also will
define my array
and this will be equal to one two three
four five
just a bunch of numbers in there
and all we have to say to prove this out
is
is my array
equal to my
array and the value here is going to be
equal to true because you're comparing
the same variable with itself but let's
say that we created another array and
this time it's going to equal the same
exact thing so i'm going to put in the
same exact numbers it's going to look
exactly the same
we'll press enter and now if we compare
my array triple equals another array
it's going to equal false
so in the first case when we were
comparing the same variable with itself
it equals true which makes sense
but why does this not equal
each other why does my array not equal
another array they look exactly the same
and this is one of the quirky parts of
javascript you'll hear that a lot but
i'm not going to get into why these are
not equal
and actually how to compare two
different arrays
using javascript it's just too complex
for what we're talking about but just
know you cannot compare everything and
the same goes for objects so if we said
my object triple equals my object it's
going to equal true because we're
comparing the same exact object but if
we say another object and we make that
equal to the same exact one so property
is going to be equal to some value
and then property 2
is going to be equal to 20. so this is
the same exact object that we had
up top but this time if we say my object
triple equals another
object
we're going to get false and you might
be wondering well maybe this is just
because we're using triple equals well
that's not the case even if we used my
array
double equals another array it's still
going to be false and if we use my
object double equals another object it
will also be false so you cannot compare
with these comparison operators arrays
and objects you actually have to use a
different library in a lot of cases and
a lot of developers turn to a library
called lodash
so if we
just type in lowdash into the browser
you'll see that this is a utility
library
that basically provides you with a bunch
of different methods that you can use to
do a bunch of common javascript
operations that would otherwise take you
writing a good amount of code to do but
again this is way too complex for what
we're doing right now so we're going to
go back and keep going with our
discussion on operators so we've gotten
through the bulk of these comparison
operators the hardest ones are done now
we just have to talk about numeric
comparison operators and these will not
come as a surprise we have the greater
than less than greater or equal to and
less than or equal to operators
and you can see how these work
40 is greater than 20 that's true
20 is less than 40. that's also true 20
is less than or equal to 20. that is
true and 20 is greater than or equal to
20.
so you can see how these
all work they're pretty common and if
you took any sort of math class you'll
know exactly how these work now the
final operator that falls into this
comparison operator category is
something called the ternary operator
and that is spelled let's see if i can
spell this ternary is what i'm saying
here and this ternary operator is going
to look like this so we'll say we want
to assign a result variable and we want
to assign this equal to the following
expression so we'll say 20 triple equals
20.
we'll add a little question mark and
then we'll say
values match
and then we'll add a colon and we'll say
values do not match and we'll press
enter and you're going to see that the
result is values match so this is a very
confusing expression to look at at first
glance but you will get used to this
this is something that a lot of
programmers really like some of them do
not like it because they think it makes
it more complicated
we haven't talked about conditionals yet
but i think you'll be able to understand
this a little bit so i'm going to try to
explain it real quick
this this expression right up here
is going to be functionally equivalent
to the following expression so we'll say
if
triple equals 20
then we'll say
return
or actually no we need to
redo this real quick we need to first
say
or declare a variable so we'll say
result variable
and we don't need to assign a value to
it yet we'll say if 20 triple equals 20
then we want to assign the result
variable
equal to values match
and if it does not equal so else that
our result variable is going to be equal
to values do not match
if i can spell right
okay so when we press enter it's going
to say that it evaluated two values
matched just like it showed up here when
we printed the result if we type out
result variable you can see that it has
been assigned that value so i wanted to
show you this even though we haven't
gone through the if else statements yet
the conditionals
but i think it's fairly intuitive to
understand we're saying if this
expression evaluates to true then i want
to assign the variable to what is after
this question mark or the values match
otherwise this else statement
which is going to be substituted by the
colon we want to assign it to values do
not match so in other words this
question mark is kind of like the if
part and this colon is kind of like the
else part and this uh everything left of
the question mark is going to be the
expression that we're actually
evaluating
and remember this is where it gets you
know this is where it's kind of
confusing when you're first starting out
remember we have to keep the right side
and the left side separate in our head
so we're looking at this equal sign
what is to the left side of the equal
sign well that is the result variable
now what is to the right side of the
equal sign well that's everything here
so this entire expression is to the
right side and when javascript looks at
this
the first thing it does is it says
what's on the right side and furthermore
how do i evaluate that and then it uses
the rules of this ternary operator to
say okay first i want to look at 20
triple equals 20. what does that resolve
to well that resolves to true for
reasons we discussed before
and therefore i'm going to grab this
value right here now if it would have
resolved to false then it would say okay
i don't want this i actually want
this one over here and then once it's
found that answer
it's done all of this work on the right
side it's come to a single answer which
is the value values match now it's going
to assign that to the result variable so
you have to be very clear with yourself
whether we're talking about the right
side which could be a really long
expression or the left side which is the
target variable that we're assigning the
end result of the right side too we are
finally done with the comparison
operators i know this took up most of
the video but they are very important
and you'll see
why once you start writing a good amount
of code you're going to use them a ton
now the last type of operator is what we
call a logical operator and there's only
three of them we have this
double and sign
we have the double pipe sign
and then we have the exclamation point
now the exclamation point is kind of the
same as what we talked about earlier
with this exclamation equals but it's
kind of going to function in a different
way
using it as a logical operator we'll
start with the and sign and basically
all this is doing is it's saying it's
looking at two different expressions so
triple equals 20 and then we put the and
sign
and now we can say 10
triple equals 10 and what it's saying is
okay on the left side we have this
expression 20 equals 20 which evaluates
to true
and then in order for the entire
expression so this whole line in order
for this to be true both sides have to
evaluate to true so in this case we get
true but we could also say 12 and in
this case it's going to be false because
the left side does equal true but in
order for the entire expression to be
true both sides have to be true and you
can see on the right side these are not
equal so we get false now the or
operator if we did the same example
and we said 20 triple equals 20 and then
we use these double pipes this is
basically or
and now we can say 10 triple equals 12
and it's going to be equal to true
because it's saying this entire
expression is going to be equal to true
if one of them is equal to true so in
this case the right side is equal to
true and that's all that we need for
this to work now if we tried to write
this expression where both sides are
actually false
i actually did that wrong there we only
have one pipe in there somehow so we'll
say 20 triple equals 18
double pipes 10 triple equals 12. both
of these are false so it's going to be
false now the last one that we're
talking about let me clear the screen is
going to be this exclamation point what
the exclamation point does is basically
reverses everything so generally we're
going to be talking about a boolean
value here so let's say that we have an
expression 20 triple equals 20 which
evaluates to true obviously if we put
some parentheses around this and then we
it still equals true but then we put an
exclamation at the beginning of that
statement it's going to reverse it to
false now it's important to note you
cannot put this at the end that's not
valid you have to put it at the
beginning of the expression that you're
trying to reverse
so that's what this exclamation point
does and it's a little bit different
than if we were to put in the
exclamation and then the double equals
that does a slightly different thing as
we talked about earlier in the video so
just to show you a practical example of
how you might use one of these
this is a pretty common one that i've
seen and i've used in my apps and we're
not going to actually be writing the
code that i would write in an app but
you'll kind of get the point so we'll
have a variable that says is user
logged in
and we'll set it equal to true so our
user is going to be logged in in this
case and then we'll say does user have
permission
and we'll say false on this one so
it might be a pretty common thing to see
if we were to
uh check both of these values to see
whether a user can perform a specific
action in an app so what we might do is
we'll say
can user
perform
action
and then we'll set that equal to is user
logged in
and
does user have permissions
and in this case if we were to evaluate
this expression on the right side of
this equal sign
that is user logged in as true but this
does have permissions is false so this
entire expression resolves to false
so in many cases in our apps we might
say if can user perform
action or something like that then we
can allow them to perform the action so
that's just a practical example of how
we might use these operators in the real
world in the final part of this video
before we get to the actual challenges
that i'm going to give you
is going to be
combining all of these operators and
this is where this concept of an
expression really comes to life so i'm
going to put a pretty complex expression
on the screen here and we're going to
walk through how it's actually working
so we'll say result is equal to
exclamation point we're going to put a
couple parentheses here
say 40 divided by 20
equals 2
and
then we'll say
something like
i don't know true
and then we'll say on the right side
try to make this clear we'll say or and
then put another parenthesis
yes triple equals to no
and when we evaluate this expression
we're going to see that it equals false
and this is actually a totally valid
javascript expression
although it's very confusing to look at
but if we take this step by step i think
you'll understand how we can combine all
these operators into a single expression
now i will say before we get into this
you generally are not going to be
writing something this complex if you're
writing something that is this confusing
to read then you could probably break it
out into several steps
and it's not a sign of intelligence when
you're trying to make it so complicated
like this you want to be as simple as
possible and in many cases
you're going to write more lines of code
in order to
improve readability of your code so this
code is not readable this is something
that would take someone you know let's
say that i wrote this code and you had
to go review this code this is going to
take you you know at least 20 seconds to
figure out what it's doing
and in most cases we want it so that you
can see exactly what the code is doing
as quickly as possible nevertheless we
can see how this evaluates by breaking
it out into different steps so i'm going
to just store each step in a variable
and then we'll kind of work our way down
to understanding the entire expression
so if you remember we're talking about
the right side versus the left side
left side is the variable right side is
the entire expression so we'll say step
one
is going to be equal to 40 divided by
20. so we'll start right here
so we'll save that into step one now the
second step is we take this 40 divided
by 20 and use the equality operator to
set it equal to 2. so we'll say step 2
is going to be equal to
step 1
triple equals 2
okay so now we can check this at this
point we're equal to true right now and
the next step is going to be taking this
entire expression that we just
basically combined into step two
and adding the and sign and putting it
to true so we're going to say
const step 3
is going to be equal to step 2
double and
true
and you can guess that since we already
had it equal to true right here
and we're doing another boolean value of
true it's going to equal true so step 3
is actually equal to true true right now
and you can see that right there
and now we want to combine this with
we've we've already done this entire
expression here so maybe we want to
store
this in a variable so we'll say step
4 is going to be
equal to
yes
triple equals no which is obviously
going to be equal to false
so that's our step four so now let's
take our step three right here in our
step four and combine them
using these double pipes so we'll say
step five
is equal to
step
three
double pipes and then step
four
and that's going to be equal
to let's see step five will be equal to
true i'll try to scroll up here so we've
got this one
um this one and this entire expression
evaluated so the last thing we need to
do is just add the
exclamation point at the beginning of
everything so all we have to do here is
say step
6 is going to be equal to not
step
and step six is going to be equal to
false and if you see up here the total
result of this entire expression is
equal to false and all these steps that
we did down here were just intermediary
steps that we used to kind of break out
this entire expression and figure out
what the result variable was ultimately
assigned so in summary an expression on
the right side of the equal sign can be
as complex as you want it to be
and furthermore it can actually be
something other than just what we've
been working with
we've been just looking at
simple variables like numbers and
strings and
simple comparisons but it can be much
more complex than that
so you could even have something like
a function evaluating to a specific
variable so let me refresh the page and
we're going to set result equal to a
function and we haven't covered this yet
but i just want to demonstrate
what i'm talking about here so in this
case we're going to return 20 from that
function
so what's happening here is again we
have to be very conscious of the left
side versus the right side so left side
is going to be our result variable and
right side is going to be the entire
function
so in this case we're going to set
the right side equal to a function that
returns a value of 20.
now this is not going to automatically
execute itself so we have to actually
assign it using something called an
immediately invoked function
and once we do that we're going to
actually be assigning that result
variable on the left
equal to whatever this function here
returns when it is evaluated so you can
see a result is equal to 20 and this
kind of just demonstrates for us how the
right side of this equal sign can be
infinitely complex and that's why it's
so important to understand
that an expression should be solved in
individual steps
that's how the computer looks at it and
that's how i would recommend you to look
at it
when you're trying to figure out what
it's going to set that variable to
like i've been saying throughout this
series
watching these videos alone is not going
to do it for you you have to actually
practice so let's jump into some of the
challenges that i've put together for
this video
and i'll say that as we get better
writing code and as we go through all of
the different parts of javascript not
just variables and operators but you
know getting into loops and functions
and conditionals and basically learning
how to write code we're going to
actually migrate ourselves over to a
site called code wars
so if you go over to
codewars.com
you're going to see this is actually a
pretty popular site for
doing different programming challenges
and i'm going to actually start
recommending challenges from this code
wars site and we can basically work on
them out of a profile and you know you
can kind of go through these challenges
on your own but for now we're not quite
advanced enough to look at that so i'm
going to pop up a few challenges on your
screen and then i'm going to walk you
through each of them and how we go about
solving them if you want to get the most
out of this i recommend trying them on
your own first so pause the video for
each of them and try to work them out in
your browser
or your dev tools console and then once
you've figured them out i'll kind of go
through the explanation
all right so this is the first challenge
and the question is why does this code
not work
and the answer is going to be because of
the const declaration that we've made at
the beginning of the code
so if you remember when using const we
cannot reassign the value so if we say
const number variable equals 0 and then
we try to reassign this using our
increment operator it's going to give us
an error but if we go ahead and change
that to let instead of const so we'll
say let number variable
equals zero and then we can say number
variable plus plus
number variable plus plus and then do it
one more time
we're going to be able to do that and
then in the end if we cancel that log
number variable it's going to be equal
to three
so that is the solution to the first
challenge challenge number two so this
one is a little bit of a trick question
these are not going to evaluate to the
same value i think you could probably
figure that out but the second part of
this question is
which one of these would you recommend
and the answer to that i would not
recommend either of these blocks of code
so the first one is going to
evaluate to false because we're using
triple equals well the second one is
going to to evaluate to true because
we're using double equals but in this
case the problem is not either block of
code but
the variables that we're declaring so
this is how i would actually write this
rather than what we have in both of
those code blocks
so we'll say first number equals 20
we'll say the second number
also equals 20 and instead of the string
value let's just put a number in there
that's the real solution right there and
then from there we can define our result
which will be equal to
first number triple equals second number
because we always want to favor triple
equals be explicit
when we can
and then now we can print out the result
which is going to be equal to true so
that's how i'd solve that problem
challenge number three now this one is a
little bit trickier but i think you
probably could have gotten it
let's refresh this screen real quick
now the question was what does the
expression five resolve two and the
answer to that is that expression five
let me make sure i get this right here
answer five is going to resolve to false
and this is why it's going to do that so
let's just walk through each of the
lines and see what they resolve to so we
have a hundred
we'll save them in the variables so
expression one
is a hundred
modulus
fifty and if you remember
hundred divided by fifty is 2 with no
remainder so we should get 0 for this so
expression 1 should be equal to 0 you'll
see that here
now expression
is going to be equal to 100 divided by
50 which does equal two
so that's going to be equal to two
then expression three
is going to be equal to expression one
is less than expression two and in this
case expression 1 was equal to 0 and
expression 2 should be equal to 2. so
this expression right here should
evaluate to true so let's press enter on
that and see if that's the case
we'll say expression 3 that equals true
as we would expect
now expression 4
is going to be equal to expression 3
we'll use the and symbol and we'll say
plus 5
triple equals
so this is a little bit trickier how we
look at this using the order of
operations is we first look at this one
on the right
so we'll say 300 plus 5 what does that
equal
that equals 305 and then so we replace
this basically
and say 305
is triple equals to 305 which is going
to be equal to true so then we kind of
replace that with true and expression 3
is true so they're both true and
expression 4 is going to result in true
and then finally we're just going to
reverse that so expression
5 is going to be equal to
exclamation or the reverse of expression
4 so it's going to flip this true to
false and we're going to get false for
the final answer
and if you tried to solve
the problem of getting this all into one
expression i'm going to just copy this
into the console and just show you how
it works
you can see that we get false just like
we just looked at
and this is how i would combine this
into a single expression remember the
order of operations matters here
moving on to challenge number four this
is actually a slight review of last time
combined with the concepts that we
learned in this video
so we're looking at an object and an
array so we'll say my object i'm just
going to write this out so that we have
something to work with
and we'll say prop 1
is equal to first value
and then prop 2
is going to be equal to 20. so there's
your object and then your array so my
array here is going to be equal to 40
50 and 2.
now if you remember from last time the
way that we access properties from
objects and arrays is with dot notation
and
bracket notation respectively so if we
wanted to say get this value of 20 from
this object all we would do is say my
object dot prop 2.
you could also use the bracket notation
with a string
for prop 2 and that will give you 20.
but i would always prefer using this dot
notation so we'll just get it this way
all right so if we wanted to get one of
the values from this array say we wanted
to get 50 we would have to use bracket
notation and if you remember an array is
zero indexed so this is index 0 this is
index 1 and this is index 2. so if we
wanted to get that 50 all we would say
is my array bracket and then we want to
pass in 1 because the index of 50 is 1
and that will give us that value of 50.
so knowing that this problem gets pretty
easy so we said in our results array
we are saying myobject dot prop 2
triple equals and then my array
divided by my array
2.
so if you remember
we'll store that in the result variable
for now but you just have to basically
break this down into different pieces so
what is
myobject.prop2 well that equals 20. now
what is my array
with the index of 0 well that is going
to be equal to 40. and then what is my
array with the index of 2
that is going to be equal to
if i can type it out here
so we got 2. so basically what this
expression is is it's saying
triple equals
40 divided by 2.
and if we look at that expression that's
going to resolve to true because 40
divided by 2 is 20 set equal to 20 is
true so if you break it down into pieces
it's not all that hard now challenge 5
is a little bit of a tough one but we're
going to use the same method that we did
in challenge 4 to solve it so i'm going
to actually just copy in the object in
the array or basically just all the code
here so we'll copy this in
we'll resolve it and let's
open this up and we need to print the
result which is going to be true
now we have to walk through each step of
this one by one to really understand it
so the first thing that we have to
remember is how to access different
properties so if we wanted to access the
quantity of nested object 1 all we would
have to do is my object dot nested
object
quantity and that's going to give us a
value of 5 down here if we were to
evaluate that expression now the only
tricky part here is this line right here
we're actually putting
the array
or we're assigning each of these nested
objects
as the values of this array
so to access this nested object number
two we could do one of two things we
could say myobject dot nested object
2 and then we might say the price which
is going to give us 150. now since we
put this into our array here we can also
access it access it like this
so we can say my array and then we would
say
we want the nested object number two
which is the
index one so this is index zero this is
index one
so we're gonna grab index one and you
can see it's really nice in the console
you'll see exactly what that evaluates
to
and then from there we can use dot
notation to get the different
attributes from it so the price which is
150.
so knowing this it's pretty easy to
evaluate this expression so if we looked
at my array 0
dot price which is the first part of our
little expression this is going to
evaluate to 100.
then we can say my array
dot quantity which is going to be 5
and then in the second part of this
expression we have the second object in
the array and we're just getting the
price and the quantity so really what
this result variable is saying is it's
saying we want to look at a hundred
times five
and compare that we'll say that's
greater than and then we'll say 150
times 2
and what this evaluates to is true
because 100 times 5 is 500 which is
greater than 150 times 2 which is going
to be 300 so that's going to give you
the result variable and you can see how
if you just break it down into little
steps you'll be able to figure out what
the expression equals and you can
actually
access
nested objects and array properties
by mixing them together
in today's video like i said we're
talking about functions conditionals and
loops and in the previous videos in
lessons three and four we talked about
javascript variables how do we declare
and assign a variable and then also
javascript expressions which includes
all of the different operators whether
those be arithmetic operators assignment
operators
logical operators etc that's what we're
going to do in this video we're going to
cover a lot of ground here
and then we're going to supplement it
with a ton of practice problems so i'm
making a video
where we're going to have 25 javascript
challenges and i'm going to walk you
through them and kind of explain how i'm
going about solving them what i'm
thinking about
and we're going to use the topics that
we covered within this video and the
previous lessons to kind of solve these
problems and we'll fill in a lot of the
gaps that are not covered in the main
content all right let's jump into
conditionals in javascript so we've
actually covered this already
just briefly in previous lessons we
haven't talked about how it works though
so let me show you a basic conditional
statement
we're going to say if some string so
we're talking about a string data type
is triple equals to so we're comparing
value and data type
another string
so these are obviously not going to be
equal because although the
data type is the same the value is not
if that is the case we're going to
console.log
the strings
are equal
and then if it's not we're going to say
else and we're going to console.log
the strings are not equal
all right so that is our basic
conditional statement when i press enter
you're going to see that the strings are
not equal so it basically went into the
second code path that's what we kind of
call it is the the different paths that
the code can take
so we're saying if this is equal then i
want to execute the code within
these two brackets
otherwise so else we're going to execute
the code between these two brackets so
there's a couple things i want to point
out here just to connect the dots for
the previous lesson that we talked about
so let's just get the basic structure of
an if then statement we have if
and then else
and this is basically what we're looking
at and obviously there's indentation uh
line breaks all that kind of stuff
that's just formatting but this is the
basic structure so in this parentheses
we have a
javascript expression
and then we have some brackets that
contains the code for the truthy uh code
path so if that expression evaluates to
true and then we have a brackets where
we can put our code for the falsey path
so if the expression is false and we've
previously covered expressions in
javascript
in terms of variables so we might have
said something like
i don't know say 20 triple equals 20
and
50 triple equals 50. so obviously both
of these
are
going to evaluate to true and then you
combine it with the and operator and the
whole expression evaluates to true and
then we assign that true value to
the variable right here now that's all
we've looked at
in prior videos but you can actually
take this expression which is right of
the equal sign
and you can drop it into
this uh parentheses for the conditional
statement so just a different way to use
an expression you'll see it a lot and
it's
something that i think is worth pointing
out i'm going to drop a couple of
different ways that we can write
conditionals on the screen so it's a lot
of code we're going to walk through each
of these
so let's open this up so i've declared a
couple of variables up top so we have a
number two number variables 20 and 10
and then a javascript expression which
is basically saying is the first number
greater than the second number which is
going to result in true
and then we've put these in some
different conditionals so the most basic
one that we can do
is going to be a basic if statement so
you don't even need to have an else
statement
at the end of this you can just use if
and this is actually really useful you
know you'll see as you start coding when
this comes into play so we're saying if
this javascript expression
is equal to true
that's what we mean by just putting it
in there so
usually you're you know kind of getting
used to seeing like an equal sign put in
an expression well if we're uh looking
at a boolean all we have to do is drop
it in the parentheses and it's going to
going to evaluate
to either true or false
so since this does equal the true we
would expect that this console.log
statement will be reached and it'll
print this expression is true and if you
come down the first
console log has been printed right here
now moving on to the next one we have an
if else statement i'm going to skip over
this because we just covered it
basically if js expression is true
console.log this otherwise this
and then finally we can
include other conditions so not only can
we do an if else statement we can also
add some other
code paths for our code to to go down
so if this is equal to true
we want to console.log the expression is
true
else if the first number is greater than
zero so
basically what we're saying here is let
me sorry i closed that out there
but if the js expression is false we're
going to skip this first
block of code and then we're going to go
to the next condition so we know if we
get to the next condition
that first one is going to be false so
we know js expression is false and then
we're checking if the first number is
greater than zero if that is the case
then we're going to say the expression
is false and the first number is greater
than zero
but if it is false so if the expression
is false and the first number is
less than or equal to zero we're going
to fall into the else statement which is
basically a catch-all for any other
condition that we might have
so the expression is false and first
number zero or less so
in this case obviously the variable is
true so we uh go down this first code
path and you see this expression is true
down here
or i guess this yeah the expression is
true
and then finally the last one that we
have is just a formatting uh difference
so we have an if statement but we've put
it all on one line and this is just to
demonstrate that we don't have to format
it
you know all pretty like we did up here
although it helps for code readability
and in other languages such as python
the indentation and formatting actually
does matter for running your code but in
javascript it doesn't it's more of just
a readability thing the last type of
conditional that you might see is called
a switch case statement and this is
equivalent
in many ways to the if else if else if
else if else
type conditional so if you have a lot of
conditions that you're testing then a
switch case statement might be
appropriate for you so let me paste um
some code on the screen again
and we're going to execute this
the output is the color is blue and
we'll see exactly why in a second
so first i put an array up here and i
put the indexes or indices on top so the
first one is an index of zero one two
three four
and then
we have to get a random index so this is
just uh some code that i wrote you don't
have to understand this but
we're basically going to get a random
number between 0 and 4 and assign it to
this random index variable so just think
of this random index variable as
carrying any value between 0 and 4 which
happens to correspond with the indexes
of the colors array
then we're going to grab a random color
from the array
so
remember we can get
something from an array by passing in
the index value using bracket notation
and since random index here
carries one of those values we can pass
that in to the colors array so this the
right side expression is going to
evaluate to
one of these colors but we don't know
which one because we have a random index
being generated
then
we come down here and we can write some
basic conditionals so if the random
color so again this is going to be
one of the array values if it's orange
we're going to say the color is orange
and then you can kind of look down here
and just see it's doing the same thing
for all of the different conditions
if we get to the last else statement
there was no color found but that's
never going to happen because we
know that we have an index between 0 and
4.
in this case the color turned out to be
blue but it was a random color random
choice we didn't know that as the
developer before it happened
now the reason that i bring this up is
because this if else if statement
where we have a lot of else ifs in here
it gets very confusing and it's tough to
read sometimes so this is why we might
want something like a switch case
statement and i'll show you the same
code written in the switch case format
oh and by the way if you're tired of
getting
into this browser console
remember you just right click inspect
element to get here
i promise you we're going to get to an
actual code editor soon but i just want
to keep this
focused on javascript we're not getting
into setting up a local development
environment yet
so anyways here is that switch case
statement
same thing up here same colors array
same random index same random color
obviously since it's random it might not
be blue which i think is the one we last
saw so let's press enter
it did turn out to be blue
might have been a coincidence there but
basically what we're doing is
everything's the same up here but we
come down to the switch statement and
what we're saying is that we have a
switch statement and we put the
expression that we're evaluating in the
parentheses so similar to the if then or
uh or the if else statement
we can put in that condition into the
parentheses and then we come into these
little
brackets which is going to contain a
bunch of cases so if the case is orange
or in other words if the random color
variable evaluates to the value of
orange then we're going to hit this code
right here
and when we hit this code sorry about
that when we hit this code the color is
orange it's going to print that to the
console and then this break statement is
a special statement that we can write to
basically say okay i found the correct
case now stop executing the code
entirely so if we were to get the random
color orange it's going to print it to
the console and then it's going to break
and then basically all of the rest of
this code down here will never be
reached because we broke out of that
statement so that's what it's doing it's
basically just going
down the the different cases it's saying
okay what is random color equal does it
equal orange no okay does it equal green
no does it equal yellow no purple no and
then we finally get to blue which it
does equal and so it's going to console
log that and then break out of the
switch case statement now there's this
last condition down here which is called
default and this is basically the
catch-all this is the else statement
in our conditional
and it's saying if random color does not
evaluate to any of these cases
let's go to the default value which
we're just going to say no color is
found
so that is the basic switch case
statement let me write this let me
refresh
and i'm going to write this in a little
bit simpler format so we have switch
and then here we have case
are the different cases and then the
break statements so this is obviously
not valid but we have a switch
then we put our condition in here which
can be any javascript expression and
then between the brackets we put all the
different cases
so
switch state or switch case statements
how often are you going to use them well
in my
experience i haven't used them a ton
usually an if statement or an if else
statement
is going to be sufficient and oftentimes
if you start using too many
switch case statements there's that's
kind of an indication that you may not
be writing the most efficient code but
that's to worry about later uh right now
i just want you to kind of be aware of
this understand how it works and uh just
be familiar when you look it up and try
to use it for the first time all right
continuing on lesson five so
conditionals functions and loops we're
going to talk about loops right now and
looping in javascript is a very
effective concept and you will use it
all the time so you really have to
understand this
um there's not a whole lot to it but i
think the hardest thing is understanding
why we need loops in the first place as
we go through coding challenges
a little bit later and you do more
coding challenges just in general
you're going to use loops a lot but it's
generally just to solve some sort of
challenge so you often will wonder to
yourself well why do we actually need
this in the real world and the reason
at least in my opinion the reason we
have loops
or the most common use case of a loop
is to iterate or loop over a set of
resources
so when we're talking about something
called a resource
that's basically saying that we have a
bunch of
pieces of data that are very similar to
each other so often stored in a database
and that might include something like
if you have a blog it might be a blog
post
i'm trying to think of of another thing
if you're running an app you have a
bunch of users and there's a lot of
different concepts that you can
replicate but basically resources is a
list of similar types of data and when
we have those it's more efficient to
actually loop over those than to
manually print them out so again if we
have an array
something like this so i'll just say
array
and then we have 20 40
60 something like this we can go ahead
and print to the console using this
bracket notation so array of 0 and then
array index 1 in array index 2.
so that's how we can manually print
each value of the array but when you
have a thousand uh different blog posts
that you want to render onto a web page
it's not going to be efficient enough
for you to just go into your code and
start typing out each and every index
not only that but once we add new blog
posts to our
database we're going to have to go in
and change the code which is going to be
extremely cumbersome it's not
recommended you you just you won't get
away with that in software engineering
you have to do things more efficiently
and that is when loops come in to
demonstrate this let's take a look at uh
maybe a sample
array of blog posts
so this is not something that you have
seen before in my tutorial videos
because we've been writing arrays on a
single line
but arrays just like you know
conditionals and anything else in
javascript can be indented and broken
onto different lines this is all just a
formatting
thing so basically what we're doing here
is we have three different objects so
here's one object then we have another
object and a third and you can see these
objects are very similar looking in each
of them we have a title property an
author property
publish date and content now obviously
the values of these properties is going
to be a little bit different for each of
the objects but you can see that you
know you can already start to infer that
if we're looping over this array of blog
posts we can use the fact that they have
similar properties and let me just show
you something really quickly that we
could do using a loop now i'm not going
to explain how the loop works yet but
just to show you what i'm talking about
so let me collapse this
so we have some room here and i'm going
to paste in this line of code
this is what we call a loop and there
are several ways to write a loop but
again i'm not going to cover that quite
yet
but what you can see
is that instead of hard coding the index
the indices that we are passing in
to our blog post array so in other words
we want to retrieve a certain
blog post
object from that array we would need an
index to do that instead of hard coding
it we're using this variable called i so
all i'm doing with the first four
variables here is i'm grabbing a
specific object from this array so i'm
only grabbing one of them and then i'm
taking all of the properties and
grabbing the value of those properties
and assigning it to each variable then
i'm printing the variables below so when
i press enter you're going to see it
loops through all of our blog posts
pretty much instantaneously or at least
it seems like it to our human brain
and it's going to loop through and it's
going to print
each of the values for each of the blog
post so this is our first one
what is javascript it's by me december
20th 2020 and some post content here and
you can see that that is the first
object in that array and then we go to
how do arrays work and then how long
does it take to learn coding so you can
see that here and then finally here at
the bottom so we have looped through
every blog post in that array now let me
talk about how these arrays actually
work we're going to go into a little bit
simpler examples so that you can really
isolate these concepts in your head so
let me write a basic loop in javascript
so we're going to let i equal 0
we're going to go until i is
equal to 100 that's just an arbitrary
number that we're coming up with you can
obviously pass a variable in place of
this like we did with that first example
and then we're going to increment the
value of i so remember this from the
last
lesson this is basically the same thing
i'm going to come out here just for a
second that's the same thing as saying i
equals i plus one
so basically saying if i is zero then
we're going to increment it by one
and then we're going to put some
brackets here and press enter and so
everything within these brackets here is
going to be considered one iteration of
this loop so the code within these
brackets is going to be executed as many
times as we do this loop
in this case we've set the uh stop
condition at 100. so let's walk through
each of these and kind of connect the
dots between the previous lessons that
we've talked about in this series and i
think you're going to really understand
this so the first thing that we see here
is we declare this for loop using the
four keyword
so this is similar to how we have an if
statement so we say if and then we put
parentheses in some brackets now we're
just saying 4.
now in the parentheses is going to be
the loop conditions the first one is
going to be the variable that we're
looping over so let i equals zero and
notice this semicolon to end that
statement
we're just starting i at a value of zero
and the reason that we start it at a
value of zero is because arrays start at
an index of zero so it makes sense that
if we're looping through our array
we want to start at the first value in
that array which has an index of 0. you
might also ask why do we choose i what
is i well i is just a variable we could
put in anything that we want we could
say my
iterator or something like that and then
all we have to do is replace each
occurrence of that with our new variable
so we can choose whatever variable name
we want and if you see this entire
expression this is very similar to or
it's the exact same thing that we use to
declare a variable in javascript now the
one thing you'll notice is that we're
using the let keyword and that is really
important it's important because this
iterator variable so i'm going to flip
this back to i really quickly because
this is kind of like an industry
standard
a lot of developers will just use this
as a convention
when looping so we're going to use the
let keyword because i is going to be
reassigned throughout the loop
as you can see at the end we talked
about this is going to add 1 to i after
each iteration of the loop
so that's basically the same thing as
reassigning it and if you remember from
the previous lesson when we try to use
this increment operator on a variable
that was declared with the const keyword
it doesn't work it throws an error so
that's why we need the let keyword in
here and then finally we have this uh
code in the middle which is probably the
most difficult to understand this is the
stop condition so basically what we're
saying here is we want to go through
this loop we want to do as many loops
until i
equals a value of 100 so each time we go
through the loop it's going to increment
by one so basically
since we're starting at zero and we're
saying less than we're going to go
through a hundred iterations of this
loop so all i'm going to do here is just
demonstrate this i want to console.log
the value of i and you're going to see
when i press enter it's just going to go
0 to 99. so we press enter and we got 99
here at the bottom and we started at
zero so that's a hundred iterations
remember starting at zero ending at 99
and the significance of this is you know
we printed console.log we just printed a
number here but you can do all sorts of
things
like we
saw with the blog post array you can
loop through the blog post array and
assign values and all that kind of stuff
to finish this topic off let's just go
through a super simple example
so let's make an array
we'll call an
arr for array
and then we're going to put in
a couple different values here so
i'm just going to put some random
strings in here
these are string values nothing of
significance
you know just put whatever we want
and then let's put in some numbers
and then a couple more strings
and what we're going to do here is
combine our
knowledge of conditionals that we looked
at in the previous video
and
looping to do an example so let's write
our loop here so we'll say i equals 0
and then we want to go until
the array is complete
so you'll use this quite often where
you're going to look at the array you're
looping over
and you're going to grab the length of
the array
because that basically means we're going
to loop until there's nothing left to
loop through
so that's a very common thing that
you'll see within arrays and then of
course our increment
operator and then we'll jump into our
loop and then in this case we want to
set a conditional so we're going to say
if the type of
array
and then we'll pass in i so remember
this i is going to be incrementing
each loop of the
or each iteration of this loop so it
starts at 0 and then it goes 1 2 3 4 5
all the way up to the length of this
array
so when we pass in i we're basically
saying okay i want to grab
whatever's in this array at the index
that i is current currently at so it'll
start with 0 and we'll grab this first
value then it'll go to 1 and we'll grab
this value so on and so forth so we're
seeing the type of
the array value so basically this is
equivalent
for the first iteration of this array if
we copy this down here
the first iteration is basically going
to be saying type of this value and of
course this is going to return string as
we've seen in prior videos while the
numbers are going to return the type of
number so let's bring this back to what
we had previously so we grab the array
variable and we pass in i
and what we're going to say is if the
type of the array and i actually didn't
even put a condition in here if it
equals number so that's what it will
return if we have one of these numbers
then i want to console.log
the array at that index so basically
what this loop is going to do is it's
going to loop through that an entire
array and it's going to look at the
value see if it's a number and if it is
it's going to print it to the console in
other words we're going to skip all
those gibberish strings that we put in
there so let's press enter
and you can see that we have only the
numbers printing so this is just a super
simple example that demonstrates how we
can use an array to quickly iterate over
or use a loop sorry to iterate over an
array
in this part of lesson five we're
talking about functions and we finally
get to do something
fun with javascript in the previous
videos previous lessons we've been
talking about the
rather mundane parts of javascript
things that you can't really do much
with
but when we combine all of those
concepts with functions we have
limitless possibilities that we can
have with javascript of course there's
other things but like i said in this
video series i'm taking you through the
most important parts we're not going
into the super fine details
yet we're going to do that through
practice problems and through real world
practice we're going to fill in those
gaps there so again we're talking about
functions in this video and the first
way that i want to start this out is by
writing out a basic function
so here is how we write a function in
javascript
we're going to say my function so if you
notice this is kind of similar to what
we've been doing with the if statements
the conditionals and the loops we have
some sort of keyword at the beginning
then we have so well this is different
we have a name of the function
and then we have a parentheses so it's
kind of similar syntax and then we have
these uh brackets here where our code
will go so with the function we have to
give it a name here and in the
parentheses we don't actually have to
put anything in there we'll talk about
that in just a second
let's go ahead and print something
hello world this is my first
function
we're going to end that statement with
the semicolon and press enter
and what you'll notice
is that it doesn't do anything and this
is different from what we've talked
about with some of the previous concepts
where everything happens at once so
remember if we you know declare a
variable
set it equal to 20 something like that
when we press enter the variable is
declared and it's assigned at the same
time
and with functions what's happening is
we break out those steps into two steps
so up here what we've done is we've
declared the function
but what we haven't done is called this
function or what we call invoked this
function those are kind of synonymous
terms
in order to do that we just grab the
name of the function
which as you can see similar to this
variable
this my function uh word right here this
is just a variable that the computer
remembers so since the computer
remembers it since we already declared
it it's going to uh recognize it when we
type it out so if we said type of
my function it's going to give us
function because it remembers what that
is
and to execute this so i'm kind of using
all these different words to execute a
function to call a function and to
invoke a function for our purposes they
are all the same thing
so anyways
we call the function using these two
parentheses right here and a semicolon
and when we press enter it's going to
say hello world this is my first
function because it ran the code within
the function
so just to review with functions you
first have to declare it and then you
have to call invoke or execute it all
the same kind of terminology
now there is one way that we can
declare
and call the function in the same step
and although you're not going to use
these all that often i do want to show
you them just so that you have an
awareness of them
and what these are called is
an immediately invoked function so let's
say that we write
another function so another function
here
and we enter down we say console.log
hello
now if we press enter this is going to
just declare it but all we have to do is
wrap this entire function in some
parentheses
and then put our parentheses that we use
to call it at the end
semicolon and you're going to get this
function to declare and execute
at the same time obviously the computer
does it in different steps but for our
purposes it's happening all at once
this is what we call an immediately
invoked function
and like i said you're not going to use
this a ton but just be aware of it you
might see it pop up in some stack
overflow answers or you might even use
it at some point so we got a basic
function but it's not useful like what
are you going to do with the function
that we just wrote
obviously there's more to it and the
thing that i want to introduce next is
the concept of parameters and arguments
and what i would say with these two
terms is they're kind of
two sides of the same coin and once you
get into more advanced programming
programmers are probably going to be
using these parameters and arguments
terms interchangeably because like i
said they're two sides of the same coin
but for our purposes
we're going to distinguish between these
so let's write a function we'll say my
function again
and it will enter down onto a new line
now what i want to do to add into this
parentheses
is going to be something called a
parameter now these parameters are
basically saying uh to the computer hey
computer um i'm going to pass in
uh some sort of values into this
function so be ready for them so
basically what i'm going to say to this
function
is hey i'm going to pass in
some number
and then i'm going to pass in some
string value now obviously with
javascript it's a dynamically typed
language so you don't have to say like
some number or some string this is just
an example maybe we could even say
something like param 1 and param 2. so
let's just go with that these are
arbitrary names that we have and then
what i want to do is console.log
param1
and then we'll go on to a new line up i
accidentally messed that up let me go
ahead and try this once more
oh we really messed up here okay
one second let's refresh the browser
clear it out
and then we need to enter to a new line
and console.log param two
all right so
what we're doing here is we're taking
the value of param one in the value of
param2 which in this case within the
function these are variables these are
variables that we can retrieve the value
from and print out
so we're going to declare that function
well as you can see it's a little bit
later in the day here so i had to take a
break but getting back to what we were
talking about with these parameters so
the question is
what are they equal to what is param1
and pram 2 equal to well the answer to
that is we don't know yet and we don't
know because we haven't assigned them as
what we call arguments
so we know that this is a declared
function but we still have to call or
invoke it
and to do that you know how to do that
you just put in the little parentheses
at the end and you'd press enter now if
we just press enter right now
it's going to return undefined because
we didn't pass in any parameters so when
this code tries to execute and it tries
to reference these parameter variables
there's no value to grab because we
never gave it a value
so to answer the question of what they
represent well they represent the
arguments that you pass into the
function
so if we have this function we can pass
in say a number and then
some string of some sort
and now these are what we call the
arguments now like i said arguments and
parameters are kind of the you know two
sides of the same coin but in this case
whatever we pass in the values we pass
in are called the arguments and then the
initial
variables that we were declaring would
be the parameters
so 20 is going to correspond to param 1
and then some string is going to
correspond to param 2. so we should get
20 and then some string printed out when
we run this function
don't worry about this little undefined
here that's just kind of part of the
console we got our 20 and some string
printed in order according to the
function that we wrote so that's just a
basic overview of arguments and
parameters now the next thing that we're
going to talk about is a brief
introduction to scopes in javascript
so
when i say scope what i'm generally
referring to is where these variables
are available in the code so in other
words
we noticed that param1 and param2 were
used within this function
but if we were to just try to print
param1 into the console it's not going
to work and the reason is param1 is not
available in the global scope it's only
available in the function scope which is
any code that's written between
these two little brackets right here
so
we pass in these values but these are
only available to the function it's not
available to the rest of the code that
you're writing in the file or the
console that you know you're writing the
code in so that's just a basic
introduction to scopes there's a lot to
this topic and as i said we're not
trying to cover every last detail of
javascript
that's something that i think you'll
have to fill in kind of outside of this
tutorial and as we do practice problems
and get into some more like real world
examples you'll start to understand
these scopes and i'll try to you know
point them out
as we go through like i said the you
don't know javascript series is a great
way to get a super deep dive into things
topics like the topic of scopes but
beware it's very complicated and there
will be a lot of confusion if you kind
of go down that route up until this time
i've shown you how to write a function
as we see on the screen right now but
there is actually another way to write a
function and let me show you how that's
done so let's go ahead and clear this
this
console
and we'll create a function just like we
are used to creating so
no parameters going in there just a
basic function and we'll console.log
something
all right so that's our basic function
now another way that we could write this
is by assigning it to a variable so in
this case the my function
variable is already defined and it
represents a function so we can't use
that in our variable declaration
but we can say something like another
function
and then we want to set that equal to
a function
so this is just a normal variable and
all we have to do is say function
define it and we'll
console.log
another thing
all right
so we set that equal to another function
and if we say type of another function
it's going to give us the type of
function now i'm saying this word a lot
so i gotta slow down here but
anyways if we wanted to invoke this
function or call it
it works the same way that we were using
it before so just like we call my
function
just like this and it prints out
something
we can invoke another function the same
exact way even though it is a variable
now there are a few little
subtle differences between these two
ways of writing functions and like i
said it gets into some details that
we're not quite ready for and i'm just
going to leave out for now
it's not and these details are not
essential for you to write good code and
get it up and running they're more like
edge cases where your code doesn't work
and you can't figure out why well it's
because of this subtle nuance so i
wouldn't worry about it too much
all right so we've got these two
different ways the main difference that
i want you to recognize is the fact that
this function right here does not have a
name
this is what we call an anonymous
function and the reason we can use an
anonymous function is because we are
assigning it to a variable so we're
giving it a name
now up here we just do it all at once we
just give it a name and we're done so if
you tried to write a function
without a name so something like this
you're not going to get it to work
because this is an anonymous function
and you need to declare some sort of
name and you see the syntax error it
says function statement requires a name
so that is not valid because it's
anonymous you have to assign it to a
variable now there is another way to
write functions and this is a little bit
tricky but i'd like to cover it because
you're going to be using this next type
of writing a function a ton so as of
2015 when the es6 standard came out so
if you remember back from i think lesson
2 we talked about ecmascript standard
and
how
there's a standards body that basically
defines the spec for the javascript
language well they upgraded that spec in
2015 with es6
and they came out with something called
a arrow function
so that arrow function looks like this
so we'll say
arrow function
equals and then we'll put some
parentheses
we'll put an arrow
and then write it just like normal
so we'll say i am
an arrow function
all right so we press enter and like our
other functions we can call it or invoke
it the same way so we just press arrow
function with the two parentheses at the
end and boom it executes
so it's functionally equivalent in a way
again there's some subtle nuances that
we're not going to get into but this
arrow function is mainly here so it
improves readability
and another benefit that it has is it
really helps out with the scopes of your
you know your code and specifically the
this keyword which we'll get into much
later but
it does improve on that that's why they
came out with it in the first place
so this is a very um
different way of writing a function but
here's the basic syntax you just have
this little parentheses which is
basically here's where you put the
parameters
then you have this arrow that's why they
call it an arrow function so an equal
sign and then a right caret
or greater than sign and then you have
these two brackets just like you would
any function
once again you cannot just use this
alone this is kind of similar to that
anonymous function we looked at and you
can't just define a function like this
and you know this this won't work
because it doesn't have a name so you
don't have a name specified
it didn't throw an error like the
previous one but you have no way of
referencing back to this you don't know
how to actually call it because there's
no name for it
so you have to assign these anonymous
functions and arrow functions to some
sort of variable these arrow functions
or anonymous functions can also be used
in something called a callback but again
that's going to be a little bit later
down the road all right from now on i'm
going to be focusing a lot on these
arrow functions i'm going to be writing
them for the most part now obviously if
you're defining a function on its own
you have to write it you know with the
normal syntax so you have to write it
with the name
and then the parentheses just like this
but for a lot of cases we can just
assign it to a variable and i'd like to
get you practicing the arrow functions
because you're going to use them so much
so the next thing that we're going to
talk about here is the concept of return
values in functions
so far we haven't returned anything from
our functions and if we're writing these
so let's say my function
save it to a variable
and use the arrow function syntax
and then we just console.log
something all right very simple my
function does not actually return
anything so if we were to assign
a result variable to it so we're going
to say my function and then we're going
to call it so remember this is just
executing the function we defined above
and then it's assigning the result to
that function to the result variable so
we press enter and this is just the
console.log that was executed as part of
the function but if we type out result
it's going to give us undefined and the
reason is because our function didn't
return anything so if we want our
function to produce a value we have to
put a return statement in there all
right so let's go ahead and do that
return
function that's what i'm going to name
it here that's just the variable
we'll use the arrow
syntax enter down and this time we're
going to return a value of 20 and we
also could have returned you know some
string or we also could have returned a
variable so if we wanted to you know
make a variable called a and that equals
20.
oh i accidentally
hit enter there but if we wanted to we
could come down here and return a now
it's going to bug out on me because i've
already declared it like right here on
accident so let's let's refresh the page
real quick so that we can get back into
this
so
um
we'll just say my function this time
we've got the fat arrow function
enter down we'll define a variable set
it to 20
and then we will return
that variable now we could also return
like
some sort of expression so what if we
wanted to return a is greater than 30
which it's not obviously so this would
return false so let's just see you know
how these different return types affect
the function we're just going to return
a which will be 20 and now we want to
set that equal to a result variable so
we'll get my function we're going to
execute it and then assign the result to
that result variable and now when we
print out the result it's going to equal
20 because it took the result value of
the function and assigned it to that
variable
like i said you can
do expressions here so if we wanted to
define another function
we'll just put 2 at the end so it's
unique and then we want to say
a is less than
30 which it is this will return true i'm
just going to put a comment there and
therefore we would expect that this
whole function is going to
evaluate this last expression here and
then return it so let's press enter and
then we'll say result 2 is equal to my
function 2
and then if we get the value it's going
to be true so you can see that there's a
lot of different things that we can
return from a function
heck we could even return a function
from a function but that's getting into
way too much detail and it's not
necessary for what we're trying to do so
i'm going to skip that hopefully this
gives you a brief overview of return
values now the last thing that we have
to talk about is what happens after the
return value so let's say that we had
i'm going to go ahead and clear the
screen
we'll say
improper
return function
and then we're going to set that equal
to
our arrow function
and we're going to return 20. or no
let's go ahead and set a variable um i
messed this up again it's kind of tough
working in the console but we will
eventually get to a code editor which is
going to be a lot easier on us so let's
say my function
do this one more time
and in this case
let's define a variable so we'll say let
my number
equal 20
and then we're going to return
my number now let's enter down onto the
next line and then we'll say my number
equals 50. all right so we're going to
press enter
and it's going to give us an error it
says unreachable code after the return
statement you won't get this from all
like this is just in the console you may
not get this error anywhere else
but this is giving us a hint that we've
done something wrong here but it is
still valid so basically what we're
saying here
is we're going to run the function
it's going to return 20 and that's
because we've returned the value before
we reassigned it so this is valid code
to write but it's useless because this
last line right here is never going to
be reached no matter what happens it's
always going to return beforehand and
you'll never return a value of 50. so
just know that for the return values
whatever happens after it doesn't matter
and you pretty much will never have
a return value before the end of your
function
so let's say that we have a global
variable
we'll just say something like
mynumber equals 20. all right so we're
going to set that in the global scope
again scopes are going to get important
here soon so just kind of keep that in
the back of your head
now we're going to define a function so
we're going to say
let's go ahead and use let because in
case i screw up again and we have to
reassign it so we're going to go ahead
and say
my function
and we're going to set that equal to an
arrow function
now we're going to say if
my number so
this kind of seems like going against
what i told you earlier about scopes so
if there's a parameter that has a
function scope it cannot be accessed at
the global level but if you have a
global variable
you can access it from within a function
so it goes one way but not the other
when it when it comes to scopes so since
this isn't a it's in technically a
higher scope than the function has it
the function can actually
recognize what this variable is equal to
so we're going to say if my number and
then we're going to enter down
and actually
i need an expression here if my number
is we'll say
less than 15
then i want to return
returned
the function
early all right
and then we're going to enter down and
then we're going to return
40. these are all random numbers i'm
making up here but it's just trying to
show you that
if you have a condition where you know
if the number is less than 15 which it
is not in this case
you can actually return multiple things
from the same function so
my number is not less than 15 so we're
going to actually skip this return
function in return 40. but if we change
that so let's say
we change that to less than 50 and 20 is
left less than 50. so we're going to
actually return this function early and
we'll never reach the second return
statement so let's go ahead and enter
that down and execute it and you'll see
that we get that return to the function
early
output so you can have multiple return
statements within a function just you
can't have like two of them on the same
line so if i were to recreate this
function
and maybe have
you know like a return statement of 50
and then return 40 right after it both
of these code paths are going to be
reached so this doesn't make any sense
you only want to return one value so
that's just an overview of return values
we're going to get a lot more into this
as we start writing some more realistic
code just wanted to give you a brief
overview
the last thing that i want to do prior
to getting into the 25 practice
exercises or coding challenges
i have for you i want to talk a little
bit about objects and functions together
so this is a little bit of a confusing
topic but it's going to hopefully help
you understand
when we start talking about the built-in
functions of javascript we're going to
talk about that in a few minutes
hopefully this will help you understand
that better so let's go ahead and define
a function we're going to call it my
function again
and then let's i don't know
return a value of 20 from it so this is
a very simple function
we'll go ahead and execute it just to
demonstrate it returns 20. now what if i
wanted to set this equal to
another variable i can actually do that
even though it's already called my
function
so i can say
um
you know alias you know an alias is just
another name for something so we'll say
alias variable equals my function all
right so if we press enter now alias
variable is exactly equal to this
function declaration that we made
above so if we wanted to execute that as
alias variable
we're going to get the same answer of
20. so we can assign it to different
variables which means that we can also
assign it to
object properties
so let's go ahead and clear the well i
guess we don't need to clear the screen
let's go ahead and create an object so
we'll say my object
and then we'll set that equal to prop 1
we'll just give it some random value
just to have something there
and then we'll say prop 2
is going to be equal to my function
all right so we have declared my object
in prop 2 just a random
property name that i've given it is
going to be exactly equal to the
function declaration just like we made
this alias variable equal to the
function declaration so what does this
mean well we can actually execute the
function by accessing a value of or by
accessing a property of the object so if
we
come down here and let's just
go ahead and say my object
and then we need to get a property from
the object so let's go ahead and get
property2 and you'll see in the
autocomplete down here it's pretty much
telling us that that is equal to my
function now if we wanted to execute it
we can still put those little
parentheses at the end and it's going to
execute and give us the same answer so
what we did here was we grabbed an
object we grabbed a property off of that
object using the dot notation and then
once we had that we just threw those
little parentheses at the end and
executed it so i just wanted to get you
familiar with this because what we're
about to talk about is the built-in
functions of javascript
so javascript has a bunch of built-in
functions and objects and all sorts of
other stuff that we can use without
having to write any code
and if you go to there's there's several
resources that you can use to see these
i'm on tutorials point which has a good
list of them but they're they're all
over documented pretty much everywhere
and within javascript there are
different data types as we have talked
about so you have strings you have
booleans you have numbers and all of
these different data types will actually
have some built-in functions that you
can call on top of them
so if we go here and just look at some
of the different methods so
method is another
i guess synonym for function we can call
like it's not completely synonymous but
if you have like an object and then you
have
a function attached to that object as we
just showed that's called an object
method so it's kind of the same thing
and you can see that we have number
methods we have boolean methods and we
have string methods and we have array
methods probably down here somewhere so
array methods
and depending on the variable type that
you're working with you can use all of
these to modify your your variables and
just take a bunch of shortcuts with your
code so let me go ahead and show you a
few of these
just to give you an idea of how they
work because when we go into the coding
challenges
throughout this course we're going to be
using these uh as much as we can now the
first thing i'll say here is don't try
to memorize these these are not to be
memorized there is documentation for a
reason so that you can google it and
look it up when you need it you'll pick
up on a few of them over time but for
the most part i only have a few of these
actually committed to memory
all right so let's go ahead and try out
a few string methods so let's say that
we wanted to
i don't know use this replace method we
go back to the console let's clear
everything out
and let's define ourself a string so
we'll say my string
equals um zac
and then we're going to use the replace
um
method so maybe i spelled my name wrong
that's how you spell my name but what if
there's a k at the end so i might want
to replace it so i can say my string dot
replace
and then i'm going to replace the h
with a k
and when we press enter it's going to
return zach with a k and now my string
is actually going to still be equal to
the original because it didn't replace
the value it just returned a new value
so it doesn't alter the original value
here it just returns a new one so if we
wanted to
say
new name we can just say
my string dot replace
h
and k
and then we set that uh equal to new
name and now now my new name
is going to be spelled differently now
something that i want you to notice
when we're looking at this is that we're
using the same notation here that we
used earlier when we accessed that
property of the object and executed it
as a function now this works a little
bit differently than that but you can
kind of think of it that way so maybe
the my string is considered your object
and then you use dot notation to get a
property off of that object called
replace which happens to be a function
that takes two parameters
and the first parameter it takes is the
letter or string that you want to find
within your string so i want to find the
letter h
within my string and then i want to
replace it with the
string k just a letter
so my string will be replaced so
these are the parameters and if you were
to look at the replace method and you go
ahead and click on it it gives you a
description of this and we're going to
learn how to you know read through
documentation a little bit later but
anyways you can go down here and just
see what kind of
parameters are required for this so
here's the syntax and it gives you
the parameters that you want to search
for then the parameters you want to
replace it with a couple examples some
output all that stuff so that's how i've
you know figured out how to use that
again we're going to go through it quite
a bit as we go through the coding
challenges
i'll just go through a couple more
examples just to get you comfortable
with what's going on here so let's go
ahead and use my string
once again
and this time i want to use the string
method called
to uppercase and you can see what that
does is it returns us the uppercase
version of our variable now i know we
got a lot of different versions going on
here so let's go ahead and clear that
out and reprint my string so that is
what my string variable is equal to
right now
we can also chain the methods together
so this is a little bit of an odd
concept
to someone starting out but you'll see
how this actually works um once we get
into the challenges so let me just do a
simple example here we have my string
equal to zach but let's go ahead and say
uh we want a new string or something so
let's call it um
i don't know
let's make a new one we'll just call it
str for string and this one we're going
to say hello world in there
so that that's the string right there
and what we want to do is first make it
uppercase so we'll say to uppercase
and we'll execute that you know method
that sits on the string
object
and that's going to
output us hello world as it's kind of
telling us here
now we can put another dot there and we
can chain these methods on top of each
other so i'm going to use another method
called split
and what split does is it's going to
take whatever delimiter that you put
as a as a parameter or not a parameter
as an argument
so if we put in a space right here it's
going to look at the string and it's
going to say there's one space in there
so i want to split hello and world apart
from each other
and then what it does there as you can
see down here is it actually changes the
data type from a string to an array
where the first uh part of that array is
the first the hello and the second is
world so let's set this equal to a
variable we'll just say
a result variable is what we want and
our result variable is now an array and
from there we can actually do array
methods so let's go ahead and go back to
the documentation here and let's scroll
down to some of our array methods that
we can use
so what would be a good one to use so
we'll use the index of method so this
just basically gives us the index of a
value so we'll say result
dot index of and then i want to search
for the word world
and when we press enter it's going to
return us 1 because this is an index of
0 and this is an index of 1 and that
matches the string that we are searching
for that we passed in as an argument to
this function now of course you don't
have to do this by chaining them
together you can do it in separate steps
so in the case of above we made this to
uppercase and then we split it into an
array in a single step but if it gets
too complex for you and you just want to
stick to the basics you can do this in
different steps so we'll say
first let's see what string is equal to
it's still equal to hello world because
we you know while we did this right here
we didn't modify the original variable
we just assigned it to a new one
so string still represents hello world
and in this case
we'll say step one variable we want to
take that and we want to make it
uppercase alright so we'll make it
uppercase and then maybe just type it
out to make sure that it worked
now we're going to do step two
right here where we say
step one so we want to grab whatever
values in step one
and then we want to split that based on
a space
alright so we set that to step two
and then step two we can print out and
we see that it's an array and then we
come to
say step three and we'll say step two
whatever value is in that variable and
then we'll say
index of like we did above and then
we'll search for the word world and
we'll set that to step three and we get
an index of one so you can see we can
split these out into different steps but
i just wanted you to know that as you
see some different syntax when you're
reading through code this is a valid way
to use these built-in methods in
javascript
all right
there's a lot here there's a lot going
on in this video and
i would never expect you to take it all
in at once and process it and understand
every last bit of it and that is why
we're going to use
a bunch of practice exercises or coding
challenges
to brush up on these skills and really
cement some of the concepts
we've talked about variables we've
talked about operators we've talked
about conditionals so if else if else or
else if doing a tongue twister there
we've talked about loops and we've
talked about functions so there's a lot
going on here and to combine it all
together and actually write code
i think it's useful to go through some
exercises
in this video we're going to go through
25 maybe a few more we'll see how it
goes but we're going to go through some
coding challenges and these are going to
be at the very beginner level so like
very beginner level of coding and what i
want to do with this is walk you through
my own thought process
and help you understand how i'm thinking
about this and how you should use the
previous lessons that we have gone
through so lesson uh three and four
where we talk about the basics of
javascript i want to apply those to
actual coding challenges like i've said
throughout this series i'm not taking
you extremely deep into the javascript
programming language
there are other people who have done
that
and
i think at this point when you're just
trying to get off the ground
digging into complex topics like you
know hoisting and
advanced scopes and stuff like that it's
not necessary for when you're just
starting and you can fill in the blanks
as you go later on and partially why i'm
making this video with these challenges
is to help you do that so if i haven't
talked about it in the previous lessons
hopefully we'll kind of fill in the
blanks here with these challenges and to
do so we're going to do this on a site
called code wars
and if you go here
pull up the screen
this is going to be the collection that
i've put together so there's 25
exercises here
that i put into a collection we'll see
how it goes i might add a few more um if
we blow through these but basically just
go to hit the link in the description
to find this
uh series of questions and then get to
this page right here create a profile go
ahead and follow me too
let's see what my
profile is
zachgall just look me up follow me i'll
follow you back so that we can do this
together
and then once you get to the collection
again link in the description you'll go
to this uh top left corner and click
train now
and when we click this it's gonna drop
us in to each of the problems uh that i
have basically chosen for this video
and i just want to give you a quick tour
of code wars if you've never been on
here before
i actually just started using it for
this purpose just to go through some
practice exercises
but basically on the left side here we
have the instructions so it's going to
tell us the instructions this code does
not execute properly figure out why
basically fix it
you can see the output here this is when
we actually run our test so if we run
our test obviously it's going to fail
and this is where we see the output and
then over here is where we write our
solution so we can write valid
javascript code over in this
terminal over here and then finally at
the bottom this is the the
sample test that we can look at so
um obviously this is a little bit more
advanced than we're um probably
accustomed to at this point if you're
watching this video
but this is going to basically be a
bunch of code that actually tests the
code that you write so it takes the
inputs that
or it takes a set of inputs it puts
those inputs through the code that
you've written and then it
gets the outputs and checks to see
whether
that matches the expected output so
that's just a brief tour
just a few other things you'll notice
that we're writing in the javascript
language
that's what this video is about uh node
is going to be the runtime so node.js is
kind of the back end version of
javascript but you know just like we've
been working on in this series we can
you know this is the browser dev tools
console
and this would be you know the same code
that we're writing here so
nothing new here and then finally this
vim versus emacs thing if you click
either of these it's going to actually
drop you or it it's going to create this
editor right here
into like say a vim editor i have a
video on this if you want to check out
the vim
code editor or text editor but don't
click this for now that's a whole
different uh ball game that we would get
into if we started using those so keep
those unchecked
all right so from this point we're gonna
go through the
the exercises i'm gonna walk you through
how i'm thinking about them the first
one is rather simple if you've been
following along with this roadmap series
you'll know exactly what we need to do
here it's saying this doesn't execute
how do we fix it well right now if we
you know ran it and did the output we
ran it earlier it says it expected
undefined to equal 1. so basically
that's saying that
we haven't returned anything from this
function and therefore we just need to
add a return statement right here
and then we can test it and it should
pass
so we pass it go ahead and click attempt
at the bottom right corner it passed all
of our tests so we'll submit it
all right once you submit a solution and
you did it correctly it's going to show
you other people's solutions to the same
problem and this can be useful but also
detrimental so listen up here
the way that this can be useful is by
scrolling down and you know just seeing
the possibilities because you can
solve every one of these problems in
many different ways and so sometimes
it's fun to see how other people have
solved them and it also can open your
eyes to different types of thinking that
you you know wouldn't have thought about
so
it is good in that way it's not good
because sometimes
people will solve these in very clever
ways and when i say clever that does not
mean the best way now i'm not a
competitive programmer
i don't claim to be i don't really have
any plans on becoming one
but when you get into the world of
competitive programming it's all about
optimizing your solution writing the
least amount of code or the fastest code
um that kind of thing
and i'm not that i just want to write
some code that helps you understand the
solution and help you read the code in
the simplest way possible and some of
these solutions down here for example
this one right here this is unnecessary
um there has you know nobody said that
you have to check and validate all of
the argument inputs so in this case a
and b are the inputs to our function
and what this person has done is
basically checked to make sure that you
know the
the inputs are not some you know invalid
input it makes sure that they're a
number and this is totally unnecessary
for this solution it never told us that
we have to check that
and this is just overly complicated in
my opinion you'll see that there's
a lot of votes for the clever and in
many cases when you see a lot of votes
for the clever solution it's probably
not geared towards the beginner it's
probably not what we want to focus on
right now at least
now i will point out one that's
a little bit useful for us and that's
down here so this would be our solution
that's what we came up with we just
added a return statement and called it a
day
now there's another way to do this that
is actually it's it's very clever but
it's also something that we talked about
in a previous lesson so that i think as
the previous video we actually might
have mentioned this at one point but
basically if you have an arrow function
which is what
we don't have an arrow function in the
original solution we just have this you
know standard function a named function
but we could set
this function equal to a variable called
multiply and then we set it equal to
an arrow function and with an arrow
function
if
you put it all on one line you don't
actually have to put a return statement
in there so this is a nice
nice thing to look at because it gives
you kind of opens up your world to
understanding oh i can write it like
this as well
all right so enough on this we're not
going to spend this much time on every
challenge but i wanted to walk through
uh how you think about these solutions
here
all right so if you were if you clicked
that button so let me actually go back
to make sure that we're clear on this
we'll go to collections go to the lesson
five practice challenges
and if you just click on one of these
challenges it's going to take you to
that challenge but when you click next
it's not going to keep you within the
collection so make sure that you've
clicked this train now button so that
when you solve the problem and click
next it takes you to the next one
in the
collection so i guess we got to solve
this one again real quick so we'll
attempt it with that solution we passed
it let's submit it
all right and now we can pre press next
uh next kata or kata i don't actually
know how to say that i'm sure there's a
reference to that that i'm not getting
be sure to leave that in the comments if
you do know what it means anyways this
is the next
problem that we have so let's go ahead
and actually is this yeah
this is it so let's train again i guess
i've already opened this at one point
um yeah when i was putting the
collection together so
the function is not returning the
correct values can you figure out why so
this is going to actually get us into
the switch case statement that we talked
about um just in the previous couple
videos
and if you remember with the switch case
statement this is basically like saying
if and then else if and then a bunch of
else ifs to test a specific condition if
you remember from the switch case
statement syntax
we are missing something right here that
is causing our solution to be wrong
and i think what's gonna happen
if we execute this we're gonna get
neptune
uh every time so let's let's see if
that's the case
yeah so we got neptune every single time
and the reason that's happening
is we don't have any break statements
here
so in other words we're getting the id
um passed in correctly so that's passed
in as an argument id is the parameter
that we're defining within the function
and then what it's doing is it's looking
at that id so that's in the switch
statement and it's saying what does the
id equal and then once it figures that
out it goes to all the cases and so it
says does the id equal one
okay if it does we'll set the name equal
to
mercury and then we'll return the name
down here
but the problem is since there's no
break statement it's always going to hit
the last case
so let's say that the id
um you know we go down to the test and
they're passing in two as an argument
and we're expecting that that will
return venus
so if we you know pass in an id of two
it's going to get passed in and then
we're going to look at case one and say
okay id does not equal one so let's go
to the next one all right id does equal
2 so let's set the name equal to venus
but instead of breaking and coming down
to the return statement and returning
that answer
it doesn't do anything it's just going
to keep going down all of the cases so
it's going to say does case equal 3 does
case equal 4 does case equal 5 so on and
so forth until it hits the last one so
we need to add some break statements in
here and all we have to do is just put
in
break with a semicolon
and we'll do that for all of these lines
all right so we've got our break
statement let's test this once more
and this time we're passing it so that's
all we needed to do we just this was
purely a syntax error and it's something
that you would have had to kind of look
up the documentation for a switch case
statement or watch my previous lesson to
figure out so let's go ahead and attempt
it we know it's going to pass and we'll
submit it
all right let's see what everyone else
was doing
there's some clever solutions here
obviously this one is very clever but i
would not recommend doing this at our
skill level right now
so looks like we did it did it okay in
this case this person has opted to use a
return statement which is valid but a
break statement works just as well so
you can see that this was the i guess
the top solution most common and that's
kind of what we
used there the one thing i'll point out
is i put a break statement after neptune
but that wasn't really necessary since
it's the last one
all right we'll go to the next
challenge
this is reversing a string so let's go
ahead and train on this
so basically all we're doing is taking
this string and reversing it
and i know how to solve this solution
with just a single line but i don't
actually know exactly how to do that i
can take a guess so let me try
and just return string dot reverse
and see if that works
okay so reverse is not a function as i
kind of suspected so
in javascript as we talked about in the
previous video there's a bunch of
built-in functions
that come with javascript and you can
look these up so we'll just say
javascript built-in
functions
and then we'll we'll go to tutorials
point i like this one it's pretty simple
and then if we go to the string methods
that's where we want to go because what
we're trying to do is reverse a string
so any time that you're trying to modify
a certain
data type you can first look to those
built-in methods so you don't have to do
something manually so in this case we're
working with a string and we need to
reverse it so let's go ahead and see
what we can do
using the string methods
and it turns out if we're just looking
through these different string methods
there's nothing that says reverse here
um i had actually for some reason
thought that we did have a reverse
method
don't know how that slipped my mind but
we don't so we have to think of another
solution now realistically if we were
solving this problem
um you know in the real world where we
had to write some code that reversed the
string what i'm going to do is this i'm
opening up google
and then i'm going to type in how to
reverse a string
javascript
all right and usually there's going to
be a stack overflow post
because stack overflows where you
basically get the answer to anything
when you're coding
and what's going to happen
is we're going to find a solution here
so i wasn't that far off we actually do
have a reverse method but this is not
going to be entirely apparent
to you if you're like a complete
beginner but what we're doing in this
solution here is we're actually
converting this to an array first
so let's go back this is all i need to
see for now
let's go back to our documentation and
take a look at the array methods
so if we have a data type
of an array
we can actually reverse it so
uh looks like there's a reverse method
right here and i'm going to go ahead and
go to the dev console
just right click anywhere on the screen
let's just show you how to do that right
click inspect element if you've been
watching the series this is not news to
you and now we can type away with any
javascript so let's see how we can do
this with an array we'll just set an
array
equal to
1 2
and if we want to reverse this array we
can just say array dot reverse
and it's going to reverse the values in
the array so basically what this stack
overflow solution is telling us
is that we first need to
convert the string into an array by
letter and then we need to reverse it
and then we need to join it back into a
string so this is a you know one step
solution where we can basically do it
all in one step we talked about chaining
these built-in methods in just the prior
video but i want to break this out into
individual steps
just for clarity so let's go ahead and
do that right now
the first thing we want to do is split
the string into an array so basically
it's going to take every character in
the string and it's going to make each
character
a value of that array so again let's
come back to our console
let's say that we have a string and
that's equal to hello
all right
and then we want to say string dot
what were we using here we're using
split and we're going to just split it
with
an empty character so
if i can get back here so we'll say
string.split
and
we'll put in just an empty character and
that's going to give us an array where
we have each
letter being separated in the array all
right so now that we have the array we
can split or we can reverse it so
let's just go back and do that here so
the first thing we have to do is
put it into array so string dot split
and then we just need to pass in an
empty character
and then from there we can reverse it so
as we saw so we'll say we'll save it
into a reversed variable so we'll say
array dot reverse
alright so that's going to assign it
there and then often times when i'm
solving a problem like this i'm going to
write some code and then actually test
it out before i move on so let me go
ahead and console.log the reversed value
and then we'll click test which is
obviously going to fail
but what we do see
is that we get some output so you'll see
that we
logged this to the console and this to
the console which basically tells us
that we have our like our reversed
variable is an array and that array is
reversed from the original string
so the last thing we need to do since we
have it in the form of an array data
type is we need to take that reversed
array and just combine it together into
a string and to do that i think
all we have to do is
join it so if we do string dot split
and then we say join
it's going to join it by a comma so
we actually will have to replace those
commas let's see how the stack overflow
solution did it
okay let's see
and we have to when we join it we have
to also enter that empty string right
there so that's just a little tricky
part to this so let's go back to our
problem
and then we'll say final answer
equals the reversed array so this is an
array and then we join it by that empty
character
and then we go ahead and return
the final answer
and let's go ahead and test that
you can see that we passed all the tests
so let's attempt it i think we'll be
fine here
and we solved it so that's just how we
take it out into different steps
of course we could have solved this by
just saying
we want to do string dot split
dot reverse
join
and this
we can delete all these uh intermediate
variables right here we can test this
and it's gonna pass everything let's go
ahead and attempt it
and submit it so like i said there's a
couple different ways to solve it but um
you might be asking at this point well
you're cheating like you went on stack
overflow and figured this out that way
and
well yes if i was doing a programming
competition um i would be cheating and
that's you know that's why i'm not a
competitive programmer i'd never want to
be because
google is you know your best friend when
you're a programmer
and it is not cheating to google
something so um we'll try to do
more of these on our own for the
remainder of the video but for now i
just really wanted to beat that into
your head that it is okay to go to
google and search something like that
and that's how pretty much everyone that
operates in a real world environment is
going to do so
just a tidbit of knowledge there
take it for what it is
all right so we'll go to the next
challenge
see what we got here
okay even or odd let's see what we are
trying to solve
so it says create a function or write a
script in shell that's not something
that we're going to do
that takes an integer as an argument and
returns even
so
notice that they're asking for a string
a capitalized string that says even
for even numbers or uh capitalized odd
for odd numbers
all right so let's see what we can do
here
the first thing i'm thinking about is
maybe a modulus operator but i don't
even think that we
[Music]
need to do that or do we
yeah that is correct so a modulus
operator
if we were to divide
something
by two right okay
i don't know what i was thinking here so
just divide it by two right so
um let's let's go over to our little
playground here and refresh
just so that we can test a few things
out so if we got 20 divided by 2
that comes out to an even number if we
have 21 which is odd divided by 2
we have a decimal
now
we would have to complete some
additional steps
to actually figure out which one's a
decimal which one's a whole number so i
kind of like the idea of the modulus
operator
because if we do 20 instead of divided
by 2
but modulus 2 it's going to give us 0
but 21
modulus 2
is going to give us 1. so basically
every time we have an even number
doing modulus 2 is going to return 0
because there's zero remainder if we do
that division operation so in previous
lessons we talked about this modulus
operator
in my video video about operators and
basically what it's doing is it's doing
a division problem and it's returning
what the remainder of that division
problem is so as we know going back to
basic math if you divide something and
there's no and there it goes into it
evenly there's going to be a remainder
of 0 which we're going to see for any
even number so if we do 40 modulus 2
that's 0 if we do
2 modulus 2 that's 0. so that's
basically how we're going to solve this
and we could do some intermediate steps
but we can actually just return the
solution
actually no we do have to do some
intermediate steps so if we need a
conditional in here we want to say if
the number so we're grabbing that from
the parameter
and then you know the test cases are
going to pass in different arguments and
then this parameter called number just
think of it as as a variable available
to this function
is going to
be different per the test case so
replace that number with whatever
argument you have
and then what we want to do is write an
expression that says the number modulus
all right so we want to say if that
is equal to so we'll use triple equals
to check both
the value and the data type to be the
same
and we want to set that equal to 0.
so if the number modulus 2 equals 0 then
we know that it is an even number so
we'll drop down into our if statement
and we'll return what we need to return
based on the instructions over here
called even
all right and then we'll put an else
statement so we know that if it's not
even it is odd so we're going to just
return
in that case
and let's test this out
all right we passed all our tests let's
go ahead and attempt it
and we passed all of our tests so let's
submit this answer and see what everyone
else
did to answer this
i'm sure there's some more clever
solution than what i came up with
all right so this is just using the
ternary operator
we talked about this very briefly in the
operators video but it's basically just
a shorthand
clever way to write an if-else statement
and we could have used this but i just
don't want to confuse anyone
unnecessarily
this looks to be our solution
um
actually there's not not much variance
here so these are just abbreviated ways
abbreviated ways to write
our function they're just using the
arrow functions rather than
our classic function here so
um we did pretty good on that one let's
go to the next challenge
all right we're counting sheep in this
challenge
see what we got here
okay we are returning the number or the
count
of the vowels in the given string
we will consider a e i o u as vowels for
this uh
problem
but y is not going to be in there okay
so that's good to know the input string
will only consist of lowercase letters
and or spaces
all right so this is another point that
i really want to bring up um if you're
you know just starting out you're a
beginner
and you're solving problems this is kind
of how an interview question might be
laid out
where the last part is going to tell you
something about the input so obviously
the the functions that we have been
writing here
they're being executed by something and
that's something are the automated test
these are this is a sample test down
here but
there's code that's going to run when we
actually click this test button
this site is going to execute our
function with a bunch of different
parameters to make sure that we
implemented it correctly you know you
don't want to just test it with one set
of parameters you want to put in a bunch
of different things
and with that we could have an infinite
number of things passed into this
function as arguments
and oftentimes in
more complex problems and
harder challenges they're going to
challenge you to handle all of the
different edge cases that might come up
and when i say edge cases you know it
might be something like okay what
happens if i
pass in
an undefined value as my argument or
what happens if i pass in
um you know a number instead of a string
into this as an argument well all these
things need to be handled by your code
so this last sentence here is it doesn't
seem
very useful and you might even ask like
why is it here but this is telling you
something about the input it's basically
saying to us as the programmer it's
saying
hey this is only going to give you
lowercase letters and or spaces
and that's basically saying in other
words we're not going to pass in numbers
we're not going to pass in undefined
values null values boolean values you
know all you need to worry about are you
know single lowercase letters and spaces
all right so that is very useful
information it's going to save us a lot
of time when we're solving this problem
all right so
it says enter your magic here spelled
incorrectly
at least in english i don't know how
spell it in other languages anyways
let's see what we got here so we have a
starting point now one thing i'm going
to fix here
they're using the var
keyword and in the lessons i've
basically told you we're not using this
and i also stand by that so let's go
ahead
and set that equal to let
because it looks like we're going to
have to reassign this at some point
all right so this is actually a fairly
easy solution
once you've been programming for a
little bit
how i see us solving this is first let's
put in our input into an array
of some sort
and then i want to loop over that array
and check if it's a vowel all right so
let's go ahead and do that there's
actually a lot of ways that you can
solve this but let's just stay
consistent with what we did in the
previous one so
we'll take
we'll we'll convert this to an array by
saying string
dot
split and then we want to pass in that
empty character so if you remember what
that does is it takes every letter of
the string and it puts it out it expands
it out into an array
so going back to this tab
we'll just say you know
let's look at an array
and then or no we'll look at a string
so the string will be hello
and then we can just say string dot
split
and then that's what it's basically
going to do here so it's going to split
it into an array and then from an array
we know that we can write a loop so this
is kind of the previous couple videos
that we've been talking about loops
so we're going to loop over every single
value in that array so to do that we're
going to say let i equal 0 this is just
the syntax we use for
looping and then we want to go for the
length so
the array that we just created has a
certain length has a certain amount of
characters
but we don't know that beforehand so
we're just going to pass in
a ray dot length and then we're going to
increment i
using the increment operator
all right so we're going through this
array and now we're just going to write
a
simple if statement
so we'll just say if
let's say we'll grab from the array
each of the indexes so remember i is
going to increment it's going to go from
0 to 1 to 2 to 3 to 4 and all the way
until it reaches the end of that array
which has the individual letters
of this you know input argument so we're
going to grab that like basically this
array um or arr bracket i is going to
represent a single letter of that array
so we're going to ask whether that
equals um any of the vowels so there's
there's actually some really short ways
that you can write this but i'm going to
go ahead and do this the clunky
you know really drawn out way just
because it's the most clear for a
beginner
so we'll say if the array or actually we
can use a switch a switch statement
um as we saw in a previous challenge so
the the thing that we want to evaluate
is that single letter
and then we're going to come down here
and we're going to say
case does it equal a
all right if it equals a then i want to
take this val's count variable and
increment it by
1. so that's what we're doing there and
then we will break out of the statement
remember that's very important all right
so we're going to do this for all of the
different vowels and we're just going to
paste this code
below here
and it's going to get all messed up with
formatting so let's see
and like i said there is a much quicker
solution
and i'm sure that we'll see someone that
used it
but this is you know in the scope of
what we've talked about already so i
just want to stay consistent with what
we've talked about you know not throw
any huge curveballs here
all right so we're getting to our last
one
let's pass that in we actually don't
need a break statement for this last one
here
and so basically what what's going to
happen here is we're going to loop
through this array so basically we're
going to look at every single letter in
the array from that original string
and we're going to ask does it equal a
if it does we're going to increment the
values count does it equal e increment
the values count and if it doesn't equal
any of those the val's count variable is
going to stay where it is so at the end
of this loop we're going to have a total
count
and then we just return it at the bottom
so let's go ahead and run the test on
this and see what we get
you can see we passed one of the tests
so let's go ahead and attempt it
and we passed all five of them so we
obviously got this correct so let's
submit it
guess it didn't submit so let's try that
again
sometimes this is a little bit slow it
has to actually run a bunch of tests so
all right so let's see what we got here
the first answer very clever um
this this gets into regular expressions
which we haven't even
come close to touching on and i don't
want to so we'll skip that um this right
here
looks um a little bit similar to what we
did
so this is actually a double loop so
we're actually looping through two
different arrays i really don't want to
get into that either because that that
will make anyone's braden spin to be
honest
got some more regular expressions
see
i'm just looking for the one that i was
thinking of that would be
a lot okay there it is
so we looped through this array and what
we could have done is just checked
instead of writing out this switch case
statement um all we would had to do is
put the vowels in an array and then we
would have to you know take that array
and use the includes method and then
loop through all the letters and check
if that letter
was included in that val's array so
that's what i was thinking of just a
little bit easier way to do it looks
like this person kind of solved it like
us but like i said there's a ton of ways
to solve each of these challenges
you know we can solve them however we
want
so let's go to the next one
looks like jenny's secret message i
wonder what jenny's secret message is
so let's train on this i gotta take a
little break here
solving all these these challenges tired
all
right here we go so jenny's secret
message jenny has written a function
that returns a greeting for a user
however she's in love with johnny and
would like to greet him slightly
different
that's romantic all right she added a
special case to her function but she
made a mistake
so let's look at the function it looks
like we're just trying to edit some code
here
all right the first thing i'm going to
do here is just run the test see what
we're getting kind of gives us some
clues
all right so now let's look at the code
let's see what what's happening here is
that we have a single parameter called
name so that's basically saying all
right this function expects a single
argument to be passed through it when
it's executed and that is called name
then we're going to use that name to
figure out if we're dealing with johnny
if we're not dealing with johnny then we
don't want to add you know
any specialized message we just want to
say hello to that name so up here this
is how we would do that we're just
concatenating a bunch of strings
together
so we're saying we have a hello string
and then we're adding the name that is
passed in and then an exclamation point
so this is basically
what we want to return for everyone
except
johnny all right so that's what we want
to return there let's space it out a
little bit and then if the name is
johnny we want to return hello my love
all we have to do here i think is
reverse these so what's happening right
now is we're going through this function
and it never even gets to this if
statement because we're already
returning something so basically every
time we run this function it's returning
hello you know name with an exclamation
point at the top it never checks to see
if johnny is the name because that's
like this code block down here just
never gets reached so all we have to do
is cut that from there and put that at
the top
so if the name
equals johnny return hello my love so
let's go ahead and test that
and it's going to pass now something
that you might
be wondering about right here if you've
been watching the videos
is this if statement so
normally we write an if statement with
these brackets and then we would put the
return right in there and that's how i
prefer to see it but
javascript has a bunch of little quirks
and if you have a simple if statement
like that we're just where you're just
returning a single line you don't
actually have to add the brackets that's
just a syntactical thing this is totally
fine if we run the test again
it's going to pass
and let's go ahead and attempt it so we
passed the test let's go ahead and
submit
just going through a couple of the
possible answers again this is another
ternary or no it's not
yeah this is using a ternary operator so
it's basically enclosing that ternary
operator within parentheses
and then it's putting it in the middle
of that string concatenation that we're
doing so
very clever but it's not something that
we need to do totally unnecessary and
it's honestly not
not quite as readable as what we have
done
all the other ones these are uh rather
simple this is a nice one this is a good
solution if the name is johnny we return
this else we return something else
we kind of did something similar we just
didn't add the else statement
all right let's go to the next problem
the next problem is n divisible by x and
y let's see what we got here
okay so we got quite a bit of
quite a few examples create a function
that checks if number n is divisible by
two numbers x and y
all inputs are positive non-zero digits
so again this last sentence is useful
because it's telling us hey we're not
going to throw any you know crazy
arguments through this function you
don't have to worry about handling you
know different types of data
you know you don't have to worry about
a string being passed into this data in
that case you might have to convert it
or just throw an error but in this case
all inputs are positive non-zero digits
so it's going to be from 1 to
infinity basically
all right so here are some of the
examples we might as well use these
so n equals 3 x equals 1 y equals 3.
this is true because 3 is divisible by 1
and 3.
all right n equals 12 x equals 2 y
equals 6. true because 12 is divisible
by 2 and 6. all right so it's basically
you know looking at all these numbers
trying to figure out if they're
divisible by each other all right
immediately i'm kind of thinking about
that modulus operator again because
anytime we look at something that says
is it divisible by
that comes in handy so and then also the
other thing that i'm thinking about
initially
is that it's saying checks if number n
is divisible by both of these numbers so
this and is capitalized which tells me
that we're probably going to be using
this and operator at some point so just
keeping that in mind as we solve it
again all inputs are positive non-zero
so basically what we're going to do is
we're going to do two different math
problems so we'll say result one
is going to do is going to be equal to n
divided by x
and then result
two is going to be n divided by y all
right so we're just running both of the
math problems and we're getting it into
a result variable
and then from here all we have to do
is basically
divide let's see so let's let's go ahead
and console.log out these results
just so that we can see some output that
we're receiving
so we will test it obviously everything
failed
but you can see what we were getting
here so we're getting some decimals as
we might expect if it doesn't go into it
evenly now a good way to check whether a
number is a whole number or a decimal is
using that modulus operator
and if you
think about it if we divide a number by
one
it's going to always go into itself
right unless it is a decimal so if we
were to let's go over to our playground
here
if we
divide this by 1 it's going to give us
20.
19 divided by 1 is 19. but 2.5 divided
by 1 is 2.5 so it's
not a whole number it's a decimal number
and because of that the modulus operator
is not going to return 0. so if we did
modulus 1
that's 0.
modulus 1 is 0. but 2.5
modulus 1 is 0.5 so any whole number is
going to
if we do modulus 1 is going to return us
with 0. so we can use that in our
solution here
so we'll say
if
result 1
modulus 1
equals
and then this is where that and
statement comes in
and
result two
modulus one
equals zero then we know that we have
a correct answer so let's see what it
wants us to return again
it says
checks if it's divisible okay
okay so we're returning true or false
so in this case we're going to just
return
true
and then if that's not true then we
return false so if the if the first
result the first division problem
and the second division problem if both
of those are not
equal to zero when we use the modulus
operator then
we return false down here so let's test
it see what we get
looks like we passed
that's great let's attempt it
and you can see that we passed all the
tests
let's see what everyone else was doing
here for this
i'm going to guess that a lot of people
solved it this way
but of course there's always these
clever folks out here that are just
solving it in one line
this one
this is interesting right here
i'm not going to go into it you know
these are these are not totally
relevant to us we solved it in a very
straightforward way wasn't clever but it
was very straightforward and that's all
we're asking for here so feel free to
look through these
let's go on to the next challenge
at this point i'm going to try to solve
these a little bit quicker
just so that we can blow through the
rest of the video i'll point things out
as we go of course but
um i've kind of
you know parked on a lot of the most
important things like how to how to look
at a test how to think about it how to
google all that kind of stuff so we'll
kind of we'll try to speed through these
a little bit faster
alright so this one is return negative
in the simplest assignment you are given
a number and have to make it or in this
simple assignment you are given a number
and have to make it negative
but maybe the number is already negative
all right so it's kind of implying to us
that we have to check whether the number
is negative first and then we have to
apply some sort of operation on it
so immediately we know that if we
multiply
something by a negative one then it
turns it you know the opposite sign that
it was
so if we
all we have to do is say if
the number is less than zero we know
that it's negative
so we're just going to return
the number because it's already negative
otherwise
if it's not less than zero then we're
going to return the number
multiplied by negative one
and that should be the solution right
there
we passed i think this is going to work
it's a pretty simple straightforward
answer
so again if you have caught on to this
when we're using the if-else statements
that's an opportunity to use a ternary
operator and you're going to see that in
some of these solutions so here is the
ternary operator at work it's basically
the same exact thing that we did has a
little bit of a different thing so if
you can just put a negative at the
beginning
of your variable to flip the sign of it
that's just a shortcut in javascript
but then
there's another solution this is
actually interesting
if you use the built-in
math function called the absolute method
that's going to turn any number to a
positive value
so if we just turn everything that we
get to a positive value and then reverse
that to a negative we're always going to
get a negative value so that that is a
clever solution and
honestly i think that's the best
solution if you just thought of using
this
but of course if you're a beginner
you're not going to think of using the
math.absolute method because you
probably don't know about it but again
you can look up these javascript
built-in functions and i'm sure that it
this one might not show you yeah so we
have the math methods down here and you
could
once again i'm on tutorials point i just
searched for javascript built-in
functions but we have these math methods
and the first one is the absolute method
so it returns the absolute value of a
number and if you knew that you could
think of it and just use that for our
solution
so anyways like i said we're not going
for the most optimized solution we're
going for the most straightforward and
clear solution for a beginner
all right so we're finding the smallest
integer in the array for this one
all right
given an array of integers your solution
should find the smallest integer
all right so this looks like a perfect
opportunity to write a loop
and you can see in our solution here
this is actually getting us into the
concept of classes which we
we have not talked about one bit so far
but basically
um each class is going to have you know
several different instance methods
um and then the find smallest int
is actually an instance method so
i'm not sure if we we might be able to
edit this let me see
well as you can see in the test it's
instantiating this new class so we can't
really do anything about it but i'm just
telling you don't worry about the class
right now
all we have to do is um implement this
method and we should be good so within
this method we're going to get some
arguments this is actually what we would
call this would be params
because that's what the params are what
we define within the function
declaration and the arguments or what we
pass through it but again in those
previous lessons i told you that
arguments and parameters are two sides
to the same coin and in this case that's
been demonstrated there
we're using args and params
interchangeably
all right so we'll just change it to
params to say stay consistent here and
then from here we're going to go ahead
and loop through this array
so the params that we're going to
receive
is an array of integers
all right so and then it says at the
bottom you can assume for the purpose of
this challenge that the supplied array
will not be empty so we don't have to
handle the case where it's empty but it
doesn't say anything well actually yeah
it does we're going to get an array of
integers so we're good
so let's go ahead and
assume that the params is an array so i
actually want to name this something
even more descriptive
so we'll call this array of numbers just
so that we can remember what we're doing
and now we're going to make a for loop
so basic for loop here
and
let's go ahead and go until we get to
the end
of this so we're going to grab the
length of that array of numbers
and then for each number in the array
we're going to check if it is the
smallest integer
so to do this we actually have to
declare
a
variable here that's going to keep track
of the smallest integer as we loop
through the array so let's just call
this
the smallest number and we're just going
to declare it because we have not
looped through any of the numbers yet
so or actually yeah let's go ahead and
declare it the smallest number that we
can possibly get
it's an array of integers and we might
get negative numbers
so let's just go ahead and initialize
this at zero so just for comparison
purposes you'll see what i mean in a
second
so as we loop through this array
the way that we're going to get
an individual number from the array is
by using this syntax here so we're going
to grab the array itself and then we're
going to pass in the index which should
be i which is going 0 1 2 3 all the way
till the length of the array so that's
going to represent our number and just
for clarity i'm going to go ahead and
say that so
we'll just say individual number
equals that so that's what we're going
to do for each loop we're going to
declare and assign a variable for that
then we're going to check and we're
going to say
if the smallest
number
is greater than the individual number
you also could have said if the
individual number is obviously less than
the smallest number either way works
then we're going to
set it to a new value so if the smallest
number is greater than the individual
number so the end of it well maybe we
should name this something more
descriptive so
individual number uh
array
we'll just say array number that's a
little bit more descriptive
i'm sorry this is this is not right even
at all i just need to take a little
break here from talking
so what we want to do is we want to say
if
the array number that we're looking at
you know in this iteration
if this is less than the existing
smallest number
then what we want to do is we want to
set the smallest number
equal to that array number so it takes
its place as the new smallest number
and basically what's going to happen is
as we loop through the array
it's going to check each number and if
it's not smaller then it's just going to
skip it and it's going to go to the next
iteration of the array so we really can
come down to the bottom of this and
return from this function the smallest
number after we've looped through all
the numbers in the array
let's go ahead and test this
looks like we've failed some so
i think this is because we didn't handle
negative numbers let's see
oh actually this is just a mistake on my
part so i initialize this at zero
but this is a problem if we have
positive numbers because
if we have an array that are you know
full of positive numbers so let's say
that we had an array that looked like
this we had 2
we had 5 and we had 6.
it's going to loop through all three of
these numbers and it's going to compare
it to our already smallest number of 0
and none of these are smaller so the
smallest number at the end is going to
return 0.
so we need to actually
not declare this
we're going to actually just
declare it and not assign it and then
the first thing we're going to do at the
very first iteration of the loop we're
going to
set the smallest number equal to that
first number so we're just going to say
if i equals 0 which basically means
we're at the very first iteration of our
loop
we want to set the smallest number
equal to
the array
of numbers
and then we want to grab that index of i
and actually we can we can actually put
this below so
let's get the number that we're talking
about first
and then we can replace this now
with array number
okay
so just to review what what i just
changed here
what we're doing is we're saying we're
going to initialize this or declare this
variable it's not going to have a value
yet so we have to assign it a value on
the first iteration of our array so
you know the first value of the array
basically and we know that that's always
going to be when i is equal to zero
so first let's get the number that we
are looking at in this specific
iteration we'll assign it to the array
number variable
and then we're going to ask is this the
first iteration of the array if it is i
want to set the smallest number variable
equal to
the first number in the array so now we
have something to compare against and in
the same iteration so still on the first
iteration of this array we're going to
compare the array number to the smallest
number they're going to be equal so
we're not going to get there it'll go
through and now it should work a little
bit better for us
and now we have an infinite loop because
i'm just getting scatterbrained here
and i actually set i
equal to one when i was looking at this
conditional
and that is a big no-no because what's
happening is now we're going through
this for loop in each iteration of the
loop we're resetting i to zero and
therefore we have an infinite loop and
that is actually something that you'll
stumble upon a lot and
infinite loops are not fun so
make sure you don't make that mistake
let's replace this with triple equals
which is going to actually do a equality
comparison
we should be better off this time so we
passed all of them
let's attempt it
and we passed the test at this point
i'll probably take a break because i'm
getting a little bit a little bit fuzzy
in the brain here so let's submit this
and let's just look at what other people
did obviously there's a better solution
in all cases
but i don't think any of these are at
the level that we're at right now
at this point i just can't even think
anymore so i'm going to take a break
and we'll come back and finish the rest
of the problems
the next challenge is grasshopper
summation so we'll see what that's all
about
it says write a program that finds the
summation the sum of every number from
one to
the variable called number
or num the number will always be a
positive integer greater than zero
remember pay attention to this right
here we don't have to worry about
negative numbers in this case
let's just look at an example because i
i want to go through that first so
if the number is 8 it's just saying go
from 1 to 8
and add everything together in
succession so
the first thing that we'll notice here
is that it's only adding one so not it's
not only adding one but
the number that we're adding only
increases by one so it looks very
similar to a for loop
so we can probably write a for loop so
let's go ahead and template that out so
we'll let i equal
0 to start we might have to change that
actually
and then we'll say i is less than num
um
yeah i is less than num because we want
to go through as many iterations
um as we need to get to
num
or the the value that's passed in and
then we'll say i plus plus
so
we start at the value of zero and if we
add zero to something that you know adds
zero so that doesn't matter so we're
fine doing that
and then it wants to go until
i is less than the number so in this
case
we may have to actually start this at i
equals 1 and then we say i is less than
or equal to number
so let's go ahead and do that let's
start it at 1 and then go up to the
number
and for starters i just want to print
this out to the console and see what we
get so i want to print out i each time
in the loop and since it's not a very
good you know place to do that
i'm just going to go over here to
my dev tools console
and we're going to paste that in there
and of course num is not defined because
uh we don't have that in passed as a
argument or anything to the function so
let's just put a random number let's put
10 in there and press enter
and what we're going to see is that it
counts 1 2 3 4 all the way to 10
which since we started it at 1 we get to
10 but if we were to start this at
0 like we normally do for
a loop
and then we take away this equal sign
it's going to go from 0 to 9 and if we
add all these numbers
it's not going to add up to the right
sum so it's very important that we start
it at an iteration of 1 and then we go
all the way up to 10. so we put that
little equal sign we also could have you
know deleted that and gone up to less
than 11. but you kind of get the point
just be conscious of that
now all we have to do is
make a variable called the sum
and we'll
initialize that at zero because we start
at a sum of zero
and then all we have to do
is say sum equals sum
plus i
so when i starts at one so we're saying
zero plus one then i increments to two
our sum is going to be stored at one
so we do one plus two and then we go i
equals 3 so our current sum is going to
be
3 because we had 1 plus 2 so then 3 plus
3 is 6. so on and so forth
so that's going to give us our sum
another way we could write this if you
were paying attention during the
previous video where we went through the
mathematical operators you can just do
plus equals and then you can say i
so what this is going to do is it's
going to take some and it's going to say
what is the value of the variable called
sum
and then once it finds that value it
says take that value and add the value
of i to it so this is an abbreviated
version of doing that but again i'm
going for readability here so i'm just
going to say sum
equals sum plus i that's the most clear
way that we could probably write that
so then we get to the bottom we've gone
through all of our iterations so the sum
variable should equal
the sum of all of those different
i values so now we just return the sum
let's see what we get
we pass both test cases i think we've
got it
all right so we passed all 105 test
cases
i'm not sure why anyone would want to
write 105 test cases for this but
nevertheless
let's submit our answer
all right let me just check to see where
we are within this
series we'll go to collections
alright so we are on
get the mean of an array so let's see
where we are here
all right so we're right here we've one
two three four five six seven eight left
all right not bad
let's go ahead and train on this so get
the mean of an array
all right
the instructions say it's the academic
year's end fateful moment of the school
report i'll remember that the averages
must be calculated all the students come
to you and treat you to calculate their
average for them
easy you just need to write a script
alright when they say a script that's
basically just saying you need to write
some code
return the average of the given array
rounded down to its nearest integer
the array will never be empty so you're
always going to get a number in this
array
and it says round it down
and what i'm going to think about
immediately is we're going to use one of
those utility functions or the built-in
javascript functions
so how do we round a number down
let's go to the built-in functions we're
already looking at the math methods
and we can see that if we look at the
floor
method or function
it says it returns the largest integer
less than or equal to a number so
basically rounds it down so math.floor
is going to round our numbers down and
if we go to the console here
let's go ahead and clear this because we
got so much stuff going on
and if we say math.floor
and then pass in a number 20.5
it's going to give us 20. so it just
rounded it down so that's basically the
round down function we're going to use
that in our practice or our challenge
here
this is kind of a useless comment
once again this marks marks right here i
don't like the name that they've given
this so i'm going to rename it because
we can name our parameters anything that
we want
so i'm going to say
score array so we're going to have all
the test scores or whatever scores we're
doing here
now within that array
let's see
what do we have to do again
we have to get the average okay
so what is the average
the average is going to be the sum
of all the numbers
divided by the count of all the numbers
all right so that's your average formula
pretty simple there
so to get the count that's the easy part
we'll just say the score array
dot length so that's going to give us
how many numbers are in this array
and then for the sum
unfortunately this is something i know
from
just writing code there is no
sum function of an array like built into
javascript so if you were to go to
google
let's go to google and search
how to sum
values in array
javascript
and let's go to stack overflow
you can use this
method called reduce and then you can
actually use an arrow function
but this is rather complicated and it's
not really at the level that we're
trying to be at right now right now
we're just trying to do it in the most
straightforward way possible and this
kind of comes later when you're more
experienced writing javascript code so
in our case we can do it a little bit
easier with a for loop
so all we have to do is write ourselves
a loop
start it at index of zero we want to go
until we've hit all the numbers in the
array
so
we can actually in this case we've
already gotten the length of the array
so all we have to pass in here is the
variable count that we stored that in so
that's a way to simplify your code
and then finally let's break down here
all right so we're going to loop through
each of these
and what we want to do is add them all
together so kind of similar to the last
problem we did but in this case
we want to assign
so we don't want to count
we don't want to say the same variable
so we'll say the sum equals 0 right now
and for each iteration we're just going
to say sum equals the existing sum
amount so it starts at zero
and then each time we iterate through
the array to the score array
we're going to grab that individual
number that we're looking at and add it
to the existing sum
so now we get down here to the bottom we
have the count and we have the sum
so let's go ahead and just return the
average which is going to be the sum
divided by the count
let's see what this results in
all right so we passed two of them
but we failed one of them and the reason
is because we forgot to round down
i forgot that requirement so all we need
to do is surround this with the
math.floor function
and that should return the right answer
i could have broken this out onto the
another line just for simplicity so
we'll say the average is the sum divided
by the count
and then we can say rounded
down
equals math.floor
and then pass in the average so take the
variable we just assigned here
and then we just want to return the
rounded
down variable and that should give us
the same answer hopefully we get this
right this time and we did
let's attempt it we should be able to
get this
awesome
so that's just how we would solve that
problem so as you can see just to take a
slight break and and review what we're
doing here
a big part of solving these problems is
um obviously getting the instructions
right and understanding what type of
input we're going to be receiving into
this function
the second part
with these easier
these easier challenges we're going to
do a lot of
looping through arrays and stuff like
that and that is actually really
consistent with the real world when
we're writing code and building apps
we're going to be doing you know stuff
like this quite a bit we're not going to
be solving useless problems like this
but we're going to be looping through
arrays a lot and setting counter
variables and some variables all that
kind of stuff
so this is actually going to be testing
us on on very useful skills that you're
going to use in the future
all right so if you remember from that
stack overflow question they're talking
about reducing it
to get the average and you can see that
that's exactly what the the top solution
or
i guess the the best practice solution
is doing
it's it's basically using marks.reduce
so this is going to get us the average
then we're going to divide it by the
length and then we're going to put it to
the floor so basically round it down so
that's that's what i was talking about
with this stack overflow solution
honestly if you ask me it's kind of
weird that the array
arrays don't have an average method
seems like a very common one to have but
nevertheless we don't so
all right so this challenge looks like
we have a picture to look at
let's let's do some rock paper scissors
okay so it says let's play you have to
return which player won
in case of a draw return draw
okay and this is just a reminder of how
rock paper scissors works i think most
people would know that
immediately when i look at this i'm not
a huge fan of this so we're naming the
variable that we're storing this arrow
function in as rps or rock paper
scissors
um
i'm going to just rename this because
we need to have
meaningful variables here so we're going
to name it rock paper scissors spelled
out
and then p1 and p2 again these are not
very
descriptive
so
let's replace those parameters with
something that makes more sense so
player one
and player two alright so now we've got
this written out i like this a little
bit better now let's go through our
different cases so
first thing you might want to do is
write some pseudo code so pseudocode is
basically
um you know just writing out like
logically how this should work and maybe
this isn't even considered pseudocode
but let's write out all of the different
scenarios that we can have so
we'll say rock is r
paper
is p
and
scissors is s
all right so for
player one
over here and then player two
and then the result so let's go ahead
and write these out
we have player one we'll do rock and
then since there's three different
possibilities we're going to have just a
matrix of possibilities so we'll go rock
rock rock
paper paper paper
scissors scissors scissors okay so
that's all the possible
plays that player one can do and then
obviously
we will go through with player two over
here
and we'll alternate so we'll go rock
paper
scissors
and then again we'll go rock
okay so in this comment we've written
out all of the different possibilities
and who's going to win in each case so
you can see that there's three draws
three times where player two wins and
then three times where player one is
going to win as we might expect
so how can we convey this
what we're seeing right here in code and
to answer that
there's there's a couple methods that
you can go about doing it but once again
i'm going to try to go with the simplest
most straightforward and easy to read
method
so seeing this written out like this
where we have all these different
scenarios
i think that we can say that we're gonna
go with player one and just have three
if statements so
if player one chooses rock if player one
chooses paper or scissors
so we'll just put out those if
statements real quick so we'll say if
player one equals rock
and then we're gonna copy that down
okay so we got rock paper scissors so
these are the three scenarios for player
one and then for player two
um we're obviously alternating between
these so let's say
player one plays rock
so
we could probably put a switch statement
in here but i don't know if we need to
so we'll just say if player two
equals
rock
then that's going to be a draw so we're
going to return draw
then we'll say if player 2
equals paper
then that is going to be return
player 2
1.
and then finally if player 2 equals
scissors
then in this case
return
player 1
one
okay so now we can basically just copy
these same three
down into each of these
and this is going to work so
this one's complete so let's just fill
out the rest of the results so player
one uh chooses paper player two chooses
rock it's going to be player
one
so if we're going paper against paper
it's going to be a draw
and then player 2 for that last one
all right and then scissors versus rock
so we're going to say player
one
this one will be player one and then
this one will be a draw
let's go ahead and test this
looks like we failed um
and it's complaining that rps is not
defined and that's just because i
changed the name of the function at the
beginning of this
which i guess i can't do after all but i
would not prefer to see it like this it
should be more descriptive
so let's go ahead and test that
and it looks like all of them pass so we
fulfilled all of our different scenarios
that we wrote out for ourselves
but i can guarantee you that there is a
more efficient solution because
in many cases we have like overlapping
scenarios but
if you're just thinking about this
logically and you want the the easiest
thing to read that you know even a
beginner could go through and understand
what it's doing
this solution works okay so let's
attempt it we passed our test and let's
see how someone who is going to optimize
it a little bit more would have solved
this problem
okay so here's the first one
so it's saying if p1 is equal to p2 then
we return a draw so that eliminates
three of our scenarios that we had to
write out in separate if statements so
that's already reducing our amount of
code by a lot
then what they're going to do is they're
going to put
the rules within
an object which is actually
quite interesting
so they're basically saying that for one
player here is the rules so
rock is always going to beat scissors
paper is always going to beat rock and
scissors is always going to beat paper
so that's very interesting how they're
doing that and then
they're saying if p2 so player 2
is equal to the rules
so it's grabbing
whatever player 1 responded with
and then it's going to grab the value of
that and compare it to what player 2
responded with yeah so this is a very
very smart solution very efficient
but at this point after solving
however many we've solved here 20 or so
my brain's a little shot and we're going
with the simple answer here now this is
something a little bit closer to what we
might have been able to do
so we could have combined the conditions
into expressions so rather than
separating it out into a bunch of if
statements
we could have combined them together
this is how we kind of started doing it
so obviously there's a lot of solutions
to this problem
all right this next one looks relatively
straightforward oh it says it's pretty
straightforward so your goal is to
create a function that removes the first
and last characters of a string
you're given one parameter the original
string you don't have to worry with
strings with less than two characters
okay so this is a going to be a great
time to use one of these built-in
functions so let's go to the string
methods and see what we have available
to us
in string so this is what we're looking
at
so
we could use this character at
because we could specify the end of the
string in the beginning of the string
with zero and then you know we could
find the length of the string to find
the last character that seems a little
bit indirect though
let's see
we can also return a substring this is
actually going to be
the most direct route here so a
substring is going to return the
characters in a string beginning at the
specified location
through the specified number of
characters
okay so i'll show you how we're going to
use this
but first let's kind of get an idea of
how it works so if we have a string and
that string is hello
what we can do is say
string.substring
and maybe i want to start at the very
beginning which is going to have an
index of 0. now we haven't really talked
about this we've always talked about
arrays having indexes
but strings also do as well you can
think of each individual character
within the string as being a separate
index so h is going to be an index of 0
e 1 l 2 so on and so forth
so if we're starting at index of 0 that
means we're starting at h
and then the next
argument that we get to pass in
according to the instructions
that we looked at here i kind of know
how to use this already but you could
click on here and it's going to say
we're going to pass in what we want to
start with and then the length that we
want to grab so let's go ahead and grab
two characters from this string so we
start at h and then we grab two full
characters starting there and we get he
so if we would omit this we're just
going to start at 0 or start at the
beginning and get all of the characters
but if we replace this with 1
we're going to get all the characters
except for that first one so we're
actually
partially
to our solution
we've got the first character removed
now we have to figure out how to remove
the last character
and to do that we have to figure out how
long the string is in total
and to find out how long the string is i
believe there might be
i think there's a method for that or a
function
so there should be yeah string.length so
let's try that out
let's get rid of this
and we'll say string.length
is equal to 5. so if we know the length
of the string and we know that the
string starts at an index of 0 we then
know where our sub string is so all we
have to do is say
string.substring
we want to start at index of 1 because
that omits the first character of our
string
and then we want to end or not end we
want to grab how many different letters
well we want to grab
let's see the string dot length
minus
uh
what would it be 2
yeah it would be 2 because we've removed
the first letter and we want to remove
the last letter so
we want to grab
just the total length of the string
minus two okay so that is our solution
right there let's just go ahead over to
our problem and write it out
so this is pretty easy we just return
string dot substring or maybe we can
break this out so that it's you know
clear as day for you uh length of string
is going to be equal to string dot
length
and notice how i have not added these
parentheses at the end that is just the
nature of this function and i just know
this by experience but you'd figure it
out uh probably by googling it or at
some point after you try doing this so
let's say we tried to do this as we
would think this makes logical sense but
it's going to say string.length is not a
function
now
go ahead and copy this just copy this
and paste it into google
and you're going to get
stack overflow answer that tells you how
to do this and it says oh you have to
use just dot length and you don't have
to add those parentheses so that's how
you might figure that out on your own
but i happen to know that that is how we
write it so string that length
and then we need to get the sub string
so we'll just return that straight away
string.substring
we want to start at the first character
or actually the second character and
then we want to get the length
of string
minus two characters
okay so let's see what we get
pass the test as we expected
okay let's submit it
now as you can see there's a maybe even
simpler way to do this so we can use the
slice method
um
if we go to the built-in functions if we
would have looked so we'd grab the
substring method but there is a slice
method
which is right above it so extracts a
section of a string and returns a new
string well in this case i was just not
being smart i overlooked that and didn't
realize but if you just read through
these this would obviously be a better
selection than substring but it does
give us the idea that you can solve this
in multiple different ways
and i'm sure that at some point yep down
here someone solved it the way that we
solved it
in this case they're doing string dot
length minus one
which is very interesting
oh so this is actually not the same so
substring
is different than the one that we used
as you can see we have the one that we
used and then substring so these are two
different methods they work kind of
similar
a little bit different so that's why
that one works that way but
you can see that
this person used exactly what we did
so multiple ways to solve a problem
let's see if we can blow through the
last couple of these
so let's go to sum of positive you get
an array of numbers return the sum of
all of the positive ones
okay
so we're going to loop through this
we're going to grab every
number from that array
and then we're going to say if
the individual number that we have
grabbed
is greater than
or no yeah we'll say greater
or equal to zero
um
i guess we don't even need that we just
say greater than zero
then we want to sum it but we need to
have a sum variable so let's initialize
a sum variable
and set it equal to zero and then we'll
say if it's a positive number we're
going to say sum equals sum plus the
number that we're using there
and then at the bottom we just return
the sum variable
and we should get the correct answer
past it all this is pretty similar to a
previous question that we did
in this video so we'll submit this
as you can see this is a well commented
solution that is kind of the same thing
that we just did so
we didn't do too bad now obviously you
can use a simpler method so reduce
similar to how you'd find the average
of an array
but once again this is this is pretty
complex like you're
using a pretty complex um
function
on an array
and you're using a ternary operator
within here so that's you know that is
optimized to the max
so we got some basic mathematical
operations let's go ahead and go here it
says your task is to create a function
that does four basic math operations
it should take three
oper arguments so we want the operation
which is going to tell us are we adding
subtracting multiplying or dividing and
then the two values we're doing so this
is this rather simple
this person has formatted this function
a little differently
than we're used to this is just a
different way to format it i'm just
going to bring it back to how we're used
to seeing it doesn't really matter
okay so the basic operation so the first
thing we want to do is write a switch
statement
you're probably getting used to this at
this point
and for the switch statement we want to
pass in the operation
so it's going to evaluate that and see
what the operation is and in the case
that the operation is a plus
we'll do something add a break statement
and then we'll fill in the rest of these
with
case statements
and then i believe all we have to do is
just fill these in so we can return
from here or we could set it equal to
you know a variable so since we added
the break statements
let's go ahead and just
initialize a variable we'll call it
result
and we're going to say the result is
equal to value 1
plus value 2.
we can copy this same line down
and then at the end we can return the
result whatever we get
so let's indent these correctly doesn't
really matter just for readability and
then we'll just change the sign here so
we can put a minus sign here we can put
multiplication sign here and a division
sign here
all right let's go ahead and attempt it
all right that worked
i have a feeling that someone solved
this in one line
we'll see this is how we did it
yep right here so this
this is very
simplified but let me explain what this
is doing so
if we type in eval
let's look at
javascript eval
and we're going to learn about this a
little bit so what this does the eval
function evaluates or executes an
argument
so if we have three uh arguments passed
in we have the operation we have the
first number and the second number and
it's always going to be the same
um for each one so each one we're just
substituting this operation
well you might think oh hey let's or
let's go ahead and train again on this
one so that i can show you exactly what
i'm talking about so let's go up here
and in this case we might just say
return
the op or the value 1 and then the
operation
and then value 2. now this is going to
obviously not work that's not valid
javascript right here
and all we're trying to do is we're
trying to turn this operation into a
javascript operator and all we have to
do to make that happen
is surround it in this eval statement
right here
and basically what it's going to do i
believe you separate it by comma
separated values
or no you put it in one big string
so let's go ahead and create our
string
so our operation
string is going to equal
value 1 plus
operation plus value 2.
and in this case some of these are going
to be numbers so we
yep that should work because value 1 is
a string so everything else is going to
be
coerced into a string so that should
work so operation
plus value one value two
and then i want to just console.log that
so that we can see what it represents
here
so we'll console log that and comment
out this return value for just a second
so let's test that
and you're going to see that the console
log is giving us the following
operations here and if you
you know look at these these look like
you know valid math operations but right
now we just have them as a string but
once we enclose it in
the eval
function
so we say eval and then we pass in our
operation string
it's going to evaluate that string so in
other words it's going to evaluate the
string of four plus seven
and then we can just return the result
and this should work the same as our
much longer code that we wrote
so let's let's go back and
just see what that one person wrote
there
they just you know abbreviated
everything but did the same exact thing
so
just another way to solve it more
efficient
next up we have a string repeat
write a function called repeat string
which repeats the given string
source exactly count number of times
okay so this is what we're going to get
they're going to pass in
we want to repeat it six times or five
times and here's the string that we want
to repeat
this is another classic example of where
you can use
a loop so we'll just set a loop equal to
just the basic syntax
we want to go until i is less than the i
is less than n so
let me replace these
number of
repeats
and then the string that we want to
repeat so
number of repeats
so we're looping through this and
let's go ahead and
make a starter string
and we'll just set that equal to just an
empty string here
now all we're going to do is concatenate
strings as many times as this loop goes
so we'll just say starter
string equals whatever exists in that
starter string plus
the
string value
and this should return the correct
answer for us
it works
pretty consistent with what we've done
in previous problems with the loop and
then we have a
variable up here that stores
some sort of value that we later return
after we've modified it several times
with
values in a loop
and of course there's a an easier
solution so you can see down here that
we can just use the repeat function i
didn't actually know this was a function
but if you go to the
string methods
there should be some sort of repeat
so let's see
i'm not seeing it right now
what are they doing here
so that is a string method
did i miss it
let's search for it on the page
don't see it here this might be a new
method
okay so maybe maybe use w3schools that's
more updated
that must have been a recently added
method of some sort
yeah it looks like this came out in es6
which is the newest version of
javascript uh spec so that's probably
why it's not on the other
site there
interesting so you can use a repeat
string to
repeat a string number of times very
interesting okay go to the next problem
convert a string to an array this should
be very easy because we've already done
it
at least i think
we've done so many problems at this
point
i think all we have to do is say string
dot
split
and then we split it with
an empty character
oh that's not how we do it okay
we don't
want to split it like that so let's see
oh okay so we want to split it by spaces
so there's a space in between these
words
so all we have to do is
press the spacebar in between these
quotes
and it adds a space in here that we want
to split it by
and this one does pass
you can see that pretty much everyone
solved it the exact same way here
be getting to the end of these problems
here congrats if you are still around
and
solving these problems with me
i would presume that
very few people would be
so remove string spaces
so remove the spaces from the string
then return the resultant string now
this one feels like there is some sort
of built-in method that we can use since
we
didn't find the newer methods on
tutorials point let's go to
w3schools
i'm thinking something called trim yeah
like trim might do this
says remove white space from both sides
of a string
i think that's what we're looking for
here
so let's go ahead and return
x which should be a string like i don't
know why they're calling it x here just
call it a string
so string dot
trim
see what that does
this is not going to work
looks like there's some numbers
put in
here and it looks like
the trim method is only going to do this
at the end of the string so let's try
this out in our
dev console
let's do a test string
uh string that has spaces between
oh i'm just blanking out completely i
got to name this variable
so string equals that
sorry about that i'm kind of losing it
here all right so if we use string.trim
it looks like what's happening is it's
only removing the spaces at the end kind
of as this
tells us so i wonder if there's another
method
i don't know if there is
so what we're going to do is we're just
going to combine the methods together so
first
maybe we put this into a an array
so we'll say string.split and we want to
split it by a space
so now that we have everything split out
now we want to go through each of these
in the array
and
we want to remove the white spaces
around them
so let's let's go ahead and write this
code out and see what we get
so we'll turn it into an array so we'll
split it by
spaces
and then we're going to loop through
this array
as we've been doing
and for each item in the array we're
going to
remove the spaces around it and we're
not actually going to build a new array
so this is going to introduce the push
method so
we'll say new array.push
and what that's going to do is add an
element to the end of the array so right
now it is an empty array and we can push
items into the array and what we want to
push
is going to be the trimmed version of
each string that we have or each
different array item which just happens
to be the subsets of that original
string so in this case
we'll say trimmed string just breaking
this out for clarity
is going to be
equal to
the
[Music]
what are we looking at so the
array at index i
dot trim so now we know that this string
is trimmed together there are no spaces
anywhere and now we're going to push
this
into the array so at this point let's go
ahead and console.log that new array
that we're getting
so let's test that
and you're going to see that we have an
array in every case that's going to have
you know the characters with no spaces
around it and in this case it's just an
empty string that's not even a space or
anything so if we combine that it's not
going to add any spaces of any kind
at this point we can use
a method called join
so all we have to do is
um
our final string is going to be equal to
our new array.join
and we want to join it by that empty
character there
and at this point we can return the
final string and i think that that
should solve the problem
all right so we passed it looks good
okay i think we're closing in on the end
here
beginner lost without a map
given an array of integers return a new
array with each value doubled
okay so there's actually um it says for
the beginner try to use the map method
and this is basically just saying um to
you as the beginner like hey you could
solve this in you know an easier way but
go ahead and try to use the map method
so we'll we'll do that we might as well
so we're going to get
some array i'm just going to
rename that so that it's not
undescriptive
and then we're going to go and look at
the map method
and this actually belongs to
arrays so we go to javascript arrays
and then we go down to the array methods
or functions and you're going to see
this one called map down here
and what this map
function is going to do is it's going to
take the original value in the array and
it's going to apply a transformation to
it and that transformation is just
basically going to
return a brand new array where every
unit of that array has been transformed
so previously we have been going through
these for loops and storing things in
variables and in creating new variables
and stuff like that but we could always
use this map method
so let's go ahead and try it so we're
going to return
the array
dot map and then in this case we
actually have to pass in an arrow
function
so this this is what we call like a a
callback function we'll get into this
a little bit later
but we're going to have a callback
function so this right here let's just
break it out you know into a separate
space so you can see what we're doing
so all we're doing is writing an
anonymous function or a arrow function
and then within that arrow function
we're going to break down into the new
line and we're going to return a value
so this is a very weird
um setup here so i'm actually going to
um
i'm going to go ahead and
remove this so i'm going to say our
result array is equal to whatever this
map function returns and then we're
going to return the result later so that
we don't have that weird syntax
so basically whatever we return from
this map method or this this function
that's actually embedded within the map
method
whatever we return is going to be the
transformation
and then whatever we pass into it so
we can just provide a parameter so
array item is going to be
what's going to be passed in there into
there as an argument so we're going to
just say array item multiplied by 2
which is what they want us to do with
each value so this is going to return us
an array with the values doubled in it
and we return the result
we passed
i would suggest reading up on that
method trying it out a little bit
but just realized that what we've done
here is we've put a function
within
this other function that takes that
function as an argument so
um to to summarize this we've basically
passed in a function
as an argument to another function and
then that function actually executes our
function that we passed in so it's it's
a bit of a tongue twister but you will
understand this with due time and i
would definitely put this on your radar
as something that's very useful in
javascript
at this point i'm doubting myself for
picking 25
problems this is exhausting but
again congrats if you're still around
let's keep going
all right is he going to survive a hero
is on his way to the castle to complete
his mission however he's been told that
the castle is surrounded with a couple
of powerful dragons each dragon takes
two bullets to be defeated our hero has
no idea how many bullets he should carry
assuming he's going to grab a specific
given
number of bullets and move forward to
fight another specific given number of
dragons
will he survive
return true if yes false otherwise
okay
so basically what this is saying to us
is that we don't know how many bullets
are coming and we don't know how many
dragons are coming either but we still
have to figure out if this hero is going
to defeat the dragon
so let's see how we do that the rule is
this each dragon takes two bullets to be
defeated okay
so basically what we could say is if the
bullets is
double or more than the amount of
dragons then we return true
so we'll basically just say in in this
case let's go ahead and use the ternary
operator i know it's late in the video
brain's probably fried at this point but
let's use the ternary operator we'll
store it in a result variable
so we'll say if
the
bullets
divided by dragons
is greater or equal to two
then
we're going to return true
otherwise we'll return false
and then we can just return the result
but we don't even need to do that we can
just return that ternary operator
so let's go to the beginning
and hit return so basically what it's
doing is it's looking at this expression
and it's
evaluating whether that expression is
true or false
and then if it's true we return true if
it's false we return false so there's
actually some duplication going on here
we don't even need this ternary operator
in the first place all we have to do is
return that expression because if this
uh evaluates to true then the hero
defeats the dragon if not then we return
false so we should be able to just do
this
we passed it and it works so that's how
you would
solve this in the most simple way
possible and honestly it's just a math
problem plus a javascript expression
with some operators
array plus an array so let's train again
i'm new to coding and now i want to get
the sum of two arrays actually the sum
of all their elements i'll appreciate
for your help
huh it looks like this person
was not writing a challenge they were
asking a question okay
p.s each array includes only integer
numbers output is a number two
maybe they weren't asking a question
very very weird wording for this
okay so this is not going to work let's
go ahead and test it as it's written
you can't just add an array together
but what you can do is you can loop
through each
value of the array and this is actually
a perfect
time to talk about embedded for loops
let's go ahead and do that
first we're going to write our outer for
loop which is just what we've been
writing all this time
so we're going to say
until i is less than array.1 or
array1.length
i plus plus
and then we go into it okay
but we also want to grab
the values of array two so basically
what we're trying to do here
let's say that we have an array of one
two three
and an array of two
three
4. our resultant array
should be
7 because we added
we added the number at index 0 for both
arrays then we added the number at index
1 for both arrays and then we put it
into a new one so that's what we're
going for i'm going to leave this down
here for a second just for our reference
but in this first loop all we're able to
get is
actually we don't we don't need an
embedded for loop
i don't know what i was thinking there
all we have to do is this we just have
to say
um
array 1 value is going to be equal to
array 1
i
and then we can come down and say array
2 value
is array 2i
all right and then we want to
say added value something like that so
we'll say array 1 value plus
array 2 value
that gives us the sum and now we want to
start building
a new array so new array equals
something empty
and like we did in a previous
problem we can use the
push method to
push a new value to that array so
we'll just say the added value here
and now when we get done with this for
loop right here we should have this new
array populated with our new value
which should be this resultant summed
array
so let's return
the new array
and see how it goes
looks like we failed in in a lot of
cases
okay let's see why
oh
so i misinterpreted this question
entirely
we want to actually
give a single number okay
so i'm new to okay blah blah
so we got two arrays we want to sum all
of their elements
okay so we don't need a new array
we just need a sum variable which is
going to start at zero
so the added value we can keep that
then we can just say the sum equals the
sum plus the added value
and then return
the sum at the end
this time we passed it okay just misread
the question and honestly i i don't know
if this was the best question to choose
i think this is our last uh
easy question
coming up
maybe so
alright so this one has some nice clear
instructions that's nice so the
introduction the first century spans
from year
one up to and including the year 100 the
second from year 101
up to and including the year 200.
the task is given a year return the
century it is in
so
the century of 1705 returns the 18th
century okay
i mean this is just
pretty basic so
let's go ahead and solve it
now it looks like the catch here is
going to be
these two examples so 1900 is going to
be the 19th century
while
1601 is going to be the 17th so
like it says if it's
you know one greater than the even year
then we go up a century okay
i believe we can use some sort of
modulus operator here
let me try
um so let's let's say that we have a
century of 1901.
um
let's go ahead and do modulus we'll just
start with 100.
okay so a hundred goes into 1901
uh
well it would be
what 19 times with a remainder of 1.
but if we had 1900
modulus 100 we get zero
okay so that's interesting so what we
could do is we say if
the century we have
modulus 100 returns a zero then we want
to just grab the first two letters
or first two digits of that number and
return it
so
in this case 1900 we just want to return
19 i believe
right so we just want to return 19. so
let's just say that this is this may be
a bad solution but let's try it so
if the year
modulus 100
equals
zero then that means it's an even
even century so we're going to just say
we want to return the first two digits
and to do that
we can
let's go ahead and look at some of the
the number values
okay so pretty much what we're gonna
have to do is we're gonna have to
convert it to a string grab the first
two
you know digits or characters and then
convert it back to a number
this may be an indirect way to do it but
we'll try it anyway so we'll say year
to string then i'm going to chain
chain something on here and i want to
grab the
sub string in this case i want to start
at 0 and grab 2 characters
and then i want to turn this entire
thing into a number so we'll just cast
it into a number
this way
and let's go ahead and test that to see
if we solved a couple of these
excellent so we solved the ones where
it's an even
now if it's not then we know that it's
not an even year
so it's always going to be one greater
so 1705 returns 18. so again we can grab
that substring
so we're going to grab first two
digits it's going to be equal to the
year
two string
substring
zero two so that gives us the first two
digits
and we wanna keep that as a number
and since we're repeating ourselves here
let's go ahead and put this at the top
of our code
and just get that from the very
beginning and now we can take this
expression here
and replace
it in here so all we have to say is
first two digits so now that works the
same we're turning that into a number
but down here what we want to first do
is we want to return a number of course
well it's already okay never mind
so this is going to give us a string we
need to return a number so
um the first thing we need to do is turn
that into a number
by saying first
two digits and then we want to add since
this is a number then we want to add one
so i think this may work actually
okay so the problem here is the test for
year 89.
since we're doing modulus 100
of course this is not going to work
if it's less than 100.
so in this one edge case we could just
put this at the top
at the very top and say
if the year is less than 100
we just return 1.
so that takes care of that case and we
test it
should pass all of them we'll see if it
passes all the tests
okay so clearly that was not that was a
quick fix solution it didn't actually
solve
our greater problems so let's dig in to
see
what we're dealing with here obviously
there are larger numbers at stake and
much smaller numbers at stake
so our
attempt at using modulus 100 is not
going to work very well
so i believe our solution may be close
i'm actually going to go ahead and
see if there's something in the
discussion down here so you can always
look at the comments and suggestions
to see what other people are thinking
about
we'll see
okay these are very useless
okay so this is not really helping us
that much
at this point my brain's so fried we're
gonna go ahead and search this on google
stack overflow
uh we'll just
say century
from year
javascript
stack overflow
just curious to see how other people
solve this
okay so
it looks like what they're doing here is
using the
math.ceiling function
let's see what this
is
okay so here's the the ceiling function
it returns x rounded upwards to the
nearest integer
so we'll go back and
attempt this again and see all those
different
test cases so let's just grab one of
them here
so 400 390
and let's see what math.ceiling
returns for that
oh and we have to divide it by a hundred
so
let's do that again
which is what we're trying to get at
because
we round this up
to the nearest hundred
okay so that's basically the answer then
um couldn't think of that on my own here
today
so
let's go ahead and try that um
instead of all this stuff let's just
return it math.ceiling
is year
over a hundred and this may not
may not get the cases where it's an even
or maybe it does let's attempt it
all right there you go so that's that's
very clever but um
i guess in this case when i was trying
to solve it here
um i did not
go through the scenario in my head where
the years would be you know greater than
say
1720 or 1930.
like i didn't think about what if we
have like year 20 000
something like that so in this case
it's a little bit of the instructions
like they didn't
you know say a whole lot about
what the input was going to be they
didn't say that we're going to you know
go up to a huge
input like they ended up doing so that's
partially the instructions and then it's
partially you know i should have thought
of all the edge cases and should have
thought of the fact that the number
could be greater than four digits like
this so
we solved the problem with
a specific set of input but not all of
the possible input and that's just
that's very common when you're solving
coding challenges you always have to
think of the edge cases so while i
didn't get this the first time it's
definitely a good learning opportunity
just to see
you know how it is when you're trying to
solve coding challenges
all right for this one we're converting
cat years and dog years in human years
so
we're only going to get whole numbers
and we're only going to get human years
one or greater
okay so 15 cat years for the first year
nine cat years for the second year and
four
for each year after that
15 dog years for the first year nine for
the second and five after that so notice
we have some similarities in the first
two they both
go up by
15 and nine in the first two years
okay so what are we getting here what's
the input
um i have a cat and a dog i got them at
the same time as getting a puppy
that was human years ago so we're going
to get a number passed in here
return their respective ages now okay
so the easiest one
is going to be
human years
plus
or no we just say
human years in there so that should be
the answer to the first part of the
array the second two are a little bit
harder so we have to get the dogs and
the cats
all right so the first thing that we
want to do
let's see
let's say human years is one well in
that case we're going to return
15 for both of them
so
let's make a variable here
and then we'll say if
human years equals 1
we want to return
this right here so we're going to say
human years
and then we're going to say the cat's
age
is going to be
what
and the dog's age
will be 15.
if the human years are equal to two
let's see
we're going to add 9 to that so we're
going to return something very similar
but this k this time we're going to
return 24 here
all right and then the remainder we're
going to say
in the first two years we get to 24 for
both the dog and the cat but then they
increment by different amounts
so how do we solve this
okay so so let's say
cat
excess years
is going to be equal to
human years
minus two
or we'll just say
we can just say excess years and use
this for both
so we're basically trying to find
you know how many years above the first
two years
are we looking at here
and then from there we can probably just
multiply it by
whatever this multiple is so
we'll say
extra
dog or no we'll start with
cat extra cat years
equals excess years times
what four
and then for the dog years we're gonna
do five so we're just going to make a
new variable and say extra dog years
so then
we just return at the bottom here if we
have not hit either of these
logical statements
because if we return from here
everything's done we don't reach any of
the code below but if we have not
reached either these code paths we're
going to reach this
and we're going to always return human
years just as the number of years but
then we're going to say
we know that we've got at least two
years if we reach this code so we'll say
24 plus the extra
cat years
and then we'll say
24 plus extra dog years
let's see if this gets it right
awesome we got it right so that's how i
would solve that problem let's see
how
other people would solve it
okay so this is interesting it's a
similar concept we asked if it was the
uh year one or year two and then we
basically just
did the same thing just in less code so
i feel pretty good about that
we did pretty good on that one so
especially
not being able to think i've been going
at this for a while now
all right i think we have like two more
in total i'm gonna make it to the end
our football team finished the
championship the result of each match
looks like x colon y results of all the
matches are recorded in the collection
all right write a function that takes
such collection and counts the points of
our team in the championship
the rules for counting points if x is
greater than y three points if x is less
than y zero points if they're equal one
point
there are 10 matches total
and x is going to be between 0 and 4
or not between it's going to be
inclusive of 0 2 4
and then y is going to be 0 2 4.
okay
so this games let's just make this more
specific that's going to be a games
array
we'll initialize by saying
let total points equal zero
and we're going to set up a for loop
all right so we're going to go through
each and we expect each value to equal
something like this
so
we'll just say value
and that's going to be games array
with the index of i which starts at 0.
so just for reference i'm going to say
sample value in a comment
and this will be
3 colon 1.
all right so the first thing i
gonna think about doing since 3 and 1
are used for calculating this
i'm going to split them
so we're going to say parts
are going to be equal to value
dot split
and we're going to split it by a
delimiter of a colon
so now let's console.log
the parts of this array and we're just
going to see what that looks like
so these are the values that we're
getting in each iteration of the for
loop
so we're getting you know one and one
two and two three and three so on and so
forth and now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna say all of these different
scenarios so we're going to say if
parts 0 so the first one
if the first value
so x
yeah so x and y so the first one is x
so if parts 0 which is going to be x we
might as well break this out into a
descriptive variable
so there's your x
and there's your y
the first and second value of that array
and we're going to say if x
is greater than y we're just following
the rules over here basically
we're going to do something
and if x is
we'll say else if x
equals y
and then finally else which is just
basically going to be that last
condition which means x is less than y
okay so let's just put it in there we'll
say total points
equals total points
plus
and in this case it's going to be three
then down here let's just use a shortcut
because we can so we'll do plus equal
this is just an operator that does the
same thing
as here except just in a shorter way so
we'll do plus
equal and then in this case it's a tie
so it's one point
and then otherwise it's zero points
so in this case we actually don't even
need this last block because it's adding
zero which doesn't even matter
let's return the total points here
all right we passed it
awesome
even going through the explanation there
i will assume that you're pausing the
video to do that
oh that's an interesting solution right
there
i'm not going to get into that though
okay
at this point i believe this is the last
question
no we
finished it
looks like we've finished all of them i
i don't know i think we skipped
this last one the val count no we did
that at the beginning anyways if you
enjoyed this video give it a like
subscribe to the channel uh please i'm
very tired right now from going through
all these challenges together with you
be sure to follow me on code wars and
i'll follow you back
and stick around for the next video in
this lesson series
see you later
[Music]
now in the last couple of videos we have
talked about
the basics of javascript essentially so
we started with some variables and we
went through you know functions and
loops and operators
conditionals all that good stuff
so at this point we're ready to jump
into some of the built-in
functions in objects within javascript
which is going to save us a ton of time
when we're actually writing our code
because it basically uh it's a bunch of
shortcuts essentially and also just kind
of the basis of the javascript language
here's what we're going to cover in this
video and the next couple of videos but
all encompassed within lesson six of the
series so we're going to learn how to
read documentation that's a really
important thing as a developer
we're going to do a quick start kind of
an overview of callback functions
they're a little bit confusing but we'll
get through them and then we'll talk
about primitive values versus
object values within javascript
talk about dates regular expressions
string methods array methods
um the math library error types and then
a couple data types that we have not
actually covered yet that would be not a
number n a n
and then also null and undefined values
so we've got a pretty pretty big laundry
list of things to cover uh in this
lesson it's gonna take a little bit of
time but i promise you when we get to
the end you're going to have a much
bigger overview of what the javascript
language is all about now the one thing
that i'll say as we go into this lesson
is this is probably going to be the last
one where we're just focusing solely on
javascript
we have to get through a lot of
different things so we have to cover
html and css and then a couple different
other things before we're actually
writing our web apps so this will be the
last kind of lesson that we're talking
about javascript alone now there are
other things in javascript that we will
not cover quite yet so that would be
like the async await and promises
and classes object-oriented programming
you know it all kind of goes together
and those are some more advanced
javascript topics that i'm going to pick
up later down the road when we've
actually written
some sort of substantial web app so hold
tight on that i'm not going to cover it
yet but we are going to get through the
basics here and then we'll start getting
into actually building that web app of
ours the first thing that i want to do
is actually go through how do we read
documentation and we can start at the
mozilla
web docs which is called mdn
for short and we've looked at this
previously
in the code challenges from the last
lesson lesson five but we didn't
actually go into depth on how to read
this documentation and i think it's
really important
to do so so you get to the home page of
the mdn web docs you go to technologies
and you'll find javascript
now javascript is documented in a
variety of places this just happens to
be
what most people consider the official
javascript documentation so once we're
on the javascript homepage you can see
on the left you've got this navigation
bar
there's some tutorials that you don't
need to go to because this is a tutorial
about javascript but then what we're
interested is the references so when we
talk about references that's generally
going to be a big part of any sort of
documentation that you're looking at
generally with documentation you're
going to have some sort of quick start
guide just to get you started with
whatever library or framework that
you're reading the documentation for
then you're going to have some sort of
tutorial usually
and then finally you're going to have an
api reference
sometimes they just call it a reference
like they do here sometimes they call it
the api sometimes they call it the api
reference
whatever the case it's all kind of
centered around okay here's the core of
of this library or language or framework
and this is where you need to go to
learn more about using it so that's what
we're interested
in for javascript and particularly
right now since this video is all about
the built-in objects and functions
we can go to this built-in objects drop
down in here you'll scroll down and
you'll see a variety of different
types of objects and
these objects have
things called instance methods
it kind of gets into object oriented
programming and i don't want to go there
but that's why i'm saying
objects and functions
now it's going to say objects here but
the functions are kind of
what we call a method on
top of these objects that that you can
call from the object so
um you can scroll down and see a bunch
of different ones
most of these are going to be irrelevant
to you as the complete beginner and
quite honestly they're going to be
irrelevant to you um even as you get
better so
the point of this video is to point out
the
most important ones the ones that you're
going to be
that you're going to need to get the
most familiar with
and we'll go through them in more detail
but i just wanted to give you an
overview of this
and then as you click through
a specific object so let's say we go to
string
which as you'll learn in a little bit a
little bit later in maybe the next video
or something a string is actually an
object in javascript like everything
else so it's a little bit confusing but
you'll get the point in a little bit
now once we're on the string
documentation page or reference it's
going to give you an overview of
everything and this is kind of the main
home page for this string object now in
javascript everything kind of behaves as
an object and it has these things called
methods on it which are the functions
i'm talking about when i say method you
can just think of it as a function
that is you know attached to that object
so as we scroll down here on the left
you're going to see this thing says dot
prototype dot whatever method we're
talking about now the prototype part
that's a complexity of the javascript
language that we have not covered and we
will not cover in this series
that's a little bit uh
above our pay grade and we don't need to
get into that to actually start writing
the code once again i've said this in
previous lessons if you want to
understand the prototype chain and all
of these complex things about javascript
um of course after you've kind of
mastered the basics you can go to the
you don't know javascript series
it's completely free so
you don't know javascript
and it's actually hosted on github
i think his name is kyle simpson
i would go to the first edition branch
here and then you can scroll down and
just see all of the different books that
he's written on javascript
it's a really good guide that's going to
take you through the nuances of this
language anyways coming back to here so
we have the object at the
beginning.prototype
and then the method so let's click on
one of these methods and see how we
actually read the spec or the reference
for each method
i think a good one
to start with
let's see which one do we want
so we want to start with the pop method
this is a really easy one to
get used to and this is not part of the
string spec so we need to go to arrays
actually so let's go to javascript and
then we'll go to built-in objects and
click array
now same thing you have all these
methods here and we're going to go down
here to the pop method
now when we get to the pop method
reference you're going to see a little
summary and then an example this is the
case for all of these different methods
usually you should be able to figure out
or get the gist of what this does and
how to use it from just the starting
section but it's really important to
start developing the skill of learning
how to read documentation and oftentimes
it can be a little bit confusing
especially since each
language and site and framework and
library it depends on how they've
written their documentation it might
look a little bit different
so anyways the pop method removes the
last element from an array and returns
that element
this method changes the length of the
array
all right so we know it is mutating or
changing
the existing array that we're working on
now if we come down to the syntax
section this is what i want to focus on
in this video because if you are a more
experienced developer you should be able
to
kind of figure out all of the nuances of
a specific method or function
from this syntax section
now when we look at the pop method
it just gives us this basic little
syntax
and you can see that there's nothing in
this parentheses
nothing that you pass in and then when
you come down to the return value it
says the return value is the removed
element from the array and then it says
undefined if the array is empty so it
tells you here's what the normal return
value is and then if you by chance pass
in an empty array which you probably
won't unless you're looping through it
or something
then it returns undefined so this is a
really basic one and just by looking at
this you can see how it works and we can
come over to our console
we can create some sort of array here
so we'll just put a couple numbers in
here
now if we print the array it's one two
three and then array.pop
it's going to return the length of the
array so 3 is the length of
the array but now
if we print the array we only have two
elements in it because it removed the
last one
now this is a really simple one but the
next one that we want to look at is
going to be the join method and that's
because it's going to add in a little
bit harder documentation for us to read
now before i do that though let me go
back to the pop method so we got this
overview section the syntax the
description just gives you some more
context around it and then you have some
examples now as we get to the
specifications this is going to actually
take you to the specific link within the
ecmascript
spec and we talked about that in i think
lesson two when we talked about what is
javascript
but this spec is going to we might as
well click it and just see where it
takes us
so it should take us to the pop method
you can see up here
and this is the spec for you know the
javascript language so just takes you
there it's not something that you'll be
probably clicking on all that often and
then finally you come down here to
browser compatibility
and you'll see all the different
browsers and then you'll also see a run
time over here so node.js is not a
browser but it's a runtime that runs
javascript so it shows you the
compatibility for this method within all
the different browsers in this case
the pop method is one of the oldest
array methods in javascript so it's
supported by all the browsers but as
you'll see
with some other methods that we look at
it's not supported in all the different
browsers and oftentimes it's internet
explorer that doesn't support it so
not a big deal
all right so anyways let's go back to
let's see not the pop method we wanted
the join method
which is going to be
somewhere here all right
so looking at the join method this is
going to be a little bit more complex
i'm going to kind of skip over this
first section just to get an overview it
says it creates and returns a new string
by concatenating or joining all of the
elements in an array all right so that's
the basics now coming down down to the
syntax where we're trying to focus on
you'll see that this
this code block here has a little bit
more complex
syntax going on so it says array.join
and then in here we have this uh word
called separator and we have these
little brackets around it
now what these brackets mean within the
javascript or the mdn documentation it
means that they are optional so the
separator this is just a description
like
that word is arbitrary so it says
separator just to give you an idea of
what type of parameter
it takes as i guess an argument so
remember we talked about parameters and
arguments two sides of the same coin
parameters are what we define when we
declare a function arguments are what we
pass in to that function when we
actually invoke it call it um you know
whatever you want to say there so
this in this case we have separator
and we can read more about this here so
the separator specifies a string to
separate each pair of adjacent elements
of the array
the separator is converted to a string
if necessary if omitted the array
elements are separated with a comma
if separator is an empty string all the
elements are joined without any
characters in between them so if you are
following along with the 25 practice
problems from the prior lesson we used
this method a couple of times and we
actually had to use that empty string to
join all the elements together with
nothing between them
so this is where we would have found
that now of course it's optional so if
you don't pass anything in there it says
if omitted the array elements are
separated by a column so it's optional
and then we come down to the return
value and it says a string with all
array elements joined if the array
length is zero an empty string is
returned so we can go ahead and test
that too so let's go into our console we
have an array here
let's let's actually create a new one so
let me clear the screen
and we'll say
string array
and then we'll say hello world all right
so what if we wanted to combine those
together now we'd use the join method so
we can say stringarray.join
now as we see it right here we omit all
of the arguments
it just joins it with this little comma
down here now if we go back and look at
what else we can do so
if the separator is an empty string it
joins it without anything between them
so let's put in an empty string here
and you can see that it
joins those together into one string
with nothing between them now we can add
a space here
and press enter and this is probably
closest to what we would want if we were
doing this
so that's just how you would read this
now the last one i'm going to look at
for reading documentation is a little
bit
trickier and we're going to have to kind
of use these concepts we just talked
about to get through it
the example that we're going to do is
the array.includes method
so let's click on that wherever it is
now this includes method determines
whether an array includes a certain
value among its entries returning true
or false as appropriate now we're going
to cover this a little bit later
in this lesson
so i'm not going to go too deep into it
but let's go ahead and look at the
documentation here
it says this is the code block that
we're looking at
and you'll notice that we have a value
to find and then we have the brackets
here
and the from index so breaking this down
from how we understand it there are no
brackets around the value to find which
tells us that there is that is a
required parameter you really can't run
this method effectively without that
required parameter
now it has this comma here which
basically means okay we're going to the
next parameter that this function will
take
and then it's surrounded by these
brackets at the beginning and end which
means that the second parameter is going
to be optional now if we look down into
the parameters description value to find
is the value that we're searching for
and it says it is case sensitive so
that's nice to know and then the
optional parameter is the from index and
it's basically saying
you can start looking within this array
at a certain index so you know if the
value to find is earlier than that index
you specify it's not going to include it
so that's just how we would read the
syntax of this and again we're going to
go through this a little bit later in
the lesson so i'm not going to do an
example right now
and just to point out what i was talking
about earlier if you scroll down so
includes is actually a little bit of a
new method i believe
i could be wrong on that but i thought
that it was offered only in the latest
spec of javascript
so if you scroll down to the browser
compatibility you'll see that internet
explorer has no support for this method
so if you're developing an application
for that has to run effectively in
internet explorer
probably the only case that's going to
happen is if you work for like a really
large company
and that company kind of has legacy
systems and applications that still run
an internet explorer you don't want to
be using this includes method because it
might screw up your application so
that's just what i was talking about
earlier
in the next part of this lesson
6 here we're going to be talking about
callback functions
when i first started i was really
confused about these and i honestly
think that it's just because i never
stumbled upon a good explanation
something that really broke it out into
the pieces that i could understand so
hopefully in this video
i can do that for you and prevent you
from suffering from that confusion for
several months like i did
now the reason we're talking about this
is because the built-in functions that
we'll see later in this lesson are going
to use callbacks or callback functions
heavily and if you don't understand them
you're not going to be able to use those
built-in methods
so with callback functions they're not
any different from the functions we were
writing in the previous lesson
use you know use the same syntax so you
can use the regular function syntax you
can use uh anonymous functions or arrow
functions it's all the same it's just a
different way of using functions and
it's just a little bit different way of
thinking in general
to start us off i'm going to paste in
some code that we're going to actually
understand by the end of this little
lesson
so this would be an example of using a
callback function go ahead and pause the
video just so that you can take a look
at it and get yourself acquainted so
i'll press enter here and you can also
simplify that code that we just looked
at
into this right here so it does the same
exact thing
you can see the answer is the same and i
would just pause the video and just look
at those two code blocks just for a few
seconds to just get your mindset
around what we're doing here now the
entire reason that i'm walking you
through callbacks here is because
oftentimes you're going to see
code that looks like the second option
here which is simplified yes and it's
how i would write it but it definitely
does not display the concepts that
you're supposed to be understanding very
well so in this section i'm going to be
writing code that i normally would not
write
just because it's a little bit longer
form and more broken out than i would
write it you know if i was developing an
application but hopefully you know that
longer form of the code is going to
clear up some of these concepts for you
and really help you understand what
callbacks are all about so let's take a
look at each of these code blocks
let me clear the screen and just get us
the
main code block and i have some comments
pasted in here
so let me clear the screen
and we'll paste this in here maybe space
it out a little bit so that we have
some room to work with
all right
and if we look at this code here
there's a couple things going on the
first thing is we have two different
functions here
the main function right here and then
the callback function so oftentimes
you'll see the callback function kind of
just
embedded within that main function
but in this case like i said i'm
breaking it out for clarity
so this main function it takes three
arguments the first argument is going to
be some number i just called it random
number it's arbitrary
um and then should call so this is going
to be a boolean value uh
value which is basically going to
ask whether we should go into the
callback and then
the callback itself so walking through
this code let's first look at result so
the result variable is going to be set
equal to the random number now what is
random number now of course random
number is a parameter to this function
and therefore whatever we pass in as the
argument
to the function is going to be the value
of random number so if we go to the
bottom where we actually invoke or call
this main function
you'll see that the random number is
going to be 20 right here so in this
case random number equals 20 and
therefore the result variable also
equals 20
because we're assigning it now if we
come down to this next part there's some
comments here that's not affecting the
code at all we just have a simple if
statement so we say if should call so if
you remember we can pass a boolean value
alone we don't have to put any equal
signs or anything
and we can place that within a
conditional
to evaluate it so if should call is true
then we're going to reach the code
within this uh this conditional block if
it's false then we just skip this
conditional block and we return the
result so basically if should call is
false then we're going to skip this and
the result is currently equal to 20 and
then we return the result so the return
of this main function is going to equal
20. but of course it returns 40 as we
see down here so therefore
the should call is true as we see here
in the invocation of the function now
the last part is the tricky part that's
the callback now the first thing i want
to point out here is that callback this
name that i've given it is entirely
arbitrary you'll see this very often you
might see
either this as callback or you might see
the letters c and b for callback and
that's probably a convention that you're
going to come across but it doesn't have
to be that way you can call that
whatever you want
it's just a normal
parameter but in this case instead of
passing in a number or a boolean like we
did for the first two
parameters we're actually passing in
another function
so
basically what we're doing is we're
passing in a function to another
function and we're asking that you know
parent function to execute
the function that we passed in
in this case my callback is what we've
passed in you can see in the arguments
down here at the bottom
so we've passed in my callback which has
just been declared hasn't been executed
yet and so callback right here is going
to equal
the declaration
of this function called mycallback so if
you know how to
run this if we wanted to run mycallback
all we have to do
is put these parentheses at the end and
pass in some sort of number and you can
see if we execute this we get 40 which
is the same answer of course that would
be the more direct way to do this but
this is a contrived example that's
hopefully going to explain callbacks to
you
all right so we've got this value called
callback and that is equal to a function
uh a function data type that has not
been invoked yet so just a declaration
and
we can basically call this just like
this but in this case the callback is
actually the function that we want to
call so we're doing that sorry about
that we're doing that in this line right
here so if should call that is true so
we get down to this code right here and
what we're doing is we're taking that
function that's been passed in and we
are executing it with the random number
parameter which happens to equal 20. so
we're basically doing what we did down
here but within the main function we're
letting our code actually execute the
function so we're setting that equal to
result which returns 40 and then we're
going to return result at the bottom so
that's going to return 40 and that's how
we've gotten to our answer now like i
showed you um with that second example a
little bit ago
it's a little bit more abbreviated way
to do this and you do not have to write
a separate function called mycallback in
order to you know basically run a
callback function so what we could have
done in the first case this is how we
executed main function
we passed in 20 we passed in true and
then we passed in a predefined function
that we had already written up here but
we could abbreviate this so let me
collapse this main part and what we can
do is say main function and we know that
we have to pass in a random number so in
this case we'll stay consistent we'll
pass in a value of 20. we want the
callback to actually be called within
the function so we need to pass in true
as the should call argument and then we
need to pass in the function so in the
first case we just put in my callback
and it worked but we also could do it
like this so we could write a
anonymous function
and this function is going to take a
number so that's just the parameter that
we're defining and we know that if we go
up to the main function here it's going
to pass in this random number as the
argument so that's what number or num is
going to represent
and then we have to break it down here
and then we have to return the num times
2 which is going to ultimately return us
40 and that's another way that we could
write that callback there's other
simpler ways so we can also do it like
this so let's do main
function
pass in 20 true and then in this case
let's just put in an arrow function so
we have num
and then we use our arrow function
syntax and then we return the num
times 2 and once again we get 40. so
just another way to pass that in and we
can even simplify this a little bit more
so we can pass in the same parameters we
don't actually need these parentheses
here because it's a single argument
so we'll take num and then
we also don't need to break down onto
the second line we can actually just
take num times two and that's going to
return it the same way and now we've
gotten our answer of 40 once again so as
you can see that's how we get from the
most you know contrived simple elaborate
example to the code that you're probably
going to be seeing in a lot of examples
this is what a lot of people use because
it's just a much simpler quicker way to
write a callback function so hopefully
this section
i know it's a little bit confusing but
re-watch it again if you are not totally
clear on this because we're going to be
going into the built-in functions that
use these callbacks very heavily and
it's going to be important that you
understand how they're working so you
might understand callbacks now but why
do we actually need them they seem
overly complicated don't they
well the reason we need them is in my
opinion um this is just based from on
experience and just observation the two
things that it enables is reusability
and asynchronous programming now i'll
talk about each of these we're not going
to go too much into asynchronous
programming in this video for reasons
i'm about to explain but let's start
with the reusability thing and that is
going to be crucial to really connecting
the dots when we get into some of those
more advanced array built-in methods
that we're talking about later in the
lesson to really understand the
reusability thing we're going to look at
a common array method that's called map
so we're going to look at this a little
bit later in the video too but i really
want to show this as a lesson of why we
need callback functions
so what this map method does if we look
at the documentation is it creates a new
array populated with the results of
calling a provided function on every
element in the calling array so it's
basically doing a transformation and
you're
able to define the function that has all
that logic to figure out what it's doing
to each element in the array let's take
a look at a very simple example
now this isn't going to make total sense
but it will kind of connect the dots
from what we just did with that original
callback example
so what i'm doing is constructing an
array very simple one at that and then
i'm going to define my custom
map
operation and we'll just say callback so
we want to be very specific with what
this function represents to us
and then the parameter is going to be
the item
from the array that we're mapping over
and what we're actually doing here is
we're kind of iterating over the array
so when we get each element of the array
which is going to be passed in as an
argument
into this function
we want to return
a value and that value is going to be
the transformed value that will kind of
occupy the new array that we have
so we're going to take the item from
array and we're going to multiply it by
2. so we're basically going to take this
entire array up here and
for each element we're going to multiply
it by two
so we've got that function defined so
far it's not really doing anything but
if we take my array
and then we actually we need to set this
equal to a new array
because that the map method is going to
actually return the modified array it's
not going to
modify the original array
so we're going to take myarray.map
so we're just calling the function
that's built into
our array
and what it requires is going to be a
callback function and in this case we've
already defined that so we're going to
pass in my custom map operation
callback
and then we're going to execute it
now if we look at the new array
you're going to see that every element
has been doubled and what it's done is
it's looped through it's started at two
then it's taken that value of two
multiplied it by two to get four so on
and so forth so you can see how
we've kind of iterated over the array
and applied some sort of transformation
defined by our callback function
now here is where we really understand
this concept of reusability
so in this case
sure it works we're multiplying
something by two but it doesn't really
convey to us why this callback is so
useful
now when the creators of the javascript
programming language introduced this map
array what they wanted was to enable the
developer to use this same method for a
variety of use cases so what if we had
an array that was full of strings so let
me copy in a new array here
i need to name it something different so
we'll just say string array
and this is going to have a bunch of
strings in it and you might say okay
well i need to find a different built-in
method to
map over this and do some sort of
transformation well because we have a
callback as one of the parameters of
this predefined function
we have a lot of flexibility and instead
of looking for a new method we can just
redefine our custom map operation now in
this case i'm not going to do it long
hand like we've been doing i'm going to
show you the shortcut so we'll say not
my array but the string array which we
just defined
we're going to call the map method on it
and then we're going to pass in a
callback function so let me template
that out
i'm going to have an arrow function
right here
and what i'm going to pass in is going
to be the item from the array so we'll
just say item from array we don't need
any parentheses around that because it's
a single argument
and now the transformation that we're
trying to do so if we do this on one
line whatever is right of this arrow is
going to be returned from that function
so all we have to do is transform it in
some different way so maybe we wanted to
construct just the first letter of each
of these words so maybe we wanted a new
array that has the letter h w m n i and
z
all we have to do is maybe return
the item from the array and actually
what i'm going to do here is pass in
no i don't need to i'm just going to
take item from array and then i'm going
to get it give it the zero index because
you can access the first letter of any
string by using the zero index second
letter by one third by two so on and so
forth so you can see that we've returned
the first letter of each of these
elements in the array and we did this
for an array of strings by just
redefining that callback function so
that's the value of these callback
functions it enables us to
reuse the same function over and over
again so in this case the built-in map
function and kind of modify it for
whatever needs that we have and we can
do something way more complex than just
multiplying by two we can have
conditional logic in here we can say you
know if the number is prime then we want
to multiply it by 2.
if it's not prime then we just want to
return the number itself you know you
can do all sorts of different things
with this as complex as you want it
all right so i think you probably
understand why we
why callbacks enable reusability why
they're important you know how they work
all that kind of stuff now let's move on
to the asynchronous topic so i told you
that
callbacks enable asynchronous
programming and what that gets us into
is a whole other topic that i'm only
going to briefly touch on here
so when i say asynchronous all i'm
talking about is code that does not run
um
immediately so with the code that we've
run here on this screen
you'll probably notice that when we
press enter it executes immediately it's
it pretty much seems instantaneous to
our human brain
now there are times when we're writing
code that it might even take up to two
three or four seconds for a piece of
code to execute and a good example of
that is let's say
our application database that stores all
of our data is you know on a in a
different continent from where the user
is actually
uh clicking so maybe i host my database
here in the united states but someone
from
i don't know italy or something is
visiting my web app
and has to access
uh the web app from their browser in
italy and so it's going to send off a
request to my server
and then to the database and that
request to get all of the
information for that web app and perform
different functions is going to take a
certain amount of time and it's not
instantaneous so we have to handle that
with our programming and you might just
say well okay let's just wait until it's
done and then execute the next line of
code well in that case with a web app
you're going to have multiple
asynchronous operations going at the
same time so you're going to have
multiple calls to a web server that are
going to take you know half a second
one and a half seconds maybe even a
little bit more and if you added all of
those together and you just did it in
order your web app is going to take 30
seconds to load and in that case
nobody's going to use it so we have to
run all this code kind of at the same
time and for that reason we have
asynchronous programming which basically
allows us to
run some code and then run other code
while that previous code is still
running
now i know this kind of gets in the
topic of like threads
execution threads on a computer it's not
really what we're talking about here and
i really don't want to get into all of
the details of this but as we go through
this series we're going to be talking
about
asynchronous callbacks promises and the
newer
es6 async in a weight
so these are all different ways that we
can write asynchronous javascript code
you'll see how it comes into play a
little bit later in the series
if you've been following along with this
series you might have heard me say that
everything in javascript is an object
but i haven't really explained myself on
that one and since we're talking about
all the built-in objects within
javascript in this lesson i really want
to give an overview of this concept of
primitives versus the actual objects
themselves i'm going to put some code on
the screen that will hopefully give you
a little bit of an introduction and some
things to think about here
so when we run this code
you can see that we've defined two
different strings and we have compared
these strings with each other
so in the first case we've got this
weird syntax here where we're actually
using this thing called a new
it's actually the new operator we're
going to talk about in a second
and then we are defining our string with
this uppercase string which looks like
some sort of object or something and if
you go to the javascript docs so or
documentation so let's go to javascript
built-in objects and then you go down to
string right here that is the same
syntax the string that we use to define
this
string right here so string one is
actually an object now string2
is what we call a primitive now this is
because we didn't you know
instantiate it with
the object syntax and you can see if we
compare the equality of these two the
triple equals which compares both value
and type is going to return false
because in the first case we're looking
at an object in the second case we're
looking at a string primitive
and if we use the double equals they're
of course true because they are the same
value they're just not the same type so
at this point you probably probably have
a lot of confusion in your head
you're probably thinking a couple things
well you're telling me that string one
is not actually a string
and the answer is yes it's it is not a
string it is actually an object and then
furthermore you're saying that this
string down here so string two
that is a string
but how would we execute any of these
built-in methods on something that's not
an object so there's a couple floating
questions here and to understand them
you have to know a little bit of the
behind the scenes stuff that's going on
with the javascript programming language
let's start off by asking the question
what is a primitive now a primitive this
is not a topic that is specific to
javascript we talk about primitive data
types across varying languages so you
know python java c plus plus they all
have their
primitives but in javascript a primitive
there are six different primitives that
we can look at and we can go to the
documentation here
for primitive and it will maybe show us
all of the different
um primitives that we have so
maybe it doesn't actually
i thought that it did but anyways the
six that we have are a string a number a
big int boolean undefined and symbol
some of these we haven't talked about
but that's totally fine we don't need to
talk about it yet
but what you can think about uh when
we're talking about primitives is that
it is the simplest form of something
so if a coding language had a periodic
table of elements then the primitives
would be those elements of the periodic
table so that's kind of how i would
think about it and those primitives can
actually be used to build up other
things
now as you would expect a primitive data
type does not have any sort of methods
or functions that you can call
on them
so it doesn't make any sense if we were
to come here in the console and let's
define
a string here so we've got some string
and now i'm going to put a dot at the
end of it just like i was calling a
function or a method on an object
and if i were to take this some string
and say to uppercase
so that is actually a built-in function
on strings so if you go down to
um the bottom here
you can see that two uppercase is a
built-in
method on the string object but if we're
saying that this is a string primitive
then it shouldn't be able to work right
well wrong it does work and that is
because behind the scenes when we have a
primitive value like this where we
define it with those little quotes or
the double quotes even it actually wraps
it in that string object so what we did
up here
right here this is actually happening
behind the scenes when you call
a specific built-in method on a
primitive
data type within javascript
now this is kind of interesting and all
but what do you actually do with it well
the answer to that is not really
anything this is more of something that
you should be aware of it's just good to
know type of information so that you're
not wondering in your head well what is
going on here you know we're talking
about strings but if we go to the
documentation it sure looks like this is
some sort of object here so it just
clears that up for us and if you go to
the string built-in object and scroll
down
a little bit we have this section called
string primitives and string objects
which kind of explains the same thing
that i just talked about so feel free to
read that and really dig in if you want
to understand this a little bit better
so the takeaway here is that you should
not be using this syntax up here with
the string constructor
this is not the way that you write
strings i taught you the correct way to
write strings in the previous videos
this is just for clarification now if
you go to the actual documentation
you'll see in this section on string
primitives and objects
down here it says for these reasons the
code may break when it encounters string
objects when it expects a primitive
instead so the documentation even
recommends to not define them like this
because javascript takes care of it for
you
but anyways that's just some information
around here now the next thing that i
want to talk about is that keyword that
we looked at because this is also a
little bit confusing and as we go into
the next couple sections of this lesson
it's going to be important to understand
and that is this new keyword which is
actually considered an operator although
we didn't talk about it when we
covered operators in a previous lesson
in the next section of this lesson we're
going to be talking about javascript
dates which you actually have to use
that new operator for to actually create
so if we wanted to create a date here
what we have to say is new and then we
pass in the date object with these
parentheses at the end and this is what
we call constructing
a instance of that date object so you
can kind of think of this
in terms of
like you have this template that you're
working with
so
the date object would be the template
and then you're going to actually take a
copy of that template and store it in a
new variable
that has all of those attributes of the
template it does everything that that
template has kind of predefined it to do
now this is kind of an object oriented
programming
discussion i don't want to get too far
into it but just know that this new
operator is a special keyword in
javascript and that's what it's doing
so if you actually look into
the new keyword it's going to do a
couple things so it creates a blank
object and then it links that blank
object to the parent so when i talk
about template and an instance of that
template that's what i'm kind of
referring to
so there are additional steps that get
into the prototype chain again i'm not
going to talk about
that because it's another complexity
that we don't need to visit right now
in the previous parts of this lesson
we've talked about a lot of the
essential concepts that we're going to
be using
when we're talking about these built-in
javascript objects and the first one
we're going to be talking about is
javascript dates
now these javascript dates are a little
bit confusing and i'll be honest i think
a lot of developers even more
experienced ones have a little bit of
trouble with certain types of dates in
javascript and the reason is because
writing javascript dates is not really
all about coding skill you also have to
understand how time zones work
and all of that stuff when you're
actually getting into
implementing the date objects and stuff
like that now i've written a post on
this so
i'm on my site here so i'll just scroll
down
at some point here i talked about
javascript dates so right here and
with this date post i really go into
detail about all of the different
time zones and how we use dates and all
the different nuances of it so i'd check
that out if this is not enough detail
for you but here we're going to actually
go into the basics of writing dates and
how we do that i showed it briefly in
the last part of this lesson
but all we have to do
is define a variable and then assign a
new date object or kind of a copy of
that template which is date
and we're going to assign it
and now if we print out to the screen
it's going to show us a
date object here and it's going to be
the current time because we passed in no
parameters or no arguments to that
date constructor now here's where dates
get a little bit confusing
what we have defined here
the value that is stored within this
date object actually represents the
number of milliseconds that have elapsed
since midnight on january 1st 1970
utc time zone that's a lot to handle in
one sentence here
and you might be asking why january 1st
1970 well the answer is not so simple
and again i would read this post that i
wrote to really get a background on that
but basically it's an arbitrary date and
time that we are basing all of our
future dates off of and what i mean when
i say the
value that we're storing within this
date is equal to the number of
milliseconds because right here it sure
doesn't look like milliseconds that
we're printing
but if you said now which represents the
date that we just defined
and then you say value of
it's going to print the number of
milliseconds since january 1st 1970 and
that is the in the
coordinated universal time zone so if
you converted this to years and then
days you would get exactly to this with
dates there are a variety of things that
you can pass into that constructor as an
argument to define a date and what i'm
going to do is just paste a bunch of
code onto the screen because we don't
need to go through writing all of it you
can pause the video look through this
for a second i'm going to walk through
it but again read that post if you want
a ton of information about dates so the
first example we're passing in
the the year the month the day and then
the time or i guess hour minute second
millisecond whatever
and we're passing that in as comma
separated
arguments to the date constructor
we can also pass in just a string in a
variety of different formats as you can
see in this code
right here
and then going down we can
input a number of milliseconds so we can
just give it the the value itself or we
can pass it in as iso 8601 format
again that post talks all about it and
then finally you can do time zones down
here you can pass in time zones
this last part the date.now
that's kind of an interesting thing that
we can talk about here so
you know we're used to creating a date
by saying new date but you can also
create a date with a static method
that's what this is called here and you
just say date.now represents the same
thing as new date obviously not anymore
because time has elapsed but it's just
giving you the primitive value of that
date now we're here in this video to
talk about some of the instance methods
that we can use on a date object the
built-in method so let's define a date
so that'll be equal to now or maybe
maybe instead we'll just say
my date because now is sometimes not
descriptive because the second you press
enter it's not now any longer so that's
a little bit confusing so let's create a
date here
and that's going to represent pretty
much
you know right now
minus a few seconds and from this date
we can use a couple different methods so
one of them will be the tostring method
and that's going to print what we've
used here in the console but of course
this is a rebel so it kind of read
evaluate print loop all that kind of
good stuff so we can use this tostring
method to print out the
string of the date and this is actually
going to print the value of that date
which is stored in the unit the
coordinated universal time or utc and
it's going to convert it to our local
time zone which is the time zone that
our computer has stored on it so that's
actually stored in some file on our
computer i'm not going to go into that
but
anyways
here we go for the next method so we
have my date and then we can use the to
iso string
so
the iso string is a specific format and
let's scroll down in my post here
because we've got it up anyways and i
think i have a little screenshot of the
utc time or not utc but iso 8601
and let's expand this just a little bit
and you can see this is going to be the
format that we're using for the iso 8601
standard pause the video look at this if
you're uh curious
all right so let's bring this back
and well not clear the screen and then
my date
get date is going to give us the actual
day of the month so today is the 16th of
january so we get 16.
we can also use my date dot
get month which is a little bit unique
because this is going to return the 0
or it's going to return the month of the
year but it's going to use 0 indexing so
instead of january being equal to one
january is equal to zero which is what
we're seeing here since this is being
filmed in uh january
so we'll go to my date dot get full year
and that's gonna return 2021. um so
those are some of the the basic methods
that you can use on a javascript date
and honestly these are probably the most
common ones you won't be looking
at anything else for the most part but
you can go to the docs javascript
documentation so again javascript
built-in objects then you can go down to
date
and then you can see all of the
different methods that we're using here
something to point out
you'll see this a couple times within
the documentation
if you look at the
date.getyear method it has this little
thumbs down icon which basically means
that it's deprecated and a deprecated
method is something that is no longer
going to be supported so you don't want
to use those now if you click on the get
year method you'll notice that in our
example we got we use the get full year
method and the reason is because it says
the get year method returns the year the
specified date blah blah blah
and it says it is no longer used and has
been replaced by the get full year
method so that's how i knew to go to
that git full year method as a
replacement
so in the previous section we talked
about javascript dates and now we're
talking about the built-in object called
regular expression and this is not just
a built-in javascript object this is an
an entire topic
like i almost think of this as um
another language that you're kind of
trying to learn in programming it's
obviously not turing complete or
anything but regular expressions are
basically a way to pattern match within
strings
and you might be asking well why would
we want to do that
and to show you why let me just open up
a web application we'll just go to
you need a budget
and this is a budgeting app that i use
and really like
but if you go to the login page
log in right here
and you type in your email address but
you type it in incorrectly it's going to
say please enter a valid email address
and you might be asking well
how does it know what is an invalid
email address
it you know you may go through a bunch
of different
you know types of emails like a big long
list of emails that's probably not going
to be efficient of course but what we
can do is we can use regular expressions
to pattern match and basically say okay
i expect to see
these certain characters and then an at
symbol because every email address has
an at symbol and then some sort of valid
domain or whatever for that email
address so we can pattern match and
that's why regular expressions are so
powerful you can validate emails and you
can also do a whole host of other things
it's great for validation but it's not
only for validation now as we're going
through this just keep this in mind
this is a very loaded topic as i said
and you don't need to fully understand
how to write these regular expressions
it's really not a high priority thing
for you right now if you're trying to
learn how to code because you can get
away without regular expressions
while writing web apps they're just very
nice to have they can really speed up
your workflow uh down the road and you
need to be at least exposed to them so
all i ask here in this video is you
understand what they are what they do
and just how to read them in general
just kind of understanding the symbols
and be able to piece together what a
regular expression is doing i wouldn't
worry about
learning and mastering how to write them
so if we go to the javascript
documentation
let's see here we'll go to technologies
javascript as we've been doing i'm just
kind of reiterating this then you go to
built-in objects and then we can go down
to
the regular expression object which is
going to
be reg exp
and it says it's an object used for
matching text with a pattern so as i
said pattern matching now let's go ahead
and write a basic regular expression
i'll show you how to do this here so
we'll say email validator regular
expression and this will be
kind of similar to what we just looked
at where it's validating whether the
email address
is correct now this implementation that
i'm about to write is by no means
exhaustive and it's definitely going to
miss a couple cases and i guarantee you
you know ynab or you need a budget is
using a much more complex expression
than the one that i'm about to show you
here
so
anyways let's go through this and
just get an idea of what we're dealing
with so let's say that our user input
this is what we type into the form so
you know i go here i type into the form
i type something that's what this user
input variable is going to represent
and i might put in something like
invalid email at g
and obviously this is not a valid email
so we should reject this by using this
regular expression so we'll say a new
variable we'll say it's is valid and
then what we have to do is we take our
email validator regular expression from
up here
and we can use one of the built-in
methods on it so if you come down to the
left
you can see all the different built-in
methods and one of these
if we go down to
methods are we even on the right one
here okay we're on regular expression
okay i was just missing it completely so
here are the methods
these are pretty
confusing to look at but the two that
we're looking at here is going to be
exec and test
so we can use test to just see if
something is valid so we're going to go
ahead and do that we're going to use the
test and then we're going to pass in our
user input so we're saying take this
regular expression or this pattern that
we've defined
and map it up against this string that
we have defined and if you press enter
it's going to
and then show what the value is it's
going to be false because this is an
invalid email and that expression up
there that regular expression did not
match it now if we look at this regular
expression there's all these characters
which probably look like complete
gibberish to you but i'll quickly walk
you through what this is doing and then
we'll go back to the basics and really
understand it
so this first character just says i want
to start at the beginning of the line
this period represents all characters
and then this plus sign that comes
directly after after the period says i
want to match any character one or more
times then we have the at symbol which
is just looking for the at symbol and
then we have this period again so we
want um
any character
one or more times and then we use this
slash to basically escape and actually
look for a period so if you have
gmail.com
we need that period and in order for
this special character to be escaped we
have to use this uh backslash or right
here
and then we use another period for any
characters one or more times and finally
the end of the line with the dollar sign
so i know that's super confusing i would
never expect you to follow along with
what i just said but just to give you a
taste of what we're dealing with here
all right so let's go kind of to the
very basics here with
regular expressions i like to think of
it in two pieces
so you have the identifiers and then you
have the quantifiers
and the identifiers can be one of a ton
of different things it can be special
characters or just the characters or
phrases that you're trying to match
these identifiers are what you're
actually trying to pattern match within
the string so if we created a regular
expression we'll say new
regular expression and then we're going
to pass in the letter g
and now i'm going to pass in a couple of
strings here so
we'll say string 1 and string 2
and you'll see that if we're trying to
match the letter g
it only occurs in the second string
right here so if we were to say the
regular expression dot test and then
pass in string one we're going to get
false but if we test it against string
two it's going to give us a value of
true because it did in fact match the g
in the middle of the string but in this
case our regular expression is just
taking a single character and looking
for it which is probably not what you're
going to be doing you're probably going
to get a little bit more complex than
that so maybe you test for an entire
word so let's type another one so we'll
say regex or
regex2 some people would say regex some
regex regular expressions whatever
but anyways we're going to say
this one is going to be equal to
an entire word so in both strings we
have the word favorite so now if we test
the second
regular expression
up against both of the strings it's
going to return true so no matter which
string we put in there it's going to
return true there
as you can see so we can also match a
full word
in addition to just a single character
but the interesting thing about regular
expressions um or i guess maybe not
interesting but important thing is that
it's case sensitive so if i were to make
another regular expression let me go
ahead and just clear the screen for a
second so we get some more room
and let's say our regular expression is
going to be equal to
um
favorite with capital letters at the
beginning and the end and we of course
need to bring in our strings again
because we refresh the page
but this count this time if we map up
the regular expression and test it
against string one we're going to get
false because there are no capital
there's no word in there called favorite
that has a capital f and a capital e
so you'll see string two also returns
false so this is case sensitive you have
to pay attention to the uppercase and
lowercase letters now you don't have to
just use single letters or single words
or phrases you can use special
characters and that's really where the
power
of a regular expression comes in so
there are a
multitude of special characters that we
can use but i'm gonna put on the screen
a couple of the really popular or common
ones
so the first one is going to be
anything that we put in two brackets
and another thing that i want to share
here is that you don't have to write a
regular expression like we did up here
this is one way to do it just like we
saw with the strings you can
modify or create a string in two
different ways
now the more common way that we're going
to be creating a regular expression is
you put two forward slashes and then you
put in your regular expression here so
in this case i could put in g
and that's going to be our regular
expression that we wrote first we could
also put in favorite and that's going to
be a regular expression and as we saw
you can actually execute methods on
you know a literal
like this so we can test
string one against this but if we go
back and lower case these letters
now it's going to return true so this
will be good for me to
show this syntax so we can quickly loop
through a bunch of different patterns
here
so we're just going to change the
regular expression here and we're
comparing it against string one
the first thing you can do in a regular
expression is a character group and all
you do is have these two brackets and
then whatever you define in that
character group is going to apply to the
regular expression
so what we could say is a to z
uppercase
and what that is doing is matching all
uppercase letters now in our string
string 1 there are no uppercase letters
so we return false because it doesn't
match but we can also pass in
uh a to z where we have all lowercase
letters which obviously does uh does
match at least one of these letters
moving on we can also have
0 through 9
which is going to match all numbers
within a string now there's no numbers
here so it's not going to match returns
false
and then you can combine these together
so you can match all uppercase letters
all lowercase letters
all numbers and then you could even
match spaces in here so if we added a
space here we could match uh spaces and
this is going to return true because
we're matching the spaces the lowercase
letters so on and so forth
so that's what we're using with these
brackets
you have a lot of different options
within those brackets now we talked
about earlier that this period when used
in the context of a regular expression
represents any character
whatsoever now this is going to return
true
because it represents any character
now the next one we'll look at is
backslash d and this is going to match
all numbers this is equivalent
to saying brackets 0 through 9. so it's
completely equivalent just a different
way to write it in this case there's no
numbers so it returns false we also have
backslash s which will match any white
space characters there's spaces between
the words in these strings so it does
match
then we also have
backslash w which matches all letters
and numbers so alphanumeric so these are
just some shortcuts that you can use as
i said when i was interpreting that
email validator this little carrot
represents the beginning of a string so
if we put in the caret and then we put
in an f it's going to return false
because the first
letter of the string word testing it
again so string 1 is actually m
now if we put in m it's going to return
true
but we could put in the f returns false
because we're starting at the beginning
of the line but if we take that out it
then returns true because we're no
longer constrained to the beginning of
the line now what we could do also is
the end of the line which is a dollar
sign
so
f is not the last letter of this string
it's actually
k so that's how we would make that
return true
and then finally we have these uh little
groups that we can make so if you put
parentheses here and then you can say um
you could say code
or
uh stake or something like that and
that's going to match either code the
word code or the word stake and in this
case we're looking at string one
stake is in there so it's going to match
so those are just some of the different
ways that we can write the identifiers
and you can see how flexible this is and
how creative you can get to match
different um patterns within a string or
like a line of text
now the next thing in the the second
piece of this equation is going to be
quantifiers
now so far we have been
using this test method to basically show
whether or not we have matched a certain
character in the string
but if we
let's rewrite this here so
let's say that we want to match
um all lowercase letters which returns
true that's all that's telling us is
that in string one
we have at least one lowercase character
now if we come over here and change this
test method to exec
it's going to do a little bit different
operation and you can read about this
here in exec
it shows you kind of what it returns the
different values of this array that it
returns but basically what this is
telling us here is that all that it
matched when we wrote this regular
expression is the letter m because it
started at the beginning of the string
it matched that one lowercase character
and it said okay that's all i need to
match
now if we want to match more than just
one character we want to match a section
of a string then we have to actually
tell it that and the way we do that is
through quantifiers so there are a
couple different quantifiers and i'll
try to roll through
all of them and explain all of them just
really quickly as this again is just an
overview
so the first one
is a star
and the way that this works is you put
your
identifier
at the beginning and then you follow
that by a star
or another quantifier that you're trying
to use and so what this is saying is
that i expect or i'm trying to match uh
any lowercase letter
and the star is saying i want to match
any lowercase
letter 0 or more times
so in this case it's you know since
we're matching 0 or more of the
preceding character it's pretty much
going to return something every time now
we can change this to a plus sign
which is going to
match one or more of the preceding
character
and then we can put a question mark to
represent either zero or one
quantity of that previous character and
in this case you see that the
matched value is going to be only the
first letter because we're looking for 0
or 1.
now we can be explicit about this so we
can say
we want to match a certain amount of
characters but before we do that i want
to add a little space
within this
identifier because right now we're only
matching
this first word here so if we add a
space in here now it's going to start
matching the entire uh sentence or
string
so if we put in the plus sign you can
see my favorite food is steak so it
matches the entire string because
they're all lowercase letters
now if we wanted to be specific we
wanted to match a certain amount all
we'd have to do is these little brackets
as a quantifier and then we can pass in
a specific number so let's say that we
wanted to match say five characters
well it's going to get the first five
characters so m y space that counts f a
and that's going to match the first five
characters now we can also do a range so
we can say
we want to match between two and six of
the preceding character
that we're looking at so it's just going
to match 6 because that's the upper
bound
but you can match like a range of
characters so these are all the
different quantifiers
and you can use these to take the
pattern that you're matching and tell it
how much of that pattern you want to
match
now before we go into kind of a final
example to just tile the concepts
together i want to show you one other
thing
and that is going to be in the
documentation there is this thing called
a flag
so if you define a regular expression so
we'll say our reg x is going to be equal
to you know a new regular expression but
we could also write it with these two
slashes you can also pass in a flag and
that goes at the end of these two
slashes
and here are all the possible flags
in this case we might want to do a
global search so it will search for the
pattern
even if it occurs multiple times and if
you wanted to use that all you would
have to do is write your regular
expression here so we might say we want
to match
all lowercase letters
one or more times and then at the end we
put a g which represents that flag
so that's just a
a slight nuance to this and you'll see
this so just be able to recognize it
anyways let's move into a basic example
where we can just apply those concepts
of the identifiers and then the
quantifiers and then we'll wrap it up
for this uh section on regular
expressions
so we're going to write
first a string so here's the string that
we're going to uh want to match so we'll
say
hello world
um
and then let's put in
a couple
numbers
and then
let's put in a couple spaces here
and we'll put in i don't know
we'll put an at symbol in here as well
and then
more of a string at the end and our goal
is to basically write a regular
expression that is going to match this
entire string
so we can do it in a multitude of ways
but i'll just
go with the most obvious ways that i can
think of so we'll write our regular
expression
and we're going to use this syntax here
so the first thing that we'll notice is
that we have some lowercase letters
to start
so
we can use the
brackets here so this is again not the
most simple way to do this but this will
hit home all these concepts for you so
we'll say that we want to match
lowercase letters and spaces so let's
add in that space right there and we
want to match that
one or more times
and then um actually i'm going to
um do this in real time so that we can
see what's happening so instead of
putting it in a variable we'll do it how
we did it before so we're going to look
at
all lowercase letters and then add a
space
and then i'm going to
execute that against the string so we
can kind of begin to see what we're
matching here
so we're looking for
all lowercase letters one or more times
so we got the hello world then we're
looking for a comma we can just put the
comma in as it is
then we're looking for some spaces and
numbers so why don't we pass in 0 to 9
and then another space and we want to
match that one or more times
and then we want to match the at symbol
and then we want to match uh lowercase
letters so
again a to z
and then we need a space in there
and then we say one or more times and
then for good measure this is not
necessary but we can just put this
little
upwards carrot to indicate the beginning
of the string and a dollar sign to
indicate the end of the string
you can see here that we have matched
this entire string now of course we can
do this a lot simpler all we need to do
is put a period in there and a plus sign
which matches any character
one or more times and there we match the
whole string but hopefully this was just
a brief overview of a very basic
explanation of regular expressions
it's a built-in object within javascript
like we talked about that you're going
to stumble upon
and eventually it may come in handy for
you but most importantly just have an
understanding of what they are what they
do and how to read them
so we've covered a lot in this lesson
but we're finally making it to the
string built-in object in javascript
so again let's come to the beginning so
technologies javascript
built-in objects and then you go down to
string
right here so we kind of talked about
the string object versus primitives got
an overview of this but what we didn't
do
is talk about some of the methods that
we can use on this string
and what i want to do as i've been doing
in this lesson
all along is basically give you the most
important methods the ones that i've
used a lot myself that other developers
use commonly and just give you a brief
overview of them so that they're kind of
in your memory bank and you have them
for recall
later when you have to use them in your
code or maybe some code challenges or
interviews or whatever so
we're looking at strings and you can see
there are a lot of different string
methods that we can
use
and again this little downwards thumb
means that it's a deprecated method so
don't go trying to use
any of those
but again there's a lot of them here and
i want to point out some of the most
important ones so what we're going to be
looking at
let's go ahead and refresh this
oh i don't know what i've done here
okay there we go
we'll clear the screen
and what we're going to be looking at is
the replace all method we're going to
look at the two uppercase method
the substring method the trim method and
the match method so that's what we're
going to be covering here and again just
basic examples of each as we go through
these i'm going to show you the
documentation first because i really
want you to get used to
reading it and understanding how it's
working so let's go to the replace all
method
it says
this method returns a new string with
with all matches of a pattern replaced
by replacement
the pattern can be a string or a regular
expression so we just learned about that
and the replacement can be a string or a
function to be called
for each match now we're not going to
get into that function piece that's a
little bit complicated but if we look at
the syntax here you'll see some new
symbols here so this little pipe
means that there are multiple types of
parameters that you can pass in
or not multiple types of parameters
because obviously there are multiple
parameters but
for this single parameter there's
multiple types of data that you can pass
in
so in this case it's saying either a
regular expression
or just a string to match and then the
second parameter so we have the comma
here to say okay we're on a new
parameter
a new sub string so just a regular
string or a function that will return
basically whatever we want to replace it
with
so come down here to the parameters you
can read a little bit more about that
but we don't need to because i'm going
to show you how to use it
so let's go ahead and define a string
really quickly so
we'll say my dog jumped on the bed
my dog is a
bad dog all right and you'll notice that
i have some weird capitalization in here
which is going to be what we're
replacing
so we want to say we want a new string
and then for the string we want to
replace all so this is different from
the replace method because
obviously we're replacing all
occurrences of the match rather than
just the first and that's why i use this
one
more frequently because in most cases i
want to replace all rather than just the
first match
so in this case we could just say we
want to replace the word dog with cat
and that's going to assign the new
string
to our variable and you're going to see
my cat jumped on the bed my dog is a bad
cat which obviously makes no sense
whatsoever because we missed one and
that's because this is case sensitive
but what we can do is write a regular
expression and we just learned about
that so we might as well do it
all right so we're going to say
correct string
equals my string dot replace all and
then in this case we're going to pass in
a regular expression and then we're
going to replace that with uh lowercase
cat so all occurrences of the the word
dog uppercase and lowercase are going to
be replaced with this right here so in
this regular expression we're going to
put a character group
and we're going to say we want either an
uppercase d or a lowercase d
and then we want to match exactly so
we're going to put these little brackets
and put a 1 in there so we're going to
match exactly one
of these characters either uppercase or
lowercase and then we're just going to
pass in
og because it's always going to end in
og in the lower case form
so then we're going to finally pass in
let's see we need to pass in the global
flag because we want to
replace or find all instance of
instances of that
so let's go ahead and press enter and
see what we got
so the correct string it looks like we
have cat in all of these instances so we
replaced it correctly again this g at
the end is just the global flag
and
there's a bunch of different flags that
you can bring into a regular expression
but this just means
match all occurrences not just the first
the next method we're looking at is the
two uppercase method this is a pretty
easy one
let's go to the documentation take a
look
it says two upper case returns the
calling string value converted to
uppercase
and the value will be converted to a
string if it isn't one all right so very
simple um
very simple function here
and we can pretty much figure out what
it does by just experimenting around so
we'll say
that we want my string to be equal to
some string
and then all we do
oh it's saying i redeclared my string so
i need to refresh the browser
because i already did that so
my string equals some string and then we
say my string dot 2
upper case
and you'll see that it capitalizes every
single character within that string so
it's very straightforward
you'll see where this comes in handy in
just a second so the next one we're
looking at is the substring method i use
this quite a bit
if we go to the documentation you're
going to see
that there are actually two methods and
if you have been following along with
this tutorial in the prior video the 25
challenges
i actually used the wrong method here so
you can see that we have the two methods
we have the substring and then we have
sub str
and this sub sdr has the little
downwards thumb which means don't use it
it's deprecated and of course i used it
in the previous video so
apologize for that but we're going to be
using the non-deprecated method and it
says it returns the part of the string
between the start and end end
indices
so if we go down to the
function signature
you can see that there's one required
parameter it's not surrounded by those
brackets and then one
optional parameter and these represent
the index of the first character that we
want to include in the return string and
then the last character if we
want that otherwise it's just going to
take everything
after that first character
so let's go ahead and give this a try
um we'll use the same string here so
we'll say my string
dot substring and let's say that we want
to get um
everything
starting at
i don't know the letter m so if you
think about this the s has an index of
zero
the o has an index of one m will be
two e three the space will be four
and the second s will be five so maybe
we'll start it at five so we just get
the second word
and then if we don't pass in the second
parameter it just goes to the end of the
string which is kind of what we want but
you could also
pass in something like 7 and it kind of
cuts it off there so that's kind of how
the substring method works
now i want to provide you with some
common ways that we might use all these
methods
and one of the common ways that i've
found to use the substring method
is if you want to maybe capitalize the
first
word of a sentence so let's say that we
wanted to take my string which is some
string with all lower case and we just
wanted to capitalize this s
and combine that into the full stream so
basically what we're looking for is this
right here
now if we wanted to convert that here's
what we would do we would say
let's just assign it to a result
variable
so we will say my string
and then we want to grab the
first letter of the entire string which
is going to be that s
now we're going to use that to uppercase
method that we saw in the previous
method right there and what that's going
to do is it's going to grab that s and
then it's going to capitalize it
so all we're getting right now is a
single letter so we can use the plus
sign we can concatenate
two strings together
so now we have to get the remainder of
the string right here
and the way that we do that is using the
substring method
so we'll say my string
and then we want to use the substring
method and we want to start at an index
of one because we've already got the
first uh the zeroth index of s so we
want to start the sub string at one all
right and then we can go to the end of
the string so all we would have to do is
basically just leave it like that and
we're done but if you i don't know maybe
have a good reason to do this you could
also grab
my string
dot length to get the very last
character in the string as our bounds of
that substring so if you press enter and
then you type out result you can see
that we have capitalized uh this string
or sentence if it was longer so that's
just a common use case of the substring
method combined with the two upper case
method and you can start to see how when
we combine them together it makes our
job a lot easier
the next method we're talking about is
the trim method and this may not seem
all that useful when we first start
looking at it but i will
show you why we might use this in the
real world so the trim method removes
white space from both ends of a string
notice it says both ends it doesn't
remove white space from in the middle of
the string
white space in this context is all white
space characters space tab no break
space etc
and all the line terminator characters
so
a carriage return here but we don't need
to worry about that
and the call signature the function
signature is very simple you just call
it on the string and it removes the
white space
so again you might say well this is not
very useful but what if we got some
external data that looked like this
so this might be some data that you
retrieved from an external database or
something and you have no control over
how you receive it
and in this case we have some spaces um
in these strings so how would we go
about removing those in returning an
object that has uh kind of a cleaned up
piece of data well we can do that using
a loop and the trim method
so let's just write a loop a for loop so
we did this a lot in the challenges the
code challenges from the last lesson
and then we
also learned it in the last lesson so
you should be familiar with this
so we're going to write the loop
i plus plus
now we're going to loop through each
piece of data and what i'm going to do
is actually break this out so i'm going
to say the current title is going to be
equal to external data
then we're going to grab the index that
we're on dot title
and then we're going to go down and
we're going to grab the current
author
equals external
data i
dot author
now we're coming down here and this is
where we're going to
reassign the values of these properties
to the trimmed version of them
so we're just going to say the external
data i
dot
title
is going to be equal to the current
title dot trim
so it's going to trim the white space
and assign it back to that property
then we'll do the same thing for the
author so external data
dot author equals the current author
that we're iterating over
dot trim
and there is our for loop so if we print
out external data we look at the array
here you're going to see that all of
these values have been trimmed of the
white space
so that's just
a way that i've used it in the past
something that has come in handy for me
so i just wanted to show you that method
for that reason
now the final method that we're going to
look at the built-in method on a string
object is the match method now this is
going to be very familiar to you because
we learned about regular expressions
already so i'm going to actually bring
in something that we've already looked
at here so let's write a regular
expression and we'll just say
we want to match uh any lowercase
characters in a quantity of one or more
and that's going to be our regular
expression and then our string is going
to just be a bunch of gibberish write
this correctly a bunch of gibberish and
then maybe some numbers in here and then
some more
gibberish letters all right so there's
our string
and there are actually two ways that we
can test this the first way is something
we've already seen where we just run the
exec method on the string and of course
since we're matching lowercase letters
in a quantity of one or more it's going
to grab all of these until it gets to
the numbers and then it no longer
matches
so that's one way we could do it
but we can also do it in reverse like it
does the same exact thing except we're
doing it from the string method so all
we have to do is say string.match
and then we pass in the regular
expression and it's going to show us
kind of the same thing
now this is going to be exactly the same
as long as you are not using the global
flag so if we were to put in um
let's say you know if we defined the
regular expression
and we put in a to z
you know one or more and then we put
this global flag in there that would be
when these two methods
do not behave identical but for our
intents and purposes you can use either
one it really doesn't matter just pick
one and go with it
to this point in this lesson we've
talked about dates regular expressions
and built-in string methods but we
haven't talked about arrays and this is
where
it gets really fun now i will say that
this list of methods that we're going to
be going through you can actually see
them on the screen
all these different methods here
so we have the push pop shift and on
shift those are kind of grouped together
we have slice splice
these are actually different we have
find index and index of they're kind of
grouped together map for each includes
filter and reduce and i chose these
because these are the ones that you're
going to be using
most of the time and these represent
kind of the bulk um you know if we can
kind of go with that whole 80 20 rule
this is this is the 80 20 rule of array
methods and it's obviously not
exhaustive
and i'm not going to go into every last
detail of each method but i hope that
this can basically walk you through the
basics of each so that when you have to
use them it's not a complete shock you
kind of know what's available to you
which is kind of half the battle
sometimes just remember these are not to
memorize don't try to memorize these
like any built-in method you can always
look them up and as i've been going
through in this video you know how to
read the documentation now and i'll
continue doing that for each of these
array methods so that you can just get
better and better at um you know
acquainting yourself with
the different
syntax of this documentation so let's
get started we'll start with the push
pop
shift and unshift methods and we're not
going to really go through all of these
in the documentation because they're so
similar but let's go to javascript again
built-in objects and we're going to the
array object which has instance methods
that we're going to be looking at here
all right
so we will start with pop we've actually
already looked at this when we talked
about reading documentation this is
going to remove the last element from an
array
now we also have
shift
right here this is going to remove the
first element of the array
then you have the method that we're
going to be using the most out of all of
these
which is the push method this just takes
an element
and
or an element or more than one element
and adds it to the end of the existing
array and then finally the unshift
method
down here somewhere
this is going to add an element or
elements at the beginning of the array
again i think the push method is
probably going to be the most widely
used but let's just go ahead and see
what we're dealing with here
so we'll make an array
we'll add three elements in there
and
maybe
let's go ahead and put a gap in there so
we'll skip four and we'll put in
five and six or something like that all
right so there's our array so what if we
wanted to
um basically add the four in there so
basically all we have to do is array.pop
that's going to take off the six and it
returns six not because the value is six
but because there are
um six elements or maybe maybe it did it
does return the element that they that
it removed from the array i'm sorry
about that all right anyways we will go
and do that again
because we need to remove one more so
now our array looks like this we just
have one two three and now we can push 4
5 and 6 to the end and we are back to
what we started with but this time it
has all of the
numbers in order
so of course we can add the zero at the
beginning so we just say array dot
unshift put a zero in there and now our
array has zero through six so you can
kind of get an idea of how this works
and there's not a whole lot to it all
right let's move on to the slice method
now this one is going to come in handy
when you need to make a copy of an array
and this is not going to be apparent why
this is useful right now but once you
start getting into
front-end programming where you're
writing code in either angular or react
or
view js or something like that there's
this concept that we call state which
basically
um
it's how the data flows through the
front end of your application and when a
user updates their profile or whatever
and that data update affects another
part of the application
the state is what makes those changes
propagated across the entire application
and when we're dealing with state we
often a deal
are dealing with immutable objects
things that cannot be changed
so making a copy of the data that you're
putting into state is going to be
extremely useful and to do that you can
use this slice method so let's look at
it
in the documentation we'll go to slice
it says it returns a shallow copy of a
portion of an array when it says shallow
here that just means that you have like
if you have nested objects or arrays
it's not going to
pick up on those it only gets like the
first layer or whatever um you'll need a
more advanced method to do like a deep
copy of an object and i'll talk about
that a little bit
later in this lesson so basically what
it's doing is it's taking two optional
parameters
so if we
don't supply any sort of parameters at
all
then it's just going to let's see what
it says so if we don't put any
parameters at all it's just going to
create a copy of the entire thing
otherwise it will create a copy of a
specific part of an array so let's see
how this works we have an array already
right here but
let's say that we wanted to take out 2
3 and 4 or something like that so we've
already got an array on the screen and
let's say that we wanted to make a copy
of the entire thing so we can say copy
of the array is going to be array.slice
we don't need to pass in any parameters
because we just want the entire thing
and now the copy of the array is going
to be a perfect copy
now if you were to compare these so copy
of the array
versus the array they're not going to be
equal so i say that loosely but that is
a concept that we talked about when we
looked at the javascript operators in a
previous lesson
all right so if we wanted to grab like a
specific part of this array so another
copy
and we want to grab
everything starting at 3 until the end
of the array you might say slice and
then you want to give it an index of
not 0 not 1 not 2 but you want to start
at 3 so you want to give it an index of
and now another copy is going to be
equal to three four five six
so that's just a
quick overview of the slice method the
next method that we're dealing with is
called splice and it is not to be
confused with slice so if we go to the
documentation
click on splice it will say that this
method changes the contents of an array
by removing or replacing
existing elements and or adding new
elements in place
so in other words this is useful if
unshift and push those two methods we
learned about are not sufficient you
want to actually replace something in
the middle of the array rather than just
the beginning or the end now i want to
look at the function signature on this
one because it's kind of interesting
so it's there's a lot going on but the
only required parameter is the start
which is the index at which you want to
start changing the array
then
the comma here it says we're going to a
new parameter we want the delete count
so it's basically saying we want to
start at a specific index and now we
need to specify how many items of that
array are we going to delete starting at
that index now if we don't provide this
because it is entirely optional
it says if this is omitted or if its
value is equal to or larger than the
array.length minus the start we don't
need to get into that then all the
elements from start to the end of the
array will be deleted so let's say that
we you know specified the start as index
of one then it's going to basically
delete everything except for that first
element
so
the next part that we have are these
interesting brackets where we just have
item one item two and then the dot dot
dot this is basically saying that you
can have an infinite number of
parameters
that you can replace
and it looks like if we come down here
to item one two
dot dot dot it says the elements to add
to the array beginning from start if you
do not specify any elements splice will
only remove elements from the array so
this kind of changes the behavior of the
entire method we go from removing
elements to adding elements to the array
so you can see how reading the
documentation can be very helpful
in our case we're just going to go
through a basic example so we'll say
that our array is going to be equal to 1
and then we'll put in some string that
doesn't belong there 4 5 6.
all right so what if we wanted to well
hold on
i cleared the screen but did not refresh
and i tried to redeclare that array
variable so let's try again so one two
three
four five six
and what if we wanted to remove that
string from there so all we'd have to do
is array dot splice
and then we want to specify that we want
to start at the index of three so this
is 0
and then 3 so we want to start at the
index of 3 we want to remove
a single element so we just want to put
in a 1 right there
and then at the end we can put in
um let's say what we want to replace it
with so in this case we want to remove
this string and replace it with
something so maybe something in between
we'll put 3.5 or something
all right so it returns the
item that was removed and now our new
array
has the replacement value in there
so at this point i think it's a good
time to just briefly mention um the fact
that we are mutating this array right
here
now when we looked at string methods
none of those methods actually
modified the existing string and that is
because an array is not a primitive
value now a string is a primitive value
and for that reason it is immutable and
you cannot change it now an array is
mutable so that means that these methods
that we're using are actually editing
the array itself and
you don't have to basically create
copies
you could if you use the slice method
though
all right so the next one that we're
dealing with
is going to be the find index and index
of method so here's the find index
it returns the index of the first
element so only one that status
satisfies the provided testing function
all right so this is where we start
getting into the callback functions that
i talked about so if you don't
understand callback functions be sure to
go to that prior part of the lesson here
and really
wrap your head around those because from
here moving forward we're going to be
dealing with them in pretty much every
array method
anyways it says if there's no match so
if your testing function does not match
an element
you're going to get a value of negative
1. so we know that if this
method returns us negative 1 then what
we're trying to match does not exist in
the array otherwise we get the index
to grab it from now this is kind of
similar so the find index is kind of
similar to the index of method so if we
come down here and grab the index of
method
it's just going to return
the first index where the given element
is found there's no such thing as this
you know callback function that matches
or anything we're just searching for a
specific string
and again this will return negative 1 if
that is not present now this is a little
bit less powerful and like i said
callback functions enable reusability in
this case we just search for a raw
string
with the find index we can specify an
entire testing function so in this case
if you can grasp your head around these
callback functions the find index is
going to be a little bit more powerful
for you so let's see if we can come up
with a good example for this we'll use
what we got for the index of method so
again array is equal to this right here
and we could just say array
index of and maybe we want to look for
that value of 3.5
and it's going to give us an index of 3.
so what we could do here is we could
basically say okay i want to get that
value here so we can say array then we
can use the bracket notation we
obviously have to pass in an index
and then we can find this index it's
kind of
circular here but i'm just trying to
show you how this might be used
and then we pass in there and now we can
actually get the value so previously we
just looked at for the index right here
but now we're actually getting the value
returned because we used that index and
grabbed it from the array
all right so that's how you use index of
now let's talk about how you might use
the find index method for a little bit
more powerful search
now what if you had a more complex array
um like this
this is obviously got a lot more to it
it's got objects that have two
properties first name and last name now
if you tried to use the
index of method so more complex array
and then you used index of and then you
started putting an object in here and
typing out first name
equals bob so on and so forth you're not
going to get a match it will never match
because you can't do that kind of
equality comparison
so all we have to do is use the find
index so this is going to return us the
index of the first match that we have
identified within this array so let's
say that we want to identify
any
or we want to identify the first item in
this array where the last name
does not equal smith
so that's obviously the last
value and that would be the zero one to
third index so we expect an index of
three to be returned
and what this expects is an argument if
we go to the find index again
you'll see that we
need to return a call back and that
callback is going to have a couple of
arguments that we can use here so let's
look at this real quick
the callback has an element so that's
the current element being processed in
the array that's not new to us
we have the index of the array we don't
probably don't need that and then we
have the original
array that we're looking at and we
probably don't need that as well
and then finally we have
another argument after the callback and
it says optional object to use as this
when executing the callback we haven't
talked about
this keyword yet so we're not going to
worry about that
all right so we need to pass in a
callback
let's go ahead and populate that
with the array item and that's all we're
going to use here we could have passed
in the index and the original array but
we don't need to and then in this case
since we're searching for anything that
does not equal smith we can just say
where array item dot last name does not
equal
smith
all right so what this is going to do is
return us a value of 3 which is the
index of the first element that is not
smith which happens to be this last
object down here john doe so you can see
how powerful this is as compared to the
index of method
there's a lot more things you can do
with it but as i said this is just an
overview of each method
the next method we're looking at is the
map method now we've already looked at
this in the documentation a little bit
earlier in this lesson
let's look at it once more
this was the method we kind of used to
prove out the reusability thing
but basically if we look at the
parameters that we can put in here it
says that we have a callback function
and then similar to the um
the previous method we just looked at we
have
the this arg which we haven't covered
anything about that so we're not going
to get into it so basically if you
remember this is just a transformation
function and it's going to loop through
an array and
perform a transformation
according to your callback function on
each element in the array
so let's consider this array right here
where we have blog posts from a database
and in this case all of them are
uncategorized so what if we wanted to
return a new array but in the new array
the category is going to be set to
something like web development
well all we'd have to do is use the map
method now of course you could you know
type it out and say blog post from
database
and then
goes at 0 and then type in the
category and set it equal to something
but that's going to get really clunky
and slow
so what we need to do is say blog post
from database
dot map
now this is where we pass in our map
function so we're going to pass in the
array
item
so as we go through each item the first
thing that we need to do is we need to
modify that actual property and then we
need to return
the item in full so we'll say array item
dot category
equals
web development all right so there we
have modified this individual array
items category property
and now we're going to return the array
item which has been modified all right
so we'll press enter and now you can see
this map function returns the following
array and in this case we now have the
category updated for all of these
properties
so this would be a really useful
function to do
in the real world and i've actually used
something very similar to this example
in some of my apps so it's
super realistic and super helpful it
will save you a lot of time next up in
our lineup is the for each method and
until this point we've been looking at
arrays
and looping through arrays in one
specific way so this is how we've been
doing it
if we have an array that has a couple
values in it now we write our for loop
so we initialize i to 0
we go until i is
less than the array.length
and then we increment i
then we drop down into the for loop and
we're going to do something here so
maybe we're just going to
print the
element of the array that we're at so
there you go prints it and we can do all
sorts of stuff within that code block
now there's another way to write a for
loop that we haven't talked about yet
and that is the for each
method on an array so here's how we
would do that
we would
say array.4 each
and now what's going to happen is we
have a callback function that gives us
the array item
and then we drop down into the function
and we can once again console.log the
array item
all right so that's just a simple way to
replicate that array up there you can
also get the index so if we looked at
the documentation
of the for each method it's going to say
here's our callback that we're looking
at and it's going to pass us the current
value and it's going to pass us the
index in the original array so again
this is this signature right here the
the function signature is going to be
very similar if not the same for pretty
much all
of these more advanced array methods
so in this case if we wanted to take
this uh for loop so let's clear the
screen once more here's our array that
we're looking at and if we wanted to do
the for loop we use four each
we want the
array item
and then we can grab the index
so in this case we have two things to
work with and we'll console.log
say the array item
and then we will enter down in
console.log the index and you can see
that we are printing
the value of one
which has a zero index the value of two
which has a one index and the value of
three
which has number two index so this is
really useful um a little bit quicker
than our other
for loop now there are a couple
differences but nothing that we need to
talk about right now you'll find those
out as you start programming and i'll
try to point them out within this series
if we stumble upon them the next method
that we're talking about is the includes
method so this is going to help you find
a single element
and determine whether it exists within
an array
so there are multiple ways to do this
and i'll show you a couple different
ways
and kind of prove out why the includes
method might be the best in a lot of
cases so let's say that you have the
following array you have my colors you
want to figure out whether
the color orange exists within this
array using some code now there are a
couple ways that you can do this but one
way that we can use is what we're
basically
accustomed to seeing and we're going to
initialize this variable right here
we'll say that it's false
and then if when we're looping through
this array if any of the colors equals
orange then we set that variable to true
and now we can figure out if orange
exists which should be true so that's
one way to do it but there is a simpler
way to do it with the for each method so
we could say
something like this so we've already got
the orange exist
variable and all we'd have to do is loop
through it that way set it to true and
we can say orange
exist and that is going to be equal to
true
now there is a even simpler way and it's
using the includes method so all we
would have to say is my colors
that includes and then type orange and
it's going to tell us true that does
exist in the array
so as you can see
it's a lot easier to use a method like
this than go through all of those for
loops and you know store the value in a
variable and stuff like that now just to
connect the dots here and show you that
there's a variety of ways to solve
problems within
coding
you could have also used the index of
method so if we would have said my
colors and then you say index of
and then you type orange
and you return that it's going to give
you an index of 3. so basically
all you would have to say is that
statement right there and you say if
that does not equal negative 1
then our
item exists with the in the array
because if it returns negative 1 then it
didn't find it and we know that it
doesn't exist so that's just another way
to solve it and hopefully you've seen
that there are in this case there are
four different ways that i went through
something like that of
checking whether something exists in an
array the next method that we're going
to use is filter and this is probably
the most
frequented method for me
this is the one that i use the most
probably i don't know for sure but
this one and map are probably the two
that i would use the most within my code
now the filter method does exactly what
you think it would do it filters out
different results so let's say that you
go on amazon and you go to your orders
page it might look something like this
you know this is fictitious it's not
actually what their data model is going
to look like
but you can see that maybe we have some
different properties on our orders array
and this is going to represent all of
the orders but you know when you go on
amazon you can click on buttons and
filter those orders by date
by whether they're open open whether
they're cancelled or whether they're
digital and we can do this with the
filter method which is basically going
to return us an array that has been
filtered based on a callback function
that we provide to it
so with this array you can see that we
have this is digital property so we
could find all of the
digital products
we could save that to an array by saying
digital orders and then we'll set that
equal to all orders
dot filter and now this is where we pass
in our callback function which again
receives the array item
and then we will pass that in to our
function and return
anything that
is
digital so we'll say array item dot is
digital which is a boolean so if it's
true
then we're going to return a true value
and it's going to be included in our
resultant array
so now our digital orders if we print
that out you'll see that we have two of
them and it says is digital true so we
know that we match those correctly now
there's a couple other filters that we
could do we could paste in this and say
okay we want all of the digital and
cancelled orders so we're returning a
condition where it says we want to check
if it is digital
and
it is canceled so in this case we can
print this array
digital cancelled
orders
and we only have one of those
where you can see is digital is true and
is cancelled is also true so this is a
super useful method and it's often used
on the front end where you're like i
said on your orders page on amazon and
you click the button and it might
execute
this filter method and just show the
user whatever is filtered so this is
really useful i use it all the time
on the front end and you can even use it
on the back end a little bit as well
now i saved the hardest for last
of course because i didn't anticipate
the fact that i'd be talking
for such a long period of time but we're
going to go ahead and try this anyways
this is the reduce method so if we look
at the reduce method
within the
documentation it's going to give us a
very interesting
callback function so instead of the
array item and then the index and then
the original array that we get passed
into our callback
it's going to give us some interesting
parameters so it gives us the
accumulator it gives us the current
value
and then it gives us some optional
parameters here index and then the
original array and then finally we pass
in
in addition to the callback an initial
value that we want to initialize this
accumulator to so i'm not going to go
through all of these i'm going to put
this into terms that i think we can all
kind of recognize
so let's go ahead and paste this in
and this is the code that you're
probably used to seeing so if we wanted
to
find the sum of this array so we wanted
to add all of these numbers together
this is how we would do it and this is
how we did it in the 25 coding
challenges that we
practiced for the previous lesson
so in this case we initialize a sum
variable to equal zero so we start the
count at zero then we loop through our
array and for each element in the array
we add it to the sum using the plus
minus or plus equals operator and then
at the end we console log the sum which
is going to equal
because that's the sum of all of these
values in the array
now what i want to point out is the fact
that this sum variable
is essentially accumulating values so
it's basically called our accumulator so
if we go back to the documentation
it shows that the first argument of this
callback is the accumulator so you can
think of this as our sum variable that
we just wrote right here so what i'm
going to do is right below here i'm
going to rewrite all this code but using
the reduce method
so the first thing i'll do is write our
reducer
callback function and what this callback
function is going to do is it's going to
accumulate the value so if you look at
the documentation
it's going to first take this
accumulator parameter which is basically
going to act as this sum variable right
here so up top we defined it like
outside of the for loop but here we can
just pass it in as a parameter to the
callback and then we have an array item
so that's going to be another parameter
and we have others but we don't need
them so let's go ahead and just use this
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to return a value so we always
return a value from the callback for
each array item
and in this case this sum variable is
going to be
accumulated over the course of looping
over this array so the reduce method
automatically takes care of that and
make sure that that accumulates a value
so all we have to do is say sum plus or
equal array item and what this is going
to do is exactly the same thing that
we're doing up here
but we're adding the array item and
we're doing it all within a callback
function
so let's define that
and now we can say that we want our
result to be equal to array.reduce
so we're
using the reduce method and we need to
pass in our reducer callback and then we
need to pass in one more thing
so if you go over to the syntax you'll
see that we have the callback which is
encompassed uh in the highlight right
here but then you'll see after that
highlight we have a comma and then
another
parameter called initial value and if
you come down and read about the initial
value it's basically saying
that this will represent the starting
value of this sum variable that gets
passed in for every iteration
so we want to start that at 0 just like
we started the sum up here at 0. and
when we press enter and print the result
we're going to get 99 which has done the
same thing as our code above so while it
looks very confusing
it is very confusing
you can kind of anchor yourself to this
more uh simplistic code that we've
already written and already understand
so that is the reduce method and the
last thing i want to show you about it
is how you can use this to basically
get the average of numbers in an array
so we went through some practice
problems
in the 25
practice problem video previous to this
lesson
and we had to calculate an average of an
array i believe
and of course there is no average method
on the array object i'm not sure why
doesn't make a whole lot of sense to me
but you can use this reduce method to
actually calculate your own average of
the array in just a single line here's
how you're going to do that all right so
we're going to say array.reduce
and then we're going to of course pass
in the sum and then the array item so
we're writing the same thing that we
have written
already we're just going to do this in
one line so we're going to take the sum
plus or equal the array item all right
so what this should give us right here
is going to be equal to
of course after we pass in our initial
value that's going to give us the sum of
the array and then all you have to do is
divide that total
by the array.the length and now you have
retrieved the average of this array so
that's just a way that this can be
really useful and you might take a
second to look at this code and see what
it's doing because it's a little bit
confusing
as a one-liner like this but anyways
that's just a really practical example
something that i've used before in uh
writing actual code all right so that is
the end of the
most common built-in array methods
now you might be wondering well what
happens if i find an operation
that doesn't have a method
already built for it and the answer to
that is you probably will be using some
sort of external library to do that and
the most common one
for us javascript developers is going to
be the lowdash library
so if you type in lodash and you click
here this is a modern javascript utility
library delivering modularity
performance and extras
if you go to the documentation you'll
see on the left that at the top we have
our array data type and you'll see that
we have a bunch of different methods
that we can do all sorts of really
interesting things with
so
we have a limited set of built-in
javascript objects but the developers of
lodash have taken it a step further
and basically
created some additional methods so if
you remember something that was tough
for us is comparing the equality of two
objects
so if we go in here and create
two objects so we'll say object one
and we'll set that equal to prop one and
some value all right and then we have
object 2
and then we want to just set that
perfectly equal to this
all right so we put that in there and
now if we try to compare them
it's going to say false and that's going
to stay false even if we use double
equals and that's because we can't
compare the equality of two objects and
if you wanted to write a function that
actually compares the equality of two
objects it's going to take you hundreds
of lines of code but if you use the
lowdash library you can actually look at
something
let's go down here
a little bit
and we have this method called is equal
and this is equal
can actually take two objects as you see
here so these are basically the example
we just came up with
and it checks if they're equal and it
returns true and behind the scenes this
library is running hundreds of lines of
code to make this comparison and you can
see how we can extend our functionality
by using external libraries
so let's go ahead and look if we go to
the documentation on mdn go to
javascript go to built-in objects and go
down to the math object
you're going to see that there's a lot
of built-in math functions and as a
developer you might be saying well hey
i'm not writing a bunch of finance
applications i probably don't need this
well i'll show you in just a few seconds
why it might be useful for you
all right so if we go down here
this is a little bit different than
we're used to seeing so if we come into
the console
and talk about like dates or something
we know that we can make a date by
saying new date all right so that's the
syntax that we're used to it's called
the constructor syntax because we are
constructing a
i guess copy of this
date template or the object i mean these
are all terms that i'm kind of using in
quotations because they're not
perfectly true but you kind of get the
point
all right so this is the
way of constructing an object now with
the math library you'll see that all of
the methods we're just taking the actual
object we're so we're saying math and
then we're just executing the method
against it so instead of saying let's
say my date equals new date
and then we say my date dot get
date or something like that we are
first constructing the object and then
using a method on it and this is how
we've done it with all of these so you
might say well why don't we say
math equals
new math
and you press enter and it's going to
say math is not a constructor well this
gets us into
the concept of object-oriented
programming
the math library actually has rather
than instance methods so
with the previous ones with the date
object and the string in the array
we have to first construct the actual
object and then we
call methods on top of that object which
are called instance because we have an
instance of that object and we call
methods on top of it now with the math
library we're just using static methods
so we just call it directly from the
object and it's pretty simple so let's
just go through a couple of quick ones
that you might
you know find useful so
let's see what my list shows right here
so let's clear the screen
and here are some of the common ones so
we have math.pi
that's going to give you the value of pi
we have math.e so this is i think
euler's constant or something like that
that might be something that you use
um and then we start getting into the
methods so we have the absolute method
and we can actually um pass in a
negative number and get a positive or
absolute value of that
we also have the
math.ceiling method which is going to
round up to the nearest integer so let's
say that we pass in math.pi
we're going to round 3.14 up to the
nearest integer of 4.
likewise we have the floor method so we
take math.pi again and it rounds it down
to 3. and then finally we have the
math.round method
and again if we put in math.pi it's
going to round it to 3 because
3.14 is closer to 3 than it is 2 4.
all right so those are some quick
methods that you can use you can also
use the min and the max
method so if we had
min you can pass in a couple numbers and
this is going to give you the smallest
number and then of course max will do
the opposite so same numbers but we get
the highest number
all right and then the final one is
math.random
so this is going to give you a random
number a random decimal between 0 and 1.
now this has implications that you
probably don't understand but we've
actually used this to get a random index
of an array for previous videos
and i'll show you exactly how we can do
that alright so
let's decompose this in two steps
so first let's get a random number and
set that equal to math.random
all right so this is going to equal
something between 0 and 1. let's just
see what it equals right now all right
so it equals 0.97
all right so we know that if we multiply
something between 0 and 1 by another
number it's going to give us a whole
number between 0 and whatever number
we're multiplying it by
so if we multiply random
number
times five we're going to get a number
between
zero and five
so we can use that to say that we want a
larger number we'll just call it that
and we'll say that will be equal to
random number um times a
you know we'll say a hundred so now we
get zero to a hundred
and then finally this is going to be a
decimal when we look at it but if we
wanted to bring this down to a whole
number we just say math.floor and then
pass in the larger number and now we
have 97.
all right so we can combine this with
our knowledge of
the length of an array to get
um a range of random numbers that are
within the bounds of an array so let's
just define an array real quick and
we'll just say
some
values
blah
blah all right so we got four values in
there
the length of this array is four so
here's how we get a random index of our
array we'll say random index and we'll
be setting that equal to
all right so we will say math.floor
because we know we need a whole number
now we want to pass in math.random so a
number between 0 and 1 and then we want
to multiply that by the array dot length
so that we can get from 0 to the length
of the array which is always going to
give us a valid index
all right so we will set that equal
press enter and now we can just take our
array and pass in our random
index and it's going to give us a random
value of that array
next up we have to talk about air types
within javascript and we're going to
combine that with some of the data types
that we haven't quite talked about
up to this point
all right so
error handling in javascript is
something that a beginner is not going
to
find the value in most likely i know i
didn't when i first started out i could
not understand why we need to handle
errors within our code
but there are some really important
implications to this so if you have an
external library that you're calling or
maybe you're fetching data from an
external database
or something like that you don't know
what the behavior of that external code
is going to be
so it could give you an error or for
that matter let's say that you're
building an app that's similar to say
instagram and your user who
maybe is got some spotty internet at the
time
is about to press post on their
instagram photo and as they're pressing
post their internet goes out
alright so clearly the code that's going
to be run is going to fail
and what we want to do is handle that
correctly so when you try to post and
you got no internet you're probably
going to see a message on the screen
that says something like no internet
please try again when you're connected
now that is proper error handling
because we have detected that something
went wrong and given the user a
meaningful message
for that now if we didn't handle errors
and we just you know ran our code and
just
you know threw caution to the wind and
said hope it works well in that case
when that user posts the photo and the
internet goes out the whole instagram
app is going to crash
so we obviously don't want that to
happen that's a terrible user experience
and that is the value of error handling
now in javascript there are three main
types of errors there are actually more
so if we
go to the
documentation
javascript
built-in objects and then we go to air
now this is going to be what we call the
base class this is the like you know
parent air type and within this air type
there are several
subtypes of errors that we might see
now there are three of them that i
consider the most common and you'll
probably see the most often and those
are the ones that we're going to talk
about here in this video so the three
we're going to talk about are going to
be the reference error the syntax error
and the type air
and i'm just going to walk you through a
couple situations where you might
encounter these and just explain like
what they are and then finally we're
going to talk about how to actually
handle an error in javascript so the
first one is going to be a reference
error so let's click on that
and this reference error it says
is going to represent an error where
there is a non-existent variable that is
trying to be referenced basically
all right so a good example of that is
if we
don't have a variable defined but we try
to maybe print it to the screen or use
it
so
let's just define
some variable
we'll set it equal to 20 and when we try
to reference that
by just typing it into the repple
or the console it's going to give us a
value but if we were to type in
another
variable
and press enter we're going to say it's
an uncaught uncaught reference error
because another variable is not defined
so when we think of referencing we're
basically trying to find a reference in
the computer's memory of that variable
and if we haven't declared it yet then
it obviously doesn't exist and we have a
reference or a lookup error so that's
the basics of a reference error
now a syntax error is the next one so
let's look at that
we'll go back to the main error page
go to syntaxair this is where you're
writing invalid javascript so this one's
not very hard to replicate
all you have to do is write invalid
javascript so
let's say that we
write an object
and we set it equal to this right here
so we'll say prop1
some value
and put a semicolon at the end
enter down
and another value and put another
semicolon semicolon at the end and it's
going to give us a syntax error because
these semicolons right here don't need
to be there those those should be commas
not semicolons so we wrote invalid
javascript and we got a syntax error
because of it so this one's pretty easy
now the last one the type error this one
is a little bit more confusing so let's
look at it real quick go back to the
main documentation go to type air
now it's going to say a type error
represents an error when the operation
could not be performed
because you're doing it on you know a
variable or a data type that doesn't
have that operation
so something that you might think is
going to throw this kind of air is i
don't know adding two objects together
so let's say that we have
object one and we're gonna set that
equal to
uh i don't know say 20 here
and then we'll come down and do another
object
this is just totally arbitrary i'm just
making some examples now what if we said
object one plus object two
you would think that instead of
returning this string with like
meaningless object
notation we would actually get a
type error because we're trying to do
something
that can't be done we can't add two
objects together like this they're not
uh integers or
or numbers when you're going to get a
type error is when you're trying to
pretty much call a method
on the wrong data type so let's say that
you have a number all right so we'll set
that equal to 20 and on that number
you're going to say to uppercase
now we know from earlier in this video
that two uppercase is a method attached
to the string object not the number
object so in this case we get a type
error because it's not a function
now this might also happen
we have these objects up here and our
property on the object is not a function
but if we tried to call it like we call
a function it's going to give us a type
error because prop 1 is not a function
so that's what a type error is all about
now the last thing that we have to talk
about is actual error handling and as we
talked about it's important because you
want to give a user
the correct message when they you know
run into an air and you also don't want
your application to completely crash
every time an air happens because it
happens all the time with code
so to do this we use something called a
try catch block
so the first part we put
the word try and then we put these two
brackets so we enter down in whatever
code goes in these brackets is going to
be
checked for errors
and if there's an error then it's going
to throw that error and send it to the
catch block so let's write some code
that actually throws an error so let's
say that same example of we have a
number
and then we try to
make that number uppercase which is
obviously invalid so we know that's
going to throw an error but because it's
within this try block
we're going to pass that air it's going
to be thrown
and then this air is going to be
populated with that new air object so
this could be anything we could make it
e we could make it air or er or we could
make it air it doesn't matter it's just
a parameter like we've seen before
so let's enter down into the catch block
and now we can actually check to see
what this error is now i'm not going to
just console log it because then you
might get confused like okay what
happened so let's go ahead and
actually
first let's let's just cheat real quick
i'm going to put a var here so that we
can use this code block again
so let's press enter and you'll see that
nothing no errors were thrown here and
the reason is we had some invalid code
but it got caught here and then we
didn't run any code in the catch block
so if we try this again no pun intended
here
we can actually print some details about
this error so let's console.log
something
where we say air
is an instance of we'll say type error
and in this case it is a type error
because we're trying to call a method
that doesn't exist on this data type and
this instance of operator is basically
going to look at whatever is to the left
of it which is that newly populated
error object and it's going to say is
this an instance of or kind of like a
copy of the template that we call type
error
now that's going to hopefully return
true
if it does what we expected and then an
error actually has a name
attached to it or a message
so we can say air dot message and print
out whatever that error message is so
you can see that if you looked at the
instance properties we have dot message
so that's how i knew how to access that
alright so we press enter and now we get
the value of true because
this
evaluates to true and then this sentence
right here is going to be the error
message so you can see that we have
handled an error what we call gracefully
we have not crashed our application and
this is going to come in handy when
we're using external libraries that we
don't know how they're going to behave
and finally kind of going along with
these air objects we didn't talk about
those much we also have three more data
types that we have not touched on
so let's clear the screen and look at
what we're talking about the first one
is going to be n a n for not a number so
that's actually a data type
then we have undefined
or actually let's go with null we'll
talk talk about null first
and then we have undefined and you can
see if we go to the documentation
we go to the main
javascript documentation with the
built-in objects
you will see that we have
not a number right here so you can see a
little bit about that
you can also see if we
look at the built-in objects that we
have undefined somewhere
so here's undefined and then finally we
have null value right here all right so
these are all you know built-in objects
and in
like when we're looking at this the null
and undefined i believe are primitives
so let me just check that make sure i'm
talking about that correctly
so yes the the undefined and null are
going to be primitives
as we talked about a little bit earlier
so let's start with the least common one
which is going to be not a number so
this is kind of something that
it it's not really used all that often
you probably won't even see it all that
often it's just nice to know about
because you may get this response um at
some point so basically not a number is
meaning exactly what you would think it
would mean it's saying that something is
not a number so if we had a string
and we set that equal to some string and
then we tried to coerce we've done this
before if you surround a
number or like a string value so let's
say that we had
this number constructor or whatever and
then we pass in a string but that string
is equal to a number value this is going
to work fine but if we tried to pass in
my string you're going to get not a
number because you can't possibly
convert a string like that into a number
so that's where you might get not a
number you also might get it if you're
trying to
you know add
uh that string with a number that
doesn't work either
and then you also will get it if you say
my string multiplied by 2
divided by 2
or minus 2. you're going to get not a
number in all of those cases again
you're not going to see this very often
so i'm just going to move on from here
the next one is going to be null
so unlike not a number you're going to
encounter null values pretty much all
the time and what this represents how i
think of it is going to be the
intentional absence of a value or a
placeholder that you put in to a
variable
so if you were to
define a variable so we'll say let
play or no not placeholder we'll just
say let my number
and then we'll set it equal to null
it says we're redeclaring it because
we've already defined my numbers so
we'll just say num
equals null
and we've redeclared this so i've been
typing into this console
too much and using the same variables
variables so let's go ahead and refresh
the whole page
all right so this should work better
we'll say num
does not equal 20 it'll equal null so
this is a placeholder value
and this evaluates to a falsy value so
if we say
um num
triple equals false
then it's going to say false because
it's not perfectly equal to a boolean
but we say if num
and then we get into a conditional block
well console.log this
will not be reached because this will
evaluate to false
so
this block
will be reached and when we press enter
you'll see this will be reached because
we said if num and num equals null so
it's a falsy value so this does not get
reached so that's just something
nice to know as you're using
conditionals and then finally we're
talking about undefined which is very
similar to null
but instead of being an intentional
assignment of value so kind of a
placeholder this is when you just
declare a variable so let's say we
declare a variable called myvar
and we don't assign it to a value now
you've probably been seeing this
undefined happen within the console but
that's not actually
representative of what we're talking
about here so if you were to type
console.log
myvar you're going to get undefined and
you're going to get it twice because it
always prints undefined within the
browser console but this actually does
equal undefined and if you were to pull
up
this conditional statement again
and you put in my var it's still going
to print this else statement because you
didn't reach
this because this evaluates to a false
value all right so that's it for this
lesson number six it was a very long one
obviously split up into multiple videos
but if you made it here congrats
and i look forward to talking about some
more complex subjects we're going to try
to get a little bit away from javascript
but in the meantime i do have some
practice problems for you and you can
continue on to practice some of the
things that we have learned within this
lesson
we've done practice problems in previous
lessons we did 25 of them that took over
two hours to do
and you can check out this video to go
to those those will be a little bit
easier for you but now in the previous
lesson or lesson six
um i guess it's this lesson we went
through a lot of the built-in objects
and then the associated functions
for those objects within javascript so
we have a much broader understanding of
what's available to us and therefore
will be a lot better at solving these
challenges so i'm going to walk through
each of them i recommend that you try
them out first on your own and then you
can go through my solution we'll kind of
look at some community members solutions
as well now in the previous code
challenge video where i did 25 of them i
didn't zoom in so i made sure to
have a nice big screen that you can see
that was a little bit annoying to
actually edit that video so
hopefully this will work out better but
anyways go to the link in the
description to get to the collection
we're going to be working on so this is
my profile on code wars um and if you go
to my profile or no this is my profile
if you go to my profile here you can
come down and you can see the
collections
and you can see that for lesson five we
did 25
problems and then for lesson six we have
some challenges
and once you get here
you can click on the train now button
which is going to take you into all of
these
problems that i've laid out for you here
on the right and there's 10 of them
so we'll go ahead and click train now
which is going to basically put us in
this list and keep us there when we
press you know next kata or whatever
that's called i think it's something
that has to do with jiu jitsu i
didn't know in the previous video but i
think i learned since then
again leave it in the comments if you
know totally what it means
anyways let's get started with our first
code challenge which is going to be list
filtering now if you remember from the
previous uh couple of videos we went
through the built-in methods and one of
those was the filter
method on an array so in this case i
would guess that we're probably going to
be using that to solve this problem
now i haven't seen any of these um or
i've seen them i picked them but i
haven't tried to solve any of these so
we're going to be going in real time
but i think the filter method's probably
going to be what we want here so it says
in this kata you will create a function
that takes a list of non-negative
integers and strings and returns a new
list with the strings filtered out
so this is a perfect
use of our filter method
we'll go here and
as we always do let's change our
parameter name so it's more descriptive
so we'll call this
so
num
list or even better num array
and what we have to do is basically
return
num array and then we want to add the
filter method on the end of that and the
filter method as you might remember is
going to basically take a callback
function and whatever that callback
function returns
if it returns true on the individual
element that we're looping through then
it's going to keep that in the array if
it returns false then it's going to
throw it out and not include it in the
resultant array so just for the sake of
clarity i'm going to actually break this
out into a separate function
and then we'll refactor it so that it's
a little bit
more concise so we'll say our callback
function
is going to take an array item so that's
how all of these
methods on the arrays work they pass in
the array item
to the callback
and then we're going to return a
condition so in this case we want to
look
and see if we have a non-negative
integer so any negative number or string
is something that we need to filter out
so we'll say
first off if
the type of array item
which is going to return us with the
type of the the variable if that is not
equal to
a number which we actually have to put
in quotes
so let's go to our our little
playground here
and if we have
a number something like this and we say
type of 20 it's going to give us number
in quotes and then if we put in some
sort of string it's going to give us
string so we're using that
knowledge and we're saying if the array
item does not equal number
then we want to filter it out and then
we also want to add a condition
we can say if it's not a number or with
these two pipes
or if the array item is negative
so how do we figure out if a number is
negative well we could just multiply it
by negative 1 and if that turns out to
be positive
that's the case but we could also do
something else
so in our callback function we need to
return either true or false which will
determine whether this individual array
item that we're looping over
will be
returned in that final array
so in this case we have two conditions
so we'll put this in a comment we'll say
our first condition is that it is
it is a number our second condition is
it is positive so all we have to say is
if the array item is greater or equal to
zero
um and the type of
the array item is equal to
number
then we want to return true
otherwise we return
false here and exclude it so this little
type of operator we've looked at it
before a couple of times
just to show you what i'm talking about
i have up here if we say type of
string
or put a string in there it's going to
return the value of string but if we put
in
say a number it's going to give us
number so that's what i'm doing here i'm
saying if the type of the item
is equal to number then we want to keep
it all right so there's our callback
function this should work
and all we would have to do is say
return
num array
dot filter and then we pass in our
callback function
and let's see if that works when we test
it
so it does work but there's a couple
ways we can refactor this
the first way is that we don't need this
conditional all we have to do really
is return this expression right here
which if this expression evaluates to
true we want to keep it
and if it evaluates to false we want to
throw it away so if we just return the
expression it should work just the same
now another way we can refactor this is
by taking this entire callback function
and simplifying it so instead of passing
it in as a declaration or whatever we
can just define it right here so we can
say array item and then use an arrow
function to actually return this so
let's break down onto the new line
and we will return this expression right
here and then we can get rid of this
second function
test it again and we should pass it now
the last thing that we can do we don't
even need these little brackets here um
we can get rid of those and get rid of
the return statement because if we put
it all on one line it should work just
fine so let's go ahead and test that
looks like we got some sort of syntax
error
uh yeah we have this little semicolon at
the end which is not valid so let's go
ahead and test it now
and we're passing it so that's how you
might take this and refactor it to work
correctly let's attempt the solution
and we passed them all so we solved this
one
just okay so we'll submit it and see
what other people have
used to solve this
solution
all right let's go down here and
um let's see this one did something very
similar to us
looks like they're
saying
if this is equal to number so i don't
know if they
accounted for negative numbers but maybe
there's something about this that does
um down here let's see
well maybe i misread this actually so
i wonder what the instructions were
maybe go back and and see i guess maybe
we didn't need to look for non-negative
numbers
i don't know all right let's move on
it's not super important you can go back
and kind of look at that on your own
all right our next challenge is
array.diff so probably getting the
difference of an array of some sort so
let's go into the instructions
it says your goal in this kata is to
implement a difference function which
subtracts one list from another and
returns the result it should remove all
values from list a which are present in
list b okay so looking at this
we see that 1 is in both of these arrays
so it's going to remove that and leave
us with an array of 2.
in this one
we have two present in both arrays so
we're going to remove that two and we're
left with one and three which gives us
our result so that's basically how this
is working
and hopefully we can use one of our
built-in methods to solve this
so just a fun fact if you go to the
lodash library
um this is something i talked about in a
prior lesson or not a prior lesson in
this lesson in a prior video
you can go to the documentation and
there's actually a method here
so
we can go to the intersection
the intersection method is going to find
what is alike within the arrays but
we're trying to find the difference so
we can go to the difference method right
here so ultimately our challenge is to
implement this method which we can use
in lowdash
it's very just kind of an interesting
thing to know and if you start using the
lowdash
library like we might do kind of later
in this series it will come in handy for
this reason
so what we're trying to do is find the
difference
and i think the way that we can do this
is by using the array.includes method
let me pull up the mdn documentation
so we'll go to the web docs go to
javascript
go to built-in objects click array and
now we can go down to the
includes method which we talked about in
a prior video
in this lesson so this is basically
going to figure out if something is
included
in another array or if a value is
included in another array so if we were
to loop through one of these arrays and
then ask is each value included in the
other and if so just remove it
then that might help us solve this
problem
the first thing i want to do is check
for the edge cases so if you see in the
test down here there's a couple times
where the first array might be uh
nothing or the second array is nothing
and in those cases we just have to
return whatever is in the other array
so let's say that if
a dot length
is equal to 0
then we want to return
b so we want to return the other array
and then we'll say if b dot length
is 0
then we want to return a
and let's go ahead and test that to see
if we got a couple of them right
and you see that we passed one of the
tests because it
passed in as an argument in empty array
so now we have to actually solve the
question of how do we get that
intersection and figure out
what is actually different between the
two arrays
so i'm just going to open this up here
to full screen and then maybe we can put
in an example just that we're
anchored to something so let's put in
something like three five six six
5 and 2
and then the second array will be
something like
3 and 6. so we know that we want to have
in the final array we want 5
5 and two
so let's see that how we can actually
solve that so what i think we should do
is loop through this
one of the arrays so we'll say a dot
four each and then we have to pass in
our callback function which will do
something on each iteration so we'll say
array item and then we also probably
want to grab the array index and i'll
show you why in just a second
so let's drop down into our function
here
and this needs to be
stored in a result we could also just
return it but we'll store that in a
result and then we'll return the result
at the end of the function so
every time we iterate through this we're
going to actually
use each item check if it exists in the
other array and if it does exist we're
going to remove that item from both of
the arrays
in each iteration of the loop
in order to do that we need something
that removes
an item at a specific index of an array
so let's go on to the documentation and
just refresh ourselves on this method
called splice
now this is something we talked about in
a prior video of this lesson but this is
going to change the contents of an array
by removing or replacing existing
elements
so we can remove
an element at a start index
and then we can
that's kind of how we're going to solve
this so
we'll say that if
the array item
or actually let's say
we're iterating through array called a
so if b
so the other array includes the array
item
if that includes the array item then we
want to remove it so i'm going to put
some comments here
we have found this element in
uh both arrays
so we know that we need to remove that
so how do we do that well we have to
probably get a new array for each of
these
and then now we're going to be working
with that as that uh you know most
recent array so let's make a variable up
here for
we'll say current
array
um
a
and we'll just set that equal to i don't
know we'll put a placeholder in there
called null
and then we'll say let current array
b
equal null so that will be the
placeholder that we're going to assign
these if we have mutated the array
so now what we want to do is create two
separate arrays so we'll say
new a
and then we'll come down here i'm not
done with this yet but we'll say new b
so we're going to grab two arrays that
have these values removed from them and
the way that we do that is basically by
saying
a dot filter so we're going to use the
filter method
and then i'm just going to
pass in
the name of the item as item because we
don't want to conflict
with this right here that we've used in
kind of the parent callback that we're
using
and then let's go ahead and return this
so long as this item that we're looping
through does not equal the array item
that we want to remove
so as long as item
does not equal
array item we want to
put that into the new array and we can
actually use the same
syntax down here
we just need to replace a with b so this
will be the new array
for each of them and all we have to do
here is replace this with our
placeholder so current
array a and i'm actually going to just
call this
new a
just for simplicity
and then new b
and we'll change that here so new a
and new b
and so now each time we basically what
we're doing so far here is we're looping
through every element within the a array
and then we're going to
basically create a new array for both of
them with the only the elements that
have not been matched across both of
them so let's see what this is returning
i'll exit out of here let's just test it
looks like we've got something going on
here so let's go ahead and print what
the result is before we actually
return it so let's print the result and
see what we're getting so a big mistake
that i made that i just realized is that
i'm actually
modifying the original arrays and we
don't want to do that because that's
basically saying okay we're looping
through both of the or through this
array but within the loop we're actually
modifying it at the same time
and we definitely do not want to do that
so let's open up the code block once
more
and now what we need to do is we need to
get a copy of each of them so
we'll say a copy is going to be equal to
a dot slice
which is just going to create a copy of
that array and then b copy is b dot
slice
so that's just going to give us two
copies of the array and now what we're
going to say is instead of a dot filter
and b dot filter we're going to do the a
copy
and the b
copy and that's how we're going to
sort through these let's go ahead and
test that and see if it gets
us an answer here so
looks like we're getting undefined for
our result and i wonder why that's
happening so let's see oh that's because
okay i'm just not thinking here so we're
not going to assign the for loop to a
value because it doesn't return
an array it just loops through it
doesn't really return anything so
returning the result is going to not
work
so what we need to do
is just return
either one of these i believe
so let's see what happens if we console
log
new a
and then maybe return it
okay so we're passing more of them now
let's see
it looks like this sample test it says
if a is an empty array
then we want to return an empty array so
i think i messed that up here
okay so here we have the first one empty
so we want the result to be empty so if
a dot length equals 0 then we just want
to return an empty array rather than the
b array so let's test that
looks like we passed all of them let's
go ahead and attempt it i'm not sure if
this is going to pass it looks like we
got some
problems if we have negative numbers
maybe
let's see what we're dealing with here
okay i think something that i'm doing
wrong here is i'm taking a copy of the
original array each time
but we probably want to take a copy of
the
new array that we've created so each
time it loops through it's going to
remove
you know one of the elements but if we
keep
making a copy of the original array
we're going to keep adding back those
ones that we removed already so
let's go ahead
and instead of making a copy here i'll
expand this out
we'll make a copy of new a
and new b so this should represent
the
updated array so how this is working i
just want to take a second to explain
this
let's say that we have
the following
example so we have one two
two and three
and then maybe we have
two
and three or something like that so
what's going to happen is we start with
array a and we're going to loop through
it with this for each loop so we're
saying okay we're going down into our
code
new a is going to be equal to null
to start and we're going to be
taking a copy of that which is going to
give us
null
and then we're going to say if
b includes the array item so in this
case the array item is going to be 1 so
we're saying if this array b
includes the value of one
then we're going to drop into this code
right here
and if that's the case then we're going
to take new a
and we're going to filter it
and set it equal to
or we're going to filter the copy and
set it equal to new a so we probably
need to initialize this
to be equal to the original array so
we'll say
we'll start it with a
and then we'll start it with b there so
now we're starting with the original
array and each time we get down into the
loop we're going to take a copy of
whatever has been updated and each time
in the loop we're going to check okay is
one included in this second array yes it
is so now let's set new a which was the
original array at the beginning but now
we're going to filter out
this item that we found in both of them
so now as we go
through the second time it's going to be
removing elements so in the first
iteration of this loop 1 is not found
here so we don't do anything
the second time that we come around we
look at 2
and we see that 2 is included in both of
these arrays so we are going to drop
down into this if statement and we're
going to reassign these
placeholder arrays
with our filtered array that does not
include the 2 anymore so it's going to
just have 1 and 3 and then 2 and 3. and
then finally we get to the last one
after a couple iterations we see it's in
both we remove that and then we assign
it to new a and new b so let's see if
this works a little bit better
looks like we passed the easy ones
and then we passed all of them so
this was a tough question like if you
look at the difficulty of it 6 kyu
and i
once once again have not gone through
this beforehand like i don't know i
didn't know how to solve this problem
before i looked at it so
um hopefully that gives you a good idea
of how thinking through this works like
it takes a lot of iterations it's not
something where i'm just like all right
we're going in and solving it i know
exactly how to do it you have to try
some things you have to test it you know
you realize oh i didn't account for this
didn't account for that and eventually
you will get to the answer so this was a
really tough one i would definitely not
call this a beginner
javascript problem but hopefully you can
see in our big solution here how we have
used
a bunch of different methods so we use
slice we used filter we used includes
and we used four each we used all of
these in the same problem and that's how
these built-in methods of javascript can
really come in handy
and it looks like after solving that
since it was a tougher problem looks
like i have leveled up here
i started this code wars thing
uh to make these videos so that's why
i'm not
a little bit higher up
all right enough notifications here
let's go to the next problem
looks like we have another tough one 6
kyu
so let's see if we can solve this a
little bit quicker than the first one
that we did here
okay so let's look at some of the
potential inputs
and at the bottom it says note all the
hashes are pre-validated and will only
contain uppercase and lowercase letters
a little dash and looks like a period so
that's all that we would expect to see
um and then looking at the examples you
see we have a list of objects where each
object has a property called name
and as we scroll over okay that's all
that we're working with there
so in this case bart lisa and maggie so
it looks like we have to put a comma
after the first one
probably a comma after the second one if
there's more than three but in this case
there's three so you put the and instead
of the comma
okay
and then in this case where there is
nothing in the array so it's empty we
just return an empty string so that's a
really easy one to start with
i'm going to actually zoom out this is a
little bit zoomed in i wanted people to
be able to see everything but
in this case we're running out of space
so
let's go if the names dot length
equals zero
then we want to return
an empty string and if we test this we
should pass to pass at least one of them
for that empty array
so we did that we got that test case
covered
now we have to actually go through each
of these so let's see how that how we
can do that we'll probably be iterating
through the array with a for each loop
but let's see
okay let's try that so we'll say
names.for each
and then we can say name will be the
argument that we're dealing with
let's put some parentheses in here
because we're actually going to need
need the array index which is the second
argument of the for each callback
and again if you wanted to see that if
you wanted to actually figure this out
on your own if you go to the for each
method so i go to technologies
javascript built-in objects
array and then i go to the
for each method and then you can read
all the syntax and it says the callback
is going to have these parameters right
here so it first passes in the current
value then the index of the array that
we're looping through and then the
original array so that's how i knew to
add in the name and then the array index
and you could have just called this the
array item to be a little bit more clear
so let's break this down onto a new line
all right so we're looping through and
that's not going to return anything so
we'll probably need to store this in
our final string which will be equal to
nothing to start all right so we'll loop
through
um and actually
if this array has a length of 0 then
this for each loop is not going to do
anything so we probably could just
return
the final string
and instead of having this if statement
up there we'll just have this so let's
test that make sure it works
with that empty array which it does
all right
so back to here we're basically going to
be grabbing the name property so we'll
say name is going to be equal to the
arrayitem.name
because we know that the array item is
going to be an object like right here
and it has a property called name
alright so we have our name
and we just want to add that to the
final string
so let's see
we need to first check
if the array index
does not equal
the
total names array dot length so base so
basically what we're saying is that if
we're not on the last index of the array
then we want to do something
so if we're not on the last index of the
array we want to take our final string
and we want to add
the current array item
name which is stored in the name
variable that we put right here
so that's going to just add the names
and then of course we need the comma
so we want to add the name
so let's just remove this equal sign
and then
we'll say final string equals
final string
plus name
and then plus a
comma and then a space
all right so that's going to basically
reassign that final string and add the
names with the commas
so let's uh console.log
the final string as we have it it's
definitely not going to be right but
we'll see what we're getting
okay so we have bart comma lisa comma
maggie comma homer comma and marge comma
all right so that's kind of what we're
expecting here but now we have to add in
the and symbol and you can see in the
last one right here we've
put in a comma so let's see what this
one actually was
passing in as a test
okay so one mistake that i made if the
array index is not equal to the
names.length remember the
length of the array is going to be
literally how many elements are in the
array but the array is zero indexed so
we'll actually never reach
the
index that is equal to the length of the
array so we have to
say the names.length minus 1. and if we
test this we should not see
this output here we should basically
skip that one
so you see that we skipped marge this
time so that is actually correct
now
we'll put an else condition in here so
otherwise if it is kind of the last
element of the array
so in here we'll put the final string
will be equal to final string
plus the
and symbol
and then plus the
name itself
all right so i don't think this is going
to work perfectly but let's test it
yeah so we're seeing and marge without a
space here so all we need to do is add a
space in there and test it
alright so this looks a lot closer to
what we're
expecting
so what we're missing here why it's
failing
is because we still have this comma here
and when we have the and symbol we don't
want the comma at the end
so basically
um
this condition is not going to be
correct
so we want to actually identify two
different situations we want to identify
when we are on the second to last and
then
when we're on the last one so instead of
saying not equal to
let's say
equal to so if the index that we're
working with
let's go ahead and expand this a little
bit so the index that we're working with
is equal to the last one
that's when we're actually going to
paste in this right here
so we want to put and name
okay
otherwise so else if the array index
equals names.length minus two so the i
guess third to last
we want to say the final string will be
equal to final string
plus the name but we don't want
any of the commas going on here
and then otherwise we just want to
return the final string will be equal to
uh final string
plus
the name plus a comma and a space
so let's try this out and see what we're
getting as output
you can see that we're getting a lot
closer so we have everything correct
except we need a space right before the
and symbol
so let's just add that real quick here's
where we're doing and let's just put a
space there
and test it again
and now you can see that we're passing
most of the test cases
now we have one down here
it says wrong output for a single name
so if we have a single name
we probably need to just return the name
itself okay so we can just cover that in
a separate test case
so we can say if the names dot
length is equal to one
we're going to just return
the
names
zero dot name
so that should cover when we have a
single name
so we passed all of them let's attempt
it
and we passed all of them so this was
another really tough one um probably not
a beginner problem necessarily but
hopefully again you see how we're
iterating through this and and trying
out different things until we get to the
final solution
all right so let's submit this one and
go to the next
as you can see someone solved it with
the reduce method which we learned about
in the prior
video of this lesson
but i didn't think of that so
that's a that's a useful one and
basically anytime that we're using like
an accumulator so in this case we
had the variable called final string so
go back in the video to see that
if you have a accumulator variable
followed by a for loop that modifies
that that's always a good use case for
the reduce method i didn't think about
it in this
particular scenario but that's that's
always a good use case
this one's very interesting i'm not
going to go through all these but be
sure to look at them because people come
up with some very clever solutions all
right so let's look at this one this
again is a pretty tough one so i guess
we're getting all the tough ones in a
row and then it's going to get a little
bit easier here
so in this problem it's basically
the name is take a 10 minute walk and
it's saying you live in this city blah
blah blah where the roads are laid out
in a perfect grid
and you arrive 10 minutes early to an
appointment you want to go take a walk
you've got an app that generates a
little route and you can go either north
south east or west
and each unit is going to be a single
block all right so we need to figure out
if a given array of directions is going
to
put us back at our original destination
and it's going to take exactly 10
minutes and it says that
each block is going to take you one
minute so you
takes you one minute to traverse one
city block
so we're basically returning true if it
does false otherwise
and then it says note you'll always
receive a valid array containing a
random assortment of directional letters
and you're not going to receive anything
other than north south east or west
so in this case i think i have an idea
of how we might solve this
just initially
so
let's open this up and say the first
condition
we know that if there's not exactly 10
elements in the array
it's going to take us more or less than
10 minutes so we'll say if
walk.length does not equal 10
we're going to return false all right so
if it doesn't equal 10 we're returning
false and not going to the rest of the
code if it does equal 10 then we'll go
into the rest of the code and see if it
gets us back in 10 minutes to our
original destination now in this case i
think what we're going to do is
initiate or initialize
four different variables
so we'll say
north offset
equals zero
uh west offset equals zero and we're
going to do this for all of the
directions so
east offset
and
south offset
all right so now we're going to loop
through the array so we're going to use
the for each method and we're going to
pass in instead of array item let's
start learning how to actually
name our parameters to be a little bit
more descriptive so we'll say
direction which will represent the
direction that we're going to receive
and then we'll go down into the for loop
and for each direction we're going to
set
our variables
offsets
so
we'll use a switch case statement so
we're going to put in the direction in
the switch statement and then we're
going to say case if it equals n then
it's going to be north
alright so we're going to put a break
statement in there
if it is west
all right and then we'll just put the
cases for all of the other ones
we don't need that last break statement
because it'll get there no matter what
okay so we're going through all the
different cases and in each one we're
going to
change the offset so if it is north
we're going to say the north offset is
going to be plus or equal 10
all right so that's just going to say
or not 10
we'll just say 1. so we've gone
north one block if the case is north and
we're going to do that for all of these
different cases so we'll say
west offset will be plus or equal one
and then
let's see east offset plus or equal one
and then in the last case we will say
south offset plus or equal one
so if we reach our destination like if
we get put back to our destination then
i think the sum of all of the offsets
should net to
zero
or not not the sum you have to
subtract them so
the north offset will
offset the south one and then west and
then east so basically if
north minus south equals zero and west
minus east
equals zero then we know that we have
returned to the original destination so
if we go down to the
for loop here we'll say
if
north offset minus
south offset equals zero and
west offset minus east offset
equals zero
then we will return
true
otherwise we return false now in all
these cases you're going to start
catching on that
when we just return true in a
conditional
oftentimes we can just return the
expression itself so let's copy that
and instead of this complicated block
let's just return the expression itself
all right so let's break out of here and
test it and see what happens
and we passed all of them so my
assumption was correct you just
calculate the offsets they should net to
zero if you subtract them and if the you
know left and right offset is zero and
the top and bottom offset is zero then
you've returned to your office or your
appointment
so let's attempt it see if we covered
all the cases and we did so awesome
let's submit it
now this one i think was a little easier
than the last two that we did but still
required a little bit of thinking and
i'm sure someone solved it in a much
more efficient way so
when it loads we'll see
all right so the first solution here
pretty much the same thing that we
did so we did pretty good on this one
all right once again we have a 6 kyu
so might be a little bit tough but let's
jump in and see
it says write a function called
persistence right here
that takes in a positive parameter num
and returns its multiplicative
persistence which is the number of times
you must multiply the digits in num
until you reach
a single digit
so i don't understand this fully at
first but let's look at the examples
alright so if we pass in 39
it says we do 3 times 9 which is going
to be 27 right here and then you do 2
times 7
will equal 14 and then 1 times 4 will
equal 4 which is a single digit
okay
now does it always do positive numbers
okay it says positive parameter okay so
we know it's going to be a positive
number
so we know how to identify whether the
solution is a single digit we basically
say
you know if it is less than 10 it's a
single digit okay
so we're probably going to go in some
sort of loop here to iterate over each
new solution
and we might actually use something
called recursion
i'm not sure about that yet but we'll
see
so let's see if this works so we'll say
um how do we get the individual pieces
of this number though so let's go
i can't actually remember if you can do
this but let's take a number like 299
and see if we can access individual
pieces of it
looks like you cannot so
we have to figure out how to get the
first
digit of each of the numbers
so in this case i probably should know
this but i don't and in the real world
this is what i would do i would just
open up a new tab
and say find
or maybe not find we'll say
get first digit of a number
in javascript
so this will work get the second digit
of a number
okay so looks like we're turning it into
a string grabbing the first digit and
then converting it to a number
okay so let's put a num
equal to 299 and then say num
to string okay it gives us 299 and then
we can grab the first
piece of that and then we will convert
that to a number now there's a quick way
to do this
you could just put it wrap it around
with this number object and it'll turn
it back to a number
or what you can do this is a shortcut
you can just put a plus sign at the
beginning and it automatically coerces
it into a number so this is the pattern
that we're going to use we're going to
grab each of the
digits of that number and then we can
see
you know multiply them together
basically
so the thing i'm curious about is
whether
we have okay so if we have three digits
here
we have to multiply all three of them
okay so that's good to know
so it could be up to maybe you know four
or five or six digits so we have to do
you know this times that times that
times that so that's something we have
to take into account here
now if it's already a one digit number
it says to return zero so
let's just say that first we'll say if
num is less than 10
which means it's a one digit number
we're going to return zero and if we
test that we should get at least one of
these correct
so if if it passes in a one digit number
we got that correct
okay so the next part let's see
so what i think we should do here
is we should convert the number to a
string and then maybe
instead of doing what i was showing you
over here converting it back to a number
maybe what we can do is take the string
and put it into an array
so let's go ahead and do that
string version is going to be
num dot 2 string
and then from the string what we know we
can do is actually convert that to an
array so we'll say array version
is going to be equal to the string
version
and then
let's see i actually can't remember
exactly what we used there so let's go
to the documentation
and go to the string methods is what
we're looking for
the reason we're looking for a string
method is because we're trying to
convert this string here
into an array
so let's go to built-in objects
string down here
and then let's look through the methods
i know that there's a way that you can
turn this into an array
okay so it should be the split method
yep that's what we need i don't know why
i couldn't think of that but
if we take a
string so let me just use an example so
you remember we can actually write a
string literal
so
some string
example and then we can take that
literal string and chain a method on top
of it
because it wraps it in the actual string
object that has methods automatically
so what we can do is say split and then
if we just pass in a empty string it's
going to split it by each of the
values here and that's exactly what we
want to do
so
let's go ahead and see how that would
work so if we say num
dot to string so we first convert it to
a string and then we say dot split
and we pass in an empty string it's
going to give us each of those
numbers
in string form all right and then from
here we can basically convert those to
numbers and multiply them together
a good way that we can do that is by
using the reduce method so
if we chain on one more thing here we
can say reduce and then we can say the
the
[Music]
accumulator which is going to be
accumulating that multiplication
operation
but we have to pass in a callback
function so we'll put the accumulator
and then the actual array item or the
number so maybe we'll just pass in num
for number and then now what we want to
do is accumulate so
multiply equal so it's going to take a q
like whatever that's equal to now
and it'll multiply that by the new
number and store that in the same
variable called acc for accumulator
so we'll just do that multiplied by a
number
and we get the answer of 162.
all right so that's our that's our
solution here so if we do 2
times 9 times 9 we get 162 which is our
answer here so this is basically what
we're going to do
and we can do it in one step like we've
done here but we can also see it a
little bit more clearly if i break it
out into steps
so let's go ahead and do that we've
already converted it to a string
now we want it to be in an array so
we'll say split by an empty string
and then finally we want to get the
multiplication
[Music]
value
is going to be equal to
arrayversion.reduce
and then we of course have our
accumulator and our number
and then what we want to return from
that callback function is the
accumulator multiplied
not added sorry
multiplied by that number okay
so that's our callback function
multiplication value should get the
multiplication of all of them and then
we'll say if
multiplication
value is less than 10
then we want to return true so
you can already see where this one is
going we can just return multiplication
value is less than 10. so if it is less
then we return true otherwise we return
false
now the problem with this
is we have to figure out how many times
um we have to iterate through this
before we get something that is less
than 10. so we're not quite done with
the solution yet
so this i believe is where the recursion
comes in and recursion in
coding languages is
probably the hardest concept that you
could
learn so this one don't beat yourself up
if you don't understand what this is
doing fully
um this is something that took me a long
long couple hours early on in my journey
to fully understand like how it worked
so don't beat yourself up but i'm going
to show you how i'm going to do this and
hopefully it will actually work so i'm
not talking a bunch of nonsense here
all right so for this solution i had to
turn off the camera
i didn't realize that we'd be dealing
with recursion here until i looked at
this problem
but a trick that you can use for
recursion and just to kind of explain
this code just at a high level and again
you don't need to understand
exactly how it's working because
recursion is a very tough subject but
basically what we're doing is we you
know go through this code which i
explained a little bit earlier and this
is going to give us our multiplication
value
and then
for recursion where we're you know
calling the function multiple times on
itself
you need a stop condition okay so the
stop condition is
when multiplication value is not
greater or equal to 10. so basically in
this
else return
and what we're doing here when we say
return 1 plus the
persistence what it's doing is
it's this is just a trick of recursion
and if you read up on
how recursive functions work in
javascript you'll see this notation
right here
but basically what we're doing is we
know that
if the stop condition is met then we
return the value of one
otherwise we're going to keep calling
the persistence function until we reach
that so if we add 1 to the return value
of each iteration or recursion then
we're going to accumulate a total value
of how many times we went through this
so again this is a little bit confusing
it was really confusing to me i had to
brush up on recursion a little bit to
solve this problem but basically this is
i think the best solution that you're
going to find for this problem so let's
go ahead and attempt it we passed all of
them so let's see how other people
solved it maybe there's a way to do this
without recursion
but nevertheless this is probably the
most efficient solution
okay so actually the first solution
might be more simple than
um what we used here
so this doesn't use any sort of
recursion at all this is simply
using the reduce method kind of as we
had used so we we did this exact thing
but it's looping through while the the
num num counter is greater than one so
and then it uses this times variable to
kind of collect the number of times that
we've gone through this
this one right here
this is
like this is as concise
of a solution as you could possibly get
this is basically what we did
it's a little bit syntactically
compressed so you have a lot of little
javascript tricks going in here but you
can see the where we do one plus the
persistence function so we're recursing
over it so that would be the most clever
solution as you can see here
but once again recursion is a very tough
subject i wouldn't expect
any beginner that's watching this to
really understand how to do that but of
course you could have solved it this way
which didn't require recursion like i
used
okay so we're on a 7 kyu
problem which should be a little bit
easier so let's see if that's the case
it says atm machines allow 4 or 6 digit
pin codes and pin codes cannot contain
anything but exactly four digits or
exactly six digits if the function is
past a valid pin string return true else
return false
so this one looks pretty easy we're
going to be using regular expressions
here
so this is exactly four digits
this is four digits but it's
alphanumeric so there's a letter in here
so it's not valid
so this one should be pretty easy we can
go over here to actually look
at these
regular expressions a little bit
so let's say that we have a string
and the string is
four digits here
and then we want to
match that against a regular expression
of some sort so if we want to do that
we're looking for numbers between 0 or 9
and we want
either 4
or 6 so the way we can do that is we can
basically i think
i think we can just wrap this in a
parenthesis
and then repeat it with an or
and then instead of 4 we pass in 6 here
so let's see if that works if we add in
one more it should not match it but if
we add in two more it should
um no so that's not working we could
just separate this into multiple regular
expressions because i can't remember
exactly how to do this
for both of them
so in this case we're looking for any
number so this will exclude letters
automatically
in a quantity of exactly four
and we could be even more specific by
saying the start of the line and
end of the line with the dollar sign
and basically if we're matching this
then we're good so if we come up with
anything here now if we put in
uh five of them we're going to get an
answer of null so we know that if we get
an answer of null then it's not correct
so let's go ahead and just write two
regular expressions so we'll say
four digits
regular expression is going to be equal
to
what we just wrote here so let's just
paste that in
and then we can come down here and say
six digits regular expression and just
change this right here to a six so we're
either matching all numbers uh in a
quantity of four or all numbers
in a quantity of six
so we can basically return you know if
both of these are null that means that
we didn't match either of them so the
answer is false but if either of them
are true so they have a you know they're
not null then we can return true so
let's say we want to return
um
four digits
right regex
um and we have we actually have to match
this up against the pin code so let's do
that real quick
so we'll say result one
equals and then if you remember you can
take the string pin number
um i'm not sure if it is a string
okay so it's passed a string value so
we're good so we'll say uh pin dot match
and then we'll pass in the four digits
regular expression
and then we might want to look for
result number two
and pass in the
six six digits regular expression
so here's what we can say we can say
return
result one dot length is greater than
zero
or no because if it's null then
we don't have an array that we can check
that on
so basically we can say
if
result 1
equals null
and result 2 equals null
then we want to return false
otherwise we want to return true because
we matched one of them so null values
default to falsy values so we can
actually remove this and say
if
not result
and not result 2.
and you can see that it passed
now we can simplify this even further
so if we say
let's see
if we just return this expression
can't spell so if we're saying
if
both of these are equal to null then we
return false so let's see if that works
it may actually be the opposite
yeah so it's it's going to be the
opposite let's see
so all we have to do is reverse this by
wrapping it in
parentheses kind of reversing the result
and this time it should pass so
this is a decent solution but i
guarantee you there's going to be
solutions that are a little simpler than
this where we don't have two different
regular expressions there's definitely
going to be a solution where we have a
single regular expression that checks
for both of them and i'll point that out
when we get there
okay so this one would be the best one
the backslash d represents the digits so
that's the same thing as our brackets
and then zero to nine and you can see
that it's doing the same thing that i
was kind of trying to do i must have
just messed up part of the syntax there
but it's just testing against this
regular expression so
um that's basically
um the best solution and this is the one
i'd recommend using if you had the time
to actually figure out how to write the
regular expression that covers both
cases
now this is another regular expression
this one should be even easier
because it's 8 kyu so it says your task
is simply to count the total number of
lowercase letters in a string
okay so let's take one of these
complicated ones here and just take it
into our
little sandbox that we've been using
so i'll paste that into the string
and we'll start over with our regular
expression
so in this case we're counting the
number of results that we have so we
probably want to pass in the global flag
to our regular expression so put that at
the end
and then we want to look for a through z
lowercase letters
and
that's basically going to give us our
answer i believe
so if we just pass in a through z and
then we pass in this global so if we
take this off it's just going to match
the first lowercase letter but if we put
it back on it will give us all of them
so that's pretty much all we're having
to do here and then we just need to
count the length of the array so let's
do that
we will just say return
string.match and then we'll pass in
lowercase a to lowercase z
we'll pass in the global option and then
we'll return the length of that array
looks like we failed one of them
so
cannot read property length of null so
in this case there's probably
no array that we're getting right so if
there's nothing
if there's no lowercase letters we're
not going to get a valid array and you
can see that here if we were to take out
all of these lowercase letters you're
going to get a value of null
so we need to handle that instead of
just tacking on the length we have to
first check whether it is a truthy value
so let's see how we can do this kind of
simply
so we can use a ternary operator to do
this
so if we if we um
basically say if this is a valid
expression so as long as this does not
equal null then we're going to get put
into
this part of the ternary operator so
let's go ahead and save the result
so the result is going to be equal to
our regular expression
evaluation
and then we're going to say if the
result
is a truthy value then we're going to
return result.length and otherwise we're
going to return
false or something like that let's see
what it says in the instructions
okay so if there's nothing we want to
return zero so sorry about that it
shouldn't be false it should be zero
all right so we passed it this time
let's just clean that up and attempt it
cool
so this one was rather simple a little
bit easier than our previous regular
expression and again as i said in the
lesson you don't need to necessarily
know like all of the details about
writing regular expressions it's just
good to be able to read them and that's
why i wanted to go through this as an
example
so the next one we're doing is going to
look at some basic dates and this one is
asking is the date equal to today
so it says write a simple function that
takes a parameter as a date object
or
takes as a parameter a date object and
returns a boolean value representing
whether the date is today or not okay so
this last part is basically just telling
us like hey there is um going to be you
know the 10th of january and the 10th of
february so you can't just look at
the day of the month which um we will
look at but not exclusively
so
let's just make a bunch of variables
here so our
check day
so this will be the date that we're
passed we can just use the get date
method that's going to give us the day
of the month
all right so check month is going to be
date dot get month i believe
we can go to the date methods so if we
go to
the mdn documentation go to built in
objects and go to date
you'll see that we have the get month
method
the get full year method and the get
date method now you might say get day
but this is the day of the week not the
day of the month so we need get date
instead
so this will be day
or this will be month of year
and then
this is zero indexed so that's important
to remember so january is going to be
zero
and then
the check year is going to be the date
dot get full year
all right and then
our
date today is going to be very similar
so let's just copy all this code down
here
and we'll say today
instead of check
and then we'll replace all this with
um
the actual current date so
today is going to be equal to a new date
that's how we initialize it and then we
can pass this in here in
place of the date
so then we just return
check day
equals
today day
and all the other ones match so let's
just write that out
all right so it's a little bit of a long
expression but it should work
all right so we passed it
now the quickest way to do this
it looks like
is this solution so what are they doing
here so they're creating a new date
converting it to a date string
and checking if that is equal to the
date that was supplied
to date string
i actually didn't know that you could do
that because this will give you
different times
but i guess it matches if you have
uh different times of the day so let's
just try that real quick in our
console just to see if it's true so
we'll set a to a date and then we'll set
b to a date
and then see if b equals a which is
false so if you go
obviously those are not going to be
equal because the value of the date is
milliseconds since whatever january 1st
1970 at midnight
but if we convert it to string so
tostring
and then try it with b.2 string
that's going to give you a false value
too so i'm not sure what's going on here
oh to a date string okay
that's what that's where we went wrong
we're using two date string
so that should work now
okay so that equals true so let's take a
look at that
method on our documentation so it says
two
string which is not some not one of them
that we covered in our lessons which is
why we didn't use it here
but it says this returns the date
portion of the date object
so that's basically going to strip off
the time
and check if it's the same day so that's
a good solution didn't think of that but
that's a lot more concise that than what
we did
this is what we did we just checked it
up against
all the different methods that we had
covered in our lessons
all right so let's go to the
next
challenge
and this is alternate capitalization
given a string capitalize the letters
that occupy even indexes and odd indexes
separately and return as shown below
index 0 will be considered even
okay so we're going to return basically
two strings for each
argument here
the input's always going to be lowercase
with no spaces okay
okay to solve this we first need to get
this into an array so we need string to
be into an array and then we'll
capitalize them separately and then
we'll combine them back into a string
and assign them to different array
values
so how that's going to look
let's see
we will say array is equal to string dot
split
and we're going to split it by an empty
string which will just separate all of
the characters by a comma
all right so if we just did that and
console.logged it
here's what we're going to get
here's our string right here so we've
got all of each letter
broken out and we know that we have to
take this array and we need to
capitalize it in two different ways
so we'll just say
array one is going to be
string.split and then we will also have
array two
and then we're going to loop through
these arrays so array one dot four each
and we'll say for each item then we also
probably want the index
because we got to figure out if it's
even or odd
and then we'll say array 2 but let's not
do that quite yet we'll just figure this
one out first
so for array 1 we want to check
if the index is we'll say even so this
will be
even
capitalization can't spell here
all right so if it's even that would
include zeros
so how do we find out if a number is
even well we could use the modulus 2
operator so if we came to our
little playground here
in the console
and we said okay 0 modulus 2 is going to
be 0.
1 modulus 2 is going to be 1.
2 modulus 2 will be 0 and 3 modulus 2
will be 1. so basically anything modulus
2 that returns us with 0 is going to be
even
everything else is going to be odd so
that's all we have to do here we'll say
if the index
modulus 2
equals 0 then it's even
and for that case we'll say array 1 at
the index that we're looking at
and then we want to set that to
uppercase
okay so we've got array 1 completed and
let's go ahead and console.log that and
see if we did it correctly
and we didn't do this correctly i don't
know what i was actually thinking here
we already have the array item
so
we just need to take the item and make
it uppercase i think
okay so we have a problem here we're
trying to modify the actual item which
is not going to modify the original
array
i just realized that so if you go to the
array methods
and go to javascript built-in objects
and go to array
you're going to see if we look at the
for each method which is right here
the callback function takes the current
value the index and the array
so we want to actually grab this third
parameter and modify it within our
problem here so we'll pass in the item
index and then the original
array and in this case we'll take the
original array
we'll pass in the index of that and then
we'll set that equal to the item.2 upper
case
so i believe this one should work now
we'll see
and you'll see that we did capitalize
the first so that's even lower case on
the second upper case on the third
so that should be working
and i believe
we did that right but let's check one
time
so capulet capitalize the letters that
occupy even indexes index 0 will be
considered even ok so we did that
correctly so array 1 is done and then we
can basically just do this again for
odd capitalization
change this to array two
and then instead of saying when it's
equal to zero we'll say when it's not
equal to zero
and then we just need to return
a final array and we pass an array 1 and
array 2
and i think that should get us to an
answer
maybe we did this in the wrong order
let's see
oh i'm sorry i'm not doing this
correctly so our arrays are
um
split out into individual letters so we
have to convert those back to strings so
let me do that real quick
um array one string is going to be array
one
um and then join by
an empty string which will
actually
yeah i believe by an empty string which
will join them all together and then we
can do the same thing for array
2 string
pass in array 2
and then we will return those like this
and see what we get
all right so we passed them this time
let's just open this up and review what
we did
so as you see we're going to first take
these
strings and turn them into an array so
if we go back here if we have some sort
of string and then we say split and we
use a empty character it's going to put
it all into an array
then we go and we loop through that
existing array with the for each method
and we know that the callback function
that we're using is going to pass the
item that we're looking at
the index of that item and then the
original array that we can actually
modify within that loop and that's we
knew this because we looked at the
documentation here
otherwise
you probably would have to do just a
regular for loop which acts a little bit
different than a four each
so anyways we're going through and we're
asking if the index is
modulus 2 equals 0 which indicates it's
an even number and when it
equals an even number we take our
original array we pass in the index into
the brackets to grab the item and we set
that equal to
the item itself in uppercase form and
then for the odd capitalization we just
basically do the opposite
if modulus 2 does not equal 0 then we
want to make it uppercase then finally
we join those back together so um if we
go to this array here so we split them
into an array and then if we add join
with an empty character it just joins
them back together to the original
string but we've obviously capitalized a
few of them in the middle so we join
them back together and then we just
place them in a new array and return
that array and that should give us the
answer
okay i think this is getting to the end
one of our last ones here if not the
last one
it says given a number return the
maximum number that could be formed from
the digits of the number given only
natural numbers pass to the function
numbers contain digits 0 through 9
inclusive
digit duplications could occur so also
consider it when forming the largest
okay
so that's a good hint for us to remember
here's an example so
three goes first two goes second and one
goes third that makes sense that's the
maximum number that we could form
okay
so basically we have to take our number
and we have to order it from greatest to
least
so i think a good way to do that is we
might have to convert it into an array
possibly
so basically what this is asking us to
do if we think about it
you know all these numbers are going to
be in
the
descending order so you have the largest
one first and so basically what this is
asking us to do is sort an array because
we know that we can take this number
convert it to a string and then separate
that out into an array and if we can
just sort that array then
we got the answer
but the sort method does not do it
correctly when we have numbers here so
let's just type it in to google
this is just an algorithm so sort
array
numerically
in javascript and we'll see what the
answers are
so it says how to sort an array of
integers correctly
and let's see
okay so we can just use the sort
function we actually can use it we have
to pass in
a callback um that will compare the two
numbers so
um let's see
the sort method takes a compare function
okay so i was just reading this
incorrectly so we can take a call back
and look at the compare function and
return the greatest number so let's go
ahead and do that uh just practice real
quick
so let's say that we have an array of
numbers so 2
6 3 1
and we want to sort that
so we will pass in our single num
and then we want to say let's see
what does it pass into this callback so
let's look the first element and the
second element is what it's going to
pass in there
so if we go to our
little playground here it's not just one
number but we'll have
the first and second element
and so if the
second element is greater than the first
then we'll return true i believe so
let's see how it did it in this stack
overflow answer it says return a minus b
so
actually it's the other way around so if
a is greater than b
we return
that as true and then that's going to
actually sort our array for us
so let's test that out real quick
we just want to return first minus
second
and now we have it sorted in ascending
order i wonder if we take it second
minus first
okay so that's going to do it in
descending order so we want to do second
minus first for our problem here
all right so the first thing we need to
do is get this into a string
so
we're just going to try to do this all
in one line because
it'll help us kind of visualize chaining
the methods together
so we're going to return
n
to string
okay so that converts it to a string
and then we want to split it into an
array
now we've got it into an array of
numbers here
and then we want to sort it and pass in
the first number
first number and second number and then
we want to return
second minus first
okay and then that's going to give us
a sorted array of numbers
so maybe we won't do this um
let's just store this in a result
for now and then console.log that result
and see what we have so far
so we'll test that
and you'll see that it prints the
console a descending order of that array
now we know that we can take an array of
numbers and we can actually
just combine those together with join
so maybe that's all we need to do we
just
at the end here so hold on one second
let's return this again
or no let's not do that let's keep it in
the result and then at the end here i'm
going to
break out
for a second and we can actually
put these down onto
separate lines
so we'll say dot split
dot sort
and then
the last thing that we want to do is
we've got it in the descending
array so then we can join it back
together as a string
and that's going to give us one big
number
and then we need to just convert that to
a number and all we have to do is add a
plus sign at the beginning to do that
so now let's see what our result equals
looks like we're getting the correct
number here
so all we have to do is return this
result now so we don't even need to
store it in a variable we can just
return it and let's see how it works
looks like we passed everything and
again this is just some indentation it
doesn't really matter how you do this
we're just chaining all these methods
together and you could certainly have
broken that out into separate steps
so let's attempt it looks like we passed
everything and see what
others use to solve this problem
okay so this person
did not pass in a sort callback they
just
passed in no
no function whatsoever and that's going
to default to ascending order as you saw
up here so it says
the default sort order is ascending so
here they're going to split it into an
array then they're going to sort it to
ascending then they're going to use the
reverse array method to make it
descending and then they're going to
join it together and then wrap it in a
number which we did by adding the plus
at the beginning
of the entire expression so you can see
i believe yeah this one right here is
the exact solution that we used
so pretty good i'm pretty happy with
that one
and with that i think we are done with
these problems
hopefully you learned a little bit i
know some of these were
more complicated and challenging than
you would expect for a beginner and
certainly when we talked about recursion
there for a little bit that's getting a
little bit over the pay grade of someone
just starting out but it is an important
topic to explore and kind of understand
it definitely will come up in some sort
of coding interview if you're doing
those
but yeah hopefully you enjoyed this
if you
care to drop a like on this video i'd
really appreciate it subscribe to the
channel for future lessons
um and hit me up on twitter i'm at zg
underscore dev uh tell me what you
thought of this video and um how the
challenges went for you
all right so i will see you in the next
lesson i believe that is lesson seven
this is an html crash course and i'm
really excited to walk you through it
and i want to show you exactly what
we're going to build over the next
couple of videos
so here is our ultimate challenge that
we're trying to create and what this
does is you've got a bunch of buttons
here on the right where we can click
them
and a random meme is going to be shown
to the screen or you can have a joke
displayed on the screen a quote
or a riddle where you're going to get
the riddle and then you have to reveal
the answer here
so this is going to be a really fun
project but before we get into it we
have to learn a little bit about html
now you'll notice that it's styled
pretty nicely and this actually has some
css in it but we're not going to be
covering that in
this lesson number seven of the series
in the prior lessons of this series
we've been talking a lot about
javascript and basically how to program
in general now we're going to jump into
html and then in the next
lesson series we're going to jump into
css and we're ultimately going to
complete our introduction to front-end
web development before we dive into the
details of html i want to start with a
little bit of an analogy that will help
us
kind of going forward in this crash
course and then also the css one in the
next lesson
so that analogy is building a house if
you are building a house you basically
have three steps first you have to build
the structure so that would be the wood
the concrete the brick the roofing all
that kind of stuff
then you have to set up the function of
the house so that would be the plumbing
the electric the water lines all of that
kind of stuff has to go into the house
to make it functional and then finally
the third step is to make it look good
you obviously don't want to build a
house that doesn't look good you want to
paint it correctly and you want to do
some landscaping around it put some
siding on it
all of that stuff is very important for
the market value of the house so if our
house was a website
the structure would be the html now
the function
the electric the plumbing all that kind
of stuff would be the javascript and
then the styling so the the paint and
the landscaping that would be the css
now you could live in your house with
just the structure or the html
you wouldn't have any function so you
wouldn't have running water you wouldn't
have heat or anything that makes a house
livable but you certainly could live
in that house and you'd have a roof over
your head now
if you add in the function you could
live with just that too so you know add
in the electric and the plumbing and now
you've got a house that is functioning
but one that is not worth that much if
you went to try and sell it because you
haven't painted it you haven't put
landscaping around it and you haven't
made it look attractive to another buyer
so that's where the css comes in that's
where the styling comes in so ultimately
the goal of this analogy is to say that
html is the only true requirement of a
web page
but if you want it to do anything useful
you got to add some javascript and if
you want to
make it presentable to other people your
users you have to add in the css so
that's just a nice analogy to remember
how everything relates to each other and
how html css and javascript play nicely
together to create a full user
experience on the web while these all
work together we're going to be skipping
the css part in this lesson so like i
said we've learned a lot about
javascript in the prior
couple of lessons of this full stack
roadmap series
and now we're going to learn about html
so we're basically going to be focusing
only on those two how do they interact
and just as a hint it's going to be a
big conversation about something called
the document object model or the dom and
that's basically the model that
represents the html and allows us to
plug our
javascript into that html and make it
functional but at this point we're
getting too detailed we'll get there in
a second first we need to understand
what is html how does it work and how do
we write it the first thing that we have
to ask is what is html and it stands for
hypertext markup language and despite
the last word language it's generally
not considered a full-on programming
language like something
like javascript that we've been working
with before
it's something that allows you to
structure
your text and all different components
that you're going to put on a web page
but it's not a full-on programming
language you can't add in a whole lot of
logic behind the scenes and make things
dynamic without adding in that
javascript now there's a ton to talk
about with html but similar to how i've
been handling other concepts within this
series i'm not trying to get into
absolutely everything and do a super
deep dive into it my goal here is to get
you exposed and learning the most
essential concepts of html those things
that you absolutely have to know to
build web applications
i think a great place to start is to
understand the overall structure of an
html document so something you have to
understand is that every browser tab
that you have open
is going to have one and only one html
document is what we call it
within it so that one document follows a
standard you know boilerplate is what we
call it structure and that structure is
what i'm going to put on the screen
right here this is going to be the most
basic way to write an html document now
everything within those html tags we
call these tags
um is going to define the whole document
and then within that document you have a
head tag which has a site title so if
you look up into the browser tab
you know the the name that you see
within that browser tab is defined by
that title within the head
and then there's other things that go in
the head of the html document some
things like
different style sheets uh meta tags all
that kind of stuff that we're not going
to get too much in detail with in this
lesson
now what we're going to be focusing on
is everything within that body tag so
that's going to represent the bulk of
your html document and it's going to
represent the stuff that you're actually
seeing on that web page
well the thing that i have up on the
screen right now is going to represent
the most basic form of an html document
there is a more standard boilerplate
that you're probably going to see so i'm
going to put that up right now
so this boilerplate html document
pretty much has everything that you
need to learn in html css and javascript
i'm not going to go through absolutely
everything that you're seeing here but i
do want to cover a few things that are
very important we're not going to
actually get into writing these
but if you'll notice you see within the
head you see this link tag and you'll
see that it
references something called a style
sheet and then it gives a file that is
passed in
so this is actually called a css
document and that's going to be fed into
the html to actually style it if you
look further down in this document
you're going to see a script tag which
represents the javascript that is
connected to the html and gives it
function now in our case we're going to
be working in an environment called
codepen so what i've got up on the
screen is a basic codepen document i
suggest that you create an account it's
free and you'll be using it throughout
this specific lesson on html
so if you look on the left side you see
html css and javascript now going back
to that boilerplate that i just showed
on the screen this is basically a
beginner-friendly way to write that so
codepen has already taken care of
connecting everything up so the css and
the javascript are automatically
connected to the html
and within this html area this is
actually going to be what we're filling
in to the body so you know how i talked
about there's the the whole html
document and then you have the head and
the body
well this represents the body and you
can just assume that css and javascript
are all connected up and ready to go
with this i'm going to be using this
codepen
playground because it's going to be a
very user-friendly way to explain what
html is all about later in the series
we'll talk about writing our html css
and javascript in our own local
environment but as we've been doing with
the javascript earlier in the series
using the browser
devtools console this is kind of the
same deal we're going to just get into
an environment that's easy to use right
off the bat like i said html represents
hypertext markup language and it only
has a few
key things that you have to understand
about it what we're going to be focusing
on a lot in this html crash course are
two things so number one we are going to
be talking about html tags
and number two we're going to be talking
about html attributes so what do i mean
by those well let's take a look at this
code pen
and you'll see that we can write a basic
html tag
by using these little brackets here so
this is this happens to be a paragraph
tag
um represented by p
and within it you have this these little
brackets here so
the
the tag itself is enclosed in the
brackets
and then between it this is where we put
some text that we want to display in the
browser
and you'll see that once it renders we
have some text
displaying within the code
codepen browser
alright so the end of this is going to
be what we call the closing tag and
you'll notice that we have this forward
slash before the tag itself so i'm going
to put up on the screen a basic diagram
that gives you the anatomy of an html
element so if we're breaking it down you
basically have an opening tag then you
have one or more attributes that you
have defined for that specific element
then you have the content that you put
within the element which can be just
text or it can be other html elements in
certain cases we'll talk about that in a
second and then finally you close it off
with a closing html tag so you might be
wondering you know what is this whole
attribute thing about you'll see you
know in that diagram that i put up we've
got a class attribute which just happens
to be one of many attributes that we can
define for an html element in this case
the attribute we're talking about is a
class attribute we're going to talk more
about the different types you can use
but in this case a class attribute
directly relates to kind of identifying
the element with css now we're not going
to be talking a whole lot about css in
this lesson but i do want to show you
just the basics
of what this attribute is doing
so we might say some class
defined within this class attribute and
then we can come down into the css and
define that and then we can maybe give
it a different color and now the text up
here is going to be red
so that's what we're doing with this
attribute but that doesn't mean that all
attributes relate to css we also can
have attributes that are totally
unrelated to css so for example
if we wanted to add an image tag
here and we're going to talk about this
a little bit more later so don't worry
about the syntax here yet
we can define something called a source
attribute so this source attribute is
going to actually give us
the image url that we want to display
within that image tag so let me get an
image to put in there real quick and
i'll show you what i mean all right so
i'm going to put a dog image in here
just as i normally do so we'll paste
that in there and now you should see
once it reloads a very large picture
here so we're going to use another
attribute that i just know from
experience about we can put a width
property on here and maybe define it to
about 300 pixels so that it's much
smaller and we can see the image
all right so again you should not
understand you know the the p tag and
the image tag
you don't need to understand that quite
yet we're going to cover it in a second
but what i want to uh demonstrate here
is that these attributes can you know
serve a lot of different purposes
and they're ultimately the same thing
like you can think about them just like
javascript variables so just like we're
defining
some sort of you know variable here or
attribute and then assigning it some
value you can do the same thing in
javascript so you could define an
attribute and give it some value here
and that's the variable the javascript
variable that we are so used to working
with from the previous lessons so it's
kind of a similar concept but these you
know what we call variables or
attributes here
are specific to these html elements that
we are creating all right before we get
any further into these details that
you're not understanding quite yet
i want to talk about the difference
between an element so an html element
and an html tag
so when i think of an element i think of
it as a complete unit so it not only has
an html tag but it also might have some
attributes or maybe even some event
listeners we're going to talk about that
a little bit later too so let me write
out a full element real quick just like
we saw a second ago
so we'll say a paragraph
element and then we'll close it off with
our closing brackets so i think of this
as a complete unit and a full html
element and we can also add on some
attributes so maybe an id
is going to be p1 or something and then
we can add a class attribute now it
doesn't matter what attributes you're
putting here i'm just trying to
demonstrate this is a full html element
now if we're talking about tags
i like to think of those as the actual
indicator for what type of element we're
creating so in this case we're going to
put a p tag
indicated by the letter p right here so
as we move forward think of the tag as
the function or like what the element is
supposed to be doing and then the whole
element as a general structure of that
html the next thing i want to talk about
is the types of html tags that we can
use
so far we just looked at a paragraph tag
and an image tag but there are obviously
plenty more that we can use within our
html documents
so the first type of tag at least how i
categorize it there's plenty more
classifications that you'll find with
official documentation but just for our
brains to understand it
i think we can think about this in terms
of normal html elements and self-closing
html
elements or maybe tags would be a better
way to say that
so let me paste in a few of them here
these are all
you know different tags that we can use
so the p tag the h1 tag
div span and strong
and all of these are what we consider
kind of normal html tags because they
have an opening tag right here and then
a closing tag and then you put something
in the middle of them to actually create
the entire element so these are what we
consider normal now there are some other
html tags that have some different
behaviors where they're actually called
self closing and i'm going to paste a
few of those within our
code pen here
so let's get a rid of these
and now we're looking at self
self-closing tags and this would be
image input meta tags these go in the
head of the html document
link tags this is how we link up the
style sheets to our html
something that's going on behind the
scenes here so these are self-closing
which basically means
we have everything we need within the
single tag and we put this forward slash
at the end of it so
rather than doing this let me just give
you a very specific example here so
rather than saying image and then having
a closing tag and then putting something
between them that's not valid we just
have to
create one tag right here called image
and then put the forward slash at the
end of it to close it so
these are the two types of tags that
we're dealing with you'll start to
recognize them as you get more
experience writing html
i'll be sure to point them out as we go
now the reason that i talk about the
difference between you know normal and
self-closing tags is they have different
behaviors
so if you wanted to embed some content
within a normal element so let's take a
div
element which i just think of as kind of
a general purpose container that we can
use in html
and i can put some text in here it's
going to work just fine as you see on
the screen i can also enter down and put
in another html element
maybe a paragraph tag here and i can
embed html within that div tag all right
so that's a normal html element that has
an opening and closing tag but if we
tried to do this with something like an
image tag all right so this is a valid
way to write
an image and we of course need a source
attribute so let me see if i can get
another image here okay so let me get an
actual image in here uh so that this is
a valid image tag all right so it's
working on the right but what i want to
show you is that if you try to put
something within this tag so let's come
right here and try to put maybe a p
element in here
and we'll put some text right there
you're going to see that this is not
going to work
all that well so you'll see these weird
brackets here at the end and while the
overall image is working and you still
see some text
printed to the screen this is not valid
html to write this is
you know it'll render but it's not valid
so just remember as we write these
self-closing html elements you can't put
anything within them now a more subtle
difference that i want to point out you
know within these elements that we call
normal or the tags that we call normal
so for example a paragraph tag we've got
some text that we can put in there now
we can also put stuff within this but
does it make sense to do so and the
answer is probably not so if we have a
paragraph tag and we put some text in
here
and then we also try to put maybe
another paragraph
tag so we'll put some more text in there
this does not make a lot of sense to me
and it doesn't make sense in general
when you're writing html because
in general a tag such as the paragraph
tag is not meant to have elements um
embedded between it other than just
plain text
so there are some html elements that
have
these kind of container functionalities
and then there are some elements that
just are meant to store text and only
text so while we don't want to put you
know elements within a paragraph tag
if we just change this to a div
that's going to be more appropriate so
we can put you know as many other
elements within a div as we want to
because it's kind of structured and
meant to do something like that it's
kind of meant to be
a more of a container type
html tag all right so we've gone through
some of the nuances of you know what
type of html tags you're going to be
looking at
now in this next section i want to
actually walk through some of the most
common ones that you'll see and you'll
use not only that but i want to show you
how to actually inspect your html in the
browser
and also how do we look these different
tags up in our documentation
you know if you don't know what
something is or you don't know what it's
supposed to be used for you can go to
the documentation to figure it out like
i said there are a ton of html tags
that you can use and i'm not going to be
covering you know even half of them here
that's not the goal the goal here is to
get you the most essential ones and help
you understand how to find
um and use different tags without having
prior knowledge of them as we talked
about earlier html is not styled it's
all about structure so
if you look at this page i've got pulled
up on the screen you can see a bunch of
really ugly
web elements
and we're going to walk through each of
these very briefly just so that you can
kind of get the gist of them and i'll
show you you know for a couple of them
how we actually look them up in the
documentation and see what they're for
so just as a preview we've got some
content elements up here we've got
headings paragraph tags
then we come down into
some more content elements so we have
span elements which allow you to kind of
custom style this this actually has some
css within it
which we're not covering but
you can see how you can do things with
the paragraph tags and make it a little
bit more customized using span
and em and strong elements and then we
can also use uh images and links so a
would be a link
image and then buttons here so we got
buttons and then we have some list and
then finally tables like i said we're
not going to be covering that a whole
lot but this is just the landscape of
most of the elements that you'll be
using on a daily basis as a web
developer but before we jump into that i
want to show you exactly how we inspect
these now you'll notice i jumped over to
google chrome here
i'm using that for a very specific
reason that we'll kind of talk about a
little bit later in this lesson but it's
very similar to firefox all you have to
do is right-click and click inspect
and then from here
if you
rearrange this you'll see that the
elements panel is where you can actually
see the html within this document so if
we click down on the body you can see
all of these elements and every time we
hover over them it will actually you
know highlight it in the browser itself
alright so you can scroll down and just
basically see the source of this html
document
which is a great way to
understand it now i also have this
this exact document linked in a codepen
pen you can find that in the materials
in the description of this video so you
can just look through this on your own
time if i go through something a little
bit too fast here all right the first
ones we're going to be talking about the
first html tags are heading tags so that
is h1 through h6
now if we go to the documentation this
is i'm going to just go through this
exercise with you so that you can get
used to
doing this but we basically go to mdn we
go to technologies and click html
and then we can go down to the
references and click the html elements
from here
we can obviously go through and look for
all these different tags that we can use
and in this case we want the headings so
i'll click h1
and you can see
that it just has one page for h1 through
h6 because they're all so similar types
of elements
when you're on a documentation page it's
good to read this first sentence here
just glance at the demo but if you come
down to usage notes this is where you're
going to learn like what is this tag
actually for you know as we talked about
html is the structure of the web and
therefore every
tag that we're using has a very specific
purpose
so this one says heading information can
be used by user agents to construct a
table of contents for a document
automatically
alright so basically what that's saying
for us
is that we can
use the h1 through h6 to organize our
web pages so let's start with an h1
element
all right and we can give it a
page title all right so that's kind of
what h1 is used for when you go onto a
web page there's always going to be a
title of that you know blog post article
or just the page in general and usually
it's going to be h1 that's what google
searches for with the search engines so
a lot of seos will
you know recommend that you have this
uh
semantically laid out so that the h1
only occurs once on the page and then
you have everything else as h2 or even
smaller so we'll make some h2s here this
will be a secondary heading
and like i said this is going to lay out
your document
semantically based on the order of
importance of your text so i think you
probably get the point of this you can
do this for you know h3 all the way to
h6
not all that complicated so we're going
to just stop it right here but you kind
of get the point play around with this
and and
basically all i'll say about this is
that h1 through h3 is probably the
furthest you're going to go you might
use an h4 every once in a while but
generally those first three are
sufficient to build a web page next up
we have the paragraph tag which we've
already used a little bit
so if we come to
the mdn documentation
and we go back to our well let me just
go through the full process so we get
used to it so technologies html
html elements and then we can scroll
down and look for the relevant tag
so we'll come all the way down here to
the p tag
so it says the html p element represents
paragraph paragraphs are usually
represented in visual media as blocks of
text separated from adjacent blocks blah
blah blah a bunch of jargon here that we
don't really need to read too much about
this is basically what you're going to
see everywhere on the web so when you
read an article blog post most of the
text is going to be a paragraph element
and it's very simple to write as we saw
we can just put some text between the
opening and closing tags and you've got
yourself a paragraph element now while
we're here i want to
highlight something kind of important
with html and there are actually two
things so number one html is not case
sensitive so if we wanted to capitalize
one of these tags and then have
lowercase
tags over here on the end it's still
going to work just fine because html
doesn't care about capitalization
now it also does not care about line
breaks so if we had a couple elements
here
let's just make a couple
paragraph tags and we put a bunch of
spaces in here and we entered it down a
bunch
let's make some
enter down and some more spaces you'll
see that the output is going to be the
same no matter what and that's because
the spaces between the tags doesn't
matter whatsoever basically when it's
rendered in the web uh or in the browser
it's just looking for the opening and
closing tag and then it automatically
knows how to
lay that out on the page so it's not
case sensitive and these line breaks and
spaces do not matter between these
elements all right with that said we're
moving on to the next elements and that
would be
some other content elements that allow
you to
basically style your paragraphs but i
will say that as we talk about semantic
html
the whole goal of the new html5 standard
which is the latest spec similar to when
we talked about javascript in previous
lessons how there's the ecmascript
standard
in es6 all that kind of stuff well
there's also an html spec that is
supposed to be followed and in the
latest one the goal is to basically use
html for structure and
function only so instead of using html
to actually style elements you're
supposed to use only css to do that that
said you will see these tags i'm about
to show you uh quite often in old code
and people still use them
so you need to know what they are and
what they do
so let's write a paragraph tag right
here
some text that i want to
emphasize and make bold
and styled alright so these words are
going to be manipulated by other html
elements and as i said earlier a p tag
is generally not something you want to
embed other html elements within so
like i said you probably do not want to
put another p tag within a p tag and put
text in there but there are a couple
exceptions and
they relate to the
strong emphasis and span elements
so the first one it's going to we'll
look at is going to be span
so let's go ahead go back to the
documentation
go back to this
reference
and look for the span tag
okay so we'll click span
and it says this element is a generic
inline container for phrasing content
which does not inherently
represent anything it can be used to
group elements for styling purposes or
because they share
attribute values
so on and so forth so basically what
that is saying is if you want something
an html element that's not going to
break down to a new line it's just going
to be in line with the rest of the text
but you want it to look a little bit
different or function a little bit
different than the rest of it you might
use a span tag
so an example of that we'll wrap this
last word
styled within a span tag
alright and as of right now you see that
it is red the reason this is red is
because behind the scenes i didn't tell
you this but i wrote some css that will
take any span element and turn it the
color red using css so if i open this up
you'll see that i
said for every span element i want the
color to be red
now i don't expect you to understand
what that css is saying yet we're going
to cover that in the next lesson but
basically that's the point of a span is
you can take a single you know piece of
text within a paragraph tag and you can
emphasize it in whatever way you want
using css
similar to a span we also have the
strong and em or emphasize
tags
so let's take a look at those in the
documentation
let's go to the em tag this is
it marks text
that has emphasis so basically italics
is what it's saying
and then if we go to the strong tag
down here this indicates that its
contents have strong importance
seriousness or urgency which is another
way of saying bold so like i said this
in the new html standard you probably
should not use these
tags but i'm showing you them because
you'll see them often people still use
them and they are valid html
so if i wanted to emphasize this word
or in other words make it italic i can
surround it with these
with this em tag and you'll see that
this one word is now italicized
now we can also make a word bold by
wrapping it with the strong tag
and now this will be a bold word
so as you can see we can use these
different html elements to actually
style our html but again not recommended
i would go ahead and use the best
practices and style these with css
instead and i know you're probably
wondering what the heck that means and
basically all that means is instead of
using the em tag we might put in a span
here for the emphasis
all right and now that this is
um
wrapped in a span
we can change the css so right now it's
just making everything the color red but
if we wanted to put an attribute in each
of these so we'll put a class and we'll
say
red
color so for for this span it's going to
be a red color
let me make this a little bit bigger and
then for this span we'll put an
attribute in there or a class
called italics all right and now we can
come down in the css
let me delete all of this so down here
in the css i can basically look at
elements that have these specific
classes
again i'm sorry for getting too much
into this but i really want to show you
what this what i mean when i say you
should style it with css rather than the
em and strong tags so what we can do is
we can select that class in css and then
we can basically say the font style
should be italic all right and once we
do that you'll see that this word is
emphasized with italics again but this
time instead of using the em element
we're using a span with some css styles
now we can also come down and select the
red color class and just give it a color
equal to red and now you can see that
we're back to the original style that we
had so again we're not covering css too
much in this lesson but i do want to
show you how it's working with the html
in unison
all right so the next elements that we
got to talk about
i think a big one is going to be the div
element now this is going to be one that
you use all the time and it's very
important and i consider it to be just a
general container element but let's look
it up in the documentation
and there's our div tag all right so
this is called an html content division
element
and it's a generic container for flow
content so like i said it's just like a
generic container that we can basically
separate out pieces of our html
and you know the the most important
thing about it is we can
take each of these individual units that
are within a specific div and then we
can style it so very similar to that
span element where we're taking a
individual piece of text and we're
making it look different than the others
we can also use some css magic along
with this html structure to separate out
our content so let me show you what i
mean by that
so let's say that we have
two div containers
all right and then within these we have
some elements
in container one all right and we'll
just make a bunch of those and then
we'll do the same thing for elements
within container two
so right now on the screen these don't
look separated at all you know you
basically
look at this and say like oh it's all
just one big piece together but since we
wrapped these within div elements we can
actually put some styles on here to
separate them out and like i said you're
not going to understand how these styles
are working quite yet
we'll do that in the next lesson but i
do want to show you how the div is able
to separate out our content so the first
one we need to identify by div one just
an arbitrary class name that we're
giving it and then div two
all right so what we're going to do is
we're going to make some boxes around
these so all we have to do is select
both of them and give them a border
all right and from here you can see that
now we're getting some separation of our
html elements and we can even put some
margin around there
and now it's going to be very apparent
that we have two very separate sections
of our html document and that is the
power of a div and you'll be using these
div elements to section out your content
all the time the next element we're
going to talk about or not element but
tag is going to be the a tag which
represents a link in html
let's take a look in the documentation
again just as a recap technologies html
html elements and then you can click a
so this is actually called the anchor
element that's what what a stands for
and it says with its href attribute
creates a hyperlink to web pages files
email addresses locations on the same
page where anything else a url can
address
all right so
an anchor tag or link tag is going to
require this single attribute called the
href attribute now
with html
tags most of them do not have required
attributes but with a couple of them
there are some required attributes this
happens to be one of them
so if we were to come into our html as
we have it here and maybe we wanted to
make a link around some of these text
so what i'm going to do is make an a tag
surrounded by this first
container one text
and right now you'll see that nothing is
happening over here when i click it
there's nothing there but once i put in
that href attribute
and i put in a link so we'll say
www.google.com
now you'll see that we have this link
styling and if we click this
it should take us to the appropriate
link now one weird thing about codepen
since it's kind of like an integrated
environment that we can write html css
and javascript
when you have link tags within a code
pen you can't click on them and actually
go
outside of codepen so i've actually
pulled up
let's let's actually look at the
local file that i have so this is what i
was showing you how to navigate around
the different elements
and if we go down to where i have the
link example right here so let's go
ahead and click this
button up here to select a specific
element and then i can click on that and
it takes me there on the right side and
you can see that i have this a or anchor
tag
with the href
attribute right here representing my
my personal website
all right so when i click this
it's going to take me directly to my
website and that's how an anchor element
is going to work now there's one
additional thing that we can add to an
anchor element to affect the behavior of
the link
so if we were to go in here and we can
actually edit
html directly within the dev tools
and if we put
a attribute called target
and then we give it an underscore blank
value so if we were to go to the
documentation to see this
you'll see that there's a couple
attributes available here
href being one of them but if you go
down you can see there's a target
attribute
and it gives you the possible values
that you can put in there and it says
where to display the linked url as a
name for a browsing context so basically
it's saying where do i need to open this
link and if we go to blank it says
usually a new tab
and that's exactly what's going to
happen once i put in this target equals
blank and i click this link it's opening
a brand new tab rather than taking me to
that link within the current tab like i
said there's other attributes on an
anchor element but those are probably
the most common two ones that you'll
need and the href attribute is actually
required to make it function as a link
at all the next one we're covering is
the input element and this one is loaded
with functionality especially when you
start putting it within a form element
alright so we're not going to talk a
whole lot about this because this comes
later in this series and we're going to
talk a lot about it in the context of
a front-end um web framework like react
or angular
vue.js
but i just want to introduce it to you
so
we'll go to input tag
we got to go back on the documentation
it actually has an entire section just
for input types and like i said there's
a lot going on here there's a lot to do
with forms within the web so let's open
up the normal html reference and go down
and find the input
all right so we'll click input
and it says it's used to create
interactive controls for web-based forms
in order to accept data from a user and
that's pretty much where we're going to
stop because that's all that we need to
know for now i'm just going to show you
a couple basic
attributes that you can use with this
and just give you the general concept of
what it is
so let's go to the
page we're working with here
and let me just clear out everything and
put an input tag now this is going to be
a self closing tag we talked about that
earlier just like an image tag is
and within this input you'll see that we
already have something showing up here
on the right that we can
type some text into so right off the bat
it's usable but if we just left it like
this and we tried to hook up some
javascript to it it'd be very difficult
to
select it and grab the data that the
user's typing in
from it
so something that we'll often do is give
an input a name and this is very
important when you put this within a
form so it can identify which input
it needs to grab data from so we'll just
say this will be input 1 and then
another thing that you can put another
attribute you can put is going to be a
placeholder
and this placeholder is going to be
whatever shows up in kind of a grayed
out
text to indicate to the user what they
need to type so we can say enter email
address here
and you'll see that this placeholder
gets put in there and then once you
start typing it goes away so that's a
very common element or attribute that
you can use for the input tag now you
can also put a predefined value in there
so instead of a placeholder if we were
to put
value it's going to replace that
placeholder with an actual value so you
can see how there's text already in here
and if you wanted to change it you'd
have to delete it and then type some new
text so those are some of the common
attributes that you can use for inputs
and again i'm not going to cover inputs
in very much detail at all right now
because we're going to talk about them a
lot later in the series next up we're
going to be talking about image
tags and we've already looked at it a
little bit
so let's go to
our html elements reference and then
look for the image tag there it is
all right so the image element embeds an
image into the document all right and
there's going to be a couple common
attributes that you'll use for this and
there's one that is required
so the source attribute is required as
you can see in the documentation
and then the alt attribute is highly
recommended so when we're talking about
web accessibility and we're talking
about
you know how do we know what this image
represents if it doesn't render
correctly
that's going to be what the alt
attribute does so i'll show you exactly
what what i'm talking about here let's
write our image tag which is self
closing
and then from here we're not going to
see anything because we don't have our
required source attribute now let's go
back to this dog photo
we'll put in the source attribute and
paste in the link to that photo
and it's of course going to be very
large here because the image is much
larger than our page here
but we can also add in an additional
attribute
and
a quick tip with html you can actually
enter these down
so it doesn't have to you know all be on
one line we can separate out the
different attributes from the tags so
we'll go with source first and then
we'll put in another common one which
will be with
so you can also specify this within css
but this would be a quick way to
make the width of this image 300 pixels
all right so that gives us a more
manageable image to work with and then
finally we have the alt attribute so
we'll say a dog image or something like
that to describe what our image is all
about
and the reason we use this is because if
our link is broken so if i just break
the link real quick
you're going to see when it reloads that
it's going to give this little image
icon and then whatever we put in the alt
attribute it'll say a dog image so if
the link ever breaks the user will know
like oh this is supposed to be a dog
image and i kind of know
what the context of this image is and
then finally one of my favorite content
elements is going to be button alright
so this is what we get to click and do
fun things with
so how we write this is you we just
basically write out button it's a normal
you know opening and closing tag type of
element
let's take a look in the documentation
real quick
go to html elements and we'll find the
button element
it says it represents clickable button
used to submit forms or anywhere in a
document for accessible standard button
functionality alright so we click
buttons all the time when we use web
apps and it basically brings our web
apps to life it allows the user to know
like okay i got to click this to do
something
so within our button we can give it some
text so we might say click me in all
caps
and you'll see that now we have a button
that we can click now it's not going to
do anything right off the bat because we
haven't hooked up any event listeners or
stuff like that to it now there's really
not any common attributes that you'll
see on a button like this
but there is one common thing that
you'll have to have for a button for it
to really do anything and that is a
event listener now we're not quite ready
to talk about events
within html but i do want to quickly
show you what i'm talking about
with buttons so if i wanted to do
something every time someone clicked on
this button
i have to assign it an on click event
now this is built in this is actually
not an attribute
this is an event listener so in here it
expects a specific function to be called
every time we click this button all
right so if i go down to the javascript
section of this code pen and i define a
basic function that says
alert me alright so something like this
where every time we
click the button it's going to bring up
an alert in the browser
and it's going to say hi alright so very
simple
and now if we put that into
the button right here
and we click the button it's going to
make an alert pop up and say hi every
time we click it
all right so that's just the basics of
event handling within html and we're
going to talk about that in a little bit
more detail when we get into the concept
of the document object model or the dom
the next element i want to talk about is
another content element and it's a list
so with a list we can basically have
bullet points or we can have numbered
list all right
so if we wanted to have a bullet point
list
we're going to use some tag called ul
alright
so
what ul stands for is unordered list and
if we go to the documentation here we
should be able to see that somewhere so
let's go down to html elements
and find ul
all right so there is the ul
and it's going to say this represents an
unordered list of items typically
rendered as a bulleted list
all right so that's basically
what that stands for and within it we
have to put some
li
tags so you can see if we click li
this element is used to represent an
item in a list all right so
we can put that here so we'll say li and
we'll say item one
and then we can copy this down a couple
of times
and give it item two and three and now
you can see on the right side we have a
bulleted list
of content all right and if we wanted to
change this to a numbered list all we
have to do is change the ul kind of
container to an ol container
you can see it changed here on the
bottom automatically and now you can see
that it is numbered and if we go to the
documentation
we should be able to click on ol to see
that this represents an ordered list of
items all right so those are the two
types of lists and these will be very
helpful to us when we're
laying out content and often times
you'll see these lists
corresponding to a loop so if we talked
about in javascript earlier how loops
work and we can take an array of
elements and we can loop through them
well it makes sense that we could
basically loop through an array of
elements and display them in a list like
this so just keep that in mind as we
move forward in the series and then the
last thing i want to cover is tables and
i know i said at the beginning we're not
going to be talking about this all that
often but i want to just glance over it
very quickly and i recommend that you
look at this on your own if you want
more details about it
so if we go to the documentation once
again we go down to html elements and
table alright so we'll click table
and it says represents tab tabular data
and then it shows you the basic
structure of a table you can see that we
have the table as the main container and
then we have the t head
tag will be the header tags
and then the t body will be whatever
data we're putting within our table
within that body we have tr tags which
are going to be the rows and then within
the tr
tags
we have table data for which we'll put
td tags in there all right so as you can
see it's a pretty complex structure and
like i said i recommend just using a
table generator you can just search for
it on google
it's much easier than trying to remember
this structure now of course you can
look it up and just copy in this example
and get started that way too
anyways let's move on to the next part
of our lesson and that's going to be
talking about html attributes in a
little bit more detail in this next part
of the html crash course we're going to
be talking about the html attributes now
i know it's probably been a little bit
confusing so far
we've gone through a bunch of different
html tags that we can be using we
briefly covered attributes and how they
work but we didn't really talk about
when do you use them how do you know
when to use them you know what's fair
game here so we're going to start by
talking about the difference between a
global attribute
and an element specific attribute in
short a global attribute is something
that's available to any html element you
know no matter what it is
an element specific attribute is an
attribute that only does something to
elements that it applies to
so a good example of this can be the
image tag so let's go ahead and look at
that on the screen real quick
so if we make an image tag and we give
it a source property and then we give it
a clasp or not property but attribute
you can see the difference between a
global and an element specific one so
again let's go ahead and put the source
in there and then let's make the width
equal to 300 like we did earlier
and what you can see on this
image tag
and then the total html element that we
call an image
you can see that we have the source
attribute which is specific to this
image tag
we also have the width attribute which
is also specific to the image tag
now the class attribute is a global
attribute which means it can be used on
any element or any tag
and to show that let's go ahead and make
a paragraph tag below
we'll put some text in there
and then we'll give it a class
all right so we've given it a class here
and you can see that
it's not doing anything right now but if
we were to actually style these two
different elements we would use these
class values as a way to select them
within our css
so as i kind of shown you showed you
earlier you can actually select these
different classes and
basically put some styles on here so
what if i wanted to put
a border on this
image we can do it like that we can make
that border a little bit larger
and you can see how we can style that or
we can come down and select the other
one so some class value
and we can give this text a different
color so maybe we'll call it green and
so now we can see that the text is green
but this is not a css tutorial i just
wanted to show you that that is a global
attribute that we can use to connect up
our html and our css but if i came down
here and put something like a width
on the p element and i gave it maybe 20
px or something like that it's not going
to actually do anything because this is
not
applicable to the paragraph
tag and likewise if we put a source on
here and then we copied in the
image url
it's not going to do anything either
because this is a paragraph tag it
doesn't have a source attribute so it
will still render in the browser okay it
just won't do anything and that's the
difference between a global and an
element specific attribute if you wanted
to connect the dots with the previous
lessons we've gone through you can think
of these element specific attributes
just like we have javascript methods so
if you remember if we have a string like
this
there are a certain number of methods
that are available to this string data
type in certain methods that are not so
for example if we wanted to
call a method like string dot 2 upper
case
all right something like that that's
going to work just fine and i'm actually
going to come over to
a console that we can use
to show this so we got a string all
right right here and then if we say
string
to uppercase
it's going to work just fine it's going
to make all the letters uppercase but if
we said string.reverse
it's going to say type error because
reverse is a method that's only
available to an array
data type so we would need an array like
this
and then use
array.reverse to actually use that
method and the same thing applies to
html attributes there are just certain
attributes that only apply to certain
tag types
all right at this point we have covered
quite a lot about html
and i want to have you actually go
through a practice exercise and a
challenge to reinforce some of these
concepts
so that when we talk about some
how we actually connect javascript to
the html you're not still trying to
figure out like how does html work so
i'm going to give you this challenge if
we go to my code pen
let's see if we can open this up here
all right so as you can see um this is
the challenge that we're going to be
working with and what i've done here is
i've put a couple different html
elements in your goal
is to basically recreate this but put in
your own personal details of course and
something that you can share maybe on
twitter use the 100 days of code
maybe hit me up zg underscore dev
but anyways we're going to be building
something like this but personalized and
i've given you a starter template so
this will be linked to in the
description below
so be sure to check that out and you'll
just open this
starter challenge up and you'll see that
within the html i've kind of laid out a
basic template for you
and it says your code goes here now
within
codepen
it actually this html part as i talked
about a little bit earlier
represents the body part so really all
we have to do is just start typing right
here so i'll leave you
with that and you can just start typing
some html so
you can put some text in there and
you're gonna see that it automatically
shows up on the screen and furthermore
it's going to be styled just like the
one that i showed you because i've
already written some
css styles that will basically apply to
your html you know no matter how you use
it
so i recommend that you just browse
through these styles but don't worry
about how they work just focus on
writing the html that is necessary to
create something that looks like this so
just a few hints as we go through this
looks like some sort of heading
we've got some paragraphs in here we've
got a link we've got a list and then
we've got an image down here so that's
basically all you need to do so go ahead
and try that challenge out and be sure
to share your results on twitter i think
this is a rather basic challenge
not saying it's going to be easy it will
not be easy
starting out but it's basic enough i'm
not going to go through it here on video
but if you'd like to go down in the
description and i also have linked to
this code pen
where i've solved it so you can see the
code that i wrote and how i wrote it
to compare against yourself
[Music]
the next part of this video we are
talking about something called the dom
and that stands for document object
model and it's very closely related to
html which we talked about in the
previous part of this lesson
now i will say if you have not completed
the challenge that i gave
in the prior video
go ahead and complete that and i would
recommend that you have at least a
basic understanding of html and kind of
understand
how to put something together within you
know a code pen document or something
like that because if you don't have at
least a basic level of understanding of
html this stuff is not going to make any
sense
before we get into this i want to show
you a little bit about the codepen
environment so that we can understand
like how do we actually debug
javascript within the browser and you
know take those concepts we've been
looking at in the prior videos where
we've you know pretty much right clicked
so let's take a look at the screen here
if we right click and
inspect and then we come to the console
then we can write you know basic
javascript within the console so we've
been working in the console quite a bit
but when we go to codepen since it's
kind of it's in its own environment we
have to do a few things to make sure
that that console is working the same so
if we come down to the js section of the
code pen this is a little bit different
than what we've been working with in the
console
now if we were to just type something
like
you know console.log
hello now this is going to be
printed to the console but it's going to
do it over and over again every time the
page loads
because this javascript that we're
working with here is directly connected
to the html document above so it's not
really like a freeform console that we
can use to test out different javascript
now codepen does have a console down
here at the bottom left and if you open
it up you'll see that we have that hello
that we printed by writing that
javascript code but we can also do
something like that down here in the
console and this is supposed to
represent the same type of thing that
we've been working with um when we right
click and inspect and go to the dev
tools console
but the problem is this is not a really
nice and easy console to work with like
if you started to
you know define a variable
with that's like a string or something
and then you type a
and you hit enter it's not going to say
it's not going to like be defined and
that's a problem because we want to be
able to experiment around and work with
our javascript as we're building it so
to solve that problem we're not going to
be using the codepen console what we're
going to do is right click and inspect
within the codepen document so it still
opens up this
console and i will note i'm in google
chrome not firefox this does not work
quite as well in firefox unfortunately
so i've switched to chrome for that
reason and if we go to the console
you'll see some of the the hellos that
we put there from earlier but if you go
to
this little drop down here when we first
enter the document you might see
something like top but in order to get
the right context to work in you have to
drop this down and scroll down to
codepen
now we can actually
select elements from the codepen
document that we've written here
and we don't have to um
or we're basically going to have some
responsiveness with our javascript just
to quickly show you this and we're going
to cover all of this stuff
in a little bit
but let me put a basic paragraph tag in
our codepen document and you can see it
showing up there
and if we have this context the
javascript context set to top
and we try to type
document.queryselector
then grab all the
paragraph tags
it's not going to grab us the right ones
so this is a paragraph tag but it's not
the one that we're looking for here so
we have to go down to the right context
so select codepen and now when we run
this it should give us the correct
element that we're looking for so that's
just really important if you're trying
to follow along with this like code
along as i'm doing it just make sure
that you're in google chrome you
right-click inspect element and make
sure that the context is the right one
it's under the codepen context alright
now we got that covered just want to
make sure that you're able to follow
along let's jump into what the document
object model or the dom is all about
now how i would describe the dom is a
bridge between html and javascript
prior to these lessons we've been going
through how to write javascript code
we've gone through all the basics of it
so you have at least
a
basic level of understanding of how to
write javascript we also just learned
about the basics of html which as you
saw is a lot easier to learn than
javascript
now what we're going to do is we're
going to take these two concepts and
we're going to combine them together to
make our
html come alive so remember with the
house analogy
html is the structure
css is the styling and javascript is the
function so
in other words with the house analogy
html is the bricks and the concrete in
the wood
the css is the paint on the house and
the javascript is going to be the
plumbing and the electric and all that
kind of stuff now the first question
you're going to ask is why are we
looking at the dom in the first place
how do we know that this is important
well the dom is basically at the root of
any front end framework that you're ever
going to work in it's the only way that
we can connect our javascript to html
and while you may not see it directly it
may kind of you know be doing a bunch of
stuff behind the scenes when you're
working with a framework like angular
reactor vue.js
it's still there it's still using the
dom api we're going to talk about that
in a second so it's important to know
that it exists and know the basics of
how it works and what it's trying to
accomplish
so what is the dom
now we know it's the document object
model which gives us a little bit of a
clue what we're talking about here but
it's a little bit more complex than just
that now i'll start with what it is not
so the dom is not a programming language
it's also not natively part of
javascript so it only exists within the
browser
and there's different browser
implementations whether you're on
firefox or chrome or safari they all
have slightly different implementations
of the dom for our intents and purposes
we don't really care about those
differences we just want to know you
know what it is and how it works so the
best way to think about the dom is an
api for an html document now you may not
know what an api is but luckily i have
done a video on just that so go ahead
and watch that if you're unclear of what
an api is but just as a you know 10 000
foot view what i consider an api and
this is my personal definition of it
that that makes sense in my head
is a software api can be thought of as a
user manual that allows developers to do
something useful with a third-party
software or hardware without knowing the
inner workings of that software or
hardware so basically the api that we
call the dom
is going to allow us to manipulate html
without knowing you know how is html
actually you know manipulated within the
browser all we have to know is how to
write the html and then how to use the
api that we call the dom to manipulate
it i know your head's probably spinning
at this point so let's jump into a
simple example to understand what i'm
talking about
so what i'm going to do here is paste in
some html all right so this is going to
be a basic html document i've got an h2
tag a paragraph tag and a button
now if we click this button and we kind
of talked about this a little bit
earlier when we click this button
it's not going to do anything and the
reason is we don't have any javascript
connected up to it in order to connect
it up
all we have to do is first identify the
element that we're wanting to make
interactive
and then once we identify it we need to
instruct it to do something via
javascript so just as an example we can
identify this button using pure
javascript and all we have to do is type
document.queryselector
and then we type in button because
that's the tag that we're looking for
now of course i need to select the
correct context to work in so we want
the codepen context
and then from here when we press enter
we're going to see the button that is
within our codepen output all right so
that's how we would select that button
now from there we can actually store
that within a variable so if we were to
rewrite that command
and then just store it in a basic
variable so btn is our variable now we
can reuse it and we can do things with
it but at this point you probably don't
have any clue what all these commands
are like what is document here what's
query selector
all that kind of stuff doesn't make any
sense yet because we haven't talked
about the dom so to better understand it
i want to bring in yet another analogy
for us now when we think about an html
document just a static html document
that we've been working with so far so
this one right here on the screen
that is kind of the equivalent to a
paper map so with a paper map there's
only so many things you can do with it
you can write on it of course but you're
not going to be able to you know click
into it and
see some more details about it
but we can do that with a something like
google maps we can click in and go to
different places and do a bunch of other
uh functions with it
so the analogy here is that html alone
is like a paper map but when we add the
dom
api with that html then it becomes
something like google maps where we have
a lot of interactivity that we can put
into it so to really talk about the
document object model let's take a look
from 10 000 feet
all right so we know some things about
javascript that are pretty familiar to
us so for example
this is a string in javascript we know
that all right
and we also know that this is going to
be a number all right but what about
that button that we just
defined here so we saved it into the
button variable
so if we look at that variable what type
of data is that
well we don't actually have a good
indication of that
all we have to do is say type of button
and it's going to say object well
clearly there's got to be something more
specific than just object
and there is when we start using the dom
or document object model terminology
from the dom's perspective
this element right here or this variable
right here is considered an element so
if we were to come to the document
object model
documentation here
you're going to see
all sorts of interfaces and stuff it's
it's a pretty complex api that we're not
going to even
cover half of but if we click in and
look at the element this is the most
general base class from which all
element objects in a document inherit
all right so that would be what we are
looking at when we have saved that
selected element into a variable called
btn and once we know that this is of
this element type we can come here in
the documentation we can see there's all
sorts of properties that we can look at
and there's all sorts of methods that we
can use on this specific variable
so we have a lot of functionality
available to us but we have to first
understand you know the the whole 10 000
foot view so what i'm going to do in
order for us to understand it better is
show you a picture that's going to
represent
what the dom is really trying to do
so at its highest level the dom has two
built-in objects that are probably going
to be used more than any other
objects that you look at so at the top
level the very top level you have the
window object and what you can think of
that as is literally the browser window
that we're working in
more specifically it's kind of referring
to the individual tab browser tab that
we're working in but in some cases it
can cross over between tabs so you can
actually
program using that one object you can do
all sorts of things within a browser
so as a general user of a web browser
there are several things that you do
every day that you don't realize are
programmable
so one of those things is scrolling down
all right scrolling down or scrolling up
every time you scroll you can actually
do that programmatically with javascript
now another thing you can do is you can
resize the browser window so if you were
to resize it like this
you can actually do that with javascript
alright and finally if you refresh the
page that's also something you can do
with javascript in the way that you do
it is by connecting into the dom
via that top level object that we call
window all right so i'm going to quickly
show you how we can programmatically do
these things by using that object but
first let's take a look at this in
the mdn documentation so we'll search
for window
and
here's what we're looking for
and it says the window interface
represents a window containing a dom
document document property points to the
dom document loaded in that window so
basically it's saying that the windows
the browser itself or the tab and then
there's an html document represented by
the document object within it all right
so that picture that i just showed you
kind of uh shows that relationship how
we have a html document that we are
putting in that browser window now from
here this window object like i said has
all sorts of properties and methods that
we can
use to do things that we commonly do
just by clicking around in the browser
on a normal basis so you can see down
this left hand side these are all of the
different
you know things we can do with it so for
example we have this alert method so
let's go ahead and inspect element so
we're in the browser console and if we
type window dot alert and then we say i
love programming or something like that
and press enter it's going to open up an
alert window and you can see how we're
already starting to program this browser
window using that object here's another
thing we can do we can open up
new tabs so if we say window.open
and maybe go to
google alright when we press enter it's
going to open a new tab and put us at
google.com so that's pretty cool
let's see another thing that we can do
is we can scroll so you have to
obviously be on a page that has a scroll
bar which this one does
and from here we just say window
scroll by and then we give it a bunch of
options here these are all documented
within this method so if you were to
um go down to the methods
of window let's see if we can find them
all right so we found the methods here
and let's see if we can find this scroll
by
method
all right so we have scroll by we can
click on that and it just tells us okay
you can pass in some options here and
those options that we're passing in are
scroll to options all right and then
from here we have the top left and
behavior so we're going to define we
want to scroll
from the top we want to scroll window
dot inner height
which is going to be a built-in property
of that window object which basically
says here's how tall this entire html
document
is all right so from the top we want to
scroll down the entire length of the
page essentially we're going to the
bottom
of this page
all right and then from the left we want
zero we don't want to scroll left and
right and the behavior
that we want is going to be smooth we
don't want to just jolt down the page we
want to smoothly scroll all right so
when we do this and close out this
method and press enter
you got to watch the screen now
it's going to scroll all the way down to
the bottom of this you know page or
whatever and i guess it didn't go
all the way down because i actually
explained that wrong so window.inner
height
if we look at that
inner height is only going to define
how large
the visible window is so it's not going
to
define how large the entire document is
so obviously this is a much larger
document so it's only going to scroll
down one entire page and then finally we
are able to actually reload the page so
we can tap into the
window.location property and then that
location property has a method called
reload and you could have found this in
the documentation if you looked hard
enough but i don't want to right now
just for sake of time so let's press
enter
and you can see
you may not have seen it but it reloaded
the entire page
programmatically so you can see how that
top level window object is basically our
control over the browser and the way
that this is happening is via the dom
api so the dom again is just an api to
connect in with our browser in html
document now another thing to mention
about this is it's a global object which
means we don't have to actually specify
it every time we use it so
i showed you before that we could do
window.alert
and then type in something to get an
alert all right so we can also do this
by dropping window like we don't even
need that because it's global and we can
go ahead and get the same results there
alright so that's important to keep in
mind with the window object and
the document object these are both
global so we don't need to specify them
before calling their methods or
properties so a couple common properties
on window we're not going to go through
all of the methods and properties for
all these objects but this is just such
a high level one an important one that i
want to
so window has a few common properties
that you might want to tap into
one of those is going to be the inner
height and i spelled that wrong so it's
not going to give me anything
so we've got inner height is going to
give us the height in pixels of the
space that displays the html so the
visible
area that's displaying that html now if
we said outer height that's going to
give us the
pixel
height of the entire browser window so
if you look at this value it's 1040 but
if you
make this browser window smaller and you
say outer height it's going to give us a
different value 894 the same thing
applies for inner width and outer width
so inner width is going to give you the
width of this space that's displaying
the html so if you resized this
you're going to get a different inner
width all right so i don't want to spend
too much time on the properties but you
can kind of get the gist of what that's
showing you
now another common property that we
might look at here with window is going
to be
local storage all right so this is going
to be a big one that will come up as we
start getting into more
advanced web development concepts and
basically what this allows you to do
is store data temporarily in the browser
so if i were to
go to the application here in chrome
it's called a little bit different thing
in firefox i actually talked about that
in like the third lesson of the series
but if you click here you can actually
see key value data pairs that can be set
and retrieved through the local storage
object so if we wanted to set an item
we'll just say test and then we want to
set it equal to 20. we can do that and
then we come to application and you can
see test
has a value of 20 here so it's a great
way to store temporary values and that
is accessed through the local storage
object that sits on the window object
all right and then finally i want to
talk about the
location
because this is going to basically
represent an object that has details
about
where you're visiting right now so right
now we're on the mdn web docs and if we
were to look at the window.location
you're going to get all sorts of details
about that
location we have in the address bar so
these are some of the common properties
just one more two more that i want to
show you here before we move on
window has a scroll x property
which is going to indicate how much we
have scrolled from the left side of the
page or i guess right and left
horizontal scrolling and then we have
window dot scroll y which is going to
indicate how much we've scrolled up and
down
so you see the scroll bar here this is
going to change the value of this
property every time
we scroll a little bit so these are all
going to come in handy as we work with
the dom later on and we want to you know
programmatically do things within this
browser window now i've briefly
mentioned it before but we can have
these things called events happening
within the dom now this is going to be a
little bit complicated but i want to
just show you a basic example of this
something that you can do on the top
level window object so
we can say window
on scroll so basically we're saying we
want to tap into the on scroll event
which basically every time i move that
browser scroll bar it's going to fire
this event and what i want to do every
time i scroll i want to execute a
function so right here i'm using an
anonymous function
and i'm just going to console.log hi
alright so something very simple
and now we have set an event listener on
this the entire window all right so now
when i touch the scroll bar we're going
to get this printing hi to the console
for a lot of different iterations here
so
that's just a basic event now i just
want you to know that that is available
and it's something that you can do but
we're not going to
really dig into the the super nitty
gritty details of it in this lesson all
right so now that we've talked about the
window object which represents the
entire you know tab that we have open or
i guess the
browser that we're working in
let's talk about the document object so
let's put that back up on the screen
that
10 000 foot view of the dom api
we've got at the top we've got the
window object and then a property of the
window object is going to be document
and this is where the real fun begins
because document is basically a
representation of your entire html
document that you've written so let's
take a look at this i'm going to refresh
the browser so we don't have that on
scroll
event firing every time but we have
window at the top and then we have this
property called document all right so we
press enter on this
and you now see that we have this
big object that has basically the html
document defined within it
and while we can expand these different
things
visually within the console there's
actually a lot of things that we can do
programmatically using this document
object we can add or remove html
elements from the existing page we can
modify existing html elements and we can
even set events on specific html
elements we saw how we set an event on
the entire window but we could set an
event
like we talked about earlier in the
prior video something like that where we
have a button and we want to wait for a
click event and we want to fire some
sort of function that does something
every time that button is clicked so
this document
object is very powerful and there's a
lot of things that we have to cover
to understand what it actually does so
let me show you a basic example of this
we'll go back over to our
code pen which we have a basic
html document here
and i'm going to type document and let's
take a look at what we're
dealing with so right here we have this
top level html wrapper which we talked
about is
going to happen
for every single html document in
codepen you know you'll notice over here
we don't have that written but codepen
is automatically wrapping our html
within the html wrapper all right so we
expand this down we have a head
code pen takes care of this and a body
and then from here this is where the
actual
html
and javascript that we're writing is
going to be placed so you'll see that we
have our h2 element our paragraph
element and our button element and then
you also see some scripts down here at
the bottom
and basically these scripts are what are
represented here in the javascript so
any javascript we type here is connected
up to our html document via these script
tags
so again don't have to understand how
that all works we'll get into that in
future lessons but
i just wanted to show you the anatomy of
this document object now if you've been
following this series all the way
through and you went through the
javascript series you know how to write
basic javascript and you also know that
if we have a javascript object we can
access properties of it
so let's define a basic object with a
property
all right something like prop 1 and prop
2.
nothing fancy here
but if we were to actually let's make a
nested object as well
we'll say nested
right here
and then
we will
end this alright so object.prop2.nested
is going to equal our value right here
because we use the dot notation to
access the different
embedded
properties and values within this object
now you would think that we could do the
same thing with the document object but
we can't all right so if we
try to do the same sort of access let's
clear the screen
and if we try document
and then let's go ahead and look at it
one one quick second so we obviously
have document now we have html then we
have body so if we typed document
dot html
dot body it's going to say we cannot
read the property of body because it's
undefined so we clearly cannot just
access these different html elements
with dot notation we have to use um the
document object model api to do so and
it's a little bit different it takes a
little bit of getting used to but
hopefully we can walk through some of
the more common ways to use it here in
the remainder of this video so i'm going
to put on a
new html document here with some
additional
parts to it so that we can really
visualize what this dom is all about all
right so we can think of the document
object model as a tree
and furthermore we can think of this
tree as
kind of like we think about ancestry
trees or whatever where you have
grandparents and then you have
parents and you have
children and stuff like that so what
you're seeing on the screen right now is
this html document that we just created
in this code pen
represented as the dom tree all right so
you can see that we have the document at
the top then we go down to html and then
from there we have the head in the body
and underneath the body specifically we
have all of this html that we have
written here
and within that html we have a lot of
siblings but we also have some children
so for example
let's look at this main div right here
for the main body so the main body div
is going to be the parent
to this h1 tag
these two p tags and this ul or
unordered list tag all right so that's
going to be the parent to these
four
now if we look at the list items
its parent is going to be the unordered
list and its grandparent is going to be
the main body div so you can see how
these relationships start to build and
furthermore we have you know the concept
of siblings so all of these list items
these are all going to be siblings
within the document object model
and this unordered list the p tags and
the h1 they're all siblings so what do
we call all of these elements well in
the document object model we call them
all nodes now this is very different you
should not
confuse this with node.js we'll talk
about that later in the series but
that's basically the back end server
side version of writing javascript this
is a totally different concept all of
these elements are considered nodes
within the dom tree now of course
they're all different so they're all
different types of nodes and i'm going
to put the
image back on the screen that we looked
at in
the prior part of this lesson when we
talked about the basics of html
so within this
element that we have defined it's a
total unit
we have different types of nodes here so
at the
simplest level we have something called
an element node and that's going to be
represented by the p tag all right and
then we have an attribute on that uh
html element and we call that an
attribute node and then finally we have
a text node which is going to be the
content that we're putting between the
starting and closing paragraph tags now
to prove this out to you i'm going to
actually take this element and create it
in javascript and then insert it into
the page that we're looking at right
here
all right so the first thing we have to
do is define each of those three
different types of nodes all right so
the first one is going to be an element
node
and let me let me actually zoom out a
little bit here so we've got an element
node and we have to use the document
object
and then we use create element and
before we do that i keep forgetting we
have to change the context
to codepen so that we're working with
the
document that we're seeing over here
rather than the whole document
all right so sorry about that and what
we're going to do is create our element
node which is going to be a p tag all
right so we're just creating that
element we just put on the screen
so let's press enter and we have created
our first element node and if we look at
that it's just going to be an mtp tag
there's nothing in it yet all right
so now we have to create our text node
alright so we're going to type document
dot create text node and then here we're
going to put in the word content which
is the stuff that was between the p tags
alright so we press enter and right now
this element node is still empty all
right so we still have an empty p tag
and the reason is we haven't assigned
the text node to that element yet
before we do that let's create our last
node which is going to be an attribute
attribute node
so we'll create an attribute and we want
to call this a class attribute because
that's the type of attribute we had on
this
html element all right so at this point
let's look at what we have here so we
have
element node which is a mtp tag then we
have the text node which is going to be
content as a string or more specifically
a dom string
and then finally we have our
attribute node which is going to be
class equals to empty so basically we
haven't assigned a value to this
attribute yet but we've initialized it
the first thing i want to do is i want
to take our text node and i want to put
it inside our
p tag or element node so all we have to
do is say element node dot append child
and then we pass in the text node press
enter and now when we print out the
element node it's going to be a p tag
with that content placed between it now
we are starting to build out this
element the next thing that we have to
do is give a value to our attribute so
if you saw before we have class equal to
an empty string
all we have to do to do that is we say
attribute
node and then we say dot value equals
sum class all right so now we have this
attribute node
if we print that it's going to say class
equals sum class so we're getting closer
the only thing that we are missing is
this attribute is not connected up with
our
paragraph element so to do that all we
have to do is take our element node and
we say set attribute and then we pass in
the attribute node
and it says it failed to execute
because there are two
oh okay i messed it up so
not set attribute we have to set
attribute node all right so we press
enter there and now the element node
is going to be our full html element
that we saw in the model before the last
thing we have to do is insert it into
the document and the way that we do that
is we use the document object so we type
document and then we use the append
child method we haven't talked about
this yet but i just want to show how it
works
and now we just pass in element node and
if you look at the bottom of our code
pen you're going to see this element
inserted into the document
and it's going to say it failed to
execute
because i messed up once again
i forgot i need to
add one more piece of code in here i
need to say document.body so instead of
just inserting it at the end of the
document which represents the whole html
document i need to specify that i want
to look at the body specifically so if
we go over to elements
and we look at the entire well i guess
this is not a good example because
codepen is adding a bunch of other stuff
but basically we need to put in the body
element so let's press enter and you can
now see that our content has been
inserted into our existing html document
so you may not have recognized it but
we're actually tapping into the dom's
api to do everything we just did
we created a new html element with
javascript alone
and you can see that we use things like
set
set attribute node and append child and
we've used create attribute create text
node create element these are all
methods that are defined within the
document object model all right so we
are actually using the dom as we speak
here now you might ask what's the point
of this every time we refresh the page
so if we refresh this page
reload it
we're not going to have those same
elements inserted into our document
anymore
and i'm not sure what i'm doing here
okay so html i actually need to copy in
some stuff here
it's because i didn't save the actual
code pen but whatever the case that
content at the bottom is going to be
temporary and you might ask well what's
the point of inserting stuff with
javascript and the answer to that is for
user experience
so
when a user creates a calendar event on
google calendar you'll see a calendar
event pop up immediately on that
calendar and that was done via
javascript you know tapping into the dom
all right another example is a user adds
a to do item to their to-do app
or a user creates a post on facebook all
of these things are using javascript via
the dom
so the dom's api
to insert elements and modify elements
that are existing within the html
document
but they're only temporary and it's
because we want a better user experience
so we want to immediately change that
you know web page and then later we kind
of save that to the database and reload
it with new data later all right so at
this point we have gone through a lot of
different angles to think about the dom
with but we haven't actually you know
buckled down and tried to understand you
know how do we actually use the dom here
what are some of the methods available
to us um
what exactly is the dom like you know
we've been working with the window
object in the document object but
there's so much more to it we can also
work with individual elements and with
each element we can do certain things
with that just like we talked about with
html and javascript before the purpose
of this series is not to make you an
expert in any one thing it's to take you
from xero to launching your first full
stack application and deploying it so
we've got to cover a lot of ground so
i'm going to walk you through an example
of using the dom we're going to cover
some of the common uh methods and
you know properties that we can use
within the dom but we're not going to
cover everything and quite frankly most
developers don't know everything about
the dom it's very complicated and
there's a lot of stuff that you will
never end up using within your career
anyways let's get started let's go ahead
and put some new html in our code pen
all right and this one says welcome to
my html tutorial click the button below
to begin
and this button what we want to do with
this is we want every time we click it
we want to add a new paragraph element
to the bottom of this page so how do we
do that well it's three steps
number one we have to find a way to
identify
the button element so that we can start
working with it number two we have to
register a click event on this button
which is part of the dom it's part of
the dom api and then number three we
need to write a function that will
insert a new paragraph element in the
web page every time we click it so let's
take a look at our button here we have a
global attribute called id every html
element
is
able to have this id attribute
and we also have a global attribute
called class every html element is
eligible to have a class on it
so we have multiple ways to identify
this button so let me take you through a
couple of those ways to better explain
some of the methods we have on the dom
here's the first way we can do it and
this is probably the most generic
we can say document.queryselector
and then we can just type in button
because this is going to be
button is going to represent the tag
that we're looking for so what this is
going to do
right now is it's going to look for any
button on the entire page here including
codepen's you know interface and the
reason is we don't have the right
context so let's go down to codepen
again and try this again so we're going
to select button
and what this is going to do
is it's going to look through the html
document that we're working with and
it's going to find the first occurrence
of a button tag and if it doesn't find
it it's just going to return null now
the question is how did i know to use
this document.queryselector
all right the reason i knew that is
because if you go to the documentation
you go to apis
dom
then you go down to dom
and you find that document object so
this is that document object that we
talked about it represents the html
document itself this has certain
properties and it has certain methods
that are available for us to use
so if we scroll down all the way to the
methods you will see a couple of
different query methods
so we have query command enabled you
won't use that much
a couple others but you can see query
selector it's actually
listed twice i'm not sure if that's
meant to do
not meant to be that way
i don't think it is actually but
we can go to query selector
and this will tell us basically how to
use it so we can put in selectors it
says
a dom string containing one or more
selectors to match the string must be
valid
css selector string so we don't know a
whole lot about css quite yet but
basically what that means is if we pass
in
to this query selector if we pass in
something with a hashtag at the
beginning that represents an id so if
you remember we've got this id equal to
btn-1
so if we put the hashtag and type bt
we should be able to find this element
again of course we got to go back to the
codepen
context it's very annoying
that i have to do that but
i promise it'll get a little bit easier
in the future
so we'll go btn-1 and we can find that
element that way now we can also use a
class selector which is a period right
so
you can see our class is my-btn
so if we do period
my-btn we should be able to find the
same button that way as well and these
are just more specific ways to find a
single element within the dom now of
course as with anything in programming
there's lots of ways to solve the same
problem
and if we go back to this documentation
let's go back to the main document
object
and if we look at some of the methods
here we've got these query selectors
which are kind of generic query
selectors that i basically it's all i
use to find elements within the html
document but you can also get an element
by id all right so that's another way to
locate an element so if we were to
replace this so we say get
element by id and then this time all we
have to do is pass in
the id you don't even need a hashtag at
the end
oh i messed this up here all right let's
try that again
so get element by id
and button one
and we should be able to find that
button once again by using a different
method so as you can see there's many
ways to skin a cat here and
with the document object model you can
get very creative with your code now the
reason that
selecting it by an id
is the most specific way to do it and
probably the best way to do this
is because you cannot have two elements
with the same id
so if i tried to copy this button
down here
and it's got the same exact id as the
other button
it's going to have a conflict so this is
not really valid html it'll still render
but it will cause you problems if you're
trying to
use any sort of front-end framework or
even locate things with the dom
so what i'm going to do here is paste in
all of the different ways we can
identify this one button let me get rid
of
the button here
the second one and then it's going to
kind of refresh
put me back in the wrong context so i'm
going to go back and now if i paste in
all of these different methods
so you can see there's quite a lot of
different ways to identify
this button but these are all valid ways
to do it and this only executed
it looks like one of them
but if you were to type each of these in
individually it's going to locate it
each time but obviously there are some
that are more specific than others and
we always prefer to be as specific as
possible when identifying elements
within the dom all right so now that we
know how to identify this element let's
go ahead and write that in our code so
so far we haven't used this javascript
section
quite yet but what i'm going to do is
i'm going to say add
paragraph
and we're going to make a function
that's going to be actually called every
time we click that button
so from here all we have to do is locate
the button and assign it to a variable
so we're going to use one of those
methods i just will choose the query
selector and we're going to pass in the
id
of that button in order to identify it
alright so this button variable should
represent our button and from here we
should be able to do something with it
every time it is clicked and i'm
actually going to not put this within
the function this will just be
in the
global scope of our
javascript document here i'm going to
close out this console so that we have
some more room to write
just for a second all right so now we
have this button being identified and
then we have a function that's going to
add a paragraph
all right and the last thing that we
have to do is we have to
add an event listener so this is how we
do that we just say
add event listener and then we specify
the event that we're trying to listen to
and then the function or the callback
that we're going to pass in to execute
on that event happening now this is the
first way to register an event
on a specific html element
this is one way to do it another way to
do it is if we take our element button
and then we say on click
and then we set it equal to add
paragraph then that's going to also
register that event on the button and
then a third way we can do it is in the
html itself and this is what we looked
at previously in this tutorial if we
come here to the button and we say on
click
and then we set that equal to add
paragraph and then we actually execute
it within those parentheses then that's
going to register that click event as
well so there's three different ways
that we can register a click event but
in this case i want to do it directly
with javascript so we'll go ahead and go
with this one this is a pretty simple
one
but you might be asking like how do we
know that that's a event that's valid
and the reason we know that is if we go
to the event reference within the mdn
web docs
this is going to give us all of the
different events that we have for
elements on the web all right so not all
of these are going to work with like say
a button but
a lot of these will
just work for various components within
a web page
so here we have mouse events and you can
see the click event
and this is going to
tell us that the event handler property
is the on click which is what we put in
right here so you'll get used to on you
know you'll basically pick up on all of
the common events
with due time there's only a few of them
that are used on a frequent basis and
the on click method is actually one of
the most common events that you'll use
in web programming so at this point we
have our event wired up and this add
paragraph function is going to fire
every time we
click the button so let's say
the button is working
all right and if we go ahead and open
back up that console
so right click inspect
go to the console
and we're in the correct context it
looks like
and we can just say
or click the button and it's going to
say the button is working
and it's going to do it over and over
again every time we click it so the goal
here is to insert a new paragraph
element every time we click that button
right now it's just console logging some
a string to the console but we can also
construct a new element just like we did
before and this time around i'm going to
show you a few shortcuts that's going to
make it a little bit easier to create
this paragraph element now we want to
have some random
data to be printed to each new paragraph
element so i'll just generate a random
number
we'll say randomnum
is going to be equal to math.floor this
is a trick that we learned in a previous
lesson
and we'll just do between 0 and 100.
something like that all right and then
we're going to
say the p
content this is what we want to actually
add within that paragraph element we're
going to combine this with the random
number we're just going to say the
random
number is
and then we're going to add via string
concatenation
that random number all right so now the
p content is the random
string and let's go ahead and just test
that out real quick
by printing our random string to the
console every time it is clicked alright
so we will click me and it's going to
say the random number is eight all right
so that's done now we need to actually
create our paragraph element
the way that we do that is going to be
we're going to define a new element
variable and we're going to use the
document.create
new element method all right so if we go
to the mdn docs
and we go to technologies apis
dom
and then we go down to
the
document object right here
and then we go down to the methods all
right so we're going down to the methods
here in the documentation
and we should see a create
element right here
so it's not create new element i don't
know why i said that here we're just
going to do create element
and then we need to pass in the type of
element that we're looking for so if we
look at the create element documentation
it's going to say that our tag name is
the only required property
or parameter of this method so any tag
name works in this case we're going to
pass in p for that tag name and now we
have a new element assigned to a
variable
the next thing that we'll do is we're
just going to instead of creating a new
text node like we did in that first
example we're just going to take the new
element and we're going to use a
property called text content which
exists on it and we're going to set that
equal to
the p content variable that we created
prior all right so if we go to the
documentation here and we go to
let's see
the element reference so
this is going to be
of type element and then the text
content is going to be part of that so
really the fastest way to do this is
just type text content
and it's going to be part of the node
interface so if you remember the dom
tree is just constructed of a bunch of
nodes
and no matter what type of node we're
working with it's always going to have
the properties and methods of this node
interface
so you can see in the properties if we
scroll down to text content
you can see that we can actually set
this
to new content
directly so we'll do that here and now
we just need to basically add this to
the document
at the very end
so the way that we do that is we come
down here at the bottom we say document
dot body dot append
child and then we put in the new element
which has our random text content
we'll get rid of this
console.log here
all right so here's the whole
function that we're dealing with
so we have add paragraph we get a random
number we generate random content from
that number
we create a paragraph element we assign
the random content as the text content
of that element and then we append it to
the end of the html body which is
basically going to be after this button
all alright so let's go ahead and test
this out so we press click me and we're
going to get a new paragraph element
with a random number every time we click
it
so it's pretty cool
like this is where programming starts to
get kind of fun is when we actually can
start building things that are
interactive and we can click buttons and
get results so hopefully this brings you
a little bit of excitement obviously
it's not something useful but we will
soon get there in future videos as you
can see with some of the examples we've
gone through there's really only a few
methods and properties that you kind of
have to remember with the dom
we got the query selectors so how do we
identify the element we want and then
the methods where we can create new
elements and modify both their content
their attributes we haven't talked too
much about that yet
but we can do a bunch of stuff with
these elements so the next thing we have
to talk about is going to be how do we
navigate an html document now i talked
about the dom tree and how there's you
know siblings and parents grandparents
child all that kind of stuff
and that's going to come into play here
how do we actually navigate through a
complex html document to do this i'm
going to copy in a predefined html
document here that you'll see we've
looked at this before
and we're going to basically figure out
how this dom um all the dom interfaces
actually work here when i talk about
you know dom nodes and you know elements
and how elements kind of inherit from a
dom node like what does that all mean
and that's going to become more apparent
when we work through the navigation of
this html document so let's put that
diagram back up on the screen where we
can see this document right here
visualized as a tree
and from this
this visual you can see that
these list items are going to be
siblings
and they're going to be children of the
unordered list
so how do we select this unordered list
and then get all of the children of it
with javascript well this is actually
simpler than you might think so
we've already been able to identify
elements from the dom so we use
document.queryselector
and then we pass in either a tag
or an id or a class name
something like that to identify it
since we only have one unordered list in
this entire document we can just put in
ul as the tag name and that's going to
when we change the context here
and try it again that's going to select
this list right here now let's go ahead
and assign this to a variable so that we
have something to work with
so we'll say our list is equal to
document.queryselector and then we're
grabbing the actual html tag
so we press enter now we have a list and
that's going to be
showing us the html here now obviously
this is just a visual representation of
the object
but if we wanted to figure out you know
what is this variable representing you
know what does the list variable
actually represent we have a way of
doing that if you're ever confused what
type of variable you're working with you
can use this handy property that every
node in the dom tree has all right so if
we say list dot node type
it's going to return us a number all
right and we wonder what is that number
well if we go to the documentation
and we type in
node
dot node type so if you were to just
type in
node type you can find this
and once you click on it and scroll down
to the constants so these type constants
this will tell you what type of element
you're working with so in this case
we got the value of one and that tells
us that we're working with an element
node and from here we can click element
and we can see okay this is the type of
node within the dom that we're working
with and here are the properties and
methods that are available to us
so if we were to scroll down and look at
the properties of the element
we see this property called children all
right so if we click on that it's going
to say the parent node property children
is a read-only property that returns a
live html collection
which contains all of the child elements
of the node upon which it is called
all right so let's go back to our
document here and we'll say list dot
children and you can see that we're
getting returned this html collection
now from here
html collection is of course another
thing that we don't understand but we
can once again
go back to the documentation
and click on html collection to see what
we're dealing with
and from here we can once again go over
to the methods and properties
and there's this one method called item
on the html collection which is going to
return us the element at a specific
index of that html collection so
basically like an array that we've
worked with in javascript before but
it's not quite an array you can't just
come over here and pass in brackets and
put in a zero or a one
at least i don't think maybe you can
um i'm not sure okay maybe you actually
can do that but
if we put in
list.children.item and we select one
this is going to select the second item
of the list so this is the way that i've
always
done it in the way that the
documentation kind of presents it but it
looks like
at least in the browser i'm working in
the bracket notation works as well
from here though
we can identify specific elements within
our list and then we can set those equal
to variables just like we did the list
itself so if we come over to the left
and we say
list item
is equal to the second one in the list
and we press enter
now we have that that entire html
element stored in a variable and we can
use
different properties on it to modify it
so if we came over here and we said list
item which is representing that second
item
and we said text content
all right this is list item number two
but we can set it equal to some
new content all right so we did this
already but watch what happens in the
html document
when i press enter it changes the
content so this is just kind of showing
you how you can you know look at the
whole dom tree and you can say okay
here's the parent and then i can get
children and then i can select one of
the child elements of that you know set
of children and then from there i have a
standalone html element that i can do
all sorts of things with i can set event
listeners on it i can change the text
content and i can do all sorts of other
things that are defined by the
documentation that i'm working with now
once again maybe we don't know what this
list item
represents what is the node type of it
well all we have to do is say node type
and we get the answer of 1 once again
which means it is an element and from
there we just go to the documentation we
can just go back up here and just search
element
and then from here we have all the
properties all of the methods all of the
event listeners that are available to
this
specific element that we have stored in
a variable all right the next thing i
want to do is i want to dig a little bit
deeper into this concept of nodes
so i've been beating around the bush
here a little bit
talking about how everything in the dom
tree is considered a node but we've also
been looking at elements and html
collections and stuff like that and it
can get very confusing like all of these
different interfaces what's going on
here like these are all different data
types they all have different properties
and methods how do i know where to look
what has what available to it so on and
so forth well before i get into this
this is a object-oriented programming
concept
and that's not something that we've
covered yet
we may cover it in future videos but
this gets into things like classes and
inheritance and
class methods and static methods and all
that kind of stuff
and the thing that i want you to
recognize right now is that we have all
these different interfaces defined by
the dom all right so at the very top
we have this thing called a node so
let's go back to to the node
and what i want you to remember is that
everything in the dom
inherits from this node interface
so
everything below it so an element um
or an html element interface these all
inherit up to this node interface which
basically means
these elements have all of their own
properties and methods but they also
have access to this you know master node
interface as well
so if we were to go look at some of the
things we have available on this node
you can see this append child method
that we've been using quite frequently
and let's see if we can find a couple
other ones um it looks like that might
be the only one
that we've been using
but we also have text content so we've
been using that to modify the text
within an html element and we have node
type we've used that one before
let's see what else
looks like that's pretty much it but
you can see that this node has a bunch
of properties and methods that are
available to anything below it so in
other words if we come back to our
document here our html document
and we know that we have this unordered
list
stored in the variable called list all
right and we know that list if we say
list.nodetype
it is of type element which inherits
from that you know
node interface that basically
defines every element
from here all we have to do is we say
list dot append child
and that's going to be a valid method
because it's part of the node interface
as we just saw
and from here we can insert an html
element and actually add it to the end
of this list but first we have to
actually create that element and this
will be a good opportunity
to show another method that we've
already seen but didn't really dig into
yet so what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to take
list
dot append
child
and i'm going to say document dot
new
or no create
element and we're going to make it a
list item and this is going to be
completely empty no content within it
and you can see that we have a new list
item showing up at the end of this list
and all we have to do now is we say
list.children and we select the final
element
um or no we have to say item and then we
select the final element and then we say
text content
and we can put in
some content here and now we have added
a new item to the end of the list and
modified it so you can see how we can
start parsing through and navigating
through this hierarchy
pretty easily once we get the hang of it
now what i want to introduce is
something a little bit tricky and this
is where we really have to think when
we're
navigating through the dom because
in this html document you can see that
we have two p elements that don't have
an id and they don't have a class
and that basically means we have no way
of identifying these in an easy
specific way
so the first way that we can you know
think about identifying
one of these elements is by the query
selector method and what we're going to
try to do here is basically insert
another element between these two
paragraph tags
and if you go to the documentation
and you go to the i believe it's the
node
let's see yeah so the node interface has
this method called insert before
and what that does is it basically
inserts a html node or element that
inherits from node
before a specific reference element
so basically in our case we're going to
use this method
and we're going to have to figure out
how do we identify the second p tag
right here
now the the way that we would think
about doing this is we say document dot
query selector
and then we grab anything
that has a p tag all right and in this
case when we press enter we're gonna get
the wrong one because the query selector
method only gets the first occurrence
now what we can do
is we can change this to query selector
all
and what this is going to return us is a
node list
so unlike an html collection which we
got when we looked at the children of
that unordered list
now we have just a node list which is a
slightly different data type if we
didn't know what this meant we can just
go back to the documentation
we can type in node list
and let's see what this does all right
so node list objects are collection of
nodes usually returned by properties
such as node.child nodes and methods
such as
document.queryselectorall which is what
we used
and let's look at
a few more things
we have some properties we have the
length of it and then we have methods so
we have
this method called item similar to html
collection where we can select something
with an index
so we can go ahead and do that and we
can actually just chain it to the end of
this
so we'll say item and then maybe we'll
pass in item number one
and that's going to
get the first index so remember it's
zero index so the first p element will
be zero then the next one will be one
so now we have selected the second
element and what we want to do is we
want to assign that to a variable
so we'll say
uh p
element is equal to that
and now we want to use the p element
um let's first say
node type and we're going to get a type
of one which means it's an element type
and we know that element is kind of like
a
child or
it inherits from that node type which is
the base class
so
we're getting the node type and so we
know that the p element or p
lm
is going to have this insert
before
method so let's go ahead and learn how
do we use that
so if we go back
to what we were looking at previously so
we've got node.insert before now let's
look at the syntax we learned about this
in prior lessons how to read this
documentation
and what we're seeing here is that we
have
um
the parent node right here is going to
be the parent of the newly inserted node
so we have to ask ourselves what is the
parent to the node that we're trying to
insert let's go back to our
html document
and maybe we can even pop up the diagram
on the screen and see that what is the
parent to an element that we insert
between these two paragraph tags in
other words what is the parent of one of
these paragraph tags well the answer is
going to be the main body div alright so
we need to pass in
a reference to this main body div
as that first
parent node right here
so we know that we have to select that
and then we have to put in a new node
which is going to represent a new
element that we create
and then finally a reference node so the
reference node as we can see down here
is going to be the the node or the
element that our new one is going to be
inserted before
um or
we're going to insert it before this
element all right so if this is null
then the new node is inserted at the end
but we don't care about that because
it's not so let's go back
and the first thing that we need to do
is identify that parent so we'll say
parent is equal to
document.queryselector
and then this time since we have a class
to select it by we're going to select it
with the class notation
so we have parent we'll just check that
that we're getting the right one
and now we just have to say parent dot
insert
before
all right and then we have to make a new
node
so the new node is going to be a p
element so let's go ahead and create
that real quick
so
actually no we
yeah we need to create a new element so
new
p tag is going to be document.create
element
of type
p
and then we're going to assign some text
content
we'll say programmatically added between
all right so now we have our new element
and finally we're going to take the
parent we're going to insert
before
we're going to pass in the
new
element that we're putting there and
then we're going to
reference the element that we want to
insert it before so that would be p
ln all right so we did that up there
before so let's see if this works
and you can see that we have program
programmatically added this paragraph
tag between
these two paragraph tags right here
so this was a little bit of a tricky
example and we kind of ventured out into
a method that we
definitely had to read the documentation
for before we knew how to use it but
this just goes to show how we can kind
of navigate around the dom by
visualizing it as a tree and really
understanding what's the parent what's
the child what's the sibling and you
know what is the interface that i'm
working with within the dom all right if
you are still watching this video um
that's awesome
most people are not going to make it
through this kind of conversation
about the document object model but
i will say that if you're at this point
you're very confused that is totally
okay the purpose of this
video in this crash course especially
this section about the document object
model
is not to make you an expert at it the
purpose is to expose you to what it is
what are some of the things we can do
with it and just get you um started and
thinking independently of okay if i
don't know something how do i go figure
it out you know we went through a bunch
of examples where i didn't necessarily
know how to use these different methods
when i didn't know what type of data
we're working with but you go to the
documentation you search for it and you
figure it out
so if you're confused that's totally
okay keep moving forward we're not going
to actually be using the dom all that
much throughout the rest of the series
but as i said in the beginning
it's super important that you understand
what it is because it is at the root of
every front-end framework that you're
going to work with
you know if you start working in react
you're going to hear something called
the virtual dom
and if you don't know what the real dom
is it's going to be very hard to
understand what the virtual dom is and
furthermore if you're working with like
angular or view vue.js you know these
all
connect in with this dom api to
um basically expose their own api so
you're gonna you know have some easier
ways of working with this html once we
get into
front-end frameworks but underneath the
surface those frameworks are just
connecting in with the same api that we
just used in this video so to do a huge
recap of html
i think of it in two different parts
first is going to be the static html and
that's going to be just the html like
the stuff you see on the page here
this is static html and no matter what
you do it's not going to change all
right now the next part is dynamic html
and that is what we see when we start
working with the dom and we start
manipulating and adding removing
changing modifying those kind of things
with the existing static html so there
are two different parts the first one's
pretty simple and i think you probably
caught
you know how to use it pretty easily but
the second one is very
confusing and even once you work with
this for years it's still going to be
something that you're learning over and
over and over again
and perfecting along the way but what i
really want you to take away is that we
can model an html document
in a predictable way and then we can
write a specification called the
document object model
and allow javascript to connect in with
that api to actually modify the static
html now the very last thing before we
get into our lesson
code challenge
is going to be semantic html and i'm not
going to spend a whole lot of time here
but
when we first went through it at the
beginning of this crash course we were
talking about the most simple elements
possible so we've got divs we've got
paragraph tags images
inputs lists all of those kind of things
with the new html5 spec
the
the new thinking on html is that you
know consistent with the concept that we
want to use it for structure
we also want to use it for intent so
what do we intend to use these different
elements for
are we trying to section off a part of
the web page are we trying to make a nav
bar are we trying to make a footer you
know normally you would just put all of
this into
uh div
elements so you can make a header and a
nav bar in a you know blog section and a
sidebar and a footer you can make all of
those things with just divs
but in the new html5 spec
it's you know you're basically supposed
to plug into some of the new tags that
they have available
and in this case instead of using divs
for all of these different um features
of your web page you should be using a
nav bar um so the nav
tag and for your section so like the
blog section that should use a section
tag as well as the
um the sidebar and stuff like that
and then you have this tag called main
which represents the main content of the
page and then you have an article tag
which might represent a single blog post
and then finally you have a footer tag
which obviously represents the footer so
all of these give more semantic more
meaning to the intent of how you're
trying to use your html and it's not
super important for you starting out but
i want you to understand
that it is out there and when you see
other people writing html and people
that are really paying attention to best
practices you'll see those different
elements pop up but remember you can
always look at the documentation if you
ever have a question about a certain
type of html tag
go to the documentation and type it into
the search bar and read about it that's
the only way and the best way to learn
as you're reading through other people's
code all right this has been a pretty
long
html crash course but unlike some like
shorter crash courses i really wanted to
walk you through my line of thinking and
help you be more independent when
thinking about html in the document
object model so hopefully this was
informative and now i have a challenge
for you that's going to really test you
this is a tough one but
i'll go ahead and solve it with you on
video after you've tried it yourself and
hopefully by doing so you're going to
learn a lot about you know how do we
reason through some of these different
concepts and how do we take our static
html and make it dynamic and bring
something to life
so what you see on the screen i showed
it to you before but this is what we're
going to create where we basically have
a random generator for memes and jokes
and random quotes
and then riddles so we can reveal the
answer
and this will be a really cool project
that i think you'll be excited to share
with your network and
be sure to tag me on twitter with it 100
days of code
is the hashtag that you want to use
but i'm really excited to dive into this
so in the next video we're going to be
solving it but i i recommend that you
first try it on your own and see how far
you can get so the link to the code pen
starter pack is in the description and
what you're going to be working with is
basically uh this right here so let me
go back to the starter
portion all right so we have some code
already written for you so i've already
put some buttons in here and i've
already linked up some of the events
that are going to be called and then
i've uh made some template functions
for you that are going to correspond to
those click events
and then finally i have all this random
data down here so a bunch of random
quotes and
uh meme urls and stuff like that and
then then i have a helper function
called get random data where in each of
the methods that you're going to
implement yourself
it's already grabbing a random piece of
data that you just need to figure out
how to
put into the html document and display
it in the right spot once again i'm
leaving a link into the in the
description so you can go through and
see like what are the user stories so
user stories are basically like what
should a user be able to do when they're
looking at this application and so i've
got those written out i also have a few
hints to help you out um just point you
in the right direction on this and then
once you've tried it watch the next
video of this series and we will solve
it together
welcome to the lesson 7 code challenge
and this is going to be basically an
html plus javascript challenge where
we're going to use the dom
to basically loop in our javascript into
our html and bring it alive into a
dynamic
web page that's going to basically
generate random memes jokes quotes and
riddles
so if you haven't seen this before just
you can click these buttons on the right
and it should generate something random
every time we click it
and we can do jokes and quotes and
riddles and
you have to reveal the riddle answer by
clicking this button right here
so
this is going to be a really cool
challenge you can obviously see that
there are some styles already applied to
it and since we haven't covered css yet
in this
full stack roadmap series
that's going to be the next lesson i've
done this for you so i've already wired
up all the css styles and all you have
to do
is write the html and the javascript
to make this thing come to life so let's
go ahead and take a look at some of the
user stories so this is from the blog
post that i
wrote here for this lesson
and just as a recap a user story is
something that we use quite often in
programming to come up with requirements
a good example of a common user story is
every time a user enters
his email
and password and clicks login it the
user should be you know dropped into
their home page within the app you know
that's a basic user story that just says
okay when the user does this this
happens and we have some user stories
defined for this code challenge
the first one is a user should be able
to click buttons on the right side of
the screen to generate random memes
jokes quotes or riddles so as we saw we
can click these buttons and get
something random
obviously going in the correct location
only one piece of content so this is the
second one only one piece of content
should show at a time
so for example if the user clicks show a
meme and there's a quote already showing
the application should remove the quote
and show a random meme
so as you see every time i click a new
button this content right here is going
to disappear and it's going to replace
it with nothing and then generate a
different type of content so right now
we have a riddle if we replace it with a
joke
that goes away down here and our joke
shows up up here so that's another
requirement
the third one content should be
displayed under the appropriate heading
so in other words if i click tell me a
joke the joke needs to show up under
tell me something funny rather than i
want to riddle or something like that
and then
when showing a random riddle the answer
should never be revealed
before the user explicitly clicks to
reveal the answer
so when i click riddle
you're going to see that i get the
riddle but i don't get the answer and i
have to click this reveal riddle answer
in order to get the answer itself
the next one is if a user clicks reveal
riddle answer and there is no riddle an
alert should show letting them know
so in other words
there's no riddle populated down here
and if i click reveal riddle answer
i get an alert up here at the top of the
screen saying there's no riddle forward
to show an answer for
and then likewise if a user clicks
reveal riddle answer and the answer is
already revealed an alert should let
them know that it's already there
so let's go to a riddle let's reveal it
and then let's click this again
and the riddle
is going to say or it's going to say the
riddle answer is already exposed all
right so those are the requirements and
of course i gave some hints here
the div element within
with a unique id or class name can be a
great way to establish a container for
future content so i'll show you how that
works
um we also need to use the html element
dot hidden property so
that has to do with hiding and showing
that riddle answer
it says there's no perfect solution
there's obviously a hundred solutions to
this
and then we got some startup code
all right so here is the starter code
that we're working with
and we have to basically take this which
only has some buttons that don't do
anything yet
and we have to turn it into this a
working
content generator so as we solve this
i'm going to try to walk you through my
thought process a little bit
but i'm not going to spend
uh in
overly detailed amount of time on each
of the components like the main purpose
of this is to give you the solution um
not to basically build an entire app and
think through every last detail of it
so let's go to our starter and we'll
keep this one up so that we have a
template to look at of what we're trying
to do
and then from the starter let's go ahead
and get acquainted with what is here
already
so we'll start in the html section
you can see in this html section we have
let's zoom out just a little bit
we have
some instructions so
notice how we've used semantic html here
so at the end of the previous video we
talked about semantic html how html
should show intent
and what we've done here is we've
created a main
tag which is going to say here's the
main content area
and then we have uh one section which is
going to be the content this is the
empty
area right here and then we have another
section called sidebar which is where
all the actions are
okay so that's what we mean by semantic
html
and it looks like everything has been
implemented for us so we have our
actions our buttons and our buttons are
connected up to click events
that are down in the javascript section
so our content what we're gonna do is
add it right here in the
section with a class called content
all right so
then of course we have css this is just
styling the whole web page for us but
this is not required since we haven't
really talked about how to use css yet
so this should just automatically work
for us
and there's no action required by us uh
in that
and then finally we have javascript all
right so this one's where some of the
tricky part is going to come in where
we're going to be working with the
document object model as you can see we
have some templated functions and we
have our to-do items
so with each of these functions we need
to show a random you know piece of
content in the correct location and
never show more than one at a time so
similar to our
user stories this is just reiterating
that
so we have a show meme function which is
going to be connected up if we look at
our html
it's connected up with this show meme
button all right so if we were to
go down here at the bottom of this
function and just console.log
is working
all right so we've got that connected up
and now we just click show meme
and if we open up the console so down at
the bottom left
and we see is working we know that this
has been wired up correctly so
lucky for us we've got this wired up
already no work to be done there all
right so we've got a show meme then we
have show joke which is um wired up to
this button
and then that does the same thing for
quote and riddle for the next two
buttons and then finally the reveal
answers function is going to be wired up
to this reveal riddle answer button
all right and obviously this is styled a
little bit differently but it's still a
button
html tag
and then at the bottom
you can see a bunch of code that i wrote
already for you which is just a bunch of
content that we can use for randomly
generated content and then it has a
couple of helper methods so it has a
data object
it gets a random number and then it uses
those two things
in this method right here to get random
data so basically what we do is we pass
in
we have a parameter called type and if
we pass in memes we'll get a random meme
and if we pass in
riddles we'll get a random riddle
and you can see that i've already hooked
that up
to these uh functions that are wired up
to the buttons
so
as you can see we have for the meme one
we have already assigned a variable to
this random meme url and if we were to
just console.log
what we're getting here
and then we press
show a meme
um hold on
so show a meme let's go to the console
and you'll see that we get a link
to an image
which is going to represent the meme
all right so
that's the overview of what we're
working with all we have to do is write
some html and then
finish these functions that have already
been templated out for us i think the
first thing that we'll do is probably
the easiest so in our template
you can see that we have these
headings here so this output looks like
an h2 heading
and these ones down here look like maybe
h3 headings or something like that
so let's go ahead and um
put those in there so where it says your
html code goes here
let's make an h2 so all you have to do
in codepen it's pretty easy is type the
um
type the tag that you want to make and
then press tab
and it creates that element for you
so we'll go ahead and type output and
see what we get
looks like we're getting the correct
element there and now we have to go to
the headings
so we want
in the next one we want
an h3
and we want programmer memes
so far so good we're looking okay
tell me something funny so this will be
jokes so another trick you can use in
codepen and also visual studio code once
we start working with it
um if you go to the end of a line and
press ctrl c and then press ctrl v
you'll get the same line
copied down
so let's do that one more time and then
replace the text within it so give me
some wisdom and i want a riddle
actually we need one more
so we've got programmer memes
oh we missed the tell me something funny
so let's do that real quick
all right so we've got our output and
all of our sections defined now if you
remember in the user or in the hints
if we go back here and look at the hints
it says the div element with a unique id
or class name can be a great way
to establish a container for future
content
so what i mean by that
is if we go here and we look at these
headings we obviously have to insert
some sort of html element probably a
paragraph tag
after each of these now how do we you
know how do we know where to put it like
how do we select each of these headings
and have a container to put it after
them well something that i
think is smart to do is create a div
element
which is going to act as that container
for all of our future paragraph tags
which will have or paragraph or image
tags which will have the content itself
so let's see what we're going to do here
so i think what we want to do is after
each of these headings instead of trying
to
dynamically figure out where to put
these different pieces of content let's
be explicit about it so let's make a div
so we'll type div and we want to give it
a class or an id because we want to be
able to identify
this individual div as the container
that we want to put the content in so
for this one let's just give it a class
and we'll call it
meme
content all right so we'll enter down
and basically what we want to accomplish
with the javascript
is we want to identify this div and then
we want to insert our content within
that container that's already sitting
there ready
and waiting for us now we could
programmatically generate a div like
this but it just would be a lot of extra
work unnecessary work and it would
require a lot more code so let's do this
with all of the different sections
so we'll go down here
and now let's just replace these classes
because we want unique identifiers for
our javascript to basically be able to
query so this one will be
joke's content or joke content we'll
stay consistent here
and then quote content
and finally
riddle
content
all right so
these should be able to be selected by
javascript very easily all we would need
to do
let me save this real quick
all we need to do is open up the console
let me
see if i can get this
all right so the console looks like
we're in the right javascript context
and all we need to do is
document.queryselector
and then since we have classes here as
the attribute we need to use the class
selection syntax which is the dot
preceding the name of the class
so if we wanted to select this container
right here called meme content
we can just type in dot meme content
and we should get that div all right so
from there
all we have to do if we want to insert
something in it is we save it in a
variable so we'll maybe say a container
and then from there we say container dot
append child and then this is where we
pass in our generated html element
so in this case let's just go ahead and
create something
for that this is just practice to
understand how we're solving this
problem we're not actually doing
anything yet
so we'll say new element is equal to
document.createelement
and then maybe we want to put in
um let's let's go ahead and practice
this with the meme container so we need
to put in an image
so to do that we type in image tag all
right so we're going to create that
element and then we're going to use
something called the set attribute
property all right so
in order to
create an image element we know how to
do that so let's go ahead and practice
that here
if we say image it's going to give us
a source attribute and an alt attribute
we're going to ignore this alt attribute
because it's not like totally necessary
and then from here we can pass in a url
to an image and that will display it
within the browser here so let's just go
ahead and go down to our data here and
we've got this array of memes so let's
just grab one of the urls just to test
it for a second
and paste that into the source attribute
of our image
and you can see that our image is
coming in there nicely and i've actually
written some css if you were to look
in the css portion i've actually
selected all images here and i've said
that the max width is going to be 350
pixels so it's already going to come in
nicely for you you don't have to worry
about doing that
so this is basically what we want to
insert into that
specific programmer memes area and if we
wanted to do that we've already got our
new image element
and all we have to do here is say new
element
dot set attribute all right so if we
were to if we didn't know anything about
this this is how we'd figure it out so
first we say new element dot
uh node type
so we talked about this in the prior
video looks like we lost the context so
we have to go back to the codepen
context let's see if that
still has this
okay we got to redefine this real quick
so
first let's select the container so we
just got to redo this because it lost
the context that we were working in so
now we have the container which is the
meme content
and then we have to create the new
element
alright so we created an image and now
we just say new element dot node type
and it's going to return us one
now in the mdn documentation
let's go to the mdn documentation real
quick
and let's type in node type this is a
method we learned about prior in prior
videos and you can see in the node
constant or the node type constants a
value of 1 represents an element so
let's click on that element and then we
come down and we can see that within the
element there are methods and one of
those should be
if i'm remembering this correctly is set
attribute so if we click on set
attribute it says that we give it the
name of the attribute we're wanting to
set and then the value we want to set
so in this case if we were trying to
set the
source attribute of an image
we just have to say new element dot set
attribute
source is the name of the attribute
we're setting and then you know maybe
we'll paste in that link that we had
earlier so that will be the value of the
source so we press enter
and now what we can do is basically take
this new element that we have
and we take the container
and we append
child we use the append child method to
pass in that new element
and boom we have a new image showing up
in that section that we want it to show
up in so like i said we haven't actually
done anything this is just practicing
and figuring out
in the live console like okay how do we
actually reason through this what
methods are we going to use all that
kind of stuff
now we should be able to go down into
the javascript and implement
some of these functions to do exactly
this
all right so let's close this out here
we don't need this for for a little bit
and then let's let's refresh the page
because we want a clean slate here
um it looks like
actually not sure why this is still
there
um let's see
oh that's right because we had put this
in here already okay
let's get rid of that we don't want
anything to start off we want this to be
empty
and now let's come down to our templated
methods and in this case we want to show
a mean
right now when we click the button
and we open up the console it's going to
print a random meme url
and we know that this url should be set
equal to the source attribute of an
image tag or image html element
so
we also know how to create that so let's
go ahead and start writing this method
the first thing we need to do is grab
the container that we want to put it in
so we will say container will be equal
to document.queryselector
and then we need to pass in meme
content all right
so we should have the container selected
you could obviously test that if you
wanted to
i think if we just pass it into
console.log
we should be able to do that
and show a meme and we get the correct
container so we're doing good so far
from here we need to
say new image is going to be equal to
document.create
it's a create element or new element i
can't remember
okay so it is create element
and we want an image element
now we just need to set the
attribute so we want to set the source
attribute and what do we want to set
that equal to well we want to set it
equal to a url
and we happen to have that already so we
just drop in the random meme url
and that should set the attribute for us
and then finally
we come down here at the bottom and we
say container that append child and we
pass in our new image
okay
so let's go ahead and save our our pen
here
and when we click this show meme we
should get an image populating in the
right section
and we do all right so
if we click it again
it should put another image in there
after this
and it does
and then another one
and we could keep going with that but
obviously the instructions one of the
user stories is saying if there's
already something there delete it and
replace it with the new one
so we have to figure out how to do that
and a good way to do that is by using an
if statement
so if we come down to our method here of
show meme
we need to ask before we
insert that into
the container we need to say if
the
if there's an existing image there so
how do we do that
one way that i can think of
is if we take
is we'll just say set a variable is
image
equal to
container dot query selector and then
we'll look for an image so basically
what this is doing is it's saying this
container which represents this div
right here
if we grab that container and within it
we look for an image element
and if we find something
then this value is image is going to
represent the actual html element
if we don't find anything
then it's going to return null so we're
going to get nothing
so basically
what we have to do is we say if
is image so if that's a truthy value
which should it should be truthy as long
as it comes back with an image
then we need to clear the contents of
this container so a way that we can do
that is by using the inner html property
and if we go to the mdn documentation
i believe this exists on the node
interface so let's take a look
looks like it's not here so let's search
for that so inner
html
okay so it's on element so on each html
element there is this property called
inner html and it says the element
property
inner html gets or sets the html markup
contained within the element
so a quick trick
this is something that i just have
learned over time you wouldn't
necessarily know it from this
documentation
is you can pass in an empty string to
this property to clear all the html from
a specific container
so if there's an image already there
we're going to say the containers inner
html is equal to an empty string
okay so basically what we're going to do
is every time we click this button
we're going to generate a random meme
url then we're going to create a new
image
we're going to check if there's an
existing image and if so clear it and
then we're going to insert the new image
so basically this is a another way of
saying let's replace whatever's there
so let's try it out
so we got our first image here and
if we click this again
it should replace it
excellent
so we're replacing it correctly we've
got this in the right spot and for the
rest of the methods
we pretty much should be able to
implement the same type of logic
and implement it for all the rest of the
buttons
so let's get rid of this to do because
we have done it we have implemented that
correctly
now one thing i want to do before we
get any further
is implement this clear all method now
the reason i want to do this is because
it's basically
since we see that we have buttons that
kind of do the same thing we don't
really need to write this logic right
here
every single time all we need to do
is we need to write one method that
looks at all of the containers here
and it clears all of the containers
before we replace it with new content
so in order to do that let's go ahead
and take some of this code here
so we'll
take that out of there and put it in the
clear all
so let's rename this variable and we'll
say
meme all right
and
let's go ahead and grab this container
so actually this is not valid code we
need to type document.queryselector
and we need to grab the meme content
container
so
we'll say meme container is equal to
that and this should represent
this div right here now we can do the
same thing for the other divs so the
joke content and the quote content and
the riddle content
so i'll show you what we're gonna do
here like this will make sense in a
second so just bear with me
so we're going to copy this down four
times
we're going to say this one will be a
joke container
this one will be
a quote container
and this one will be a riddle container
and then we of course have to replace
this with
joke
and
quote
and riddle all right so in this
javascript that we just wrote we are
basically selecting each of these
containers that should have the content
that we're putting in
and from here all we have to do is set
the inner html to an empty string and no
matter if there's something there or
there's nothing there it doesn't matter
we're just going to clear it no matter
what
so we'll say meme container dot inner
html equals an empty string
and we'll do that four times over and
just replace these variables with the
correct one
all right so this clear all method is
going to look in all of the different
sections
and it's going to clear them no matter
what's there
so all we have to do down in this show
meme thing is before we append a new
image we just have to call the clear all
method
so that should clear everything out so
let's try it out let's show a meme and
then click it again and it looks like
it's clearing it and putting in the new
one and that's going to happen for all
of these because we're just going to
pass this clear all method into each of
these template functions
okay so the next one is show a joke all
right so we've already got a random joke
text but let's go ahead in console.log
the random
joke text just to see what we're working
with
so let's click the button make sure it's
working and let's open up the console
all right it looks like we're getting a
string that represents the joke so in
this case we want to insert a paragraph
element and put this text content in it
alright so the this should be rather
simple
so we'll say new paragraph
is equal to
document.createelement and we'll put in
a p tag
and then we say p dot text content is
equal to the random joke text so i'm
taking the variable here which should be
equal to a random joke and i'm assigning
it to the new p element that i just
created
and then finally i need to
clear all because i need to clear
anything that's there already
and then i need to insert it into the
container so
before we wrote out a different variable
that selects the container and then we
did it in two steps but we can basically
just do this in one step so we can say
query selector in this case we want to
get the joke content
i can't type
and then at the end we can just chain on
this append child and pass in the new
paragraph element
let's see if that works by clicking tell
me a joke and it's saying p is not
defined
that's because i for some reason
uh just said p instead of new p
so that should work better this time
all right so we're getting um some
content here now this will be the real
test if i click show a meme
does this content get erased and a meme
show up that's what should happen
so let's show a meme
and we see that in the jokes
section there's nothing there which is
great so let's tell another joke and you
can see that we have a joke but no meme
so far everything's working great
so let's go to the next method that we
need to implement so this will be a
quote
all right so let's go ahead like we've
been doing will console.log the random
quote
and we'll click the button
and you can see in the console we get an
object with two keys or two properties
we have the author property and the
quote property both which are strings
so what we want to do here is we want to
display a p or a paragraph
element
and then another paragraph element right
below it with the author
so let's do that
so we'll say
the quote itself is going to be
document.createelement
and that will be a paragraph element
and then we'll say the author
is going to be
document.createelement and that will
also be a p element
now for the text content the quote will
be pretty straightforward we just say
quote.textcontent equals the random
quote
and then we need to actually get the
quote property which is the quote itself
now for the author
text content
we need to grab the random quote again
and grab the author property but we also
want to put that little dash
before it so all we have to do is make a
string with a dash and a space and then
we concatenate that with the
um the author name all right so we've
got our text content
or
let's see if we did this right so we got
our quote and then our author
stored in 2p elements
so now all we should have to do
is first clear all so we clear
everything out and then we come down
here and we say document.queryselector
we want to grab the quote
content container
and then we append
child and we put in the
first we want to put in the quote
and then the next thing we want to do
is grab the same container and put in
the author
so let's go ahead and run this
looks like we got a random quote working
just fine
but this is kind of messy i want to
refactor this a little bit
we'd never want to write the same thing
two lines in a row that's just bad
practice
so what we want to do is we want to
store the container like we did before
in a variable
so let's put this right here
so now we have the container in that
container variable
and now we just have to
call
container.appendchild for both of these
and this should work
still
awesome so now we can do jokes we can do
quotes and we can do memes and they all
kind of clear each other out when
a new piece of content is generated
now the last one is going to be the
hardest one and that's because we only
want to show the riddle itself but we
don't want to show the answer to it
until this reveal riddle answer is
clicked
so let's mark off our to-do's here we
are done with the show quote
we are done with the show joke
and we're done with the clear all method
so we're we're doing pretty good here
and finally we have to show the riddle
so i think what we're going to do is
let's first see what we're getting it
already shows us i already wrote in a
comment that says this is what you
should get but let's just verify it
always good practice
so console.log random riddle and let's
click the button
we get our random riddle with a answer
prop and question prop
so
let's let's go ahead and
um be explicit about this and i'm going
to show you
a little es6 or the latest spec of
javascript i'll show you a trick on how
to
destructure i believe that's the correct
term for it but we're going to
destructure properties off of this
object so all we have to do is we say
const and then we put these little
brackets here
and then we pass in the properties that
we're looking for so we want a question
and we want an answer
and that will be set equal to the random
riddle that we're getting
so now we should be able to console.log
a variable called question
as well as a variable
called
answer right here so let's see if that
is true
all right so we got these printing out
okay and basically what i did here
this right here is the equivalent so let
me comment it out
for a second
what i just wrote there is the es6 or
the latest spec of javascript equivalent
syntax to doing this
so we say
question is equal to random
riddle dot question
and then answer is equal to random
riddle dot answer
so these two lines of code can be
simplified into this single line of code
right here by putting these little
brackets
around there and selecting the property
that you want so that's just a little
trick
thought i'd show you as we're solving
this
all right so we've got our question
we've got our answer now we have to
create our paragraph elements so i think
we're going to show the
question and the answer both in a
paragraph element
just like we did with the quote but we
obviously have to hide the answer up
front so how we'll do that is this
we'll say the
question element will be
equal to document.createelement
we'll put a paragraph tag in there
and then we'll set the
text content
equal to the question itself
and then let's go ahead and take
since we're inserting twice let's go
ahead and get a single variable for the
container
so
document.queryselector
and we'll grab the
riddle
we need a dot at the beginning to select
a class
we want the riddle content div so that
will be
this riddle content div
and that should work and now we want to
say container.appendchild
and we'll put in the question
element
let's see if that works
okay
awesome we have this paragraph element
um
representing the riddle
and now what we have to do
is we have to insert the answer but we
have to make it hidden
all right so i think the way that we're
going to do this
if you remember from the hints
it says you may need to use the
htmlelement.hidden property
so let's take a look at what that is
so the html element property hidden is a
boolean which is true if the element's
hidden otherwise it's false
and you can actually set this equal to
true or false to navigate between
something that shows and something that
hides so that's good to know
we should be able to use that on any
element that we're working with here
all right so what we're going to do is
we're going to create a
similar to this question element let's
just copy this down
and this time it's going to be
the answer
so we'll do answer element
and then that will be set equal to the
answer all right now there's one
additional thing that we have to do
so we've got this button over here
called reveal the riddle answer and
that's going to call
this function down here called reveal
answers
now if we're anticipating in the future
this is something that you'd probably
figure out after you implemented it and
you're like oh shoot i realized this now
but i've already built this i know how
it works
so what i'm saying is that in the future
we're going to have to click this button
and we're going to have to figure out
whether there's a riddle answer
available and whether that riddle answer
is hidden or not hidden
so in order to do that in order to make
our jobs easier we should probably set
an id attribute on this paragraph tag
we're calling answer
so we've already set the text content
so let's let's go ahead and
append this to the html so just so that
you can see what's going on here
so we're appending the answer element so
now when we
say riddle me we get the riddle and the
answer which is obviously not what we
want to do
but what we can do here
is after this we say answer
element dot set attribute
and what i want to set is an id
and then what i want to do with that id
is set it to
riddle answer all right so what this is
basically going to do
is down here in the riddle content it's
going to create a p tag
that has an id
equal to riddle
answer okay and then the answer to the
riddle will be sitting right there
so
later on when we click the reveal riddle
answer button it's just going to say
okay go find me
a p tag with an id of riddle answer
and if that's there
then
if it's there and it's hidden i want to
unhide it if it's not there i want to
alert the user that it's not there
okay so that's basically what we're
doing with that code down here
and then of course we need to
call the clear all method
as we did with all the other functions
and then the last thing we need to do is
we need to
hide this so we need to grab the hidden
property and set it to true on this
answer element
so when i click riddle me we should see
just the question and the answer should
be hidden
so let's click riddle me
and we get exactly what we're looking
for here
so that's good now the last thing we
have to do
so we have completed this to do i
believe
let's click let's just test it by
clicking out or clicking on some other
ones
okay looks good so far
and now we have to implement this reveal
answers so let's go back to our
requirements here
our user stories say when showing a
random riddle the answer should never be
revealed until we click that button so
we got that
if the user clicks reveal and there is
no riddle an alert should let the user
know that there's no riddle there
if it's already there and it's already
revealed another alert should be
popped up
so what we need to do here is we need to
first check
let's see what do we need to check
so what we need to check is if there is
a riddle answer
or not or not a real answer but a riddle
in general
so the way that we do that is we first
grab the
riddle container
which will be equal to
document.queryselector
riddle content
okay so that should give us this div
right here
and then from there
we can say
the riddle is going to be equal to the
riddle container dot query selector
and in this case we want to search for a
paragraph tag
so if there's any paragraph tag sitting
within that div we know that there's a
riddle there
and if we know that there's a riddle
there
then we know that you know we either
need to reveal the riddle answer or we
need to alert the user that it's already
revealed
okay
so now we're going to do an if else if
statement so we'll say if
there is a riddle
if there's a riddle revealed and then we
actually we have one more step to do
so we need to say the answer
is equal to
document.queryselector
and the answer is going to be what we
named it above right here so
riddleanswer is the id that we're
looking for
so we just put this hashtag to search
for an id rather than a class
and we type in riddle
answer
okay so there's our answer and what
we're going to say is if there's a
riddle
and
there is an answer
then i want to alert the user
there is already
an answer
revealed
actually no because
even if there's
an answer
if there's an revie
hidden it's still going to be registered
under this variable so
let's go ahead and test that out real
quick let's comment this code right now
and then we'll console.log
answer
okay so what we would expect
is we've already created in this
previous method
we've created this element
with an id called riddle answer but
we've hidden it so it's there it's just
hidden so what we want to check is when
we search for this by its id
if it is hidden what value do we get so
we're going to console log that answer
i'm first going to click riddle me
and then i'm going to click reveal
answers i'm going to look at the console
and you can see that even though it's
hidden we still found the element within
the dom
using this query selector
so in other words we have to check
whether it's hidden so we gotta
print out answer.hidden instead of just
answer
so let's generate a riddle and then
reveal it and we're gonna see that it
that the hidden property is set to true
so now what we need to do is uncomment
this code
and we're going to say if riddle and the
answer is hidden
then we need to reveal it
okay so we need to say answer dot hidden
equals false
all right so that line of code right
there
should pretty much complete
our
web page here with the exception of
those alerts so let's go ahead and
generate a riddle and click reveal the
answer and you can see that it reveals
the answer right there
okay and maybe we even want to come up
to this method and instead of just
setting the text content to answer we
can put
the answer
is
and then the answer so let's try that
one
it says the answer is an echo so perfect
now the last thing that we have to do is
handle those other cases so else if
so if the riddle
is true so if there's a riddle there and
the answer is hidden we're going to
reveal it
if the riddle is there
and the answer
is not hidden
so right here
um so we basically this is redundant so
if we make it to this else if block that
means that the that either the riddle
was not there or the answer was not
hidden
so if we get here and we say if the
riddle is there
that's all we need to check so if the
riddle is there and we're trying to um
we're trying to unhide it again then
we're going to say alert
the answer is already
revealed
okay so let's see if that works
so we'll click the riddle we're going to
reveal it and we're going to click the
reveal button again
and it says the answer is already
revealed
all right and then the last piece is
just the else statement which basically
means that we
don't have a riddle at all but we're
trying to reveal the answer so we'll say
there is no
riddle to reveal the answer to sorry the
video cut out here i do not know exactly
where i was at but basically we were
just completing the last part here where
if you
click on the riddle and you reveal the
answer it reveals if you reveal it again
it's already revealed
or if you have a random quote and you
try to reveal the riddle answer it's
going to say there's no riddle to reveal
the answer to
so we've pretty much completed this
challenge
hopefully it was fun for you
a quick way that you can share this is
click the share button down here and
share it on twitter be sure to tag me
at zg underscore dev and put in the
hashtag
hundred days of code
that's where you can get support from
the tech community the webdev community
on twitter
and hopefully
um we'll see this popping up a couple
times i think this is a fun little
web page to create with some interactive
javascript
and if you want to customize it a little
bit you can go down to the js section
and replace some of these quotes and
some of these memes and
jokes with your own favorites
in this video in subsequent videos we're
going to be going through a css crash
course so this is all about styling your
web pages now before we get into a lot
of the details i want to show you
exactly what we're going to be able to
build by the end of this and we're going
to use a tool called front-end mentor
because this is basically
a bunch of professional looking web
designs that have been implemented for
us but they have not been coded so what
you do is you click on a challenge and
you can go in and get the design and
then you code up the design and submit
it and get feedback on it so the three
that i've chosen
based on what i want to cover are going
to be this little
single price grid component this will be
the first one that we do right after
getting through the crash course
and it's a nice little introductory
challenge you see that we'll make a
desktop version and then a mobile
version
and then we will move on after we've
gone through a couple other tutorials to
this
testimonials grid section which is going
to help us get through
the skills of flexbox and css grid which
are going to be super important to you
as a developer before i get into the
topics i just want to say that the
prerequisites are basically you got to
know how to write html the basics of
html is all you need
we're also going to be working in the
codepen environment so this is just an
example right here
where we can type out html css and
javascript
so get yourself comfortable with that
and then optionally like i said we're
going to be combining all of our skills
for some of the code challenges so
watching the previous
parts of this full stack developer
series is going to be important
now in this lesson on css i want to go
through what we're going to actually
learn but more importantly what we're
not going to learn i'll be completely
honest when i put this together i got a
little carried away i thought this was
going to be a simple crash course
in css but
was
humbly reminded
that css has a lot of things going on
there's a whole lot of things that we
can cover and i tried to keep it
honed in on the most important concepts
per how i've been trying to do it with
this series but there's just a lot to
cover so as you can see on the left
we're going to be talking through what
is css
and the basics of it we're going to be
walking through the box model which is
basically defining how much space an
element is going to take up on your web
page
that's going to get us into some
discussions on block versus inline
elements box sizing and layouts
and then we're going to cover a bunch of
other things and i'm pretty excited to
share a four-step system that i use when
i create html and css basically take a
design and put it into code because
thinking through that was really hard
for me when i first started and i want
to share that with you
so that's the main core lessons we also
have some supplementary or optional
lessons which includes responsive design
so what happens when your web page gets
put and opened up on a mobile device
like an iphone does it look the same is
it going to have a pleasant experience
for the user
in today's age that's required if you
want to make a web app so we're going to
talk about that in a separate video and
then we're also going to have separate
videos on flexbox and css grid which is
going to allow us to layout our elements
a little bit and like i said we have
this project right here
which gives us a great opportunity to
apply those concepts and put this into a
nice looking grid now what we're not
going to be covering in this crash
course is going to be graphic design and
wireframing now there's a good reason
for that that we're using front-end
mentor because they already have
professional looking designs built out
and implemented for us and i don't want
to waste a lot of time on going into
design principles that i'm not really an
expert at
so we're gonna use and leverage existing
designs and learn how to turn those into
code on a web page don't get me wrong
these are super important concepts
as a full stack developer you always
start with your wireframing and your
design and your requirements and all
that kind of stuff but that kind of
comes later down the road i really want
to focus on the core concepts of how do
we actually turn things into code we're
also not going to cover css
preprocessors i'm not going to talk too
much about it but basically
it's a more convenient way to write css
and it basically allows you to write a
little bit less code and it gets
pre-processed or i guess transpiled down
into vanilla css through a bunch of code
that does that so
sas and less are popular
preprocessors and you'll often find them
on much larger projects where trying to
organize your css is really important
but we're not going to be working with
that we don't have huge projects going
on and it's not essential to our journey
what we're also not going to be talking
about is css frameworks so the last
thing that i want to do in this full
stack web developer series is lock you
into a path
to something that is really popular
right now but may not be in two years
and that's kind of the deal with css
frameworks when i was first learning
bootstrap was huge
every tutorial was talking about
bootstrap and now tailwind is a pretty
popular
css framework and all these frameworks
are doing is taking vanilla css what
we're going to be learning
and writing some abstractions on top of
that and just making it more convenient
to you know lay out elements on the page
and style them more quickly and
efficiently i think it's really
important to understand the bare bones
basics of writing vanilla css and
therefore we're not going to be looking
a whole lot at these all right at this
point i think we are finally ready to
get into the css crash course
as always apologies for the long intro
but i really want to make sure that
we're clear on what we're actually going
through in this lesson the very first
thing that i want to dive into is the
basic syntax of css so we already
learned about html and you might
actually recognize this html diagram up
here from the last lesson now css is
relatively simple and all we're trying
to do
is target a specific html element and
apply some sort of style to it or some
some sort of layout to it in this
example here you can see that we have
defined an html element with a class
called sum dash class
and then down here at the bottom where
we look at our css
we're using something called a css
selector
and we're targeting a class
of some class so we're basically saying
with this rule down here
i want to find any html element that has
a class of this
and then i want to assign this specific
css property
to that specific html element or
elements if there are multiple elements
that have the same class now this is
just one of many examples that we can go
through so in this case we're targeting
a specific class we could also target
ids or html tags and we can do a bunch
of combinations
of the three so we're going to be
walking through how that works and then
we're also going to be talking about
these properties down here so similar to
what we talked about with javascript
when we're looking at
javascript objects where we have you
know some sort of property and then a
value
at the other side of that property same
thing applies here with css we have a
bunch of predefined properties that
we're able to use
to achieve different types of objectives
whether that be
laying out you know html elements on a
page so do i want to put something side
by side with each other or do i want to
just style it so do i want to make the
background green or do i want to make
the text red or something like that we
are of course going to get into all of
the most common properties and selectors
and all that kind of stuff but as with
all the other lessons that i've taken
you through i want to basically
introduce this documentation so this is
the mdn web docs we have visited this
many times
in the prior lessons of this series
but now if we go to technologies we can
go to css
and then we go to the css reference
and then we scroll down
and you should find this section called
index and this is going to list out all
of the possible css properties that we
can use to achieve these layout and
style objectives for html elements so as
we go through this if you ever get lost
you can always look up these properties
that we're using on this documentation
page so we've got the basic syntax of
css and we'll go into that even a little
bit more
but what is the actual purpose here like
what are we trying to do
well there are two things in my head
that css is really good for and that is
going to be layout and style
so how are the elements the html
elements laid out on the page are they
on top of each other are they next to
each other are they in a grid a table
all that kind of stuff
and then furthermore we can actually
apply styles so what color is the text
what color is the background do you have
a background image what kind of font are
you you know working with on the page
so what i did was i put together a
really basic example of this
this is nothing fancy but it just shows
you
don't worry about the css
quite yet here but it basically shows
you how we can combine the two so we've
got a container on the left and a
container on the right and then
furthermore we have
colored borders and a little bit of
colored text within this along with you
know some headings and paragraph text so
this is kind of the ultimate goal of css
we can not only you know do style but we
can also do layouts but if you zoom out
even further the real goal of css is to
target a specific html element or
elements
and apply some sort of styling to that
element or elements there are three
primary ways that we can select and
style html elements with css we can do
it by html tag we can do it by a class
which is the the syntax example that we
looked at a little bit ago then we can
also do it by id
so if we look at this on the page here
let's go ahead and just make a simple
paragraph tag and put some text in there
so the first thing we can do is we can
just target that specific html tag
and give it a different text color and
you'll see that this turns red up here
we can also add in a class so we can say
paragraph
you know element or something like that
and we can replace this by adding a
period before which indicates i want to
target a class
and then you type in the class that
you're trying to target
and then you give it some sort of style
and again we can see the red text there
and then finally we can also have an id
on an element so let's just call
this one abc or something like that
and we can come down here and use a
hashtag
in the front and that's going to say i
want to try to target some sort of id on
the page
and then you type the id and then once
again give it some sort of css property
as you can see we've styled this red
once again if you've been following
along with this series these look
familiar to you because we talked about
them with javascript already
so if we were to come down to the
javascript section
and you know we go through our basic
document
dot query selector
and then we try to target a specific
html element on the page we use the same
selector syntax so if we were trying to
target this element by its html tag we
just drop in the letter p which targets
all or targets the first paragraph
element that it finds on the page we can
also target it by class so once again we
put a dot before and then we
target the class that we're trying to go
after and that's going to find the first
html element
with that class on it and then finally
we can do the same thing with these ids
so we can just type in hashtag and then
the id and we've selected it with
javascript so this is actually a pretty
familiar concept if you've been
following along with this series and
it's relatively easy to kind of grasp
and hold on to but what is not so simple
is understanding what happens when you
have multiple css selectors in a single
style sheet
and they're all targeting the same
element what happens there which css
rule takes precedence over the other for
example if i put in this css style sheet
if i targeted the id right here and gave
it a color of green
let's see if i can write that correctly
and then i also come down and target the
class
and give it a color of red
you have to ask yourself which one's
going to apply we're going to cover that
here in more detail in just a second but
i want to go through a couple other ways
that we can actually target html
elements
when we have some more complex html in
our web page aside from selecting html
elements with tags classes and ids we
also have
something called combinators that we can
do to parse through all the html and
target specific elements and to help us
with this i'm bringing back a diagram
that we looked at in the prior lesson
on the dom or the document object model
and what the dom describes is the
structure of your web page and how the
html is laid out and in this diagram we
talked about how there's grandparents
and there's parents and there's
children children and siblings
based on the level that an html element
is at in the document
so you can see that coming down here
we've got you know an h1 a p tag another
p tag in an unordered list and all four
of these are considered siblings so
that's just a quick review and what we
can do with this is we can come back to
our
playground here and actually select
different html elements based on these
relationships the first combinator that
i want to talk about is selecting
descendants in html so if we go back to
our our visual dom tree you can see that
this div right here has several
descendants so it has direct children
which are these four elements
but then it has grandchildren which the
children and the grandchildren are all
considered descendants of that specific
div so what we can do within css is we
can target all descendants with a single
selector now i'm going to do it the
wrong way first so that we can see why
this matters in the first place
let's say that i wanted to style these
list items right here
one way that i could do it is i could
target the html tag li
and then i can give it some sort of
style so maybe i want the text color to
be green i'm sticking with this color
property because we haven't talked about
all the css properties yet and it's
pretty simple and easy to kind of
intuitively understand
so with this example i tried to
select and style these list items and
did so successfully but by targeting it
just like this we run into problems if
we change the html structure in the
future
and let's say that we put in some sort
of footer so
this isn't going to look great but let's
go ahead and make a div
and then an unordered list and then you
know footer link
number one
and then we'll put three of those in
there so
number two and number three
so this list right here imagine this
being down low in the footer and what we
would want to do with that is we want to
actually make those align horizontally
and we probably want to style them with
a different text color and we probably
want to give them a link
and you see what's happening when we
just
select the li elements all descendants
we're actually picking up these footer
links right here and we don't want to be
so there's a better way to actually
target specific types of descendants
within a document
to allow us to have more specificity
with targeting our html elements to make
this example a little more clear let's
go ahead and add some class
attributes here
so this will be the
we'll call it the main container and
then the second div down here
is going to be called
the footer now this is not semantic html
like we talked about previously but
it'll do the job here
so what we're trying to do is we want to
style just these list items so the the
ones within the main container div but
we don't want to target the ones that
are sitting in the footer because those
are going to be styled a little bit
differently
the way that we can do that rather than
just targeting the li tag what we can do
is we can actually combine selectors so
combinators is what we're calling this
and i can say i want to target the main
container class
and then i want to look for any
list item that is a descendant of that
main container class so the first div
that we talked about here on the left
that's the only div that has this class
and so therefore we're only going to be
styling the ones that we're targeting at
this point we can also add additional
list items to
our main container div and it's going to
get that style so if we were to come
down right after this list
make another div
another on an ordered list
and then put in some text here you're
going to see that that will turn green
because it still is a descendant of that
main container but once again we have
our footer links
you know avoiding that style because
we've been specific in selecting only
descendants of that main div now i want
to stop for just a second and look at
this syntax that we're working with
so you can see that we have a class
selector with this period right here
that determines that and then we have a
tag selector
separated by a single space so what we
call this first one is going to be a
pre-selector and then the li is the
actual selector so in this css rule that
we've defined we're not really targeting
the main container we're targeting list
items so the one that is furthest to the
right is always going to be the html
element that we actually want to style
if we were just targeting the main
container here so if we drop this down
into a separate rule
and gave a color of blue
per se you're going to see that not only
list items but everything else there is
going to get that style so it's very
different saying i want to target this
main container class
and saying i want to target all of the
list items that are descendants of this
pre-selector main container class all
right i'm going to clear all these
styles out and also clear the html that
we're working with
and let's go ahead and drop in some
different html because the second one
that we're going to talk about the
second css combinator is how to select
children of a specific element with the
descendant selector which is just a
space separating two different selectors
we're grabbing everything below a
certain html element but with the
children selector we're only grabbing
the first children so with this div
right here that we're calling an id of
main
we only have three or we have four
different children so we have the first
three paragraph tags and then we have
this div element which are all going to
be considered children so if we wanted
to style just those elements then we can
use a slightly different syntax so
remember we're targeting an id right
here so instead of using a period
we're going to use a hashtag
then we're going to pass in that id
drop down into our css rule
and now what we're going to do is give a
color of
we'll call it green again now this is
just going to target everything because
we're just targeting everything in the
div but if we added a child selector
combinator we can target just those
first three paragraph elements and how
we do that is we use this little carrot
right here
and we type in paragraph tag right after
that so what this is saying
is i want to look at the div with an id
of main
and then i want to grab all of the
children the direct children
that are p tags below that so the only
three that qualify for that rule are
these first three paragraphs and
therefore we style them to have a text
color of green so we know how to select
descendants we know how to select direct
children now there's also a css
combinator or combinators that we can
use to select sibling elements now i
will make the disclaimer that i don't
use these ever i don't know if i've ever
actually used these sibling selectors
and the reason being is because whenever
you change your html structure it's
going to affect the css rules so it's a
little bit brittle
when you're putting these together but
the reason i'm walking you through them
is because you may see them in code
somewhere and it's just good to know
that they exist and how they work to do
this i'm going to copy in a little bit
different html because we need a
different structure to work with
and let me zoom out just a little bit so
we can see more
so within this html you can see that we
have another you know main container and
then we have paragraph elements and list
items uh separated
throughout the html i'm going to get rid
of this css rule right here and now
we're going to select some sibling
elements let's say for some odd reason
you want to style every paragraph
element that directly follows a list
group
so in this case it would be this first
paragraph here and the fourth paragraph
here because they directly followed
these list groups
in order to do that we can use a special
css combinator that selects only the
first
sibling of an element what we call this
is the adjacent sibling selector so
what we'll do is we will grab
let's see how do we do this we need to
grab all unordered list so ul is what
we're going to target and then what we
do is we add a plus sign
and then we target all p elements that
are going to be adjacent siblings to
those unordered lists and from here we
can just assign we'll call it blue this
time and what you'll see is that only
the first paragraph and the fourth
paragraph have been targeted now what i
was saying just a little bit earlier is
that if you change your html structure
at all these rules break so if we were
to come in here and for you know some
reason this is actually pretty common
we wanted to maybe wrap
this
last unordered list in a div so let's
copy this in another div
and then you're gonna see that our rule
that we wrote has broken down so this
fourth paragraph here is no longer
styled with blue text and that's simply
because we changed the structure of that
html
so that's why i'm not a huge fan of
these selectors
they're pretty
fragile in that sense now the last
sibling selector we looked at the
adjacent one which just grabs the first
sibling next to an element but we can
also grab all siblings next to an
element so let's say that we wanted to
style all of these paragraphs
that are direct siblings to an unordered
list the way that we do that is we open
up our css and instead of a plus sign
we're going to use this little tilde
sign right here and what that's going to
do is it's going to look for unordered
list and it's going to look for direct
siblings that have a you know a type
paragraph and give it this style so once
again pretty fragile
i don't use these often but they're good
to know you know how they work and
you might see them in code at some point
and hopefully you would fix them and
make them a little bit more robust over
the last few minutes i've talked about
how fragile these selectors are but
didn't really offer you a better
solution so that's what we're going to
do right now
if i had a situation where
let me go ahead and remove these css
rules
if i had a situation where i wanted to
target
this first paragraph in this fourth
paragraph what i'm going to do is just
give them a class so i'm going to come
to the html and on the first paragraph
i'm going to say
blue text color is going to be my class
name and then i'm going to copy that
same class
down to the fourth paragraph
and now i'm just going to select that
class with our class selector
and then i'm going to give it a color of
blue and now we've achieved the same
exact result but now if we change the
html structure this css rule is not
going to break so that would be the
preferred method at least in my head of
doing that now believe it or not there
are other ways to select html elements
other than these the main three which is
tag class id
and then also the combinators
we have some other ways to do it so
let's say that we had this specific html
right here
so we have a p element and a div element
and they both have the class called
regular text let's say for some odd
reason we want to style all elements
with a class regular text a certain way
but we don't want those styles to apply
to a div element we only want them to
apply to a p element
well one way that we could do this is we
could come down to our css and write
this funky syntax where we actually
specify
the class that we want to target along
with the tags so we're kind of
grouping them all together so what this
is saying is i want to style only
elements that are paragraph elements
that also have this
class so it's kind of like an and
statement
and you come down here give it a color
of blue we'll say and now we have
selected only one of these as opposed to
if we just were to select the
class and then give it a color blue it's
going to apply to both of them so that's
a kind of
obnoxious way to solve this problem
right here it's totally unnecessary but
i just want to show you that there are
other ways that you can do this and
i mainly would say if you're going down
that route i would use it on a
case-by-case basis you don't need to go
out trying to learn all the different
ways because in the end the three main
ways tag class and id are going to be
totally sufficient
for writing good web applications by
this point hopefully you're at least
somewhat comfortable with writing a css
rule that targets a specific html
element we also kind of talked about how
you might target multiple elements i'm
going to write out a couple css
properties that we have not covered yet
so i wouldn't expect you to understand
how they work but just try to follow
along
intuitively for the moment and we'll get
into them later
so we've got this html right here where
we have a div with a class of box one
and then another div with a class of box
2.
and what we want to do with this is we
want to
apply some styles that are going to be
shared across these boxes and then some
styles which are going to be unique this
is very similar to the example we looked
at a little bit earlier where we have
two boxes right here and some of the
styles are the same so these are the
same sized boxes they both have
borders but the borders and some of the
text are going to be different between
the two
so how do we go about you know writing
the least amount of code and achieving
that same result here is going to be the
most inefficient way to do it but it's
still going to work okay
so what we're going to do is we're going
to target box 1 by class and then we'll
also come down in target box number 2 by
class
now at this point we can use some css
properties again we haven't learned all
of these quite yet
but maybe we want to give a border to
both of them so i want to give
box 1 a green border
and then i want to come down and give
box 2
a blue border
so now we have borders around these
elements
and let's also add some padding to both
of them so we'll give them 20 pixels of
padding we'll talk about these units a
little bit later
in this crash course
and then finally let's go ahead and
write some text in here we've got
box box 1 and box 2 and i want to give
these different colors so this box will
have green text and this one is going to
have blue text so far in this example
everything's been a little bit different
but let's say that we wanted to um make
these the same width and height so let's
say that we want box one to have a width
of 200 pixels
and then a height of 200 pixels and then
we come down here with box two and we
give it a width of 200 again
and a height of 200 again
so in this case we've got two boxes that
have some different properties but some
similar properties so one way that we
can actually
simplify our code a little bit and
share some properties is by this special
css syntax where we just leave a comma
between the two classes that we're
trying to select or ids or tags or
whatever you're trying to select both at
once so what this css rule is doing here
um this box one and box two is it's
saying i want to select both
uh elements with a class of box one and
elements with a class of box 2. so what
we can do here is we can take these
width and height properties
and take them out of these individual
styles and go ahead and put them
right here so we've basically eliminated
two whole lines of code and we've
followed the dry principle which is do
not repeat yourself and that's a pretty
important one that you're gonna you know
come across as you develop you know
bigger and bigger software as with
everything in code there's multiple ways
to do this so we could write this rule
right here where we're targeting two
elements at once and applying
shared styles now we can also achieve
the same exact result by instead of
targeting it in our css we can actually
give
multiple classes to a single element so
instead of having just box one and box
two
maybe we have each of these have their
own classes but then they also have a
shared class which is called box
so instead of coming down into the css
and targeting it like this all we have
to do is get rid of these and give them
that shared class and now we're going to
get the same exact result but in a
slightly different way
now honestly this is probably my
preferred way of doing it it just is a
little bit more straightforward and
simple in my head but both of them are
valid ways to you know
provide shared styles to your html all
right for the most part i think we've
covered a lot of the selector stuff with
css but while we're here we do have to
talk about the
pseudo selectors now we're not going to
get into a whole lot of detail here
because i don't think it's extremely
important at this point but i do want to
mention it i want to show you
probably one of the most common ways of
using something called a pseudo selector
so let me get rid of all this stuff here
and paste in a simple button so you can
see that we have a button right now and
you know click it it doesn't do anything
it's not styled nicely or anything like
that
but what we can do with this button is
we can apply something called i believe
it's a pseudo class
and that pseudo class will allow us to
style this button differently based on
different states of the button before we
get into this there is a page on the
documentation if you just type in
pseudo classes to
the mdn documentation you can read up on
it but let's go ahead and get back to
this example and i'll show you exactly
what this does
so what we're going to do is first
target the button so maybe we want to
apply a couple styles to this button
again we haven't gone through the
properties quite yet we're going to get
there
but let's just say that we want to give
a background color of navy and then we
want to give
we'll say text color of white
and you're gonna see that we now have a
slightly better looking button not
really a really nice looking button so
maybe we get rid of the border so that
it looks a little bit cleaner and then
add some padding in here all things
we're going to learn a little bit later
in this course so now we've got a button
that looks a little bit better
not great and what we want to do with
this is we want to
attach this hover sudo class which
basically says i want to target the
button html element
and when it is in its hover state so
basically when i hover my mouse over it
i want to apply these styles so the
first thing that i want to do is give it
a different cursor so when you hover
over this you'll see that the cursor
stays the same but i want it to be that
little clicking cursor
so all we need to do is come down and
give it the cursor property and say we
want it to be the pointer so now if we
hover over this you'll see that the
cursor changes to that hover pointer
another thing we could do is we can
change the opacity of this so maybe we
want to give the background color uh 80
opacity
so now we're going to get a different
cursor and then it's also going to
change color to kind of indicate to the
user that they can click this and it'll
do something
so that is all made possible by this
hover sudo class and then if you were to
go to the documentation there's all
sorts of different pseudo classes
that you can use you know here are a
couple of these
but we're not going to get into a whole
lot of detail on that right now now the
last thing i want to talk about while
we're on the topic of css selectors
is kind of differentiate between two
that we've already talked about
so we've already seen
these multiple selectors so let me go
back
we've got this box example but let me
let me bring this back to the multiple
selectors where we have box 1 and box 2
being selected
and let's go ahead and compare this
to something like where we go with box
one and then we pass in a p tag or
something like that now these are they
look very similar but they're very
different in this case we're saying i
want to target box one and box two
and then in the second rule we're saying
i want to
target any p element so the the actual
selector that exists as a descendant of
the box one class element so they're
very different try to keep those
separate in your head as we go through
this tutorial now that we've covered how
to select html elements with css rules
let's talk about this whole cascading
concept so css stands for cascading
style sheets and what that term refers
to
is the concept of when you've got
multiple style sheets which is possible
and multiple css rules within those
style sheets that all compete against
each other to style the same html
element
it's asking which one is going to win
which one's going to take the most
precedence and actually style the
element before i start writing a bunch
of things i want to show you a tool that
we've actually looked at before
but we
have not looked at yet with css so i
know i've been working in firefox
previously we're in google chrome just
because i've got this google slides up
here
but we can do the same thing we can
inspect elements with the dev tools
and when we come to the elements tab
which is the first one that you're going
to see in all browsers
you can parse through the html
and you know click through and
drill down and figure out which html
element that you want to look at and
then in this right hand pane over here
this is where all of the styles that are
applying to that element are going to be
housed and in many cases you're going to
see multiple styles so let's go ahead
and just click on one of these here so i
don't know it doesn't really matter
but what you're going to see on the
right side is a bunch of styles and in
some cases
you're going to see that they're crossed
out
and what that basically means is that
they have been
um canceled out by another style sheet
or
css rule that takes more precedence over
the one that was written
so that's what you're going to be seeing
all the time with your web pages and i
want to talk about how we determine
which one takes that precedence let's
throw some html on the page here one
that has plenty of things to select so
we have a div with a paragraph element
within it and the div has a class the
paragraph element has a class and an id
so we've got plenty of ways that we can
select this html element and we're going
to do so so the first one pretty easy
let's go ahead and just use a html tag
selector and give it the color red
now let's come down and select a class
so we're going to select
the p element by its class and we're
going to give it a color of blue
so far we've changed what we're looking
at here each time that we've
written a rule
let's come down and be even a little bit
more specific so let's
select this by its id by putting a
hashtag and typing in the id
and then this time we're going to style
it a color green
so in the first case we tried to style
it red then we tried to style it blue
and then finally green and as you can
see within this document this last rule
right here is currently winning it's it
has the most precedence and we're going
to find out exactly why that's the case
in just a second but let's keep going
there's actually multiple ways that we
can you know select this single element
and i'm actually going to paste them all
in because i don't want to
bore you and waste your time by typing
them all out but let's go ahead and
paste all of the different ways that we
can style this same
paragraph element it's pretty pretty
wild how many different ways that we can
do this so we've got the three that we
wrote and then we've got all of these
different ways that are all targeting
that same element
and the question is when we look at all
of these how do we know which one is
going to end up you know winning and
which one's going to apply now i'm sure
the question that you're asking
is why would this ever happen why would
you ever write
10 different rules that are going to
style the same element
well the answer to that is you probably
would not but what could happen is you
could have external style sheets that
are going to come into your project and
they're going to have their opinions on
how you know certain elements need to be
styled and then you've got your own
style sheets
locally within the project and those
have styles so it's pretty common to see
multiple style sheets coming into a
single web application
and it's really important to understand
you know which one's going to win so
there are two ways that we can determine
this or there's two factors in this
equation
so let's go ahead and just write this
out two factors for determining
css
precedence
all right so the first way
is going to be or let's go ahead and
make a
an ordered list because we're just
practicing here so the first way is
going to be
the location of the css rule in the file
and the second one is going to be
the specificity of it so the specificity
of the css rule
now we don't really understand either of
these quite yet but the first one is
pretty simple and the second one you'll
catch on because we talked about it so
much earlier in this lesson so let's
start with the location piece so
location of the css rule in the file
this is really what we're referring to
when we say cascading style sheets
so if we came down here to the css and
we targeted list items so
these two list items right here is what
we're targeting and we want to turn them
a different color
now i'm going to write this rule right
here and then i'm going to take the same
exact css rule but just change the color
to blue
and you'll see that it actually changes
the color to blue but it's not quite
apparent
why the bottom one is going to take
precedence over the top one well that's
just how css works you always read from
the top to bottom and basically the way
that i think about it is
the
the css interpreter that's reading
through and figuring out what to apply
is going to just read from the top and
it's going to say okay i want to style
all my list items
with a text color of green
and then it's going to say okay as long
as i don't see anything else
in the rest of the style sheet or any
other style sheet that comes after it
then that's going to be the style that i
apply
but if i do see something which i do
here then i'm going to replace that
previous style with the most recent one
that i saw when i read it from top to
bottom so that's what we're talking
about when we say cascading style sheets
and that's
one way that we can determine precedence
with css selectors now i know it seems a
little weird because when we worked with
javascript you definitely cannot declare
the same variables and stuff like that
so it seems a little odd that we could
put the same exact css selector in one
css style sheet but this is totally
valid that rule does not apply to css
like it does javascript it's a totally
different type of you know language that
we're dealing with here so we know that
the last selector in the file is always
going to win unless
we have a selector that's higher up but
has more specificity so that is the
second piece of this equation and we're
going to break this out
real quick to see how it works so let's
say that we have these list items right
here and let's go ahead and add a class
to both both of them so we'll just say
list item
something very generic here
and we know that now that we have the
class we can select it in two different
ways so the question i have for you is
if we try to select this with its tag so
just use the li tag to
color the text and then we also added a
rule that selected it by class
which one is going to win over and then
furthermore does it matter which order
we put them in in the file before i type
this in just pause the video and see if
you can kind of reason through that
for a second
all right so let's try this out first
we're going to select it by the
tag and we're going to give it a color
of
green
then we're going to select it by its
class and we're going to give it a color
of blue
and you're going to see that it changes
to blue but we don't quite know yet why
this is the case because in the first
rule that we talked about we said okay
we read top to bottom and we're always
going to take the last rule and apply it
so that would make sense here because
list items the last rule in the file and
it's got a color of blue so that's why
it's styled that way well that's
actually the wrong answer
the reason that it's styled blue is
because the second rule is more specific
than the first
so if we were to take this and put it
before
this other selector
we're still going to see blue text
because
even though this is last in the file
this first one is more specific so the
question is how do we know what is more
specific than another to figure this out
we just need a little visual which says
that um on a continuum from the left to
right so least important to most
important or in other words least
specific to most specific
we have tags then classes and then ids
so you might have picked this up by now
but if we were to put an id so let's say
list item number one
and we try to style this um let's go
ahead and put at the top of the file to
make sure that we rule out this whole
you know first to last uh stuff that
applies
and now we're going to select it by its
id and we're going to give it a color of
orange
in this case you're going to see that
this specific one
it's not applying to both because you
can't assign an id to two different html
elements
but when we're looking at this first
element we're selecting it
uh one time right here
another time right here and then a third
time right here and this top one despite
being at the top of the file is going to
be the most specific because of this
continuum right here and therefore it's
going to be the one that wins out and
applies the style to that html
element if you're following along
intently
you're probably asking yet another
question and that is what about these
combinators that we talked about earlier
in the video
what happens
if i get rid of all these css rules
and i come in here and let's say that i
select it by just its id and i give it a
color of green
and then i also come in and i say
i want to select
let's see
i want to go ahead and look in all the
ordered list
and i want to target all the
list items that have an id
of list item number one
so this is going to be the same exact
element that we're selecting so it's
going to be the first one right here
but let's go ahead and see if we can
turn this a different color with this
selector right here
and we can and even if we take this and
we put it at the top of the file
we're still going to get the same result
it's still going to be blue because this
rule right here
is more specific than this one right
here despite the fact that we're using
the most specific selector according to
this little continuum
so as you can see it gets a little bit
tricky here when we start using
combinators but there is two ways that
we can
identify pretty reliably which one's
going to win out
the first one is probably my favorite
which is to just try it out and in this
case it's really easy we're using
codepen
and we can just try it out and see what
works but that's not going to give you a
really good understanding of why it's
working that way so there's another
method that we can use where we can
actually calculate with numbers the
level of specificity of a css rule
let me lay out the steps here
we'll go ahead and practice some html
for a second so let's go after this
first list item
actually the second list item because
we're talking about specificity
and let's make another ordered list
so the first step that we're going to do
is we're going to count
the number of id selectors in the css
rule so that's step number one
then we're going to come down we're
going to count the number of class
selectors
and then finally we'll count
the number of tag selectors
all right so if we're looking at these
rules down here
let's go ahead and apply this math and
we'll first count the number of id
selectors in the css rule so both of
these
have a single id so they have one id now
if we go down to the next one count the
number of class selectors they both have
zero
and then finally the number of tag
selectors the first one has one but the
second one has zero
so the way that this is going to work
out we can write some
css comments right here and i might as
well just go right above the actual rule
so if we use this little comment syntax
which is a forward slash and a star and
then a star and a forward slash to close
it out
and we can count this up so we'll say id
selectors
this is going to be one
we'll say class selectors
it's going to be zero and then tag
selectors will be one so if we add these
together we get a number of 100 and one
if we do the same exact
little math problem here let's copy it
down to this next rule
we can say that the id selectors we have
one we have zero class selectors and
zero tag selectors so our number is
going to be 100. so in this case the
second rule has a specificity of 100 and
this first one has a specificity of 101
which means it is one
point or whatever you want to call it
more specific and therefore it will be
the one that applies to this element to
really nail this concept i'm going to
paste in some code so we don't have to
type it all out and i'm just going to
walk you through a few more calculations
all right so we've got a little bit
different html but all it is is a
paragraph tag with a bunch of ids and
classes to give us
flexibility on how we select them so in
the css i've written several rules that
are going to be at different levels of
specificity and let's just walk through
how each of them are calculated
so our first example we have two classes
so
we get 0 to 0 and our total is 20.
come down here we have two ids so this
is going to be
uh
actually should be oh no we're in the
wrong spot here so we've got two ids
zero classes and zero tag selectors so
our specificity is 200
come down to the next one we've got a
tag and we've got an id
so we have 1 0 1 for 101 and then you
get the point we just go down and do the
same thing for the rest so the most
specific one is the one with two id
selectors for a specificity of 200 and
you can see that the color orange is
what applies to this
paragraph element in the web page
hopefully at this point it's making
sense we know how to select things we
know how to determine the
order of precedence but there are a few
other little gotchas that we need to
walk through and one of those is going
to be inline styles so if we were to
write a paragraph element with some text
we can come down to the css and we can
style it of course
but we also have the option if we give
it this style attribute which is just an
html attribute as we talked about in a
previous lesson
we can pass in css style rules into this
these little quotations so i can give it
a color of blue and then maybe i can
give it some padding of 10 pixels
and we separate this by these semicolons
and we can write as many rules as we
want to
now the interesting thing about these
inline styles is they take precedence
over everything else
so even if we were to come in here and
let's say that we give it an id
of you know paragraph or something like
that so let's go ahead and select our id
and let's give it a text color of orange
you would think that because of this css
importance diagram that this is going to
be the most important rule and the color
is going to be orange but obviously it's
not it's blue and that's because any
inline style is going to take the utmost
precedence over all styles
now there's one more thing that even
makes it a little bit more confusing and
that is the important keyword
so if we came down into this style right
here
and we put a space
an exclamation mark and we typed
important
what that's going to do
is it's going to override any style from
any style sheet and it's basically
saying like this rule right here is very
important and i don't want to look at
any of the precedence rules that we have
defined within the css language so even
though we've got these inline styles
this is still going to apply and even if
we came down here and changed this from
an id selector to a paragraph selector
same deal we're still going to get this
orange color because we've defined
important on that css property now we
can use this important keyword on any
property that we want i've been looking
at the color property mainly just to
stay consistent
and avoid confusion before we actually
dive into all the different properties
but this can be applied to anything else
so if you wanted to override the padding
style
and say 50px or something like that if
we put it in just like this not going to
change anything but if we put an
important at the end you're going to see
that this text moves a lot because we've
added some padding
so that's the whole deal with important
but i would recommend that with both of
these types of selectors so the the
inline selectors and the important
selectors
use them at a minimum in reality you
almost never want to use these inline
styles because it just clutters up your
html
now i've of course used it all the time
because it's very quick it's a great way
to just quickly put a style on an
element
and there's actually several css
frameworks that
do inline css only so you don't even
have separate style sheets you just all
you write it all in the html document so
it's kind of a contentious topic
among different camps but in general you
probably want to stay away from these
inline styles for now
just because it's going to clutter up
your code
likewise with the important style i
think this is a more unanimous
viewpoint
you should not be using this important
keyword unless you absolutely have to
and the only um example of this that i
guess i've experienced that's a really
good reason to use this important
keyword
is if you've got multiple style sheets
so maybe you're using a css framework or
a ui kit library that's got a bunch of
like buttons and modals and stuff like
that those are going to have predefined
css styles and if you want to override
them
often you have to use the important
keyword otherwise there's no other way
to select them with enough specificity
to override the existing styles so once
again use the important keyword only
when you have to
pretty good rule of thumb to stick with
for the last hour or so or however long
i've been talking here we haven't really
talked about css properties yet we've
been using the color property
among a couple others
but there's hundreds of them that we can
possibly use to
both position the elements on the page
and style them so remember css is all
about layout and style and there's
different properties that allow us to do
those two different things
so to start us off let's just see a
super basic example something that you
might
have to do pretty often and that is
let's go ahead and take a a div put some
text in it and then style that as a box
with specific dimensions maybe a
background color and a border or
something like that
so here's how i'd approach that with css
so first you have to make the div then
you have to put some text in there so
some text
and i guess what we want to do is first
get that background on there so i'll
just select the div since there's only a
couple elements here
and we'll give it a background color of
i don't know we'll call it navy
we'll give the text color white
we want to give that div a width of say
200 pixels and a height of also 200
pixels so we've got us ourselves a
square with some text in it but maybe we
want to put that text in the middle of
that square so we can do that that would
be kind of a layout or a positioning
type property so one way we could do
this pretty straightforward is going to
be add a line height and set that equal
to 200 pixels which is the same height
as the square
and then maybe we want to just set the
text alignment to center so that's going
to bring it to the middle of the square
and then we can furthermore put on maybe
a box shadow
something like that so let's just
write something out really quickly and
you'll see what happens as we get a
little shadow
showing
on this box and then maybe we could even
i don't know we could
put a border on it or something so we
could say border one pixel solid i don't
know something like green it's not gonna
look great but you see that we have
maybe we can put five pixels instead of
one to make it more visible and now you
can see that we have a green border on
there
so this is just a super basic example
but you can see how we use some style
properties and we use some positioning
properties
and this is actually not perfectly
centered anymore and we'll talk about
exactly why that's happening when we get
into the concept of the box model but
let's get rid of this
and ask the question that you're
probably wondering and that is how do we
know what css properties to actually use
i just went through that example really
quickly and i had these on the top of my
head because i've just been doing it for
a while but when i first started i would
have no idea how to do what i just did
and i have to look up every single
property that i was using and
furthermore i'd have to look up like if
i wanted to do something i'd have to
type into google how do i center
a paragraph element within a div or
something like that so it's really
difficult without experience to know
what properties to use and when
and there's really no great solution to
that other than practicing and really
you know just applying these concepts
that we're learning in this crash course
in my opinion the best way to understand
the box model better is to just look at
it interactively
and a great tool to use to do this is
the firefox dev tools so we've talked
about this in prior lessons
but we're coming back here and as you
can see i've got this html document here
in
the browser
and then what i've done is i've selected
the
content element that i've just made a
single div
and i've put some text in that div
and what i've done is i've applied these
five
uh styles that are pretty directly
related to the box model to see how
these play out you know
on an actual web page so as you can see
if we go to the layout section of the
dev tools so we're up in inspector we go
to layout and then we can scroll down
to see the box model
and this gives us an incredibly
interactive way to see what each of
these represent
so if you go through and you want to see
how you know why does the content and
how tall is it
you come into these little
properties and you can hover over them
and you see on the left side of the
screen it gives you an outline of
exactly what that is applying to
furthermore we can see that we've got
some padding in here and again it's
highlighted up on the screen it gives
you a really nice
outline of where that padding sits
furthermore we've got a border it
outlines that really nicely for us and
then even some margin on the outside
now there are other tools that help you
visualize this like in google chrome so
if we came back to
google chrome you can see that if we're
just looking at it i don't know let's go
ahead and just select one of these
elements here then you can come down to
the box model and you can kind of see
what's going on but in my opinion it's
just not quite as good as firefox so
that's why we're working in firefox in
the first place but tools aside what
actually is the box model well the box
model represents
these pieces that we're looking at but
more specifically you have the content
itself which is going to be you know
text or just some space that we've
defined by a width and a height
and then outside of that content we then
have some sort of padding or like it
doesn't have to be set it could be zero
padding but in this case i defined 20
pixels of padding
and then outside of that we have a
border and then outside of that we have
a margin and within this box model
i mentioned that it tells us how much
space an html element represents within
the web page and the properties that
play into that are going to be the width
the height the padding and the border
now the margin is a little bit different
because while it does take up space
it doesn't actually define the space
taken up by that individual element it
kind of adds like some space around the
element um so that if you have two
elements and they're squashed together
you can just kind of space them out a
little bit
so those are the components of the box
model let's go ahead and dive in with
some
i actually made a code pen that's going
to allow us to interactively play around
with this box model so on my screen i've
got a code pen that's i've got some
javascript written up in here you can
drop down these uh select
elements and select different css
properties to apply to this orange
paragraph tag up here and why i created
this is because when we're talking about
the box model sure we can get into width
height
padding border margin all that kind of
stuff but what's really confusing about
the box model in css in general is that
based on the
values that you're passing to certain
properties the rules of the game
completely change
and to highlight some of those rules
i thought it would be helpful to put
together this example
and just visually walk you through like
if we switch a certain css property what
is that going to do to our html element
that we're targeting the first property
that i want to really touch on and dig
into is the display pop property so
this is a related property to the box
model and once again the box model is
not just one thing
but this is
highly related to what we're talking
about here and if we scroll down to our
documentation i've just gone to mdn
technologies
css
the reference and scroll down to the
index
and we can find the display property
somewhere in here so let's scroll down
see if we can find it
here's the d
section and we'll go ahead and click
display
so it says this property sets whether an
element is treated as a block or inline
element in the layout used for its
children such as flow layout grid or
flex so there is a lot packed into this
single property and honestly it's
probably the most
complex property that you'll deal with
when you're writing css but we're going
to dig into each
piece of it and you're not going to have
to read all this documentation i'm just
going to walk you through it
so you can see that there's a couple of
or there's there's a lot of different
things that you can pass to this
property
but the main ones are going to be block
inline
inline block
flex and grid so if we came back to our
box model example
if we came down to the display type
right here and did the drop down you can
see that we have all of these different
possible values excluding flex and grid
and the reason we're excluding those is
because flexbox and css grid are going
to be totally separate videos
that are going to require a lot more
explanation so for now forget about
those we're just going to focus on these
ones right here
so by default whenever you're dealing
with most html elements you're going to
have a display property
of block but at this point doesn't mean
anything to us like what does block mean
what does inline mean since flexbox and
css grid are kind of out of the equation
here we're just focusing on block inline
and inline block display types
and based on what you set your elements
they're going to
interact with the page and flow through
the web page a lot differently so it
kind of changes the rules of the game
now by default each element is going to
have a certain type of display
now most elements are going to have a
display type of block and you can see in
this example
that the default display type of a p
element is block
but if you were to look at another type
of element so if you come up to the html
that we've got here it's a little bit
messy but this span element which is
represented by this green text
that's actually going to be by default
an inline element so the question is how
do we know which elements are going to
be by default a block and which ones are
going to be by default inline and then
furthermore what do they actually do
what what's the difference between a
block and inline element
to understand this
we've got this example laid out so watch
what happens when
i switch
a block element to an inline element so
i'll drop this down i'll say inline and
you'll see that that orange
div is going to jump up to the line
before it and it's going to share that
same space with the span element
now that's the behavior of an inline
html element so what you'll see here is
that since a div element has a natural
display type of block what it's going to
do is occupy a hundred percent of its
container space and in this case the
container is 100 percent of the body
html tag so it's occupying all of that
space
and furthermore the height if we don't
give it a height specify it explicitly
it's going to automatically take up the
height of the content within it so
however large this text is is how
big of a height this element's going to
occupy the second thing about block
elements is that these elements occupy
their own space they don't share lines
with other elements
so as you can see here our div
in orange with the orange background
occupying all the space and it's also on
a different line than this green
span element that's right above it
and the span element actually has a
default value of inline rather than
block so
different rules up there but since this
one is a block then no other element can
occupy the same space as it the next
thing about a block element is that it
respects its width and height properties
so that doesn't make a whole lot of
sense yet but you will see what i'm
talking about in just a second
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
drop down the content width and this is
just going to apply a 400 pixel width to
the orange element so you can see that
it no longer takes the entire width of
its container because we've explicitly
given it a width
and then furthermore we can give it a
height of 200px or pixels so now it's
occupying a space of 400 by 200.
so
what happens if i were to
do the same thing with an inline element
let's go ahead and see so i'm going to
reset all of the properties so we're
going back to the beginning and now what
i'm going to do is come down here and
set our div to be a display type of
inline and you can see when i click that
it comes up onto the previous line
because inline elements
actually can share space they don't
break to a new line by default you'll
also notice that they don't occupy all
of the space they just occupy the size
of the content within them so
it's just occupying the
text that's within this div because
we've set it to that display type of
inline
now the last interesting thing is that
unlike a block element that obeys
or adheres to its width and height
properties
the
inline element is not going to so even
if we set the content width to 400
pixels
not going to change at all we can also
try that with the height set it to 200
pixels
not going to work so in other words if
you set it to inline
width and height css properties are not
going to work on it so as you can see
depending on you know one property's
value you have different rules of css
which can get pretty confusing sometimes
and it's why i'm spending so much time
on it here now the last one that we have
not talked about is a combination
between the two
so just to review a block element it's
going to take all the space of its
container it's going to take a height of
the content within it and it's going to
break to a new line and respect its
width and height properties an inline
element is going to just be the width
and height of the content within it it's
not going to break to a new line and
it's also not going to respect the width
and height properties if you try to set
them now an inline block kind of adopts
a couple attributes of both so the the
main difference if we were to switch
this inline to inline block
then the only difference is now it's
going to respect its width and height
properties
right now we don't have those or i guess
we do have those set we have tried to
set the content with in the content
height but because we have an inline
element right now
it's not respecting that those
dimensions but the second we change this
to inline block
we're going to get those width and
height properties back just like we saw
with the block
but in this case we can still make it
inline so although it's broken to a new
line here that just happens to be the
case
because it's too large to fit on that
line above
so inline block just basically takes all
the properties of inline but instead of
ignoring width and height it now
respects those properties and takes that
space up
this concept may not seem super
important to you right now but i promise
you as you go through
knowing whether you're dealing with a
block element or inline or inline block
is going to be super important and then
further down the road when we start
talking about flexbox and css grid
it becomes even more important to
understand this kind of stuff
let's go ahead and reset everything here
and the next thing that we need to talk
about are box model variations so to
this point we just looked at the firefox
dev tools and you can visualize the box
model pretty well but there's actually
another
way of you know conceptualizing this box
model and using it just like the display
property and all other css properties
have their default values
the box type down here is going to have
a default value of content box so that's
what we're seeing right here
but we can switch this to be something
called border box which is basically
going to change
how all of those properties so width
height
padding border and margin it's going to
change how those
relate to each other within the box
model to understand this let's go back
to our firefox
dev tools
and let's go ahead and calculate the
total size or space that this particular
element is taking up
so the way that we would do this is by
adding things together because
the default box type is content box
so basically what we have to do is if if
we wanted to find the total height of
this element over here we could of
course just hover over it and we can see
exactly you know what the height is but
if we wanted to calculate this
we just come down into the box model and
we say okay what is the height of the
content
well the height of the content is going
to be a hundred pixels
so we say a hundred and then we add on
whatever the padding is on both sides so
we add the top padding and the bottom
padding which on both sides is going to
be 20 pixels
so we go 20 plus 20 is 40
plus the content height of a 100 is 140
and then on top of that we add the
border dimensions which is going to be 5
pixels on the top in the bottom
so in total the total height or space
and height that this occupies on the web
page is going to be 100
plus 20 plus 20 plus 5 plus five so that
equals i guess 140 150 in total
and then the margin the additional 20
and 20 or 40 pixels that's not actually
going to play into the box model that's
kind of separate from it it doesn't
actually
indicate how the total height of this
element so let's go ahead and see if we
can hover over this and you'll see that
if we hover over the entire element it's
showing in pretty small text that the
height is 150 just like we calculated so
again 100 plus 20 20 5 and 5 is our
total height and then likewise we can do
that with the width so
we grab our content width which is 400
we add both of the paddings on the left
and the right which is 40 so we got 440
and then we add the
uh
border which is 5 and 5 so we got 440
plus 10 is 450 and that's when we hover
over it is what the
width is going to be
so that calculation that we did seems
awfully complicated and it kind of is
because we're having to add all these
different components and
consider okay what's the left padding
what's the right padding what's the left
and right border you know it would be a
lot easier if we could just define i
want this element to be 400 pixels wide
and 200 high and be done with it and
then have all the rest of the padding
and border and stuff just be within it
and that is what the border box
value of the box type property allows us
to do so all we have to do is come to
the styles of the element and then we
say box type
and we say we want border box
now if we apply that
it's not going to work because let me
see why
invalid
property name oh i must be blanking on
what we're actually using here let me
let me
see what we're talking about here so
box type so i was totally blanking out
it's not it's not box type it is box
sizing that box type is just what i
named it in our code pen but if you say
box sizing equals border box you'll see
that this changes just a little bit so
let me go ahead and uncheck this and
watch the content up in the left
top left
you'll see that something is going on
here
and it's really hard to tell what that
something is when we just have one
element on the page but what i've done
is put together another code pen that
really helps us visualize the difference
between
the border box and the content box now
stick with me here because i know it
seems a little bit boring and why would
we need to worry about box sizing but
when we start making grids and we start
you know putting elements within other
elements it's going to become really
important to know you know how much
width do we need to give to children
element to fit within the parent
container so on and so forth so let's go
ahead and dig into that example that i
created and you'll see exactly what i
mean so as i mentioned when we flip that
box sizing from a content box to border
box
it basically takes the calculation of
the space that html is occupying and it
changes it so now instead of taking
the content height plus the padding plus
the border to get our total height
we just look at the height property and
that is our total height
and it's a lot easier to kind of
reconcile in our brains
and furthermore it makes it a lot easier
to put elements within other elements so
as you see on the screen here
what we're looking at is a couple of
divs and i've got a child div and a
parent div and what i'm trying to do is
i'm trying to fit the child div within
the parent
and not have it break out of its space
and if you see on the right side where
we've got the output of this
you can see that the content box we've
got the parent container which has just
a that's just a picture background
that's not css
um but that's the space that it's
occupying and you can see that the child
with that border on it because border
you know has
an impact on the total size of a content
box you can see that by adding that
border we're breaking out of that parent
container and that's really going to be
a problem when we're trying to arrange
elements on the page
so furthermore if we were to add padding
to this so
basically what this button is going to
do when we click it is it's going to
take the child element which is the one
with the border on it
and it's going to add some padding to it
so when we click this you'll see that it
makes it break out of our parent
container even more and that's because
when we add padding or a border to
something that has a box sizing of
content box it's going to add space to
that element it's it's always going to
be additive now when we come down to a
border box type element
it's not going to so what's going to
happen is the
the content width and height is going to
be adjusted based on how much border and
padding there is so you can see from the
start we're already fitting the child
element which is
got the black border
right on top of the parent container
and if we add some padding instead of
getting larger it's just going to make
the content within it a little bit
smaller
so let's toggle the padding and you'll
see that this text right here is going
to come inwards a little bit
but we're not going to see the the
border break out of that parent
container
so
i understand this is a little bit
confusing especially if you're just
starting out in css but i really wanted
to introduce this concept because
you will stumble upon this down the road
and you'll probably see like i said
something like a css reset so let me let
me go ahead and grab that code that i'm
talking about and show you exactly what
i mean
oftentimes you'll see in
a css
style sheet the following thing and this
is going to change the stuff over on the
right a little bit but that's not the
point
what you'll see is that on the html
element or the root element they're
going to change the box sizing to border
box so it's going to take the root style
and make it you know this nice little
handy border box where you know the
width is the width and the height is the
height and there's no math going on
there and then these next couple of
rules
similar to what we talked about where if
you put a comma there it will select
multiple you know classes or ids or tags
or whatever that's what these are doing
and this is a wild card character that's
basically saying i want to target every
element in this entire document
and then what it's doing
is it's saying i want to set the box
sizing property to inherit which is
basically basically going to look up and
say okay what is the root element set to
whatever that's set to
inherit that down to all of the
different elements on this web page so
in effect what we call this is a css
reset and it's going to
change the default box sizing to this
more
easy to understand border box you know
box sizing all right i know we've
covered a lot we've come a long way in
this crash course so far we're not done
yet but i want to do a quick little
review on a few things
so we've learned about how do we select
things
how do we select html elements we've
learned about what takes precedence when
we have multiple css rules and we've
learned about the box model and what i
want to review here is the box model
just go through a few things that you
should keep on the top of your mind
so first off the box model describes how
much space an html element occupies
the space is heavily influenced by that
box sizing property
that we just talked about whether that's
content box or border box so content box
you have to add the content width and
height to the padding in the border
well with the border box you just take
the width and the height and that is the
total space that your html element
occupies
so the space is also or space and layout
is also heavily influenced by the
display property so whether we have a
block element an inline element or an
inline block element is going to
influence where those elements are
sitting on the page so those two
properties box sizing and display are
going to really play together
deciding how our web page is laid out
and furthermore that display property
has two additional
values that we
have not talked about but will so
flexbox and css grid which is going to
allow us to make grids and it's going to
allow us to space elements out really
well
so that's going to be super useful to us
in the future and finally the most
important components of the box model
are height width padding border and
margin
margin doesn't play into the total space
it occupies but it does control the
space around it and then finally all
other css properties are going to be
kind of supplemental to these core
concepts so whether we're styling the
text color or we're doing a background
image or making a different font those
are all going to be just kind of
supplementary to these core concepts
what i would recommend is that you come
to this uh
little example that i put together
it's in the description
and just click through all of these
uh attributes and or not attributes but
css properties and see what happens with
different combinations so change the
display type to inline and then try to
set you know different margins and
paddings and stuff like that and you'll
see like okay the margin doesn't really
do anything when it's in line but the
padding does and then if we set this to
block and then change the margin then it
is going to do something
aside from the
display property and the box sizing and
a couple other things we just talked
about there's one other css property
that you'll use pretty often and it will
affect the flow of the elements on the
page
and that's going to be the position
property so this position property has
i think about four or five different
possibilities so let's go ahead and
write those out
we need to make an unordered list and
then put some list items in let me get
my notes here
so we can have a value of static
we can have a value of absolute
we can have a value of relative
and then we can have fixed and the last
one is going to be sticky so when i'm
talking about this
position property all i'm saying is that
if we came down
and targeted this unordered list
and then we gave it a position we can
say
we want it to be fixed but what does
this actually mean well this position
property is going to be really handy
when we have to
lay out things on the page and like make
things like nav bars
so that's what i'm going to go ahead and
show you is an example of how we might
make a nav bar
and show how that will stay at the top
of the page rather than scrolling down
when we have content that exceeds the
total height of the viewport or the web
page that we're looking at a few notes i
want to make
this first one the static
is going to be the default value so if
we came down here and defined
the position of this unordered list to
be static that's kind of redundant
because it's already going to be that by
default and then the other node i want
to make is
the sticky property
value is going to be a little bit newer
it's unsupported in some browsers and
i'm not really going to touch on it
because we can achieve very similar
things with this fixed property
all right so those are the possible
values let's walk through each of them
and see what they actually do for our
html
so the first thing i want to do is
create a nav element so we talked about
semantic html in the prior lesson how we
want to use what the intent of that
element is and if we want to make a nav
bar we should use the nav
html tag
so within that nav we can make some sort
of list which would be kind of a list of
different links or something
but just to keep it simple i'm just
going to put in some sort of heading so
we'll just put in an h2 element and
we'll say
this is the nav bar
so you're going to see that pop up on
the page
and it's nothing special at the moment
and actually let's go ahead let's make
this an h4 just to be a little bit
smaller
and what we want to do in the css is we
want to target that nav element we want
to give it a background color of blue
we're going to talk about those
background styling properties so bear
with me
here well we don't know about them
and then i want to make the height of
this equal to we'll call it 60 pixels
so you can see we have some sort of nav
bar sitting up on the page
and i actually don't like this blue
let's go ahead and do navy and then
change the color of the text
to white just to make it look a little
bit better and what you'll see is
there's some space going on around this
we would you know ideally want this to
be at the top of the page you know have
no white space around it and that's
happening for two reasons by default
this h4 element is going to have some
sort of margin around it it's just a
browser default
that is set on this element we didn't
set it but it's already there
likewise codepen has a default that puts
some either margin or padding
within the body element so anything that
we write in this html is going to have a
little bit of padding in there so that
you know we have this white space so all
we have to do is just cancel that out by
writing a css rule so we'll start with
h4 and we'll just say we want zero
margin on there see what that does
remove some of the margin
and then
we want to come down and say on the body
we want to have
zero margin i don't yeah i guess that's
all we needed we just need to zero out
the margin and now there's no space
around this so
looking good there and if we wanted to
center this text within the nav bar we
can use a little trick um we can use the
line height property to basically say
okay i want this text to be
you know x amount of pixels tall
and in this case we know exactly how
tall the nav bar is 60 pixels
so what we need to do with this h4 is
make the line height equal to
60 pixels and now we're going to see
that go right in the middle
and the last thing we'll do is on the
left side of that h4 element let's just
put some padding on the left of say 10
pixels and that's going to push it out a
little bit
so i know we haven't talked about a lot
of these properties we will in a second
but
you can see how this is the snav bar is
coming together but the problem is right
now if we were to scroll down on this
page the navbar is going to kind of go
away and we don't want that
since there's no other elements when i
scroll you're not going to see anything
so let's go ahead and add
a
div that has a bunch of boxes in here so
we'll say
we want to div with a class of box and
then let's replicate that several times
down
and then we'll come down here and style
all the
classes of box and what we're going to
do is we're going to give it a width of
200 pixels and a height of 200 pixels
and let's go ahead and give it a
background color of
i don't know green is fine for now
you're going to see just big one big
blob because they're all kind of
smooshed together
but all we have to do is add some margin
around it and those are going to be
separated out
so the reason that i created those is
just to give us more than enough content
so that we can actually see some
scrolling action
so now you'll see the scroll bar here on
the right because we've got too much
content for the visible screen
and when we scroll down
what happens we're not going to see that
nav bar anymore and as you're probably
used to with most sites the navbar needs
to stay up top
and the way that we do that is by using
the position property and we can just
come into the
nav bar right here and we can say that
we want the position to be fixed
and what that's going to do is a lot of
things that we don't expect and it's
going to look a little bit intimidating
for a second until we figure out exactly
what's going on
so when we put it to fixed it actually
takes that element out of the the flow
of the
html document so previously we talked
about how we have block elements and
inline elements and if we change those
you know it kind of breaks them out of
the flow of the content
likewise with the position fixed
property now what's going to happen is
we have to explicitly set the width of
this
so let's go ahead and set the width to
be 100 of its container
and that should span it across the
entire
web page here another way that we could
do that
is a property called 100 viewport width
so vw
and that is actually the same thing if
we just came over to let's come over to
our devtools in firefox
and if you remember we could say window
dot inner
height and get some sort of value here
and this means that the height of the
visible window here is 966 pixels
we can also get the inner width
right here which is
773 and if we were to you know change
this right here and run it again it's
going to be a different value because
the visible
width of this
viewport changed
so
these properties we know how to get them
in javascript through the dom but we can
also get them within css by using either
100 viewport width or 100 viewport
height so vh
so
that is just a really useful
thing to know i use it all the time
especially when i'm making full page
layouts and nav bars and stuff like that
now the last thing about a position
fixed element is that you have to
specify
the offset that you have to its parent
container
now in this case the parent container of
our nav is going to be the body element
and that's going to be basically this
visible screen right here
so all we have to do is come down and
say from the top i want it to be zero
pixels and that's gonna pull it up to
the top and then since we have it as a
hundred percent or a hundred percent
width we don't really need to define
this other one but let's go ahead and
say
we want it to be zero pixels from the
left
so at this point what we can see is that
as we scroll down our nav bar stays at
the top and it's considered fixed
positioning
the last thing that we would probably
want to do is address this issue right
here
our boxes or our main content
has now spilled under our fixed nav bar
and the reason is because this fixed nav
bar doesn't take up any space so unlike
a block element or even an inline
element that takes up some sort of space
to the html document this nav bar
occupies zero space whatsoever
so
to make sure that the main content is
below it at all times we have to give a
margin on the top of this
boxes div class so we come down to the
css give it
target that class and then we say we
want to give the margin top
probably should be
a little more than 60 pixels so let's
just go ahead and say 80 pixels
and that should bring all of our boxes
down and now it's working just fine
so that is the fixed positioning and
it's going to be really useful when
you're trying to make a nav bar at the
top even at the side on the right side
or even a footer at the bottom of the
page that's a really good use case for
this the last couple position uh
property values that we can use so
absolute and relative positioning
again we're not talking about static
because that's the default and sticky
because that's kind of out of the scope
here but when we're talking about
a fixed positioning what we just looked
at
that's going to set the element it's
going to remove it from the flow of the
document and take up zero space and it's
going to be positioned relative to the
viewport which is always going to be the
edges of the browser window so as you
saw we said we want it to be zero pixels
from the top so at the very top of the
viewport and zero pixels from the left
so the very left of the viewport
now with
relative and absolute positioning it's
somewhat similar we're still pulling
things out of the flow or at least with
absolute positioning we're pulling them
out of the flow of the document
but we're positioning them relative to
other elements
so let's play around with relative
positioning first
so let me target this first box right
here and what i want to do is i want to
give it another class
called
rel position just to give it some
indication of what it's doing
and then within this i want to make
another div
and i want to say this will be absolute
position we're not going to do anything
quite yet with that but i'll show you
what it does in just a second so let's
focus in on this relatively position box
which is this first green box that we're
targeting
we'll come down into our css
and all we're going to do is give this
relative position class
a relative position
and what you're going to see here is
nothing has happened yet but what
happens when we scroll
is now this first box goes on top of our
nav bar
so only the first box though the rest of
them go behind it and that is a direct
result of setting that relative
positioning on the element because what
that does like i said with a lot of css
properties setting one value will kind
of change the rules of the game
it's no different here what this does is
enables a new property called z index
which basically says okay we've got all
these elements on the page what is the z
index you know three-dimensional rather
than two-dimensional so which one sits
on top of another
and when you put
relative positioning or absolute
positioning on an element
it now has the z index so now what we
have to do is define
what needs to be on top of another so we
need to come up to the nav bar and give
it a z index of 1 to put it on top of
this
element once again so that's something
really important to know about the
relative positioning
but what relative positioning really
does is it
as you saw it didn't really change the
actual position of that box
but now what we can do is define these
top
left right and bottom properties
on this element and it will
change its position relative to itself
so that's kind of a
confusing topic but basically the way
you can think of it is if that green box
is sitting right there right now
if we
give it a
top value and we say
20 pixels
it's going to go down 20 pixels
and
confusingly enough
since our i believe our margin was 20
pixels exactly it's going to blend it
into the other boxes so let's let's go
ahead and
make this 10
so that we see some separation still but
it basically takes the original position
and if we add the top property it will
go 10 pixels below where it was to begin
with
so it's a little bit confusing but it is
a useful
type of positioning
especially when you have some stubborn
elements in your html that you just need
to get to move just a little bit but you
can't quite do it with
normal css properties
and finally if you set the rel the
position to relative on a parent element
then you can set absolute positioning on
the element within that parent element
so what we can do is we can look at this
div that we put within the relatively
positioned div
and we can take this class
and target it with our css so we'll
target the absolutely positioned element
which is not showing up yet but let's go
ahead and give it a width of 20 pixels
and a height of 20 pixels
and give it a background color of say
orange so we're going to have all sorts
of nasty colors here on the screen
and what you'll see is that by default
it's going to sit up there in the top
left corner of its parent
and that's because we haven't positioned
it yet so
let's give it the absolute
positioning and what that's going to do
is now we have those top
uh bottom right and left offsets enabled
on this specific element but instead of
being an offset based on the viewport so
with this fixed nav bar
whatever we pass to those
properties is going to be in relation to
the
edges of your viewport
now we're going to be setting these
top right bottom left offsets based on
the position of the next highest element
that has relative or absolute
positioning and if there's nothing above
it that has those positionings then it's
going to use the html element or the
root element so
in this case we have something that is
relatively positioned as the direct
parent which is this green box so if we
were to come down to the absolute
position and say we want to put it 20
pixels from the top
it's just moving it down 20 pixels
relative to the edges of this parent
container
and then we can put it
i don't know we can say from the right
we want it to be 30 pixels so it's going
to pull it over to the right and offset
it 30 pixels off of that right edge
so that's what the absolute positioning
does and it has to be used in relation
with that relative positioning once
again if you don't have an apparent
element that is relatively positioned so
let's go ahead and
remove this
position relative
and now it completely disappears and you
probably are asking yourself where did
this just go
and the answer is it's i'm thinking it's
probably behind the nav bar so let's go
ahead and give it a z index of 2 which
is greater than the navbar which has an
index of 1
and now you can see it pop up up here in
the nav bar and the reason it's up there
is because since we don't have any
relatively positioned elements as its
parent or you know grandparent it's
positioning itself relative to the
viewport just like we saw with the fixed
positioning
so now
what we can say if we look at this
absolutely positioned element if we
change the top to be zero and the right
to be
also zero it's going to be perfectly up
in the top right corner
as you can see here in the screen as you
can see these position properties can
really help you control where the
elements sit on the page
and they're really powerful layout
properties
obviously you're not going to be a
master of them after just watching this
brief tutorial or demo
but hopefully it exposed you to what's
possible and when you stumble upon it in
the future or in the code challenges
you'll know exactly what's going on if
i'm being honest we've made it through
the hardest part of css
in the first part of this course the
remainder of this video and this crash
course is going to be a little bit more
fun a little bit more straightforward
and you're going to really start to see
the magic of css coming into play
so in the remainder we're going to talk
a little bit about css units so we've
looked at them already but
pixels
em rem units
percentages
maybe a couple others that actually
that's probably it and then we're also
going to look at color codes and
different color stylings so we've been
using the color property to change the
text color throughout this tutorial but
we're going to get into you know how do
we define different colors and you know
how do we do color themes and stuff like
that
and then we'll dig into font properties
so how do we change the font that's on
the page and different font families and
import fonts and stuff like that
and then finally we will talk about
background properties so how do we make
an image as the background of your web
page
and then at the end i'm going to talk
about
writing shorthand css so that's going to
bring a few things together that
you may catch on to as we write it but
that'll be pretty interesting and then
to cap it off i'm going to give you my
kind of four-step system of how i think
through
putting together html and then styling
that with css
effectively so it's basically like get
the layout first then
put the you know styles on and you know
iterate over that process
before we get into the remainder of the
css properties some common ones you'll
use we have to talk about measurement
units within css
so you can see them on the screen here
pixels pretty straightforward and common
em and rem those are font units uh like
measuring how large the font on the
screen is and then percentages that's
going to really play into some
responsive design that we'll talk about
in a later video
so we'll start with pixels and it's
you've probably already looked it up
seen me using it it's relatively
intuitive but your computer screen is
made up of pixels and the higher
resolution your computer screen is the
more pixels you can cram into it
so there's
it gets into a pretty complex discussion
when you actually start
thinking about it too much
when you're looking at a web page and
trying to calculate how many pixels
exist on that web page but if you just
look at it as
a way to explicitly set the dimensions
of html elements it's pretty simple
so for example
you saw that we made this little orange
box in the top right corner we set it
equal to a width and height of 20 pixels
so that's obviously somewhat small
and something that i wondered when i was
first starting out is how do i get a
good grasp of how many pixels to assign
to certain types of
elements and it's kind of like riding a
bike like as you go through and write
more and more css you'll get a feel for
what are kind of the average pixel units
that you'll be assigning to different
types of things so for example i know
that whenever i set padding or margin
it's usually going to be in the range of
10 to 20 pixels
when i set a border radius it's going to
be in the range of 4 to 7 pixels and so
on and so forth you kind of get a feel
for how large
um a pixel is after you've written css
for a while next up i'm gonna skip down
away from those font uh units so talking
about em and rem i'm gonna skip those
for a second and talk about percentages
now percentages are kind of the
preferred way in a lot of cases to
define the width and height of certain
elements on the page because when you go
from a desktop to
a mobile device you're going to need
relative dimensions rather than just
saying oh i want this element to be 500
pixels so a good example of this let me
just take what i've got here on the
screen
and i'll go ahead and
restyle this first box so it's the
relatively positioned box
i'll leave it how it is and i'm just
going to say that i want the width to be
600 pixels
and what it's going to do is it's going
to be wider now
and the problem here is that when i
resize this screen and we go to a mobile
device
it's going to get cut off so as i make
this smaller and smaller you're going to
see that that box just goes off the
screen completely
and the problem with that is
you know you want to have responsive
designs so a better way to do this is to
say i want the width to be i don't know
we'll call it 80 percent
of the container
so as we resize this you're going to see
that that
always stays 80 percent of the container
that it's within and that's a great way
to write responsive web pages and again
we're going to be talking a lot more
about that responsive design in a
separate video but that's why
percentages matter in the first place
now something about percentages that can
get a little bit confusing is it's all
relative to its container
so let's go ahead and apply a few
concepts we've learned so
the question is how do we get this
little orange box back in the green box
so that we can play around with this
well all we have to do is set the
position back to relative so this orange
box is going to now be relative to the
green box so when i uncomment this
property right here
it's going to put this orange box in the
top right corner of the green box so at
least i think that's what's going to
happen
and that's exactly what happened so we
now have that there and now what i'm
going to do is
go ahead and reposition this so instead
of
being in the top right we're going to
put it in the top left
so we'll put in the top left and now
what we're going to do is give it a
width in terms of percentages rather
than pixels
so what happens if i give it a width of
well now it spans the entire width of
its parent element not the entire web
page because it exists within that
parent element so it's going to occupy
the width of the parent element
in other words if we were to set
i'm just going to do this to make the
math a little bit more simple but let's
go ahead and set this green box equal to
say 500 pixels
so the calculation for this orange
element is going to be
500 pixels times 100
is equal to 500 pixels
and if we were to change this
positioning to
call it
now it's going to be 80 of 500 which is
i guess
4 400 pixels yeah about 400 pixels is
what this is now
so you can see it's relative to its
container not relative to the entire web
page when we define percentages we've
talked about pixels and percentages now
let's talk about em and rem units
so these are
specific to font sizes
and we haven't really talked about fonts
yet but we have looked at text on the
screen so why don't i go ahead and put
some text within our absolutely
positioned div so now we've got some
text here
and we can change the size of that text
using the font size property we'll talk
about that a little bit later but if we
came down into our absolutely positioned
element
and we give it a font size
we can say it can be 16 pixels which is
generally the standard font size of a
paragraph element
so you won't see it change because
that's probably the default that it
already is but if we went and changed
that to say 18 pixels you'll see that
the text gets a little bit larger now
when we're talking about em in rem units
that's kind of the more preferred way to
define text sizes within a web page and
the reason being is if you're going
around hunting and pecking for you know
trying to find all of the different css
rules that you've defined font sizes in
it gets pretty difficult you want to
define it at one level so at the top
level of the document and then
everything else needs to be relative to
that
assignment
so what you'll generally see with font
sizes
is you'll see
the html element so if we target the
root element itself
and we give it a font size you'll
generally see it be set to about 16
pixels
from there
you will then define elements below that
root element in relation to that
16 pixels so if i came down to the
absolute positioned element so this text
right here and i said that i want the
font size to be
one
rem
that means that it's going to be 100
of the size of the text in the root
element or rem
so in this case the root element is html
and the font size is 16
so if we define it as one rem then that
means that we're doing 100
of 16 pixels or in other words 16 pixels
and if we change this to say 1.2 rem
that would be 120
of 16 pixels which
i don't think i can do that in my head
right now so
you figure that out with the calculator
on your own but basically it makes it
larger than the default font size
likewise we can also use em units and
that basically means relative to its
parent element so if we have this
relatively positioned element which is
the green box right here
and we set the font size
right here to 16 or no we'll go ahead
and say something
a lot larger so that we can distinguish
this
so the relatively positioned element is
going to have a font size of 24 pixels
and then if we came down and we said we
want one e m
in the child element it's gonna set it
exactly equal to this 24 pixels but if
we change this back to rem units now
it's going to go back to the 16 pixels
because now it's relative to the html
declaration which at the top
is a font size of 16 pixels
so as you can see the benefit of doing
this and using these em and rem units is
you can define it one time and then
everything else is relative to that so
let's say that you have your web app and
you would originally define it to 14
pixels
and then you start using the app and
your users start complaining oh
everything's too small
instead of going and changing every css
rule all you have to do is go up to the
root element
change that and then everything else is
relative to that so that would be the
benefit of using em in rem units
speaking of fonts
let's go ahead and see how we can set
custom fonts on our html
so i'm going to get rid of all this
because all these colors are driving me
nuts
they're just so ugly i can't can't deal
with them anymore so let's get a clean
slate so let's go ahead and put a
heading element
and
some paragraph text
and then maybe one more um
we'll call this the original style text
and what we'll do
here is this will be
the
original id and what we're going to
style this as is we'll we'll put these
two as a new font style and then we'll
keep this one as the original just as a
reference point when we're dealing with
fonts in my head at least there's about
four properties that are highly relevant
that you have to know the first font
property that we're dealing with is the
font
family which is going to define what all
of the text on your web page in your web
app what that's going to inherit
and especially if you define it on the
body or even the html so the the whole
document you can define the font family
and that's going to apply to everything
within the document
unless something is of course
overwritten with a font family on a you
know more specific element but let's go
to the documentation i just searched for
the font family property
you could also go to technology css
reference
come down to the index and then
somewhere in the f here we can find the
font family looks like it might be at
the very bottom though
okay so here's the font family so that's
how you get there
and as you can see
we are giving two values to this or you
don't have to but in most cases you're
going to give two values to this the
first one
is going to be the font family that
you're wanting to specify
and there's a bunch of built-in font
families that you can use
let me just see what we can find
default font families
there's probably a resource
i think this is the one i clicked on
before so
w3.org it looks like this defines a lot
of those default families that are
available in all your browsers
so this first one is going to represent
the family and then the second one or
the second argument we will call it to
this property is going to be the
fallback font
so there's only a couple of valid
fallback fonts and they're literally
just like the
type of font so everyone knows like a
serif and a sans-serif font and then
like there's a mono space font which is
more like a typewriter type thing
so those will be fallbacks for if the
browser doesn't support the first one
that you define
but let's just go ahead and look in at
an example in most cases you're just
going to put them in quotes that first
one because it'll be two words so let's
copy this one in that's a good example
so we'll put that in there and you'll
see how this changes
and i can comment it out
you'll see it change and then uncomment
it and you'll see the change of this
font
now the question is what happens if we
want something more custom what if we
want like a really nice looking
professional font
well there's a couple ways that you can
do this in css and a couple of them i'm
not going to walk through but the
easiest way is to go to google fonts so
let's open up
google fonts
and go here and then from from this page
we can search through all different
categories of fonts so let's say that we
want only serif fonts
and then we can go down to
oh i guess different languages that
they're available in
and
different font properties so
let's scroll down and just pick
something um
see if i can find one that might be a
little bit popular i believe you can
sort by
trending or most popular
so maybe we look at roboto rubato slab
all right so that's a good one
and from here you just go down to all of
these different font weights and styles
and you click select this style
so in this
in pretty much every case you're going
to select the regular
so we'll click select that style
and what you'll notice is that
in this link that we're going to use in
just a second it looks like it's just
pulling in a default link but the second
we
add in a different weight so let's say
that we want the boldest version of this
font and we click select style
now you're going to see that there's
this little parameter in here that
defines that we want the weight of 400
and 900 and each additional weight that
you add is going to add a little bit
more
size to this import so you have to be
careful with that but for the most part
grab a couple and you should be good
so in this case we have a regular font
and we have a very bold font
and all we have to do is
take this link tag which is a valid html
tag that we had talked about earlier and
that's actually how you import style
sheets to an html document
and we'll come back to our
codepen playground
and come up to
settings um
i believe html
and then in this
section here stuff for the head we can
just paste in those link tags
and now those fonts have been imported
into our document and we can access them
with css
now this is a little bit different than
how you would do it if you were writing
outside of the code pen environment so
just for a second i'm going to comment
out all of this html
and show you exactly how you would do
this
on your own so you're going to need an
html
a body
and then of course the head so this is
our basic structure of an html document
and then you'll of course have a link
to your styles.css or something like
that
so this will be representing your
stylesheet
not here but in a different document it
would
and then you can also copy in those link
tags that
we imported from google fonts
so this is how you would basically
import a font to a custom html document
that's outside of this
you know nicely programmed codepen
environment
so anyways let's get rid of that we
don't need that
we'll uncomment
or
not uncomment
okay so we're back to
the start and now all we have to do is
replace these two
lines with the imported font if you go
back to roboto or roboto slab
you're going to see that the css rules
to specify this family is right here so
we can just copy that
come back here and replace this whole
line
and now you watch the text change to
this new font
so that's how you would import a custom
font it's pretty much how i always do it
for a lot of my web pages and apps is
use google fonts it's free and very easy
to use
so that is the first and most important
css property when we're dealing with
fonts we'll go ahead and give a font
size of 16 pixels because we're on the
root html element and that is a very
standard value to be giving
an entire web page
now what gets interesting
is the font weight property
so font weight determines the thickness
of that font but the
interesting thing about this one is you
can only use the weights that you've
imported if you're using something like
google fonts
so if you remember when we were looking
at this we only imported a weight of 400
and
900 which means if we give
the um let's go ahead and target a
specific element
so in this case
uh let's let's say this will be thick
font
and
target that by its id and then give it a
font weight of 900
and you're going to see that this goes
bold because we're specifying it to be
900 but since we only imported that one
weight if we change this to say
you know 700 it's not going to change
anything on the page and the reason is
we didn't import it but if we were to
change this back down to 400 then it's
going to go back to normal because we
did import the 400 or regular font size
so that's that's how the font weight
property is related to those imports
that you will do the last thing we'll
talk about is line height so let me put
in a paragraph tag and here let's go
ahead and copy some lorem ipsum font
which is basically just generic
text that we can use
and what you'll see on the page is very
normal looking text now if we change the
line height so if we target the
paragraph elements and give it a line
height of
call it 30 pixels
you're going to see that it spaces this
out a little bit more than the original
and i believe the default line height is
going to be the same as the font size
but
i could be wrong on that i would have to
check
but basically let's let's see we can
actually check that so we'll go one rem
and it looks like no it's not the same
as the font size because it definitely
got smushed a little bit more
but anyways
line height is basically going to give
you the space between the lines of text
when there's multiple lines of text
we are getting to the end here we have a
couple more topics to cover and one of
those is colors
so there's not a whole lot to know about
colors but i do want to walk through
some of the basics
so far we've been talking about just
basic
you know color so if we came into our
paragraph
element here we give it a color of say
red
now red is pretty easy to understand
it's the color red but that is a
built-in css property and i'm wondering
if there's a resource that has all of
those potential properties so if you go
to the mdn documentation
go to the color property so the color
css property
and then i believe there should be
some sort of list of all of the possible
colors that you can use
let's see if we can find it here so it
looks like here's a few of the color
keywords that you can use
this looks like a list i don't know if
this is exhaustive
of all of the possible ones but it sure
looks like it
so
you can just go to
color value is where that is on the
documentation but that's what we've been
looking at so far and there are also
other ways that you can define colors so
you can define it as a hex or
hexadecimal
you can define it as rgb
or you can define it as rgba so
we'll walk through all of these and i'll
show you exactly what they do to help us
out a little bit we're going to use this
built-in color picker
just type in rgb to hex or vice versa
and usually comes up on google there's
other tools that you can use as well
let me zoom in so that we can really see
what we're dealing with here
and you'll see that in this color picker
we can drag to look for different colors
we'll just stop here on this green
and what you'll see is all these
different codes
so we could just type in to our css we
could just say we want
green or we want something like light
green those are both valid
values but if we wanted to be more
specific and go with a color theme we're
going to have to use
something a little bit more complex
and these color codes allow us to get to
a very finite amount of detail with our
colors
and what you need to understand is that
each color is built with red green and
blue
which is defined by this rgb value so
the first number
is going to be red then green and then
blue
now these numbers go from 0 to 255
i believe that's one byte
is how much space that takes up in
memory
and
each different combination of those bite
values are going to give you a different
color based on the blending of those red
green and blue values
and if you were to take these three
values and convert them to hexadecimal
notation which is just a numbering
system
you get this code right here so
the 128 would be represented by 80 in
hexadecimal
235 would be represented by e and b
in hexadecimal and 52 uh oh just drag
something around there 52 will be
represented by 34 in hexadecimal so
these are the same exact thing just
expressed with different notation
now there's one other thing that we can
do and that is add an rgb a value
so let's go ahead and copy
this hex code in so we'll copy that into
our our color for text color
and you'll see that it changed a little
bit
and that works we can also come back and
grab the rgb values and then in our css
all we need to do is type rgb put some
parentheses and separate those values
from 0 to 255 by commas
now there's one trick that you can use
if you add an a at the end of the rgb
you can define one more value within
this i guess array or whatever we're
calling this
and this represents the opacity that
we're going to define
so if we wanted 100 opacity basically
the same color we give it one
and that's going to give us the same
color but if we wanted 50
opacity you give it 0.5 and you can see
how this has been kind of grayed out we
can actually use our
our new skills of absolutely positioning
an element
let's go ahead and write a div in here
and we'll say
uh overlay
and come down and style this so we'll
say overlay
is gonna be a width of 200 pixels
a height of 200 pixels
and then we're going to give it the same
exact color right here
so and then maybe the p color will just
be
uh black by default so that we can see
it really well and then
this overlay is not showing up and why
is it not showing up hold on
oh that is because we've set the color
we need to set the background color to
actually get something to show up
now this is not over the text yet but
all we have to do is say
position
absolute
and then give it 0 from the top
and
there we go so we've now got this box
sitting on top of this text and you can
see that we can actually see the text
through it because we've given it this
50 opacity value if we flip that to one
it's going to disappear because it's 100
percent opacity and it's covering all of
the text so that's what the rgba
css
value is able to do with colors now
speaking of colors
i recommend going to adobe color which
is a great place to kind of explore
different color themes
and it will show you like all the
different complementary colors to
certain codes
you can even go to explore or go to
trends
and you can look through different color
themes that people have put together
for different you know niches so graphic
design illustration architecture game
design and you can go in and click on
these palettes and it will give you all
the hex codes that you need and you can
set those up in your global css values
and then your whole web page is going to
be themed in a uniform way
all right let's get rid of all this
stuff because we're ready for the uh
i think the last
category of css properties that you'll
probably need to be aware of and that is
background properties
so far we have talked about background
colors and
you've seen me do this with these boxes
where i'm just giving them background
colors so that we can see them on the
screen but you can also do background
images and with background images there
are a couple of properties just like we
talked about before
certain properties set to certain values
kind of change the rules of the game for
the rest of the the page and that is the
same deal with background images so i'm
going to walk you through
a couple use cases with backgrounds and
how you might see them you know in in
real life when you actually start
putting together web pages the first one
is simple like i said we've already
talked about it and let me just go ahead
and make some
simple text on the page just just so we
have something but what we're going to
target is the body element so that's the
whole web page
and i'm going to give the body element
a background color
of green
and you're going to see on the screen
that it turns completely green
so that is the easiest property the next
thing that you can do
rather than just making a solid color
background is you can put a background
image on your web page
it's actually pretty common for like a
home page here's my golf website you'll
see that there's a background image
there
and
this background image i've actually
pulled this out
into its own link so that we can use it
within the codepen environment so let's
copy this link so that we have it ready
and now what i'm going to do is
put a div up here and we're going to
call it the main
content
and then we're going to put the text in
there just that we have something
to see
and from here we will grab the main
content
and we're going to say background rather
than background color equal to something
like blue we're going to say the
background image is equal to a url
and i guess i copied in the wrong thing
here so let me grab that link again
and now we have a url so the problem
here is it's only taking up this small
amount of space and that is because we
have not defined the size of this main
content
so all we need to do is say the width of
the content is going to be a hundred
percent of the viewport width so again
that's the whole visible screen is 100
of that width
and what you'll see is there's still
some gaps here and that's because
the code pen environment automatically
adds some margin
around the body
so what we need to do there is reset
that so we'll go to the body and give it
a margin of zero
so that should bring it in line there
and then we have this p element which
has some sort of margin on it too which
is adding this top margin so we'll make
the p margin equal to zero as well and
now we have this at the top of the
screen
so if we
come down here and give it a height
of
percent of the view viewport height
now we're gonna see this image across
the whole page
now obviously this image is not showing
what it is like this is
who knows what this image is and we need
to position it a little bit differently
so the way that we do that is we'll use
a property called background size and
we'll go ahead and set that equal to
cover
so that's going to cover the whole
container that we have it as a
background for and then we want to make
sure that we specify the background
repeat to be no repeat
just in case a screen size
you know is so big that it has to repeat
and then finally i think we need to add
in
the background
position which is going to take two
values it's gonna say
i think you can just say like bottom
right or something like that so let's go
ahead and look that up
if we go to the documentation
and type in background position
so it says the background position sets
the initial position for each background
image
it's relative to the position layer
okay
and you can see that there's multiple
different
values that you can give it you can give
it values relative to different parts of
the screen or you can just say position
it at the top left or center
that kind of thing so
what i will do is just position it to
the right
bottom right works but we can just
position it to the right because
our golfer here is on the right side and
we need to pull it over so that you can
see
him in the background so this is our
basic background image and then from
here you can put text on the screen so
what if we
went up here and said
on the body we want the color
of the text to be white so that we can
see it
and instead of paragraph text maybe we
have like an h1
welcome to
my site
or something like that and then of
course we need to remove that margin
because it's messing it up
and we'll come down here give it
some margin on the top which would be 50
pixels
actually no we don't want to do that we
want to do
some padding on the top so that it
doesn't
bring the whole image down
and then
maybe we'll say on the body
that we want the text alignment to be
center so that's
centered on the screen
so we have a welcome message says
welcome to my site and you've got a nice
background image there's obviously a lot
more that you can do here i didn't even
scratch the surface on all the different
things you have to think about when
you're putting together a background
image and trying to actually get
elements like this
piece of text on top of it so that gets
a little bit more complicated but
hopefully this is just a nice overview
of those background properties to see
what's possible
all right so the last thing i'm going to
say about css properties
is that there is a short shorthand way
to write them in some cases
so to this point you've seen me just
writing these properties and you know
not really explaining okay i'm i'm
giving it a margin of zero right here
but what does that represent you know is
the zero margin gonna be a margin on the
left the right top bottom all four of
them and the answer is it's gonna be all
four of them because this margin
property is a shorthand css property
and what you can do let me let me go
ahead and get us a better example here
because this is not a good example
so let's make a div
and target that div give it a width of
200 pixels
a height of 200 pixels and a background
color of green just that we have
something on the screen
and then from here
um actually let's let's make a couple of
these so that we
see two of them
and you can see that they're combined
together because there's no margin but
if we were to put some margin on this
we can say the margin is just 20 pixels
and be done with it or we could say that
the margin top is going to be 20 pixels
so that it doesn't space it from the
left side of the screen
so this margin property when it's
defined just on its own
is a shorthand property you can give it
one value which makes the margin on all
sides equal
or you can come in here and you can give
it four different values so let me make
sure i got this right
but the first value should be the top
margin
then you have the
looks like the right margin
then the bottom margin and finally the
left margin so you can define different
values for
you know top right bottom left
instead of writing it all out like this
so we could say
this this line right here i'll comment
it out and that's going to be equivalent
to this so we'll say margin top is 20
margin right is 5 pixels
margin bottom is 10 pixels and margin
left
is 20 pixels so these four
properties combined together is the same
exact thing as this one shorthand
property
so you'll see this very commonly in css
where
another great example of this is border
you could say border is one pixel solid
black and you'll see that border pop up
or not very well let's make it 5 pixels
so you can see it better
and this is a shorthand property so what
we could have done is comment this out
and say
border size is 5 pixels
the border color is black
and then
the border i believe style
is solid
and it looks like i got something wrong
here because the size is all messed up
but let's let's look it up in the
documentation
so we'll type in border
and it says that it sets the values
border width border style and border
color so that's what i missed it's not
border size it would be
border width and now you'll see the same
exact result as you saw
let's go ahead and
comment this out just so that i can
prove this out
so we'll comment out those three
properties and comment this one back in
and the shorthand property has the same
exact effect so shorthand properties are
really quick and easy way to write css
you'll kind of get used to them and just
wanted to let you know that that was
going on because i know it's kind of
confusing when you see all these
different properties being written
and nobody explains oh what we can
define the margin right using like three
different ways of doing it
congratulations if you've made it this
far i know it's been probably a couple
hours at this point of me talking about
css and properties and concepts box
models all that kind of stuff
but hopefully that was a good
introduction for you and at this point
we're going to kind of prep ourselves
for the html and css challenges that we
looked at at the beginning of the video
so i'll be walking you through those on
video in separate videos not this one
but before we get there i want to
introduce the four step method that i go
through when i'm writing html and css
because it was not offered to me when i
was first starting out or i didn't find
it on my own and i think it would be
really helpful to you because it took me
a while to figure this out and
really get into a good routine so this
is a systematic way to write css in html
and the first step is to figure out what
you want
what you want to put on the page and
oftentimes that comes in the form of a
design
now we talked about we're not going to
go through wireframing or graphic design
in this course we're just going to use
we're leveraging
existing designs that have already been
built but that is a huge huge concept
here you never want to go into it where
you have no idea how you want to design
the visual elements on the page and try
to write the code and design it all at
the same time it's really confusing and
i've done it too many times and i would
not recommend it
now once you have the design or at least
some sort of wireframe that gives you a
sense of where you want to put the
elements you have to think of step two
which is how do i want to arrange those
on the page with html now this is a
highly intuitive step you're going to
get a lot better at this with experience
and it's much easier after you've
written a couple of apps to understand
oh i need to put you know a div
container here and then i need three div
containers within that main div
container and then within each of those
containers i probably need some text and
then maybe another container so you'll
get a lot better at realizing you know
how to use divs and different semantic
html elements
on the page as you go along
the third step is how can i use css to
achieve that outline or layout
and this is where all the stuff we
talked about in this crash course come
into play if you don't know some of
these properties and you know how they
work and how they you know
disrupt the flow of the elements on the
page then you're not going to be able to
do this very well
so like step number two you'll get a lot
better with practice on this one and
then finally step four i really think
this is probably the easier
step of this process and that is how do
i want to style these elements so once
you've got them laid out on the page
styling them is
rather trivial you're just putting
different colors and some padding maybe
some margin that kind of stuff on them
maybe some text decoration or
you know font sizes that kind of stuff
and it's pretty trivial compared to
getting the layout correct in the first
place
so to go through this process i'm going
to give you a short example here at the
end of this video
and then make sure to keep it in mind as
we go into the challenge videos and i'll
be sure to
kind of adhere to this process as we're
building those front-end mentor
code challenges so here's what we're
going to build with this four-step
method
this is
we can think of this as the design so
let me go ahead and change the view so
that it's
very clear
so we're going to go to full page view
and you'll see the design that we're
trying to make it's nothing fancy but
just looking at that visual design
how can we lay that out in html
so we have to decide you know looking at
this do we want some containers built
out you know it looks like they're next
to each other how do we accomplish that
with html
so let's go back over to our playground
and start writing this out i'm gonna
actually put these side by side so that
we can see them a little bit better
when i look at this design the first
thing that i see is two div elements
so i'm thinking i'm definitely gonna
have two divs
and usually when i put something
together with html i have a container
div so kind of like the overarching
parent to all the elements
so what i'll do here is start us out
with the template we'll say div dot
container and press tab
to make a div with the class of
container
and then from here i want to make a div
with a class of box 1
and then i want to make another div
with a class of box 2.
so we've seen this before so if you
remember you might be able to kind of
figure this out but this is the basic
structure that i think i want
to lay that out and of course there's
two pieces of text so in each of these
divs i'm going to put some sort of h2
we'll call that box one
and then we will say we want some text
in there
and then we can just copy this down into
box two
as you can see on the screen on the left
this looks nothing like the one on the
right
and the reason i knew to put all these
html elements in this fashion
is because i have experience doing it
and i just know that we have a
overarching container
each div is going to represent each box
and then there's content within each of
these divs that we can you know center
and style a little bit later so let's go
back to our our four-step pop process
here
we already asked how we want to arrange
them
that's the design itself so what we're
looking at over on the right
we said how does this arrangement look
in the form of html we already wrote
that out it doesn't look anything like
it yet but it will and now we have to
say how do we use css to imagine that
layout that we see on the right so from
here we have to take css and get these
boxes
i need to label this one
correctly we need to get these two boxes
and put them next to each other
now what i'm most comfortable with is
flexbox i know we haven't learned it and
that's going to be a separate video
but i'm going to go ahead and use it
here just to give an example
and how you use that is you basically
take the main container
and you display
that as a flex item
and what that's going to do is it's
going to put the boxes right next to
each other
now what you have to do is for each of
the boxes
we're going to give it a width
or no we're not going to do that we're
going to
give it a flex basis
of 50 percent and we'll give that also
to box number two so flex is going to be
50 that's basically going to make them
equal to each other
and then we need to give them a border
so that we can see
what is going on and i think it's about
two pixels
is what the border we're looking for is
so we've got the border here on box
number one we can copy this down to
box number two
we want to make that one blue
okay and the next thing that we want to
do is probably give some margin around
it because currently they're right next
to each other
so we'll give it a margin of say 20
pixels
and down here we will give it a margin
of 20 pixels as well
looks a little bit big so let's reduce
that to 10 on both of them
okay that's looking a little bit better
and then with the
box one and box two we probably also
need to do text align center so that the
text is all centered
we're going to refactor this in just a
second
so now we're centered and at this point
we're pretty much spot on with our
layout
so
we need to go to the last step which is
how should each element be styled we
already have a border so that's kind of
part of the process but
the only thing that we need to do really
is give it a color of blue for the text
on the right
and then give it a color of green for
the text on the left
and there you go um we have a pretty
similar layout i think partially why it
doesn't look exactly the same as
because it's smaller but maybe we gave
this some different dimensions but i'm
happy with this we accomplished kind of
what we wanted here
the only thing that i would do is
refactor the css because currently you
can see we've set flex equal to 50 on
both of these
we've also set the text line and the
margin
so we can combine those into
one selector so put a comma there
select both boxes
and then get all of these common
properties that apply to both of them in
here
so we'll grab the margin
and the flex basis
and then we go ahead and delete that
from these properties or from these
selectors
and it should look the same now so this
is how you would go through that four
step process to solve an html and css
challenge
let's jump in this is what we're going
to be building here it's going to be a
nice way to practice
a lot of those basic css and html skills
that we've just learned
there's nothing crazy going on here but
it will give us that good opportunity it
looks like we've got a few different
font styles
font weights
a little bit of color in here and then
even a button down here that we can
style and maybe add a pseudo
class hover effect to so it'll be a
great comprehensive introduction to
writing html and css
this code challenge comes from the
frontend mentor website which is a great
resource that you can scroll down and
see a bunch of professional
web designs for different things that
will challenge you to use
different skills in html css and
javascript the one that i picked here is
rather simple it's kind of on the the
easier side of this
but we are going to walk through a
couple others so as you see this grid
and the crowdfunding product page those
two will be coming up in future video
challenges for this video i've purposely
not looked at this
yet and figured out how i'm going to do
it so this is completely raw and uncut
i really want to just show you my
thought process we talked about
this four step system for writing html
and css in the actual css crash course
and i really want to apply this and walk
you through my thought process
of how i take a design such as this one
and think about how do i lay it out how
do i style it and what resources am i
using to do so i'm not the best at
writing html and css in the world far
from it there are plenty of people that
could come in and critique what i'm
about to do
in many many ways but my goal here is to
show you just a realistic look at how we
go about building something like this
consistent with what we've been doing
in the prior videos we're going to be
using the codepen
environment so you can start a blank
code pen document and just follow along
as we go through this challenge i think
our first step is going to be going over
to the front-end mentor website
we don't need this page anymore
but if we go ahead and click the visit
challenge hub for the single price grid
component which i'm going to leave a
link in the description to this so that
you don't have to go searching for it
you'll find
some starter files a design file that we
don't need this is more on the side of
you know if you're using figma or sketch
or even photoshop or something like that
to mock up the design it might be useful
to see what are the components and
layers going on there but like i said in
the crash course this is not about
graphic design or wireframing we're
solely trying to take a pre-existing
design
and turn it into code
scrolling down you can see that this is
the newbie difficulty level so it should
be relatively straightforward to solve
almost 10 000 people have tried it and
about 2 000 have finished and i fully
intend to be
in this bottom category as should you
and the brief that we're given
is pretty simple so it says your
challenge is to build out this pricing
component
getting it looking like the design okay
you can use any tools that you'd like
we're going to use vanilla html and css
we're not bringing in
anything additional except maybe a
google font or something like that
it says your users should be able to
and what i want to call out right here
is this is called a user story and we've
touched on it previously within this
crash course when we built the html
challenge but a user story is something
that you will write down in the
requirements gathering phase of building
a web page or web app and it's basically
saying okay let's come up with a list of
things that the user should be able to
do if this is implemented correctly so
the first requirement is that we should
be able to view the optimal layout for
the component depending on the device's
screen size
we have not yet talked about responsive
design that's i believe going to be the
next video in this series
so
we may leave this part out i'm not quite
sure yet we'll see how long it takes to
build the first part but basically what
that's saying is as we resize the screen
or if we look at it on desktop or our
mobile device it should you know look
good to the user
the second one is you should see a hover
state on desktop for the sign up call to
action so in other words what they're
talking about is this
button down here when we hover over it
we should see some sort of interactive
thing happening whether that be the
button gets larger or changes colors
opacity
something like that so we can get a
little bit creative with what we're
doing there
it says download the starter code go to
the readme file this will give you
further details the style guide will
give you the colors and the fonts that
we need to use
so i'm going to go ahead and open this
up you'll see that we have some folders
and some files if we open up the readme
it's written in markdown
which is kind of hard to read here so
what i'm going to do is open all of
these files in a tool called visual
studio code
which is the code editor that we will
eventually be using within this series
but for now like i said we're going to
be using this codepen environment
because it's a lot more
interactive and you can see the changes
happening in real time so let me get
that opened and then we'll look at some
of these files i've got all the project
files open in visual studio code which
again you'll get very used to as we go
throughout this course
but basically we're just using it to see
the the files for now and if we open up
readme you'll see that it's written in
markdown if you don't know what markdown
is just go google it real quick to
understand it basically takes
these little two hashtags for example
and this would become an h2 element
within html so i've got it open in the
preview it's a little bit easier to read
than
you know the stuff going on over here
most of this stuff is not new the one
thing that i'll talk about here is
down here in the deployment section
so they recommend that you use get
version control
to
host this and push it to your repository
and deploy it
with for sell now we're going to just
put this up on github pages and we're
not going to actually be using the git
utility because we haven't covered that
in the series yet
but i do want to you know give you a way
to see it live on the internet and
github pages is a really simple way to
do that i'll show you exactly how that
works but it will not be the focus of
this tutorial the style guide we don't
really need to go through this
all that much right now but we'll be
referring back to it when we have to
figure out okay what font are we going
to use how large is this card going to
be
and what colors are we putting in there
so this will be a good reference so
let's close that out and i think
everything else looks like we have
design these are just uh preview images
to reference
and then images we just have a favicon
which is going to be kind of up in the
browser tab
and finally we have this git ignore file
which has to do with the get version
control utility we're not going to talk
about that and then finally in
index.html which has some predefined
html boilerplate to start with but once
again we're going to be using codepen
instead of doing that just because it's
a little bit more interactive for us all
right let's get started uh coding this
thing so once again we'll go back to
this four-step system for writing html
and css
and for this
i use this four step system on a
component by component basis
so in our case we're just building this
simple card so we can pretty much use it
one time through but if we had a much
larger project we'd kind of iterate and
do this process multiple times
so the first thing is how do i want to
arrange these html elements on the page
that is basically talking about
this design right here so how do i want
to design it we've already have that
done for us so we can go to step two
how do i
make this arrangement look
using html so
the way that we can figure that out is
primarily by experience just knowing
how you can write html that will be
turned into something like this
but i'm going to walk you through my
thought process and just kind of start
to give you that experience
so just taking a look at this design the
first thing that i'm thinking about
is how do i
lay this out with html so what are the
container elements that i need to use
and as we talked about a div element is
a great you know container type element
so what i'm thinking about is there's
probably going to be four main
containers that we're looking at from a
high level
the first one is going to be the entire
design itself so that will be one div
then we'll have something for this white
box right here
the bottom left box and then the bottom
right box so really what we're going to
be looking at is something like this and
excuse my poor drawing i'm using a mouse
so this is kind of tough
but if we break it out like this
and then we draw something around it
this top one is going to be
a div
and then we'll have another div here
and we'll have a div here and a div here
so we're going to have four in total and
that's going to represent our entire
design as we move down to this this
bottom left section which will be
contained in a div it's going to be a
little bit trickier than this top one
because of this part right here so you
see how we have some text
and some more text styled right next to
each other horizontally
and as we know elements are block
elements by default usually so we're
going to have to find a way to lay that
out so that they're both on the same
line
and they have two different styles so
that'll be interesting to see how we do
that and then finally at the bottom
we've got a button which we'll spend a
little bit of extra time on because we
need to have a hover effect on it
and then in the bottom right we have a
pretty straightforward design
where we just have a heading and then it
looks like an unstyled list so it's not
necessarily paragraph text it looks like
this is a list without bullet points so
i'll show you exactly how to do that
and then finally
we have
some different colors throughout but
that's not really related to this step
so we've gone through steps one in steps
two so what i'm going to do is actually
take step number two and lay this out
with html as we just talked about so
i've got my design here on the right and
my code pen here on the left so
let's go ahead and start with this
the first thing that i'm going to do is
make a main div that we're going to call
the container or more descriptively
we'll call it the card because this is
what we call a pricing card
card is just terminology for something
that's like all contained within a box
then furthermore i said that we're going
to have three more divs
so let's lay that out and we're going to
give i don't know we'll call it an id so
maybe let's be more specific with
everything here because we're only
making one card
in a real css project you might want to
make a card design and then apply it to
one class that you can you know use with
multiple elements but for here we can
just use ids and be super specific
so we have a card
then we have the top section
and then we'll come down make yet
another div
this is going to be the bottom left
section i'm just being super descriptive
here
and then furthermore
we're going to have a bottom right
section
so let me expand this so that we can
really see what we're dealing with
it's not going to show anything on the
screen yet because we haven't put
anything in these divs
but one thing that i just noticed that
we probably should be doing
is this bottom right section here we
probably should wrap that in another div
just because they're horizontally next
to each other so really what we can
visualize this as is we've got one
section up here
and then we have one section down here
and then within that we have
two more sections like that so over here
in our html we're going to wrap
these two in a div so let me take the
bottom two sections
and put those in a div as well and make
sure that we have some good indentation
so that we can see exactly what's going
on
pretty easily
let's give this one an id so we'll just
say bottom
section
so if you look at this on the right my
extremely messy design we have this top
section which is this big box
and then at the bottom we have the
bottom section which is the big box
surrounding these two little boxes and
then the two boxes down here are
represented by the bottom left section
in the bottom right section and then
everything is encompassed this is
getting extremely messy
with a card right here
all right so let me go ahead and disable
this that we don't have all that drawing
there but you can kind of see how this
layout is going to map over to this
design at this point let's put something
in here so that we can start seeing this
come to life
at the moment we have an empty web page
because we've got a bunch of div
elements or containers that we've laid
out
but there's nothing in them
so what goes in these sections
let's start with the top section so
right here contain contained within this
single div
and what we're going to put in there is
it looks like a heading so that looks to
me
somewhat like
we'll call it an h2 heading and it says
join our
community so that will be our first
heading right there and of course this
is not going to look anything like the
card at the beginning we're going to use
css styles to make this a lot prettier
in just a second
we'll come down here and this looks like
maybe an h4 heading that says
day
hassle free
money back guarantee
all right so that is the second part and
then the third part is going to be some
paragraph text
so gain access to our full library
and i'm going to stop talking so we can
speed through this
all right so we've got our top section
already created
and once again it looks nothing like the
top section over here but we will get
there in due time now we'll come down to
these other sections here so we need to
finish the bottom left section which
we're going to put in this div right
here
and then the bottom right will be going
in this div so with the bottom left
section
it looks like we have an h4 tag so
similar to how we use for the 30 day
hassle free
money back guarantee
we'll go ahead and use that same one for
the monthly subscription because it
looks close we can always change it
later
so we'll put in monthly subscription
and then like i said once we get down to
this little
area so if we circle these
two pieces right here
this is going to be what i think
as another container div so let's go
ahead and make another div and then
within that div
we want to have we'll say
um
i guess we can just make another div
that says
and then
one more div that is going to say per
month
so this is going to
this total container is going to wrap
that pricing component and then we're
going to take these two divs right here
and make them go horizontal to each
other
as you can see they're you know block
elements so they're breaking to new
lines but
you'll see how this comes in handy in
a little bit so let's go to the next
part
get rid of these lines here
and you can see that after the pricing
it gives us a small
text down here so we'll we'll put a
paragraph and we'll say full access for
less than one dollar a day
and then finally at the very bottom
let's space this out once more we're
going to need a button that says
sign up
and you'll see that this button comes on
the page here
and then finally this is where it gets a
little bit confusing since we haven't
added any css yet
but this container on the far right is
going to be next to the container that
we just created but for the time being
since everything is a block element by
default it's going to go right under
here so let me go ahead and write this
out it looks like we're using the same
kind of header here so we'll stick with
the h4
and say why us
and then down here as i said you could
interpret this as paragraph text you can
make a bunch of
paragraph text that breaks to new lines
or we could just make a list and then
take the bullet points out later with
css
so that's what i'm going to do i'm going
to make an unordered list and then each
list item is going to be what we're
seeing on each line
okay we've got it all written out we've
got all the text and elements that we're
probably going to need for this entire
card but as you can see this looks
nothing like the card that we have on
the right and believe it or not we're
going to use just vanilla css
to take this ugly looking thing and turn
it into the card that we see on the
right
so in reality if i was building this
myself and i wanted to do it as quick as
possible
um what i would do is probably not lay
it out like this where i've got all of
the text on the page at once
i would probably do it in pieces but i
wanted to lay this out to just show you
how we can visualize a
design
of course you need a little bit of
experience to do this but
we can visualize a design and turn it
into html elements and we can take what
looks like nothing special and turn it
into
this card on the right but let me go
ahead and walk you through what i would
do in real life so i've basically
created a clone of this
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to delete all that text that we
just put in here so we'll get right back
to
where we started and as you can see we
have just the layout that we had created
earlier where we have the whole card we
have the top section bottom section and
then the sub sections within those
and realistically what i would do first
off just to get everything laid out on
the page correctly is start giving
some dimensions and some borders on this
so that we can visualize it and then i
would put in the actual
text elements so let's go ahead and do
that real quick and you'll see exactly
what i mean so if we were to come back
to this four-step process
this step number two can involve some
css
as i'm about to show you so we'll open
up the css
pane
and what we want to first do is target
the overall card
so
to do that with an id you use that
hashtag and then supply the id
and now what i'm going to do is just
give it some sort of width and height
and also tack on a border so that we can
see it on the page
so let's go ahead and give it a width of
200 pixels and a height of 200 pixels
and then a border will be one pixel
solid red
so now you're starting to see and i'm
gonna actually make this three pixels so
we can see it better
you'll see just a basic container on the
page now the next thing i want to do is
go see what the specifications for the
size of this main card is because this
outer container we are calling card
should be the total dimensions
so if we go back to visual studio code
and see our specifications so we're in
the style guide right now
it says that the designs were created to
the following widths
so like i said we're not going to be
getting into responsive design in this
tutorial
so if you were to look at the desktop
design it looks like this and that's
what we're creating
but there's also a mobile design which
you can see has a slightly different
layout
and in real life what we would be doing
is we'd be designing on desktop to look
like that and then when we resized the
page so
as we you know resize the page in our
codepen environment we would expect this
design to change
but for this one we're staying simple
since we haven't learned about
responsive design yet and we're just
creating this one right here
so the specification for that desktop is
going to be 1440 pixels but if we came
to codepen and we gave it a width of say
1440 pixels it's going to go completely
off the page so we're going to take a
little bit of liberty here
and make our own design based on the
size of our code pen
editor which i'm guessing is going to be
around we'll call it 700 pixels maybe
um that's a pretty good size we're
probably going to want to give ourselves
some some width here to work with so
let's make it 600 pixels which is going
to give us all of this space right here
and then for the height we're just going
to eyeball it because they haven't
specified exactly what that height
should be
so let's look at the desktop design
again
you can generally grasp the aspect ratio
here and you can tell that we're off by
a little bit so let's maybe throw this
up to
350 pixels
and that looks like generally the aspect
ratio that we're dealing with right here
so nothing nothing perfect but it's
going to get us close now the next step
since we have our main container laid
out and we just see it visibly
we're going to do the same thing with
each of the sections so you can see that
we have our top section which we can
come down into our css and target
and for this section we're going to give
it a width
of 100 percent because we want it to be
filling up the entire space of its main
container
and then we're going to give it a height
if i can spell that right
we'll give it a height of 50 percent
because
well maybe not 50 it looks like the top
section
is call it
40 and the bottom section is about 60 so
maybe we'll go in that range where we
give it a height of 40 percent the width
of a hundred
and of course we can't see anything yet
because we haven't given it a background
or a border so let's throw in a
2 pixel
solid green border so you'll see that
pop up
in the top section here and that that
looks pretty good so far
now there's one problem that we're
seeing already that i want to fix right
off the bat before we get any further
and that is this
box sizing so as you can see when we put
the border on this inner container
you're seeing that it's kind of breaking
out of the parent container on the right
side here
and the reason that's happening is
because our box sizing is set to the
default content box so what we're going
to do is a basic css reset that's going
to make every element on the page abide
by
the border box box sizing and we talked
about that in the first of three lessons
in our css crash course
before so go back and review that if you
have to to apply the border box box
sizing to every element in this html
document
we'll just come to the top of our css
file and paste in a predefined html or
css reset so we're saying on the total
document we want the box sizing to be
border box
which will as you see it will make this
box go within its container and then the
second rule is just basically going to
say i want to grab every other element
and apply
or inherit that you know root level box
sizing so by just adding these two rules
you can see that our boxes are fitting
nicely within each other if we comment
them out it's going to be breaking out
of the box again if we comment them back
it goes
or it should update i'm not sure why
it's not updating let's uh refresh the
page
there we go so it is within the box
with that fixed we can go to the bottom
section
um so let's let's go back to our design
here for a second we've got our top
section bordered out now we have this
overall bottom section so
we will write a css rule to target the
bottom section div
which is right here so you can see the
bottom section which has the two sub
sections within it so let's come down
here
and
just paste in these properties because
that's all we need
but it's obviously going to be the wrong
heights and widths for now so
we do want a 100 width we want it taking
up all of that but the height that we
want is going to be 60 rather than 40.
because as you see with 40 it doesn't
take up the full
uh height of the entire container but
now that we've made it to 60
and then we'll turn this to call it blue
you'll see that we now have a
outer container in red
our top container in green and our
bottom container in blue
now the last thing that we have to do to
get this layout um perfect is going to
be adding these two
containers in the bottom section that
will be side by side
i'm going to add them one at a time
because it's going to require us to do
something a little bit tricky
because they go next to each other so
let's target the
bottom left section first so we'll copy
in this id
into our css put that hashtag in front
to target it
and here we're going to copy in the same
properties again
just to get our border
now this is going to be incorrect at the
moment because we're giving it a width
of 100
but really what we want is a width of 50
percent because we want that to take up
the
first half and then the height that we
want is going to be 100 percent
now i'm using these percentages because
we have these already broken out within
their containers
so let's put a different color on here
um maybe we'll put on
what's contrasting to blue we'll say
orange
so that we can see that pretty nicely
within that container
and the reason that this works is
because the width
the width of 50 percent is going to be
relative to its parent container
so if we look and ask ourselves okay
what is the parent container of this
bottom left section well that's going to
be the bottom section and the bottom
section is outlined in blue right here
so rather than saying 50
width of the entire document we're just
saying 50 width of the bottom section
which is already outlined for us and you
can see
that it's occupying perfectly 50 percent
of that
now if we did the same thing with the
bottom right section so let's change
this id
to the bottom right section and then i'm
running out of colors here but maybe
we'll just give it a 2 pixel solid black
border now we're running into problems
here because now that we have
a bottom right section it's breaking
down onto a new line because all of
these divs are by default block elements
and they occupy their own line so in
order for this to work
we actually have to make both of these
you know subsections
inline block elements so we don't want
to make them inline because inline
elements don't respect the height and
width properties which we want them to
respect but we do want them to be up on
the same line so what we're going to do
is come to both of them and say display
inline block
and then once again
display
inline block now at this point you're
probably wondering
why are these boxes not lining up next
to each other we've given one of them
fifty percent with the other one 50 with
and we've turned them
into inline blocks which basically means
that they both can sit on the same line
unlike a block element
now the reason that this is happening is
probably going to make you pretty mad um
because it made me mad when i found it
out for the first time and a lot of
other people
and it's kind of just a quirky thing
about css so when you make an inline
block
that respects the white space within the
document and believe it or not if you
come up to this html
where we have the bottom left section in
the bottom right section
there's actually some white space
between these two elements so
this this space right here is considered
white space for inline block elements
so if we were to just backspace and
bring this right next to each other
it's going to bring this box up within
that container and it's going to fit
perfectly
now
i know what you're thinking
like i said this is kind of infuriating
that this is the reason that that was
doing that and that's kind of you know
coding in general sometimes you just
find things that are completely
ridiculous and what i will say is that
there is
some hope so in the next couple of
videos we're going to be talking about
css grid in flexbox
and both of those will be a much more
optimal way to make this layout like
we've done here
and you won't run into these weird
quirky problems that just exist
as a part of kind of the older
method of writing css
all right so just keep that in mind we
have taken the divs that were nicely uh
laid out in our html above like this and
we've just removed the little white
space between them and now it's going to
work just fine so that's hopefully the
only little hack that we're going to
have to do throughout this project
and like i said it's just it's a little
bit frustrating but
we have to do it here and until we know
css grid and flexbox at least
but this would be kind of your old way
of lining these things up now the last
thing that we have to do here because
we've got our layout so if we come back
to
visual studio code
you can see that we've got our top
section bottom left and bottom right
section all outlined with these ugly
colors and and whatnot and at this point
we can start putting html elements
within them so let me go ahead and grab
some of the text that we created over
here just in this ugly
space
and i'm just going to copy the exact
html
and put it into each of the sections
that it belongs in
so we're going to see some html go up
here and of course it's not going to not
going to fully fit at the beginning
we will fix that i promise
and then let's come down here grab this
put this in the bottom
left section
and you'll see that we have some
some spacing that we're going to have to
address here and that is partially due
to the
the default margin that is given
that is being given to h2 and h4
elements and paragraph elements
and then finally the bottom right
section will copy that
and paste it into the bottom right
section
okay so we've got all of our elements in
here and now we have to fix a few things
one of those things is the default
margin that we're getting on these
elements so i'm going to actually
inspect the whole page
it's going to look very weird for a
second
but if we hover over
some of these elements you'll see that
we have this orange
margin on top and on bottom of those h4
elements and that is because it's just a
browser default it's something that just
it you know happens by default and if we
go over to this page you can see that
all of our text is is spaced out pretty
nicely and that is because of those
browser defaults but obviously over here
we don't want them to be in effect
because we want our
document to have no spacing around we
want to add our own spacing so all we
have to do
is come up to the top and to our html
or sorry css reset where we're just you
know resetting default properties i'm
just going to grab the h2 element and
the h4 element that we have as well as
the paragraph element
and give it a margin of zero
so hopefully that will fix a few things
you can see that we
have no spacing around here
all right the last problem we're dealing
with here it looks like we've got all of
our text without default spacing so
that's nice
and the last thing that we're worrying
about is this orange box which is oddly
just
sitting there floating in space
and if you were to right click and
inspect this
and you start clicking around
looking at this
there's not going to be any
you know obvious reason why this is
sitting down here there's no margin or
padding or anything going on here
so you kind of have to ask yourself what
is going on
and from experience i just know that
when you have an inline block element it
follows different rules than a block
element and there are different
properties that will allow you to modify
how those rules are applying to your
html
now that's kind of similar to all css so
when you change display properties and
box sizing there's just different rules
of the game so if we were to come over
to the mdn documentation
and type in
vertical
align
this is going to show us a property
and it says the vertical line css
property sets vertical alignment of an
inline
inline block or table cell box so this
does not apply at all to block elements
which is the default type of html
element for
pretty much everything but what it does
is it basically says this is a pretty
good visual right here
if you have two inline block elements
that are sitting right next to each
other on the same line they can be
aligned
at different vertical positions
and by default i'm not sure exactly what
the default is here
probably the baseline or something like
that
but anyways we want to make sure that
this
gets the top alignment because if we
come back to our
challenge here we want these two
inline blocks to basically lock up to
the top
border of their container
so if we go into each of the sections
and for the bottom left section that's
behaving oddly if we type in vertical
align and then say top it's going to
bring it right back up and snap it to
the
top edge of its container
now the bottom right section just so
happens to snap up there naturally
but let's go ahead and
add the vertical line top for
consistency's sake and this will also
snap that to the top
so at this point it looks like we have a
nicely laid out card
and although it is pretty ugly we've got
everything that we need all of the
content in there and we've got the
layout that we need so at this point
it's all about styling so in our four
step process we looked at number one
that was just looking at the design in
some cases you'd actually do the
designing
in step two we asked ourselves how do we
lay that out with html so we templated
everything out
now in step three we have to ask how can
i use css to achieve the layout that i
want and that's exactly what we did here
we just used a few basic css properties
to put some borders and really visualize
the card component that we're trying to
create and now finally how should we
style each element and this is kind of
the fun part where
our ugly layout example is going to turn
into
what we see in this example a nice
styled card so i think the first thing
that i want to do
let me go back to my example here
since this is just called layout example
let's let's copy all the html here
into our original code pen
and of course all of the css we'll copy
in there too
so this should get us back to where
we were there and i can go ahead and
close this out
so we've just got this one example and i
think what the next step here is going
to be
is to get these background colors uh put
in there so we're going to start to get
something that doesn't look so ugly so
just looking at the colors
let's just drop these into google
because i'm really not sure just they're
saying cyan bright yellow light gray
in a grayish blue and to be completely
honest i don't know what that refers to
here
it looks like this might be the yellow
um not sure where the gray is maybe this
text right here
let's let's go ahead and type those into
google real quick so we'll go rgb
and there should be something
rgb to hex maybe
okay this is what we're looking for just
the color picker on google
and all we have to do is go back to our
style guide
and let's see what this cyan color is so
we'll we'll paste in these values right
here i'm not sure why they're giving us
hsl values because that i really haven't
used those
all that much in web development you
usually stick to hex and rgb
but they are so let's go ahead and
convert those to something a little bit
easier to use so we'll grab a hex color
here and let me just replace
this just so we have a reference
and then let's paste in the hsl for this
yellow color that we're working with
which to me looks more green maybe i'm
colorblind who knows
go for those hex values at the end here
just for reference
and then we'll do the same thing for the
remainder because i like working in hex
and i've never really worked with uh hsl
so we'll go
back and
put these in here
now to me when i look at this
these bottom bottom left and bottom
right boxes they
they look like different colors to me
this one looks like just a lighter
version of the left
and in the style guide i'm not so sure
that they've given us
two of those options so if we came in
and looked at the cyan
color so let me paste that in here
it looks like that would be the bottom
left color
that we're dealing with or maybe even
the bottom right color
so what i'm going to do is just drag
this that we have different colors maybe
i'm missing something here but
let me just drag this so that we get a
little bit lighter color that we can
work with
and then i'm going to grab that hex
value and paste it into the style guide
so
we'll put
put that in there as darker
and then lighter and at this point we
can grab these color codes and start
using them so we'll grab the darker
color
and we'll come back to our code pen
and just put in a background color
property so for the bottom left section
we know that we can use the background
color property
and paste that in there and we should be
getting that darker cyan color
alright so at this point we can probably
remove that border
and that looks a little bit nicer for us
and i'm also going to remove the bottom
section blue border
okay so we're looking a little bit
better here and now i want to fill in
the background color for this right
section which
as i just got a slightly lighter hex
value
so we'll go to the bottom right section
get rid of the border
and replace that with a background color
and paste that in
and it's looking like it's it's a little
bit lighter but
compared to the example it's there's
more of a contrast here so let's go
ahead
let's play with that a little bit let's
make it even a little bit more
light
grab that hex value
and see what that looks like
okay so that's that's a little bit
better i like that contrast and you
could even come over to adobe color
and we'll go to this
this
adobe color tool and what i could do
is i could grab the bottom left section
hex code
which is the darker cyan
throw this in the middle here
and then i want some shades of this
color so
we could grab maybe this shade over here
which ensures that it's gonna you know
nicely go together
and let's put that one in the bottom
right section just to get a little bit
more complementary uh colors here
and then
i'll go back here and and replace this
just so we have a reference of it
okay so we've got these two um the top
is going to be white and then at this
point i think we can remove all of the
borders just so that we don't have those
ugly colors going on
so let's let's go up here remove the top
section green border
everything looks good and then the red
border around everything
and boom we have ourselves a nicer
looking layout
now as you'll see
in the example
design
it is kind of standing out against the
background and you'll also notice that
there are some little corners that are
rounded so i want to do that just so
that we have something as a reference
here
and i also want to kind of make this
come out from the top left corner of the
page so all we'd have to do for that is
just add some padding to the body
so if i go here and just add some
padding of 20 pixels to the body you'll
see that that comes in a little bit so
remove it
add it back and you can see our card
just shifts inward so that we can kind
of visualize it a little bit better
and then finally for the card because
that is the main container around
everything what i'm going to do is add a
box
shadow and this property is going to
take i believe five different arguments
and they're all kind of
referencing where the shadow is going to
go so i can open up a tool
called box shadow generator
for css
and there's a a couple tools here i
don't know which one's the best
they all should work but as you see this
css box has a box shadow around it and
you can you know drag these sliders to
get different sorts of box shadows
applying to this
so this is a good visual tool that we
can use to to see what we want
and in our case we probably want a a
much
smaller box shadow so let's let's go
ahead and
actually no we want to stay close to
zero
so we'll go around four pixels and maybe
three pixels or something like that and
make the blur radius a little bit
smaller
and the opacity that we want
let's make it down to like
0.2 or around that area maybe a little
bit more
i think that looks pretty good
so the codes that we need it's showing
us that we need to paste in all of these
these webkit and moz box shadows are
just for like other browser support we
don't necessarily need them so i'm just
going to copy in this rule right here
and we'll paste it in to the cart and
now you're going to see around the edges
we're starting to get a defined
edge to our card so let's go back to
our design
and you can see that we're getting a
little bit closer here
what i want to do is round the corners
now so all we have to do
is say on the main card we say we want
to border radius of call it five pixels
all right so we've got our border radius
on here but what you'll notice is that
the bottom
right corner
and the bottom left corner
do not have a border radius and you
might ask why because we've given
a border radius of 5 pixels which should
apply all around that
container element
but the problem
is because we have these two inner
container elements that are perfect you
know squares and they occupy a hundred
percent
of the space within that main container
so as we make a border radius we're
actually
those inner boxes are actually breaking
out of the main container now
and what you're seeing there is those
those uh child containers there's a
couple ways that we could fix this but a
cool little trick that you can use and i
know this is not necessarily obvious but
if you do enough googling you would find
this out if you
set the overflow property
to hidden
on the main container element
you'll see that those
borders go rounded and basically what
that's saying is we want to take those
perfect square children containers
and since those are breaking out of the
main container we want to say to the
main container css style okay if you
have anything that's breaking out of
your borders just hide it and so that's
what allows those bottom border radiuses
to apply so just a cool little trick
it's also one of those frustrating
things about css where
it's doing things that you would not
expect and that is literally the name of
the game with css
is figuring out how to get around the
things that you're not expecting to
happen
okay so we're getting a little bit
closer here
the next thing that we can do that will
just add a really nice touch
and make this look a little bit cleaner
is some padding i think
so let's jump back to our design and you
can see that all around the content here
so around
every bit of content there is this space
this nice padding in here
and what we could do is we could come in
to our code pen
and we could just say on the total card
we want to add some padding
of say 20 pixels
but that's going to
mess us up a little bit because although
it adds nice padding around everything
now these are not occupying 100 width
and also we want some padding within
these sub little containers so what i'm
going to do instead of adding it on the
total card
to get padding like that i'm going to
add them on each individual section
so we'll call it a padding of about 20
pixels that's a pretty standard amount
of padding to add
and we can just look at this little
space between the edge and the text on
the top and the left
to get an idea of how large that padding
is
and that looks pretty in line with our
design so i'm happy with that and then
let's copy that rule down into the other
sections so not the bottom section
because that represents everything here
but i want to do it in the bottom left
section so we get that nice padding and
then i also want to do it in the bottom
right section which will make the
padding
nice there too so at this point we've
gone from a completely ugly layout
design to something that actually makes
sense visually we obviously have a lot
to do with the text styles and colors in
that button but we're getting a lot
closer let's go ahead and change the
text color you can see that everything
in the bottom is a text color of white
and then the top has varying text colors
so we'll start with the top and you can
see that the the heading is the same
color as the bottom left or at least it
appears to be
so let me grab that bottom left color
and we'll go ahead and apply that to our
join our community text block so let me
collapse the js here and we'll go up to
the join our community and what you
could do is you could target everything
in the top section that's in h2
and since we're not planning on changing
the html
structure anytime soon i'm pretty happy
with that you could also throw an id
you know that says title and
directly style it
but in this case let's go ahead and
practice our combinator skills our css
combinators to style this
so we'll come down here and at this
point you'll see the css is getting
pretty busy you might want to rearrange
it and organize it by section but for
now let's just keep going and what we'll
do is we'll say the top section is the
pre-selector that we want
and then we want to grab every h2
element which is simply that first title
and what we want to do is style it a
color of that bottom left so now we're
going to get the correct color
let's go back to our
visual studio code
and see what else we have so we have
this kind of lime green yellowish color
as the next one
and that is going to be
this hex code the bright yellow
so going back to our code pen
you can see that this is the only h4
that is sitting in our top section
so we can grab a similar rule
as we just did except this time we're
grabbing h4s and giving it a color of
yellow
so there is our yellow color and then
finally
we should have some sort of gray color
and let me
get to our visual studio code
this this paragraph text is gray
and in the style guide
i believe that is the light gray that
we're looking for so let's copy that hex
code
and then make all of the paragraph
elements
in the top section
equal to this light gray color
okay so that is that is very light i'm
not sure if that's what we were supposed
to do
it appears pretty pretty good here but
it's pretty darn light when we're
looking at it here so i'm going to go
ahead and make this a little bit
stronger of a gray
maybe it's the grayish blue actually
let's try that instead
ah okay so i think that's what they
meant
for this style
yeah i think that's what we're looking
for here
so the grayish blue looks a little bit
better we'll stay with that now we just
have to add some
some spacing between these so if you
remember at the very top of our html
we did a reset that said for all h2 h4
and p elements
we want to
add a margin of zero so that removed all
the default spacing and now we can do it
custom and since we've got all three of
these elements selected with these
combinators we can just drop into these
rules and do so
let's take a look at our design it looks
like there's a good amount of space
just by experience that looks about 15
pixels between the top and the next one
let's go ahead and try that by adding
a
margin
bottom
of 15 pixels
and you can see that's a nice little
spacing there
um
what i'm starting to see is that our top
section now that we've got this laid out
is a little bit small from a height
perspective so
i think i'm going to adjust our our
total dimensions here
um previously we had said the bottom
section has a height of 60 in the top 40
percent i'm going to change that to 45
and 55.
and you'll see now we have a little bit
more realistic uh breakout between the
two sections i'm pretty happy with that
so
the last thing we need to do now that we
made that change is add some spacing
between this these two text elements and
then
we've already got some padding at the
bottom so we'll go down to our rule of
the h4
and add a margin on the bottom of 10
pixels which seems about right
so comparing that up
i think we're getting pretty close and
and now that i'm looking at it we might
actually need a little bit more padding
around this
uh than we've given it so
let's go to
the top section wherever we did that and
let's increase that padding to say 25
pixels
that that looks a little bit better
for us and then we'll go ahead and
update that to 25 pixels in the other
two spots that we
had added that
okay so we're doing pretty good there
and it looks like our total card size
is it's starting to break out but i'm
gonna wait on that before i try to
restyle because the text is going to get
a little bit smaller when we set the
font size and change the font style
so the last thing we'll do is come down
and since everything in the bottom it
looks like is a color of white
we can just go to the
selector that we used
for the the entire bottom section so
rather than trying to style the text in
the left
section and the right section we can
just go to the entire bottom section and
give it a color of white
that looks pretty good
i think that should work and then you
can see the button color is not being
styled because that is a separate
element there so what i can do is
actually target
all buttons
because there's only one button on the
entire page
so we'll we'll style the button and
we'll give it a color of white
and that's going to give it a text color
over white we'll make that show up a
little bit better once we
add a background color which looks like
that lime green but i'm going to wait on
that for just a second
the next major change that i want to
make is getting this text to be the
right font family
right now we're just using the browser
default whatever that is i don't
actually know off the top of my head but
we want to make this a different font
completely and if you look at the style
guide
it's going to say the font family that
we're looking at is carla and if we go
to this link
we can see all of the different styles
that we need now the question is what
what font weights and you know styles do
we need
well we can go and look at the spec it
says we need weights of 400 and 700
so let me take the font weight of 400
and select that style
and then the font weight of 700 and
select that as well
we will grab the link tags that we need
we'll go back to our code pen over here
go up to the settings
html
and in the stuff for the head element so
since codepen gives us our own little
environment we don't actually have to
make
the head
element or boilerplate so we can just
paste it here
and by doing this and saving and closing
we now have access to that new font
but it hasn't changed anything because
we have to actually select it within our
document
so up at the root element we want to
give a font family
of
carla and you can see that it changed
our design completely
and it says that the
overall font size is going to be 16
pixels
so let's go ahead and say that the font
size in the root element is going to be
16 pixels which is just going to apply
to those
paragraph elements as i'm flipping back
and forth between these two designs
looks like we still need a little more
space after this so let me do that real
quick
before i get into
anything else we'll add 20 pixels to
there
okay and then i'm i'm thinking that
we're running out of space vertically
and since we
came up with an arbitrary height
at the beginning
i don't mind changing that because they
didn't specify what the height should be
so let's go ahead and
turn that to 400 to give us some more
space and i think this looks a lot
closer to the card that we're working
with here so just adjusting that gives
us a pretty good look and now we've got
our font family
styled here i think the next thing we
have to do is figure out of that font
family they had us download the font
weight of 400 and 700 which means
that some of these should have a font
weight of 700 or bold so let's look at
our design and see which ones
that would apply to
it looks like to me this 29
uh call out is the only one where the
font weight is you know extra bold so
let's come down and
um
because the default font weight is going
to be 400 or you could also specify it
in the
root so we'll say 400
but that's once again going to be the
default so it's not going to change but
if we came down to our
price right here
we're going to have to actually
uh put some
identifiers on here to enable us uh or
it let us select it with css
so i'm gonna say
price
um price container and then
this will be an id of price
and then this will have an id of
price frequency
or something like that so now we have
ids to basically
select each of these little components
here
and if we come down to our css we need
to set the price to a font weight of
700. so we'll come down to the bottom
we'll set our price to a font weight of
700 and you'll see
that this gets a little bit bolder so if
i uncomment it it's not bold if i
comment it back it's going to be bold
and then while we're here just give us a
ballpark uh font size let's go ahead and
say 1.4
rem
which is basically going to be
of the root elements font size which we
know is 16 pixels so do 140 times 16
pixels and that's how many pixels we
just made that font size too
all right looking back we're getting
closer we're not
we're not too far off i think the next
obvious thing that's going on that we're
missing is this button because our
button looks terrible
in comparison so let's go ahead and make
a button that is about the same size
here
and also has that background color we've
already selected the button so that we
could give it
white text but now we can just
go ahead and grab this color code that
we used for the h4
up here
and apply it as the background color
to the button
so we'll give the background color that
light green you can see that there's by
default this border that looks pretty
terrible so we can set the border to be
equal to
none
that makes that look a little bit better
and then there's more spacing
than we have here around this text so
that's a good use for padding
so all we need to do is come in and add
we'll say 10 pixels of padding
that looks roughly correct and then
finally you can see that this has a
border radius so the button has curves
around the edges and it's equal to kind
of the size of that container so
remember we put some padding around the
edges of this container so the new
size that we're going to have is we
should be able to just say a hundred
percent i believe
so let's say the width is going to be a
hundred percent
and yes that's going to get it get us
equal to that parent container
so at this point we just need to add a
border radius of call it 5 pixels
and i think our button is looking pretty
good
so
it looks like we're a little bit wider
than this right here but i'm not too
worried about that we have the
perspective
pretty good and the most important part
is that it's a hundred percent of the
container
so i think at this point we have all of
the colors
in place let's just check that
yes we do so we have all the colors that
we need
and our font family is correct
now
we just need to do two more things we
need to to get the font sizes and font
weights
a little bit better and then we also
need to get everything spaced out in
this
price
and the frequency horizontal to each
other i'm going to go ahead and say that
this top section is completely done
it's not you know perfectly aligned with
this design but it's very close um and
part of this is we're looking at a much
larger version of this so
um we're never going to get it like
exactly perfectly it's just not worth
our time
but down here let's go ahead and start
working on this bottom left box
so
this monthly subscription
that looks okay maybe a little bit heavy
in font but i'm not too worried about it
but there needs to be some space between
it and the price
so let's target this right here and put
a margin at the bottom of it and the way
we can do that is go find in the html
the tag that we want so the bottom left
section
and like we did in the top section we
can just target individual elements
so we'll
target that and then we want to use a
combinator to say
that we want to target the h4
potentially
let's see what we have here so we have
the monthly subscription as an h4 and
that's the only h4 in this entire
section so we're pretty safe
to target it with the combinator and now
we want to give it a margin on the
bottom
of call it 20 pixels
i think that's pretty good
maybe a little much so maybe we'll go
with something like
not 5 but 15 pixels
okay i like that and now the next part
is we're going to take this per month
and drag it up onto the line that the 29
dollars is on
so to do that we once again target the
bottom left section
and
actually no we're not going to target
that we now have the this individual
price container
so that we can work specifically with
this
layout
and what i want to do is grab the price
frequency
right here so we'll target the price
and i want to display this as an inline
block because i want it to come up on
that line
uh next to the 29 dollars and at the
moment
it's not doing it because the 29 dollars
is not an inline block
so we can target both of those we can
say price frequency
um
and
the actual price to both be inline
blocks and now they're coming
onto the same line and since we have
both of those elements within this div
container the price container we can
just say on the entire
price container
that we want a margin on the bottom of
call it 20 or 10 pixels what you'll see
here is that the per month is kind of
aligned to the bottom of this 29 dollars
in a quick way
to do this you know if we were using
flexbox this would be super easy
but a kind of a quick hack to change
this
is set the position of this element to
relative
which then allows us to
basically if you remember from the first
video of the css crash course
we talked about how relatively
positioned elements
you can set them
basically relative to themselves so if
we give it the top property and then we
want to bring it upwards so we basically
want to do a negative amount of pixels
and we say we want to bring it up maybe
three pixels you'll see that that per
month kind of goes up a little bit so
watch the per month and i'm going to
uncomment or i'm going to comment this
out
it's going to go back to the bottom and
then i'm going to put it back in there
and it goes
up to the middle so i kind of like how
that's sitting and then furthermore on
that price frequency the font size
should be a little bit smaller so we'll
give it 0.8 rem
so that's a little bit closer
and then you'll also see that
it has a little bit more space between
the 29 dollars and it's also a little
bit lighter so it's not quite as
punchy of a white color
so all we would have to do here is maybe
give it a trans or not transparency but
we could give it an opacity of maybe 0.8
and that makes it a little bit lighter
for us maybe even 0.7
okay i like that and then finally a
margin to the left of it of maybe five
pixels
and you can see that spaces it over to
the right so i'm pretty happy with how
we've got that spaced out
that's relatively relatively close in
style and position
and i like the size of the 29 dollars so
i think we're done with that little sub
component of the top of the bottom left
container
next up are full access for less than a
dollar a day
that's a little bit large in my opinion
um
because it looks like this text is even
a little bit smaller than this paragraph
text up here
so we probably want to make this a
little bit smaller in relation to the
paragraph text
the way that we'll do that is this is
the only paragraph element within the
bottom left section
so once again we will
grab the bottom left section and maybe
even just copy this rule right below
here
and target all p elements which will be
a single element and give it a font size
of maybe 0.9 rem units
and that gives us a nice size maybe
we'll make it even a little bit smaller
so 80 of the
the original text size of 16 pixels
and then finally we just have to bring
this button all the way down to the
bottom so
we have a couple ways of doing this but
one of those ways would be
you know taking this p element and just
putting a margin on the bottom of maybe
40 pixels
and that should bring the button down
now flipping between these two
i'm seeing that uh
this
these text right here is kind of in the
middle of the top in the button
so i'm going to change a few of these
alignments here i think we need a little
bit more margin below the monthly
subscription so let's add maybe 25
pixels instead of 15.
and that gives us a nice little layout
there so it's not perfect
not exactly the same but it is fairly
close and we've gotten all of the
functional
and layouts pretty good here so at this
point i think we're done with the top
we're done with the bottom left
and now we just have the bottom right
which should be relatively simple to do
so the why us piece is already pretty
good i like how that's sitting it's in
alignment with monthly subscription same
size as it so
so that's good
and now we just need to take the bullet
points off of our list item and align
those two uh to the left of each other
so let's see that how we would do this
so to really show you what's going on
here let's open up the
chrome dev tools
and try to just rearrange this so that
we can see everything
it's a little bit weird debugging html
and css in a codepen environment because
you've got all these different windows
open but really what this right side
elements is doing is looking at this
html page so if we were to click this
selector up here and come down and grab
the entire list that we're looking at
you'll immediately see that there is
some sort of you know padding and margin
around this list by default
so the the margin is fine that doesn't
bother me at all
but that green little box on the left
side of all the text is some default
padding that is added to list because
generally you want those lists to kind
of be indented from the main text so
that's what you would want but here we
don't want that so if we go over into
the style right here and we basically
say
padding is equal to zero you're going to
see that everything goes to the left and
it lines up with the text like we want
it
now the last thing is there's bullet
points that we don't want there and you
can actually set the list style property
and set that to none
and by doing that all of the bullet
points go away and so those are the only
two changes that we'll have to make to
get this to work so let me go ahead and
refresh the page so we get this reset
because those changes we made were
actually temporary
and then we'll come down to the very
bottom
and since there's only one list in our
entire html document we'll just target
it by tag
and we'll say the padding is equal to
zero
and the list style is none
so we've removed the
list styling by using this attribute or
property
and remove the padding on the left so
it's all lining up just like our
design here but what we are missing is
this looks a little bit smaller and it
also isn't so
such an intense white color so it looks
like the opacity of it might be a little
bit lower similar to this per month
piece of text
so all we need to do there
is say font size
and we'll bring it down to
what did we say
this one was
0.8 rem so 80 of the root element size
or 80 times 16 pixels
and then we can bring the opacity down
to 0.8 as well
and i think that looks pretty pretty
good there
it's not exact but it is it's pretty
much in line with uh with everything at
this point i think we're pretty much
done
the only remaining item
that i can think of is this button right
here so the button is currently
not doing anything when we hover over it
and i want to change that especially
because that was part of the
requirements
so here's our button styles
in this block right here
and in order to
style it on hover we need to give it the
pseudo class
of hover
and once we do that this was something
that we talked about and i think the
first lesson of the crash course
and the first thing that we always want
to do on hover is change the cursor to a
pointer so you can see how the cursor
changes as i hover over this button and
that's just to indicate to the user that
hey you can click on this
so from here we also probably want to
change the color when we hover over it
because the cursor is not obvious enough
so we could just take this uh background
color right here that's already on the
button and make it a little bit lighter
or a little bit darker so let's grab
that hex code and bring it into our
color wheel of adobe color
and let's just see if we can find like a
shade of this that would work
i think
something like maybe this one on the
right would be
okay
and if we bring that in
and we change the background color to
the hover state to that little bit
darker color it's going to just have an
effect where it's showing us oh hey you
can click here and it's going to do
something and to make that even more
pronounced there's a property that you
can use called transform and there's
plenty of
values that you can pass here but one of
those is going to be the scale function
and we can just say like 1.1 or
something like that so we can scale it
and you'll see that it you know gets a
little bit larger when we hover over it
and that's that's even a little extreme
maybe we'll just do
1.02 or 102
and i like that that's a nice little
subtle indication to the user that when
they hover over and click this it will
do something
now right now this button doesn't do
anything but just for fun just to add
something in there we can come up and
use what we've learned in the prior
lessons of this
full stack road map
and come up to the button
and add ourselves an on click listener
and we'll pass the function alert user
which we have not created yet but we'll
come down to the js section and say
alert user
and then we will pass an alert that says
hey
you clicked
the button
so let's finish that one up and now when
we click this button it's going to alert
the user that they clicked it
so obviously not you know useful but
it's a nice little addition to make this
a little bit more interactive
now the final thing that we
could do here is make this mobile
responsive and what i mean by that is if
we drag this right side over
to the left you'll see that it just
disappears
right here and it just flows off of the
page which is a terrible user experience
if you're on mobile
so this would be about the size of a
mobile device
so if your user you know
looked at this
design
this is what they're going to see which
is completely useless to them so what
you would want to do
is make it a mobile design and as you
see
in the front-end mentor challenge it
tells you that you need to design
something like this
now we haven't talked about
mobile and responsive design quite yet
and i'm going to cover that in a
completely separate video i think that
might be the next video after this one
so for now we're going to keep it just
desktop only but in future challenges
future front-end mentor challenges we
will make that
we will make this mobile responsive
now there's one more thing that i want
to do because it's quick it's easy and
it will give you at least a little bit
of a win here in terms of being able to
share this and show it off so
if we come to github let me open up a
new tab
and go to github
if you followed along with this full
stack roadmap
from the very beginning i had asked you
to create a github account because
you're going to need it as a developer
no matter what it's just kind of
expected of you to have a github profile
so if you've already got one great if
not go ahead and create one
and let's go ahead and click create new
repository right here
and we'll say
pricing
card
frontend mentor
challenge is what we're going to name
this repository
and we're going to call it an
implementation
of the
front-end mentor
code challenge
and we're going to make it public
and you don't really need to initialize
any of these but let's go ahead and add
a readme i'll just show you what that is
and you click create repository
so we're going to go through
version control and how to actually get
this within the terminal a little bit
later in the series but for right now
we're just going to use github's
ui or user interface to post our code
and then deploy it to github pages
and what github pages is going to do is
it's going to allow you to host this
challenge you just created on the web
and share it as a url
so here's our initialized repository
every repo or repository is going to
have
a readme or at least it should and this
should give an introduction to
what this repository is all about and
oftentimes when you're building a web
app
the readme will give instructions on how
to run it locally and how to develop it
and you know you get the point
so
within the repository we obviously could
make files on our local computer and
then use version control to push the
files up to this
interface but for right now we're just
going to add a file
and we're going to click create new file
and this one is going to be called
index.html
so this will basically be
all of the html that we just created and
index.html is the default html document
that github pages
is going to look for when it's trying to
serve it on you know the live url
so it needs to be named this and from
here
if you were to go back to our html and
copy it all
and paste it in here we have the body
section implemented but since codepen
already implements the head tag and the
um body tag
that's not going to be here so we need
to add those pieces in order for this to
work
so the first thing that i'm going to do
or actually let's let's come back and
write out that structure so basically
we'll come to the top and we'll say that
we need an html tag
and we'll copy this one and put it at
the very bottom
and then furthermore let me zoom in a
little bit so you can see what i'm
working on
and then after this we will need the
head tag
and we'll just we'll call it
uh my front end or no we'll say
pricing card will be the title which is
going to show up in this little tab when
we're viewing it live
and then we'll close out the head tag
we'll come back to this in just a second
to add those fonts that we put in and
then we've got the body tag which is
going to be closed all the way down here
at the bottom
and then lastly let's just indent
everything
to a proper level and now you can see
that we've wrapped everything together
in this html
the last thing we're going to need to do
here is
link up all of the style sheets and the
fonts so if we go back to our pricing
card go to settings
html we're going to need all of that
stuff that we had in the head
and we're going to put that right after
the title so you can see we have these
two link tags
and then furthermore we're going to have
to link up our css stylesheet that we'll
put in in just a second
so the way that we do that is another
link tag
and
i believe the
href
is going to be
style.css
which we're going to create in just a
second
and this will be a stylesheet
so we'll close that off
and what this means is basically i want
you to pull in
the file called
style.css
in the
directory that is
basically hosting this index.html file
you'll see what that means in just a
second
so for now let's go ahead and commit
this new file
and go down to add another file
and this one is going to be style.css
which is what i just talked about how we
linked up to that within our html
and from here we should be able to just
paste in all of this css
right here that we had created
so nothing nothing else to do here we
can just go ahead and commit that file
and then finally we need to add our
javascript file so
we added just a few lines of javascript
down here
but in order for that to work we need to
actually connect it up to our html
and the way that we're going to do that
is go back to our html file
click edit
and then come down to the bottom of the
body and this is where we need to have
our script tag to do that we just type
out a script tag which is not
self-closing there's actually two pieces
to it
and we need to give it a source
and we're going to say um
let's say just
index.js
is what we're going to call our
javascript
document so
commit those changes i believe that
should work
so long as we go to the main
file here or the main directory and add
that javascript file
so we need to name this index index.js
as we just referred to in our html and
then we should be able to paste in
that function that we created
and commit the file
from here
this is
a complete repository i believe unless i
missed something but we'll find out in a
second
now the only thing that we need to do is
add another branch now this is
a little bit complex we're getting into
version control branching but basically
the rule here within github is if you
make a branch called gh dash pages or
github pages
it's automatically going to look for you
know the index.html file on that
different branch and it's going to
deploy it automatically for you so it
does a lot of the heavy lifting and you
can for now kind of just think of it as
behind the scenes magic but we will
later learn how this all works
so we're going to create a branch called
github pages
and we're going to create it from the
main
branch so it's going to copy all the
files
over
okay so at this point we've got all of
our files in github pages and if i did
everything correctly which
usually does not happen in coding
it should show up
down on this github pages link
so let's see
if we click view deployment
awesome it looks like our card actually
did deploy correctly with the styles
because it's all styled and if we click
sign up hopefully
we'll get the alert
so awesome we have um our deploy link
which you can just copy and paste this
link up here and share it with anyone
and they can see the project that you
just worked on you could also submit
this to front-end mentor if you wanted
to to get feedback on your project
so
awesome we've got something deployed and
shareable
[Music]
as you saw in the intro our goal as web
developers is to avoid our users hurting
their eyes after they look at our web
application on a desktop device a tablet
a mobile device or whatever they're
viewing it on let's take a look at some
of the prerequisites
it's basically just html and css which
we covered
for the most part in the prior lessons
of this series now let's talk about this
for just a second on what we're going to
be covering here because this is a
massive topic that i cannot do
justice to if i'm not defining exactly
what we're going to be learning i'm
going to start on the right side of this
screen
and as i said i am not the best designer
in the world graphic design is generally
a painful experience for myself
i've put together a few decent designs
over the years but nothing that you know
i could call myself a designer in any
form or fashion but the good news is as
a full stack web developer you do not
need to be a great graphic designer for
that reason i'm not going to teach you
the design side of things and as we've
talked about
previously in the series we're going to
be going through and making some of
these challenges with html css and even
javascript so this is frontend mentor
and this is one of the designs that
we're going to create after we learn
about css grid and flexbox over the next
couple videos
and you can see that there's a
responsive design here we're going to
talk more about that in just a second
likewise we have this challenge right
here which is just another looks like
crowdfunding page so this will be a fun
one to do
and what you'll notice here is that as
we're going through our course here
we're leveraging existing designs we're
not trying to do this on our own and
that is the point of this video is to
teach you how to leverage those existing
designs and make sure that
everything is responsive and looks good
on all devices that you might see it on
so here are the lessons that we're going
to learn in this video
first off what is responsive design now
you probably have a general idea of that
but we'll dive a little deeper into it
next we'll be talking about mobile first
versus desktop first designs and
honestly it took me years to figure out
what this actually meant which
looking back is is kind of silly because
it's not that hard but
we're going to talk about that so mobile
first versus desktop first
next up we'll talk about css breakpoints
how they relate to media queries in how
we actually write media queries within
our web apps and then finally i'm going
to leave you with a responsive design
checklist this is not going to be super
detailed just a high level checklist
that you can go through to make sure
you're covering your bases
and a little project what we're going to
do is take our design from a previous
video so it was the previous video i'll
link to it up here where we designed
this pricing card
and what you'll see with this pricing
card is as we resize the screen
it just gets cut off so i'm going to
teach you in the challenge at the end of
the video
how we can take this situation
and turn it into this one where as we
resize it gets close gets close and then
boom it breaks and it looks a lot better
on a mobile device something that your
users will not be angry about let's go
ahead and dive into that question of
what is responsive web design
and the answer to that at least in my
head i like to keep it simple so that we
can remember it
if your users
hurt their eyes looking at your web page
on a desktop device or a mobile device
or a tablet or whatever they're viewing
it on then you have not designed it
responsibly so that is a good little way
to remember what responsive design is
all about now here's the thing it's 2021
and there's a lot of website builders
there's you know squarespace there's wix
wordpress
a bunch of other website builders that
kind of take care of this responsiveness
for you and for that reason most
websites nowadays are responsive and
they look pretty good so i had a hard
time
actually finding a bad example of
responsive web design for that reason i
created one that's not going to be
anything
crazy but let me close out a few tabs
here
and what i created was this you know
very basic example of bad web design but
a few things that you'll notice here is
as i make it larger and larger so this
is a pretty big screen i'm working on
you'll notice a few things so first off
as my eyes read across this text i have
to cover a lot of real estate on the
screen to actually get through one
single line of text
and that's kind of a no-no when it comes
to responsive web design you want that
text to be you know generally less than
we'll call it 700 pixels
um so it needs to be you know in the
middle of the screen and needs to be
narrow enough for your eyes to not have
to basically move great distances to
read it so that's one piece of this
another piece is you see this nav bar up
here we've got a couple links on the
left and a couple on the right and they
are very spaced out to the point where
it's it's almost too spaced out so those
are a couple issues going on with this
on a very wide screen now if we make
this more narrow
you're going to see something that is
just going to hurt your eyes which is
not the point of responsive design
so as we get smaller this could be a
mobile device of some sort you'll see
that we have two columns here and that's
not going to work on a mobile device you
want to have most content to be you know
full width on a mobile
screen and then also you have all of
these links up at the top and the
contact link is almost getting cut off
to the point where you can't even click
it or see it or anything so that's a big
problem if we were viewing this on a
mobile device now what i did was i went
ahead and improved it a little bit so
this is the improved
version of this design
where you'll see on a wide screen
the article text is only a certain width
i think i made it something like 650
pixels wide as a maximum and you can see
that we can skim this text without you
know moving our heads from left to right
and then also you'll see that the navbar
has has been brought in so these links
are not you know at the very edges of
our page
and then as we resize this you're going
to see that
everything changes so
right around here i believe somewhere
right there so you'll see at this break
point
this column goes under the main text
which is going to be a little bit easier
to see
and then also you'll see the
links at the top are going to turn into
a navigation menu that it doesn't do
anything because i didn't want to spend
the time to do that but this would be
like a drop down so that you could see
the links there and then i left the home
link so that you can still navigate that
way so even on a really small device you
can see that you know most of this looks
pretty good now
obviously this is not the most visually
pleasing design in the world
it's not meant to be it's meant to show
you
generally what responsive design is to
get a better grasp of what this is all
about let's take a look at really good
examples of responsive design and i'll
point out a few things that are good
about them the two portfolio sites we're
going to be looking at are
cassie evans this is just a really nice
looking site
and jason lanksdorf i think i said that
right i don't know either of these
people but i have found their portfolio
sites and they're just really visually
pleasing they've done a really good job
at responding to different screen sizes
so as we look at this let's go ahead and
break this this window out so that we
can kind of resize it but let's just
take a look at how these websites react
to different screen sizes
so here is
cassie's website and this is the home
page you'll see that as we resize this
to a more mobile device that big text is
going to get broken out to the main
portion we're going to get rid of that
image right there
so it's a little nicer to see on a
mobile device and then as you scroll
down you'll see everything is kind of
full width if we were to bring this back
to a desktop now it's got a nice little
layout so you kind of get the point this
is just a really nice
example of good responsive design right
here likewise jason's site is pretty
good in this respect so you'll see
there's this picture here on the left on
a desktop device and as we resize
it's going to get put on top the button
gets a little bigger so it's easier to
click on a mobile device
and as we go smaller and smaller you're
going to see that it's really easy to
navigate around if we click the blog
you'll see it's the same thing
on a mobile device it looks really nice
and everything is easy to click
on a desktop it's also really nice and
you can see that it's in the middle of
the screen this was what i was talking
about earlier you don't want your text
to be the full length of a desktop
device because some of them are going to
be huge screens and you'll have to move
your head to read the text in the first
place next up we have to talk about
mobile first versus desktop first web
designs when i was first learning i'll
be honest i could not figure out what
the difference between these were
everyone was talking about it and saying
oh you want to do mobile first mobile
first but i never understood what they
were talking about and it wasn't until i
realized that these concepts of mobile
or desktop first design
has nothing really to do with the design
phase of a project and it has everything
to do with when we start writing our css
so it's really important when you're you
know learning all these concepts to
really separate the design phase from
the coding phase of a project you don't
want to get into the
situation where you're trying to design
something and code it at the exact same
time because after all designing
something is very right brained and
coding something is very left brain so
you're going to get to the point where
you're just in complete confusion if
you're trying to do both at the same
time so my rule for myself at least is
before i write any code whatsoever i
need to have at least a basic visual
representation of what i'm trying to
create but if you're a very mediocre
designer like myself or if you just have
no design skills whatsoever what do you
do you know do we actually try to design
something or do we just hire someone to
do it that's a question that i was
asking when i first started in my
opinion you really have three options
when it comes to you know getting that
first visual representation of your web
page in front of you number one you can
hire a designer and have them design it
for you but in most cases especially if
you're watching this you don't have the
time to go figure out what designer
you want to hire and then furthermore
you know you don't need to pay anyone to
learn how to code so that's kind of out
of the equation that's for later down
the road when you're trying to actually
build a product and sell it and you need
to have a really professional design
build the second option is to browse the
internet for free designs and that's
what we've done with the front end
mentor challenges this is a great way to
kind of outsource that step for free and
what you can see is we've got these
designs that we're going to be creating
already built for us and we don't have
to think about them at all as we scroll
through this you'll see that there are
desktop versions here and then there's
also mobile versions so that you can see
how do we want this to look on both
sides of screen if you're not super
worried about what you know your end
product is going to look like but you
want to still make it mobile responsive
you can put together a wireframe and you
can use a tool such as figma
so this is a really popular place to put
together a wireframe or even a mock-up
which is a complete representation of
what you want to build but usually
pencil and paper is good enough for a
basic wireframe and your goal with a
wireframe is to just get a general idea
of where the elements that you have on
your page should be arranged based on
the size of the screen so i'll put
something up on the screen just a basic
wireframe that i created for we'll just
call it like a blog where you have a
sidebar and you have some regular
content and you can see a desktop
version and a mobile version and this is
entirely sufficient if you're just
trying to get a basic understanding of
what you're creating now like i said if
you're trying to build out a product or
something or if you're a great designer
you can use a tool like figma which is
going to allow you to put on put
together full-on mock-ups and the
difference between say a wireframe and a
mock-up is a wireframe doesn't really
care about you know the colors and the
fonts
all that detail it just cares about kind
of the layout of the elements on the
page now a mock-up is a full-on
representation of what you're trying to
build so a tool like figma or adobe xd
or sketch or a couple other different
good tools for that can allow you to
create full-on mock-ups like the one
that we're looking at here with
front-end mentor so this has not been
coded yet but it's a
perfect visual representation of what we
do want to code you can do that with
those tools so coming back to the
original question what's the difference
between mobile first and desktop first
design you see with all these mock-ups
we have a version of the desktop and
mobile on both so does it really matter
which one you create first well the
answer to that is you're asking the
wrong question now this took me a long
time to realize but mobile first and
desktop first has nothing to do with the
actual design phase it has everything to
do with when you start writing that css
and when you put together your break
points
so in order to understand these better
we have to dive into something called a
media query with css and along with that
concept comes
the concept of breakpoints to better
understand what i mean when i say
breakpoint let's look at a code pen that
i put together to explain it
now if i said i want a breakpoint at 600
pixels
what i mean by that is as the screen
gets smaller or bigger than a width of
600 pixels i want to have different css
rules for both of those
so in other words if i'm on a mobile
device or a desktop device i want
different css let's do a quick review so
let me come to a page that i'm i'm not
really using here so let me close out a
few of these
this is just the web docs for css we're
going to right click and inspect and
then go to the console and if we were to
type window.enter with
it's going to give us a number and that
number 714
is the visible width of the screen so as
we resize this so we're kind of pulling
it to the left and right and resizing it
we can run this again and you're going
to see we get a different number so now
it's only 356 pixels wide so that's what
we talk about when we say the the
viewport width
so what i've done is i've written
a little bit of javascript here to make
this slightly bigger for us to see
and what i've done here in the bottom is
basically said when it resizes the
screen i want to change the content
of this up here so i've got a span an
html span that has a number in it and
that's going to be populated by the
window.enter with property every time
the screen resizes so in effect you're
going to see as i drag this this number
is going to
update live and also what i've done and
we're going to learn more about what
this is is i've written a break point at
a minimum width of 600 pixels and i've
included some different styles within
that break point so one of those is
going to be the h1 tag is going to have
a color of red
on screens that are bigger than 600
pixels or equal to
and then when it is not so a mobile
device we're going to have a color of
green so you'll see as i resize this we
get closer to 600 so we're about to hit
it and when i hit 600 it turns green so
we'll go back up turns red
back down it turns green so that is the
basics of a css breakpoint now of course
changing the color of some text based on
the screen is not really that useful and
you probably won't see it all that often
but what you will see is css that
affects the layout of your html changing
on different screen sizes
let me go ahead and uncomment um some of
the code here
that i've created
and what i've put in here is a couple of
pictures these are just placeholder
pictures
from the placeholder dot com
and
then we come down into
the css and you can see that when
we have a screen size that's a mobile
screen size so when we say mobile first
it's all these rules at the top
we have a width of 75 percent and as we
come down into this break point of 600
pixels you're going to see that the
image width is going to be auto which
basically means it's going to fill its
container so in effect our break point
at 600 pixels is going to say okay if
it's 600 or greater i want to have
these image images sitting next to each
other otherwise i want to put them a
hundred percent width of its container
and they'll stack on top of each other
so as we resize this we get closer and
closer to 600
it's going to change so watch what
happens when we get below 600
right there you'll see that the images
went to 100 percent width or not 100
percent width 75 percent width and
they're going to stack on top of each
other because they no longer fit next to
each other on the screen
so that's a good example of a basic css
breakpoint and how we can use it to
rearrange the layout of our page
so you have a basic idea of what a
breakpoint is in css
but the question becomes
what break points do i actually use and
there's not really a simple answer to
that let's take a look at this web page
right here this is screen sizes
dot es there that's pretty clever you're
going to see that there are a lot of
different devices that we could possibly
build our web page for
and there's no way that we can go
through all of these there's hundreds
and hundreds of different devices
there's no way that we can optimize for
all of them so we have to do our best at
guessing you know which screens do we
want to set our breakpoints on and
design them a little bit differently in
general mobile devices are going to be
somewhere in the range of 320
to call it 480 pixels wide you'll have
tablets between 600 and 800 pixels you
have you know regular sized laptops
around the you know 1024 to 1440 pixel
range and then bigger desktop devices
are going to have a width of call it
2500 pixels
so those are just generalizations but as
you can see on the screen there's all
sorts of different numbers
and i don't want to get into the
discussion of
things like pixel density and what is
the difference between the actual width
of a device and the adapted pixel
interpretation for us as web developers
it's a pretty complicated topic if you
can just remember those guidelines that
i just mentioned you should be good so
as you're deciding what breakpoints you
need to use for your
web page or your web app you have to ask
three questions in my opinion so the
first one is going to be
will the web page even be used on a
mobile device and is that your intention
there are plenty of apps that are not
meant to be used on a mobile device so
think about budgeting apps or
you know big spreadsheets things that
just don't look very good on a mobile
device
you probably don't want to waste your
time energy and maybe even money to
create a pleasing mobile experience
you're just going to say to your users
hey this is not meant for a mobile
device you should be using our
application on a desktop another
consideration would be are you offering
a mobile application if you are you know
a good example might be something like
youtube so
the youtube application on a mobile
device is really nice to scroll through
and use but their
web version so if you were to open up
the browser and then type in youtube.com
rather than opening up the mobile app
it'll still be a semi nice experience
but it definitely won't be as great of
an experience as opening the mobile app
so if you're creating something and you
plan on making a mobile application you
may not have to put quite as much time
and thought into how it looks on
different screens
the second question you might ask is is
it actually important to have a
different design for each screen
if you've just got a basic website that
just has text on it and you don't have a
lot of images or anything like that
then it may not be that important to
have a bunch of break points you may be
able to get away with one design for all
devices and it'll work just fine and the
final question you have to ask is are
there standards for this you know why
can't i just use the industry standard
for what everyone is using for break
points
and unfortunately given the fact there
are so many different screen sizes and
screen sizes are constantly changing as
new physical devices are released to the
world there's not really an industry
standard that we can go off of well
there are no industry standards per se
there are these things called css
frameworks and as i talked about in the
prior videos we're not going to be
covering
in depth any one css framework given the
fact that i don't want to lock you into
any one thing i want to teach you the
fundamentals of css rather than trying
to teach you a framework but
having a framework
to piggyback off of when it comes to
break points is a very smart decision at
least in my opinion
these guys that create the frameworks
are thinking about you know break points
all the time they have to incorporate
those break points into their own
frameworks and therefore if it's good
enough for them then it's good enough
for me and hopefully everyone watching
this given the fact that break points
are not an exact science and these guys
think about it a lot more than you know
someone like myself would one of the
most popular frameworks or at least
long-standing css frameworks is
bootstrap
now bootstrap you'll find it in several
tutorials you can kind of read up on it
it's basically you know a css framework
is all about making your job writing css
easier so a lot of times these css
frameworks are going to create grid
systems
in layout systems so that you can just
have predefined classes that you can
pass in
to make your sites mobile responsive and
stuff like that
so with that they have their standard
set of break points and if you scroll
down to
um
on bootstrap's documentation it has a
list of these break points and you can
see
that there are about
five of them so
by default bootstrap is what we call
mobile first and you're going to start
to catch on to what this means
and when i say mobile first it means
that we are first designing our css for
a mobile device
and then what we're saying is anything
greater than
576 pixels
will have these styles and then anything
greater than 768 will have these
different styles so basically you're
starting with the mobile device you're
writing your css and then you're writing
little blocks of code with these break
points to define oh what happens when we
have a bigger device so that's kind of
what we mean when we say mobile first
so here are the break points got 576 768
992 1200 and 1400 for small medium large
extra large and xxl
so those are the standards for bootstrap
and they're going to be our standards
but the question is do we have to use
all of them and the answer to that is no
we don't need to use every single
breakpoint here we just need to use
enough breakpoints to make our designs
look suitable on all devices and based
on what you're creating that may be one
or two break points or it may be all of
these break points that you have right
here if we're looking at an example like
this pricing card that we created i'm
not sure really what happened here
but anyways we have this pricing card
and for this we really only need one
break point now if you're incorporating
this into a application you might have a
couple more but really we just have two
states that we have to create we've got
this full on state which can be on
basically tablets and above and then we
have this mobile state where
everything's stacked on top of each
other so in this case we only had to
come down here and write
one single break point so we have the
min width being 576
which i got from right here so anything
greater than a small device or a mobile
device is going to have
x styles all right so we've been in
theory land here this whole video and
we've been talking about the the design
aspects and break points and how do we
choose them but we haven't actually
written any code yet and i want to do
that now i want to show you exactly how
to write a css breakpoint
and how that relates to this thing
called media queries
so i'm going to come to my code pen and
make a new one so that we can just have
a playground to work in
and then
down here in the css this is where we're
going to write our breakpoints but we
first need to have some html so
we'll say responsive web design
example
and from here let's just put in an h1
welcome to the tutorial
all right so we have some html to work
with and now down in the css section we
can write a breakpoint and the basic
syntax of the css breakpoint is this
so what i copied in here is a what we
actually call a media query
and the breakpoint is the number that we
pass in as a minimum width to that media
query
now we have a little bit more to learn
about the syntax because we have to ask
ourselves what does this at media
actually mean
and if we go over to the mdn
documentation
let me close out of here
this is what we've been using so far in
this series and you can come down to
technology css
and then if you come to the css
reference so in the css reference the
first paragraph has all sorts of links
that we can go to
and it says use this reference to browse
alphabetical index of all the properties
pseudo classes pseudo elements data
types
functional notations and at rules
and this last one the at rules is what
we want to click on
so what these are they're css statements
that instruct css how to behave
so that would be fitting into our
categorization of media queries
perfectly so if we scroll down
you'll see down here
in the index these are all the different
at rules or whatever tells the css how
to behave and if we click on media
that's going to take us to the media
query page
so this is an at rule that can be used
to apply part of a style sheet based on
the result of one or more media queries
all right so then we come down to the
syntax and you're going to see some
pretty complicated stuff being written
but this is the basics of a media query
and if we come back to our
example here you'll see the basic syntax
just has at media and then in
parentheses we write whatever rule we
have and then down here this is where
the css is going to go so if we wanted
to specify some css for
our h1 we're going to put it there so
any time the screen is greater than 756
pixels
the text will be red so if we shrink
this it goes back to black
and then we go to red so that's the very
basic syntax but in this rule we're
actually selecting every type of media
device
so if we go back to the documentation
and let me drag this over so we're not
getting so confused with our tabs
but if we come to the media rule
and scroll down to the description
you'll see that there's this concept of
media types
so we have all print screen and speech
and you can actually define within your
media query
which device types you're actually
trying to target
now in our case when we wrote this one
we're just saying we want all devices
now you can also specify in that rule
that you only want to target
certain devices now we're going to be
working with screens
mostly that's like a mobile
like an iphone or android a tablet or a
desktop screen so that's kind of our
forte as web developers but you also
have print and speech which are some
more
specific use cases that you can target
so let's see how we could change our
rule to target those devices
so if we said media all
and
this is going to say that we want to
target all
media types so this is the equivalent
of this those are the same thing but if
we come in here and we say media print
and this is only going to apply to
print as basically like a print preview
view on a screen so as you can see
our rule down here of the color red no
longer applies to this text because
we're only targeting print media devices
likewise we could put in
speech
and that's also not going to work
because this is not a speech media type
but if we put in the word screen it's
going to now apply because this is a
screen
and this rule should apply to it now
with these media rules we can add some
logic in here i'm not going to get too
deep into this but i want to at least
show you what it is
so let's say that we wanted to target
only screens
at a width between 400 and 600 pixels
now we could do that in one media rule
and the way that we would do that is by
writing some logical operators within
css so if you remember with javascript
we came down here into the javascript
section and we just typed in some basic
code
we can use conditionals so we can say we
can create an if statement that says if
my var
is greater than 10
and
my var is less than 100 then we'll do
something
within this code so you can see that
this little and symbol is the logical
operator that we're using now css
actually has logical operators just like
this so we don't need this javascript
code
anymore but we can rearrange this rule
to have those logical operators and
target multiple conditions so let's go
ahead and do that let me get rid of this
comment
the first thing that we're going to do
when we're having these logical
operators we have to put this operator
called only so
only when it's a screen
is when we're going to use this rule and
then we can drop down onto some new
lines just to separate these things out
we'll put our brackets down here
and now we can add another one here so
we can say and
max width
is
something like 800 pixels so let's just
change this we'll go what did i say we
wanted we wanted something between 400
pixels
and 600 pixels
and now what we're saying with this rule
is
so at media so we want an at rule for
css
we only want to target screen media
types which is what we're looking at
here
and we want to target something with a
minimum width of 400 pixels
and we want to target one some something
with a max width of 600 pixels so
basically what we're saying here is only
screens between 400 and 600 pixels
should this h1 css rule apply
so if we make the screen really big
that's not within those bounds but as we
go down and you can down here right at
the bottom you'll see a little pixel
indicator as i scroll but as we get
between 400 and 600 we should see it
turn red and then we go back to black as
it gets smaller than 400
so you can see how we can use css
logical operators with our media queries
to target
different types of conditions now you
can also bring in other css at rules so
if we go back to our
documentation
we'll click back
this is our our at rules page
and you can see we have media queries
but we also have things like import and
supports so if we click on supports this
basically is an app rule that lets you
check to see if a specific css property
is supported in the browser that the
user is using so a good example of this
is flexbox and css grid which we'll
learn about in the next few videos
those are not yet
supported by all browsers now most of
them do but things like internet
explorer i don't think do and maybe a
couple others with css grid
so you can see in this example we can
use this to basically check whether
the display supports display grid
property and then if so we will use that
property within our css so as you can
see media queries and css at rules can
give us a whole lot of power when
designing our pages for different
devices
media types and different browsers so
we're not going to get too far into it
because that's not the point of this
video but i did want to show you the
basics of it just so that you were aware
now at this point i want to take you
through we'll call it the 80 20 guide of
media queries and css breakpoints i'm
going to show you how to take these
standard breakpoints that we have
from the bootstrap framework and
incorporate it into an actual css
document to do that let me put some
images on our page
so we'll say welcome to the tutorial and
then we'll have a bunch of just
placeholder images with on the screen
so what we want to do with these images
is make them responsive based on the
screen size so something that i can
think of is maybe on mobile devices we
want it to be you know 100 percent with
just like we're seeing here where
they're vertically stacked then maybe on
tablet devices we can have two images
per row and then on a desktop device
that is much larger we could have
uh we'll call it four images
in one row across the page as i just
described we want to have three
different states of our web page we want
a mobile display
a tablet display so two images and a
desktop display four images so we have
three states and that requires two css
break points to achieve
now you'll remember bootstrap has you
know five of them
we only need two of these because we're
not making a super complex design and
that is a good demonstration of how you
have to look at you know what your
purpose is and then decide how many
break points you don't want to just
throw in a bunch of break points just to
have them there the first thing we need
to do is put in a basic css reset now we
talked about this in prior videos of
this series so be sure to watch those if
you haven't
but it's just changing the box sizing so
that we can
fit these images reliably
next to each other without any unwanted
behavior
the next thing we'll do is we'll add in
our break point templates
if we go to bootstrap and look at what
we need here i think what we're going to
do is grab this one right here so
i just want to mention here this top one
this is not actually a break point that
we need this is kind of just the default
so as we talked about this is a mobile
first
approach where we want to design the
regular css or the default css to apply
to a mobile screen and then we will
conditionally style any screens that are
larger than a mobile device with these
breakpoints
so we're going to grab the greater than
or equal to 576 so that's basically
saying what happens on anything greater
than a mobile device
and then we also will probably grab the
992 which is basically saying everything
greater than say a tablet so mobile
tablet and desktop is all we need to
cover so we'll say 576 and 992.
let me just jot this down here so 576
and 992 so i don't forget
and now we can write our media queries
so like i said you can just use this
basic syntax you don't have to put any
of those logical operators in there and
we're going to say min width is 5
76 pixels and then put some brackets to
break it down
we will copy this
put it right below and change this
number to 992.
we can get rid of the comments here
and we should be set up to have our css
breakpoints now now right now the
pictures on the screen no matter what
size screen we have
are not going to be responsive now
you'll see that they come next to each
other on this larger screen and that is
just because naturally
an image is i believe an inline block
element which means it doesn't have to
have its own line
and these are i believe 500
pixel uh images
yeah we put in 500 pixels for these
images using the placehold placeholder
service and therefore if the screen is
bigger than say a thousand pixels so 500
plus 500 those inline blocks are going
to wrap up onto the line so this is
nothing of css that we've written it's
just the natural flow of html so in our
mobile first approach let's go down to a
mobile device which is going to be
right here
and what we want to do within
this css we'll go right after the css
reset
and what we will do is we'll target all
images on the page
and we'll give them a width of 100
and what that's going to do is it's
going to resize all of the images to be
100 of the viewport and you'll notice
there's a little bit of padding that's
just natural
a default padding and margin of this
browser in the codepen environment but
we have these as a hundred percent width
now as we resize this you're going to
see that it maintains that 100 width all
the way up to these larger screens and
of course this is a way too large of an
image to have on the screen so we want
to wrap these on you know next to each
other on the lines so what we'll first
do is we'll come into this media query
which is basically going to say anything
greater than a mobile device is what we
want here
so we'll target images and what this is
going to say is if the screen is greater
than 576 pixels we want to override the
original image style
and put it to something else so in this
case we'll give it a width of
we wanted 2
per screen so we'll say 50 percent
and now we should see these wrapping
um
no they're not wrapping let's change it
to 49 percent okay there we go now the
reason we have to do 49 this is not
going to be a problem once we learn
flexbox and css grid but it's just
uh white space and a couple other things
that are causing this so
um don't mind the fact that it's 49 it
should technically be 50. so as as you
see here on a mobile device we have 100
width and they stack on top
then as we
resize to be greater than 576
they will break onto two or two per row
and then now we want to make it four per
once we get above
992 pixels so right now it's going to
stay as 2 per row no matter how big we
get
but if we come down here and add an
image style and give it a width of
24 percent
you'll see that as we get larger it's
going to put 4 per row so now we see we
have one per row here
two per on a tablet and four per row on
a desktop device so we've successfully
written a mobile first approach to css
and we've designed for three different
screen sizes now i want to walk through
how the css interpreter is actually
working here because
sure we can write these break points but
we really have to understand what's
going on otherwise we're going to make
a silly mistake that i'm about to show
you
so looking at the css we have to ask
ourselves how do we actually read this
or how would the the browser be
interpreting this
so by default we've got all these images
here and when css is red we'll we'll
first read the css reset we'll make the
border box um different and then as we
come down we'll say okay i have an image
css selector giving it a width of 100
so the css interpreter is going to say
okay great the width of all images is
now 100
now as we come
um further down
you'll see the media queries and it'll
the browser will basically say
so is my total width of the viewport
greater than 576 pixels
let's go ahead and make that true so
now we're at the biggest size and so as
the browser's reading this it says okay
yeah it is bigger than 576. so let's go
ahead and apply this rule so it says all
right now images are not 100 we're going
to replace that with 49
and then it reads even further down and
it sees this next media query and it
asked it it basically asks itself okay
is it greater than 992 pixels the
viewport width of the browser the answer
to that in this case is yes so it's
going to say okay now my images need to
be 24 width and we're going to replace
these previous two rules up here so what
we're doing is we're walking through
that cascading concept of css where it's
read from top to bottom
and the last rule so long as that last
rule has the same specificity
as rules above it is going to be the one
that applies
so where this is important is the order
of the breakpoints that you're adding or
the media queries so if i were to take
this last media query
and place it above
this one things are going to change for
us and that is because of how the css is
read from top to bottom
so in this case what you'll notice is on
a mobile device we look good it's
working fine
but as we go up we're only going to get
two images per row no matter how far or
how wide the screen gets and you might
look at your css and say well why is
that we've defined that anything greater
than 992 should get a width of 24
percent but the way that css is read is
top to bottom and what it's doing here
is it's saying okay first we have this
rule here that sets it to 100
then we're going to ask ourselves is the
screen bigger than 992
the answer is yes so now we're going to
set it to 24
then it reads down once again and it
says is it greater than 576 and the
answer is still yes because this is
inclusive of all screen sizes
so now it's going to replace that image
width with 49
and override the 24 right here so the
lesson here is that your media queries
the order of them is very important and
you're going to need to do two things
so first you need to add your media
queries at the bottom of your css style
sheet and the reason is you've got all
these rules for the default style which
would be the mobile screens and you need
these at the end so that they can
override those styles
and then second if you're going with the
mobile first approach which is basically
using min widths rather than max width
then you need the greatest width to be
at the bottom so you need to go from you
know smallest to greatest otherwise what
we just saw is going to happen and
nothing's going to behave as you'd
expect so at this point i want to
revisit this topic of mobile first and
desktop first design
i've alluded to it over the last couple
of minutes what this actually is but i
think we're ready to fully understand
the difference between the two like i
said earlier it has nothing to do with
the design phase of your project when
you're just getting the graphic design
laid out in your wireframes or your
mock-ups doesn't really matter because
you're going to design multiple screen
size designs no matter what but when we
come to write the css
the difference is going to be whether
we're using media queries with a min
width or we're putting in media queries
with a max width because that's going to
change how we think about our css
entirely in this case we used min with
which is basically the equivalent to
mobile first design because all of the
default styles up here are going to
automatically apply to
screens and since we're using min widths
that's going to apply to mobile devices
now as we go up in size that's when
we're going to start replacing css
properties
according to those bigger screen sizes
so what you see here is mobile first and
now i'm going to reverse it and we're
going to actually do a desktop first
approach which is not what i recommend
but i want to show you the compare and
contrast
so if we wanted to go desktop first
then we would just have to change these
two
to max width all right so let's change
both min widths to max width and you'll
see that everything is working a little
bit differently it's basically the exact
opposite so as we get bigger we go to
that 100 width and as we go smaller we
go into the grid which is obviously not
what we want and the reason is because
we thought of it from a mobile first
perspective when we built it
so basically when you're doing desktop
first all of these default rules are
going to apply to your desktop devices
so anything that is greater than this
the greatest break point that you've
assigned is going to get all of these
default styles
so we're basically starting from the
widest and then as we go down we're
replacing rules so if we wanted to work
this the same as we had before we're
just going to have to change the widths
so all of these rules are for you know
desktop devices so we want to replace
this hundred percent with 24
that should get us back to the point
where we have the four
four pictures per row
now as we come down we're going to
change
the max width of 576 so this is
basically referring to
all mobile devices we want to make this
100 so that on a mobile device we see
them stacked on top of each other and
it's not working
let me go ahead and refresh the page
to make sure we got this
oh actually this is a good lesson so
when we go from desk or from mobile
first to desktop first the order of the
media queries is going to change so when
we had min widths we said we want the
smallest to largest going from top to
bottom but in this case it's going down
this style sheet and it's saying okay
is the screen less than 576 so let's
make it a mobile
it's saying is it less than 576 the
answer is yes so let's apply an image
width of 100 percent
then it goes down and it reads is the
max width or is it less than 992 in this
case that is also true so it's replacing
the width to 24
so that's why we're still seeing the
grid there so if we wanted to make that
work we need to put for a desktop first
approach we need the largest media
queries first going to the smallest and
now we have our intended behavior of 100
with
on mobile and then we should get
let's go ahead and replace
this last one here
to be 49
and now we should have a correct design
so 100 on mobile
we'll have two images on a tablet
and then we'll have four images on the
desktop
so as you can see
mobile first versus desktop first is all
about how we're writing our media
queries and whether we're using mid
widths or max widths in general you're
going to find that the consensus among
the development community is to use a
mobile first approach and the reason
behind it is as you're getting into more
complex designs
it is just easier to use the natural
flow of html on a mobile device
so no media queries required and then
tweak it as you get larger because in
many cases a desktop first design is
probably not going to look very good on
a mobile device but the
inverse of that so a mobile first design
it will probably look okay on a desktop
device without any modifications so in
summary you're basically going to have
to write less code
in most cases all right so we've covered
the basics now the next question is what
do i actually put within these media
queries
and the answer to that is i can't
possibly teach it within one lesson
you're going to learn you know how to
resize things based on different devices
through experience and time i'm about to
show you a basic example of just that
but first i want to leave you with a
responsive design checklist so let's
jump over here
and go to the checklist so you can just
you know take a screenshot of this write
it down
whatever you want to do but this is what
i go through when i'm looking at my
design and my web page and testing it on
different devices i want to make sure
that i check all of these boxes and if
you can check all these boxes you've
covered 95 percent of what you need to
and the rest is going to be you know
just subtle little changes and highly
dependent on how
many requirements you have for your
project first up we want fluid layouts
this is basically saying you know what
we just looked at where we have you know
single images on a mobile device we have
a row of two images on a tablet in a row
of four images on a desktop so that's
what we mean when we say fluid layouts
we want to make the content you know
just look good in general
now images we want to make sure that we
have the right aspect ratios and we're
not stretching images to be you know too
wide too tall too big on certain devices
we also want to do the same thing with
text we don't want to have huge text on
a mobile device where you only have you
know four or five words per line that's
a really poor user experience
the next thing up is overflow so that's
basically you don't want to have any
text or images or whatever cut off
on the side of the screen so you've
probably seen a mobile design before
where you know half the image is off the
screen you want to avoid that
and then
similar to that we want full width
mobile content so in general this
doesn't apply to everything but in
general everything that you look at is
going to be stacked on top of each other
rather than having columns you never
really want columns on a mobile device
and then finally just general usability
so this is not too hard just get a
friend
someone who will give you honest
feedback have them play around with your
web page on multiple devices
and anyone is going to be able to tell
okay this doesn't feel right this one's
kind of clunky it's hard to use this on
a mobile device you know i'm squinting
on the desktop to see this you should
get pretty good feedback and just using
a common sense approach is usually
pretty good for this all right at this
point we're going to apply these skills
we just learned
and we're going to take this pricing
card challenge where you can see that
everything's getting cut off and it's
not responsive and we're gonna make it
responsive so
the answer to this is actually
relatively simple and we can do it in
one of two approaches so the first way
we could do it is a desktop first
approach which like i said i don't
recommend that as your default way of
approaching css but in this case we did
design this with a desktop first
mindset we didn't really think about
mobile design when we were doing this
and therefore in the css and html that
has been reflected so in this case you
can see that the width of this
card that we've created
we
decided that
as we were creating the card and you can
see it right here so we've assigned a
width of 600 pixels to this
and for that reason i think we can
assign a media query or a break point
around that 600 pixel mark now if we did
it exactly at 600 pixels
then you're going to see a design where
you know we're at 635 pixels here and
looks like about 600
right here and obviously there's
something cut off so you want to put a
little bit of a little bit of wiggle
room there so we might want to write our
media query to be somewhere around 650
pixels
so what we'll do is we'll come down to
the very bottom of the css
as we're supposed to with media queries
we'll write at media
and then we'll say max with because
we're solving this in the desktop first
approach
because this will be the simplest
solution and we'll say 650 pixels
so dropping down into this css rule all
we really have to do is make these
bottom the bottom left and the bottom
right
containers that we created we want to
make them 100 width so that they
naturally stack on top of each other
so i believe all we have to do if i'm
thinking about this correctly
is target those two and give them a 100
width when the screen is less than 650
pixels
so the ids for this would be bottom left
section so let's grab that
throw it in our media query
and paste that in and then we want to
put a comma because we want to also
do the same thing for the bottom right
section
so let's grab that
and put a hashtag to target it
and then we'll make a css rule so right
now in this media query we're saying
anything any screen that's less than 650
pixels i want to target the bottom left
section in the bottom right section by
their ids
and then i want to give them a width of
a hundred percent all right so at this
point our screen is greater than 650 but
as we resize
you'll see that it's done something for
us but now we have to figure out what's
going on here because we've completely
lost the bottom right section it's
pretty much disappeared and the reason
that that is happening is because we've
set explicit heights on this card if you
scroll up to the the top of the css
you'll see that we gave the card a width
of 600 pixels and a height of 400 pixels
and then we also set the overflow to be
hidden
which was what allowed us to make those
rounded corners at the bottom
so what's happening here when i resize
this
and we're basically losing
this right side entirely is because
now when we stack them on top of each
other it's greater than that height of
400 pixels
and we're hiding that overflow content
so it's not being shown here
so if we were to come down to our media
query
and set the height
to be auto
it's going to change something for us i
believe
no that's not going to change because we
don't want to assign that to the the
sections we want that to be to the main
card
so we need to target
the
card itself
so down in our media query we're going
to target the card
and now we're going to set the height to
be
auto which is going to
take away that explicit height and give
it
its automatic height and you can see
that now we are
resizing correctly but the last problem
is you're going to see it's still cut
off because for this card component we
still do not have an automatic
width so we've only assigned a 100
percent width to the bottom left and
bottom right section
so if we were to assign the width here
to auto or even a hundred percent we
should see that it resizes now
appropriately so i think what we can do
is we can actually take
since we've duplicated this with we can
take this height auto and we can put
this up into this rule and then we can
just include
the the main card within that
and delete these and i think it should
work just fine
so let's resize it
and you can see that it works just fine
and you can see that all we had to do
was add this little block of code to
make it mobily responsive but i don't
want to leave you hanging on this one
i said throughout the whole video we
want to go mobile first mobile first so
i want to stay true to that and show you
how to make this mobile responsive from
a mobile first
perspective or strategy this desktop
first approach worked pretty well
because we originally created this from
that approach but ideally we would have
created the original card from a mobile
first perspective so i'm going to show
you how to convert that
so let's delete our media query that we
just created you'll see that it goes
back to being cut off and not being
mobily responsive
and now what i want to do is create that
mobile first design so instead of a max
width we're going to write a media query
where we have a mid width
which is going to be 576 pixels we'll
just go with that so anything greater
than a mobile device is going to have
um whatever styles we put in here
now the cool thing about you know media
queries and break points is that you
don't have to duplicate all of your css
a lot of styles are going to be applied
similarly across devices so for example
the color of this button in this text in
these backgrounds that's not going to
change based on whether we're on a
mobile or desktop device so we don't
need to rewrite those
likewise our text is going to stay the
same we're going to have the same font
style no matter what so really the only
things that you have to alter
between
break points is going to be layout
related properties so what i want to
start with is the overall card so if you
remember
in the top part of the css we have a
rule for card
and right now we're giving it an
explicit width and an explicit height
now if you remember from a mobile first
perspective
everything that's not within the media
query itself is going to apply to a
mobile device
so naturally when we're on a mobile
device we do not want these explicit
widths and heights so let me go ahead
and comment those out for a second
and what you're going to see is that
we've already done a lot better so the
the overall card
is the right width and height now but
we've got some problems going on within
the bottom left and bottom right
sections now we don't want to get rid of
these widths and heights altogether so
let's go ahead and
take those out of the the main card and
then scroll down to our media query
and we'll target
the card element and paste in those
rules again
so now we want to give it a width of 600
and a height of 400 on any device
greater than a mobile device or 576
pixels
so let's go ahead and resize this
and it should break
somewhere around here so right there you
saw it so that was where our break point
was and you'll see that based on the
explicit width and height we've given it
it's not really fitting correctly so we
can actually change this it should work
just fine so maybe we'll say something
like i don't know 550 pixels
so that gets it fitting on the screen
and then the height can go ahead and
stay at 400 pixels
so now as we have our mobile device it's
somewhat responsive and then as we go to
anything greater than a mobile device
it stays as this card the next thing
that we want to look at is the bottom
left in the bottom right sections
so here are the styles that we have for
those
and you'll see that we've given them
widths of 50
each
so
in this case when we're on a mobile
device we do not want these widths to be
50 we want them to be 100 percent
so let's go ahead and comment this out
and when we do that it's going to have
the default width of auto which is going
to be 100
so by default it's going to be 100
and if we comment out both of these
i think we should start to see something
that makes a little bit more sense so
you'll see that we have
some auto actually no i said that wrong
we cannot just use it as auto we need
the the text to span 100 width of its
container
so in these styles we need to
i guess
go ahead and set a width of a hundred
percent
so that fixes this section
and then we'll come down here and set a
width of 100 and that should pull this
one to the right
all right so we're looking good there
and i think for the most part we have
our mobile design complete so i think
this is exactly what we want so our
mobile design is complete we just need
to make this desktop design
look a little bit better because as of
right now it obviously is missing an
entire section so really we can just
let's go ahead and delete the width of
50 percent even the commented out
section here
and then we'll go down to our query at
the bottom that says anything greater
than
a mobile device
and we're going to target the bottom
left section
and the bottom right section
and here we're going to give it a width
of 50 percent just like we had before
and now you'll see that it fits just
perfectly and as we resize it it goes
it resizes perfectly on a mobile device
so that is the difference it's very
subtle especially because our project is
very simple there's not you know
hundreds of styles
but the difference between a mobile
first and a desktop first design
is really important and you really have
to internalize that as a full stack web
developer
in this video i'm going to teach you how
flexbox works we'll start off by going
through what's available to you what it
can actually do and then we'll spend the
rest of the video which will be the the
majority of it diving really deep into
how flexbox works how do we calculate
different things and use all of the
properties my goal for this video is to
be the most in-depth flexbox tutorial on
youtube and the reason i'm making it so
in-depth is because it's important i
think that not only knowing flexbox
allows you to
eliminate a lot of the frustration when
it comes to layouts in css but it'll
also set us up for our next lesson which
is going to be on css grid so let's get
started this is a flexbox crash course
and the prerequisites for it is going to
be a basic understanding of html and css
i've covered all of this in prior
lessons of this series so go check those
out if you're unfamiliar here's what
we're going to be covering in this video
we're going to learn what flexbox is how
can help you out and make your life
easier we're going to go through all the
basic properties of flexbox and we're
going to get pretty detailed in those so
that you really understand what's going
on there and then finally we're going to
look at a front-end mentor project this
testimonial uh grid over here which
we're going to be creating with flexbox
in the next video a few of the things
that we're not going to be covering
shorthand flexbox properties so there's
a couple properties within this css i
guess module or framework or whatever
you want to call it that allow you to
write less css to achieve the same thing
and that's not our goal here we're
trying to learn flexbox you can apply
those much later down the road when
you're more comfortable with flexbox and
we're also not going to be getting very
advanced with this i have written
advanced flexbox properties but we're
pretty much covering all the properties
i guess probably the better way to say
that is we're not going to be going into
advanced flexbox methods and you know
different layouts and all that kind of
stuff my main goal is to get you
understanding how the system works
and get you very comfortable with using
it the obvious starting question is what
is flexbox well if you have been
following along you might have realized
that as we're writing our css there's
really two main components you have
layout related properties and then you
have style related properties so a style
property would be like a color or a font
or something like that it doesn't really
affect how things are laid out on the
page but layout properties do that's how
you create you know grids and you know
nav bars and footers and sidebars all of
that kind of stuff so far we have not
been using flexbox and our job has been
a little bit difficult because we've had
to use
uh you know hacky ways of getting
layouts to work flexbox is going to come
in and really help you out with that
layout side of things
and per the mdn web docs flexbox
is called the css flexible box layout
module and it's a model for displaying
items in a single dimension so either a
row or a column in future videos we're
going to get into css grid which is a
two-dimensional layout module within css
and some you know might say that css
grid is better than flexbox or vice
versa but they really work together and
we're going to cover how those work
together within our css whatever the
case flexbox and then subsequently css
grid which again is a future video these
are kind of the future of css layouts so
in the past like i talked about you had
to use like floats and clear fixes and
inline blocks and specific widths and if
you watched one of the previous videos
we had to almost
you know hack our way to getting items
to fit within a container by removing
white space from our html these are not
good solutions they're not sustainable
and so flexbox along with css grid come
in to provide a better model for doing
layouts but enough talk let me show you
exactly
what we're dealing with here
so what i've got here is some basic html
and i really want you to start
understanding this container child
relationship within html so if we look
at this we can see that we have a div
element with a class of container and
then we have three div elements all
having the same class of item this
relationship is very important the
container is the parent to all three of
these you know children
elements to show you how this
relationship is important
let's put some width and height
dimensions we'll go with 100 pixels for
the width and height of the items within
this container
and we'll give them a background color
of say orange
and then maybe we'll give some margin of
5 pixels so they're kind of separate a
little bit
so here you can see the three div
elements these are the children elements
to that container
and the reason this parent-child
relationship is so important is because
the second you enable flexbox on a
container all of the child elements
become what we call flex items
so this is really important and first
off let me show you what happens when we
have the normal display property so
right now by default each item here and
the container are all going to be a
display type of block so they're block
elements
and you'll see as i type these in it's
not going to do anything because we're
basically just
explicitly writing in what was already
the default now with block elements as
we talked about in prior css videos of
the series these are going to have
certain characteristics and flex items
and flex containers are also going to
have certain
display characteristics so if we remove
this display block which again these are
just defaults for
div elements
and we come up to the container and we
type display flex you're going to notice
that these items change and the reason
they change is because by adding the
single property on the
container element or the parent
we are basically making a flex container
which holds a bunch of flex items the
container and the items have specific um
characteristics that you know normal
block or inline elements do not have in
just a minute i'm going to explain
exactly why these flex items are going
in a horizontal direction rather than
vertical but for now i really want to
drill home this point about flex
containers and flex items now you might
ask well if i set display flex on this
container and all of these are going to
be flex items
then can i also you know make the flex
item a flex container and the answer is
yes you can actually have an element
be both a flex item and a flex container
at the same time and that's why it's
important to always keep these
relationships clear in your head let me
show you what i mean so if we come down
to the final
div element which currently is just a
flex item and then we put in a few more
divs so let's put in a class of sub item
and then we're going to copy this down
three times and right now this doesn't
have any dimensions but if we copy this
css selector of item down and then we
put in sub item and give it some
different dimensions so we'll give it
something very small like maybe 15
pixels
wide and tall
and then we'll make the background color
blue
and a margin of 1 pixel something like
that and what you'll see is that these
line up within that third container
because they're children of this third
flex item but at the moment these are
not flex items themselves they are block
elements by default this brings up a
very important point so if you look at
our css we have put the display flex
property on this main container
and when we do that it only turns that
container into a flex item and then the
direct children not all descendants but
only the direct children will become the
flex items so in this case all of these
divs are going to be flex items but the
sub items are not going to be flex items
these will be the default block elements
now what i can do is i can come in and
turn this final div into a flex
container which will then subsequently
turn these sub items into flex items as
well just so that i have a unique
selector on here let me turn this into
item three
we'll put another class on there and
then all we have to do is come down here
on item three
and write display flex and what you'll
see is these three blue boxes right here
are going to go in a row just like the
orange boxes are as we go throughout
this tutorial i want you to keep this
clear in your head this exact model that
we just laid out here so let me just
walk you through it one more time at the
top level we have a div called with a
class of container this is a flex
container and the reason it's a flex
container is because we put the display
flex property on it
now all of the items these three items
right here these are flex items and the
reason they're flex items is because
their direct parent is a flex container
now these sub items right here these are
also flex items but it's not because we
have display flex on the main container
it's because we've put display flex
on this third item right here i know
this is confusing right now it's going
to get a lot more clear as we go through
the tutorial but what's happening here
is this third div within the container
is both a flex container
and it's a flex item so it can actually
serve as both types at the same time in
relation to the main container it is a
flex item in relation to these sub items
it is a flex container with that level
of understanding between the container
and flex item and how we can combine
those here are the flex container and
flex item properties that you can use
we're going to go through each of these
but you have to keep them very clear in
your head when you're going through
because you have to first identify am i
dealing with a container or an item and
as you saw in some cases you can be
dealing with both so you can actually
put
a combination of these properties on a
single html element sometimes this gets
a little bit confusing and something
that i had done when i was first
learning flexbox
is i had this cheat sheet that i found
here
it's a really great resource i'll be
sure to link to it in the description
but i just keep this open
whenever i'm working with flexbox
because it's very interactive you can
you know click on different things and
and see how different flex properties
work
and it covers pretty much everything now
as i just mentioned some properties
apply to the container and some to the
items
this resource does not really separate
that out on the left
side right here but for each property
you'll come down and you can see what it
applies to so this one applies to flex
containers
so i'd use this resource keep it open
as you're learning flexbox it's a really
good you know little cheat sheet to have
in addition
as we've been going through in this
course you can always look it up on mdn
web docs so as you can see we're on
flexbox and here's the property
reference for all of the valid
properties that we can use
and you can click on each of them and
kind of get an overview of what
what's available and what i'll point out
is this formal definition down here for
each property is going to tell you what
the initial value is and sometimes
that's important to understand what the
default values you're dealing with are
the reason understanding these default
values is so important is because when
we have
um you know flex items and flex
containers like this
putting this single rule on a container
is going to set a bunch of properties
by default that you're not seeing you
know in front of you in reality when we
put display flex on this container
it's setting all of the properties that
i just pasted in here so it's setting a
flex direction justify content align
content items in flex wrap
and these are all of the default values
so you can see that nothing changed over
here on the left because they were
already applied
by default likewise flex items have
default properties so i can come down to
the item
itself which is going to be a flex item
and paste in all of these properties
right here and the reason nothing
changed on the left again is because
these are the defaults that we you know
that flexbox comes packed with what
we're going to do in this tutorial is
learn how we can modify the default
values on all of these
uh properties right here to get the
intended result that we want the last
thing i want to point out before we jump
into our first property
is just a quick note on shorthand flex
properties
so if we came down to the flex item so
this is targeting one of our flex items
here
and we put in something called flex
and we gave it a value of uh let's see 0
1 and auto
this right here is what we call a
shorthand flex property
and it is the exact equivalent of
writing flex grow zero
flex
shrink
one
and flex basis of auto so these three
properties written out longhand is the
same thing as this single property
written out shorthand
and for this tutorial like i said we're
not going to be looking at these
shorthand properties because
we have enough to deal with with the
longhand properties just understanding
how they work so just wanted to clarify
that because you might see that in the
flex cheat sheet so if you came down
here
flex flow is a shorthand property i'm
sure flex is somewhere on here
but whatever the case just know that
those exist but we're not going to be
covering them i think at this point i've
covered all of these you know
prerequisite pieces of knowledge to
really jump into flexbox let's go ahead
and get started we're not going to use
this because it's pretty ugly
and i actually put together a little
demo here
so you can check out the javascript for
this it's basically just toggling some
of the values here
and what this demo is meant to
explain explain
is the main tenet of flexbox and that is
the fact that we have one dimensional
one-dimensional model where we can align
items on either the horizontal or
vertical axis as you'll see in the html
we've got some some html up here none of
this is really important what we're
really focused on here is going to be
this piece right here so we've got our
main container which is going to be our
flex container and then each of these
divs are going to be the actual flex
items and i've actually styled these a
little bit just for you know visual
purposes but it's not important to this
tutorial so if we're looking at this
html the way that we create a flex
container
of this div is by selecting it with css
and writing display flex on it so by
default that's going to create a flex
container and then all of the direct
children are going to be
the flex items so all three of these
divs right here
now the next property that we have to
understand and this is a really
important part of flexbox is the flex
direction property and this is by
default going to be set to row what this
property is defining is what we're going
to be using as the main axis and what
we're going to be using as the cross
axis i've written this out
with html and css so you can see that
this is the main axis horizontally and
this is the cross axis vertically but
what happens is if you change this flex
direction property you're going to
change the flow of the items within the
flex container and when you do that
that's also going to change the main and
the cross axis so by default this is set
to row which means everything is going
to go horizontal and the main axis is
going to be horizontal but if we were to
toggle this flex direction which is
going to via javascript change the flex
direction to column
then what's happening is the main axis
is going to be vertical and the cross
axis is going to be horizontal now so
now we're looking vertically well
previously when it was set to row we're
looking horizontally so as we learn new
properties keep two things in mind first
off as we talked about you got to know
which
html element is the flex container and
which are the flex items number two you
have to know which
direction the flex items are going to
flow in so if you've got this property
flex flex direction set to row they're
going to go horizontal and the main axis
is going to be horizontal and if you set
it to column it's going to flow um
vertically and the main axis is going to
be
vertical as you can see in this example
our flex container is
has a certain height and width and the
reason is because we set it down here so
if we find the container that we set it
on we set the width and height to 300
and 200 pixels
now if we comment these out we get rid
of the dimensions on the container
it's going to act similar to a block
element where it kind of spans the width
of its parent container and then the
height is going to be based on the
content of the items within it to keep
things simple we're going to keep this
width and height set on our container
just so that we can have a nice visual
to look at as we explore some of the
different flex properties for the
remainder of the tutorial we're going to
be working here in this workspace
and i want to just kind of derive how i
got here just so you're not confused
with pre-existing styles that i put on
here
so what i have is basically four div
elements
within a main container and as of right
now what i'm showing you there's no flex
box enabled here
except on these items right here but
that's not what we're trying to cover
so these are basic divs and as of right
now they're displaying as block elements
and there's no you know dimensions on
the container so let me kind of derive
how we get to our workspace
first off i'm going to set a width and a
height on our main flex container
and i'm going to put a border on it so
just uncommented those properties out
and what you'll see here is a black
border that is 4 pixels in dimension and
then the width itself is going to be 408
pixels on the whole container the reason
that it's 408 is because if you add the
left border of 4 pixels in the right
border of four pixels
that gets you eight pixels and therefore
what i wanted to do
was basically make the total area within
the container uh 400 pixels exactly so
that we have a better time doing you
know basic calculations so that's why i
made it 408 pixels
now we have to uncomment the display
flex to make these flex items
so now you're seeing that they're
sitting you know on the horizontal axis
and that's actually because of the flex
direction row
default
setting here
and this is how we get to our basic
workspace and then finally i will
uncomment these two lines of html which
are going to be styled somewhere down
here so that we can see the cross in the
main axis
at all times and as we go through the
rest of the tutorial we're always going
to be working with a flex direction of
row so therefore the main axis is always
going to be horizontal and the cross
axis is always going to be vertical
if you want you can switch this and call
it flex direction
column and you can see how all of these
rules that we're about to go through
work out from a vertical axis
perspective the next few properties
we're talking about are alignment
properties which
allow you to align
and space out these flex items within
the container the first one is going to
be justify content so if we come to mdn
here's the formal definition
and we'll come down to the
formal definition here and see that the
initial value is normal if we read about
what normal is
it says the items are packed in their
default position as if no justified
content value was set
so that's kind of what you're seeing
here it's all just kind of by default at
the start of that axis now similarly if
we
set the justify
content property to start
this is going to achieve the same thing
so we're just putting it at the start so
for all intents and purposes you can
think of the default property for
justify content to be start if we wanted
all of the flex items to go to the end
of the main axis rather than the start
we can just type that into this property
so if we replace this with end you'll
see that all of these jump to the right
side
and you'll see that as we're looking on
the main axis that's how we're deciding
where these items are going to go we're
flowing horizontally so the start is the
left side and the end is the right side
we can also change this to
center which is going to put them right
in the middle and then we have some
additional property values that will
actually space the items out a little
bit the first one is going to be
space between so if we type space
between
these are going to be spaced out with
equal amount of white space between them
within the container
we also have a property called space
around
so if we change this to that
you'll see that there is now some space
surrounding each of these items on the
main axis
now what i'll have you notice here is
that the
amount of space between the items so
this little area here and here those are
all going to be equal in dimension
but the edges so to the right of this
fourth element into the left of the
first
that's a little bit smaller than the
space between the elements so that's
kind of the
how we distinguish the space around
property
value with the space evenly property
value
so when i type space evenly you'll see
that these change just a little bit and
now what's happening
is every piece of white space between
the elements are going to be exactly
equal so the justify content property
tells us how the items are spaced out
and aligned on the main axis
let's go ahead and set this back to
start because i want to have the default
values
so that now we can talk about the next
property which is the align items
property let's go ahead and look this up
in mdn
we'll type in align items
and you'll see that this is the property
that we use when we want to align flex
items on the cross axis so remember we
set
this example to a flex direction of row
by default and that means that the main
axis is horizontal and cross is vertical
so the align items always applies to the
cross axis
and is going to decide how these items
are aligned vertically looking at the
mdn docs you'll see that the initial
value is again normal and if we go to
normal wherever that is
i guess it's at the top here
it says the effect of this keyword is
dependent on the layout mode we are in
as you can see in the third bullet point
it says for flex items the keyword
behaves as stretch and if we come down
to
stretch it says the flex items are
stretched such that the cross size of
the item's margin box the same as the
line while respecting width and height
constraints
that's an overly confusing way to say
that by default
the align items
if we set it to normal is going to
stretch the height of these items to the
total height of the flex container
unless you have a specific height set on
those items already so this brings us to
a brief discussion on the width and
height properties of flex items
right now we don't have any width or
height set on either or any of these
flex items right here so they're getting
i guess what you call the defaults and
with flexbox
a flex item is by default going to get
the width
of
its inner content and the height is
going to stretch to be equal to the
total height of the flex container
as you can see the inner content is
going to be the numbers that we've put
in here and i know there's a little
space there but it's still considered
just the inner content and then the
height is of course the height of the
full flex container
now if we come down to flex item number
one
and we give it a width of say 100 pixels
it's no longer going to
have that default width of the content
it's going to respect that width that
we've set on it likewise if we give it a
height of say
50 pixels
it's going to respect that height as
well
so if you put explicit width and height
properties on your flex items by default
they're going to
get those so long as there's not you
know overflow within the flex container
or you've set different properties that
we're going to talk about in just a bit
just as a quick review
the
items here the flex items do not have
explicit width or height properties and
therefore
the default height that a flex item is
going to get is going to be the total
size of the cross axis so in this case
the main axis is row cross is column so
total height of that column is going to
be the natural height this is no longer
the case when we start putting in
different values for the align items
so once we put in something like flex
start
you're going to see that all of these
items
pull up to the top of the cross axis and
they no longer have that total height of
the cross axis
and what's happening here is they just
have the width and height of the inner
content so if we change that inner
content then it's going to adjust the
size so one way we could do that let's
say that we have this first
flex item we'll come all the way to the
bottom
and i'm going to uncomment this
little rule that i wrote that made the
font size for this first item much
larger and you can see that as we make
the content bigger or smaller the flex
item itself gets bigger or smaller
because we don't have those explicit
width or height properties
now i'm going to leave that there
because it's going to bring up a very
good point
here in a second
so right now we have flex start we can
also
bring these down on the cross axis to
flex end so these are at the end now
and then we can center them with center
and this is actually something that's
really hard to do without flexbox so
really cool uh part of this flexbox
model what you'll see with the center is
that there's like an imaginary
horizontal line going through the middle
of the content in these
flex items
but we also have this property value
called
baseline
and what's going to happen here is we
actually draw that horizontal line
kind of at the at the bottom of each
piece of content within the flex item so
because this first one has much bigger
inner content
our flex
baseline is going to be in a different
spot so they're not going to be
perfectly aligned flush with the top of
that cross axis so far we've learned a
couple of properties
justify content and align items so we
can play around with these let's just do
a few examples so that we can kind of
review and recap so let's go ahead and
say
justify content will be center
and align items will also be center
this is how
you can take content flex items and put
them in the middle of a container and
this was very difficult to do before
flexbox so this is a really cool
advantage of having flexbox
and then we can of course change all of
these so we can put the justify content
to end
and put that there we can also
put align items to
flex end i don't know why you'd want to
do this but you can put in the bottom
right corner of the container
so
very flexible no pun intended of what we
can do here with these alignment
properties let me reset everything
let's just put these back to the
defaults so all you have to do is delete
them and they're back to their defaults
and then we will come down here and
comment out this
last rule that changes the font size of
that first item
so now everything is equal and what i
want to do is actually
make
each of these items a specific width and
height we'll go with 50 pixels by 50
pixels
one way that we can do that since we
have two classes set here and each flex
item has this fi class
we can just target that one class give
it a width of 50 pixels and a height of
50 pixels
and now we have these perfect little
squares
sitting as our flex items by default if
you don't change any properties flexbox
will respect the flex item width and
height properties so we set those to 50
pixels by 50 pixels and that's what
we're getting right here
and if we came down to the flex
container again and we set that align
items property to say stretch
or something like that you'll see that
they're not actually going to stretch
down to the total height because we have
those explicit properties set already
but the next thing i want to explore is
what happens if you have too many or too
little
flex items within your flex container
in this example if you remember from a
few minutes ago when we talked about the
actually it's at the top here
we set the width of the flex container
to 408 and the height to 200 pixels
because the main axis is horizontal as a
result of the flex direction equal to
row property
the width is really all that we care
about right here because everything is
going in the width kind of direction
so we set this to 408 exactly for the
example i'm about to show you if you've
got a container 408 pixels wide in that
container has a four pixel border on the
left and the right
then the total white space that is
available for these flex items is
exactly 400 pixels
if each of our boxes are 50 pixels in
width
that means that we can fit a total of
eight flex items perfectly within this
container let's go ahead and do that
just to see what i'm talking about so
all we have to do is copy this down four
more times and you should see a bunch of
items pop up here let me just go ahead
and
change the labels so that we can see all
our flex items a little bit better and
now you can see that we have eight items
perfectly fitting within our flex
container but what happens if we take
all of these flex items and we double it
so let's say instead of 8 flex items of
50 pixels each we have 16 so we double
it what happens then well let me go
ahead and do that real quick
i'll just copy all of these items and
paste them below
and what you're going to see as we
extend this is that these items are
overflowing outside of the flex
container there's a couple weird things
going on as well
if you'll notice it doesn't look like
these items are 50 pixels wide anymore
now of course if you were wondering how
wide these elements are you don't have
to guess you can right click
inspect element and you're dropped into
the firefox dev tools and the reason i'm
in firefox i know i've been switching
back and forth between
chrome and firefox throughout this
series but i'm in firefox because the
devtools have an awesome flexbox
little module here that you can inspect
elements with and really see what's
going on so all we have to do is come up
to this
inspector here we click that so that we
can select items on the page
and let's first start with our overall
flex container
when we click that flex container the
layout tab is going to drop us down into
this section called flex container
if you
collapse that you'll see that there's
also grid in the box model so these are
different you know models that we can
look at but if we look at flex container
and then we toggle this little button
you can see all of the different flex
items outlined for you as well as some
overflow space and other elements of the
flexbox
we'll turn this off for now but we can
also go down to the flex items and you
can see they're being highlighted here
on the left
as i hover over them so you can click
them with this little inspector here so
maybe we click on number eight
and we can look here within the
inspector of everything that's going on
with this individual flex item we're
going to talk more about all of this
stuff
in just a bit we're not quite ready yet
the thing that i want to draw your
attention to is the fact that if we go
down to the box model which we learned
about in previous lessons we know all
about how this works
and you look at the total size of a
single element so we'll click on number
four you'll see that the dimensions are
33 and a half by 50
which is not what we set them to we set
them to 50 pixels wide and 50 pixels
tall
so the question is why is it shrinking
the width like we didn't tell it to do
that why is that happening furthermore
if these are overflowing outside the
container what do we do about that we
obviously don't want to show this to our
users we don't want our flex items just
going indefinitely off the page and
especially if you're making say a grid
of images where there's hundreds of
images and you're using flexbox to
display them you don't want them going
on a single axis you know indefinitely
to the right or indefinitely down in
this situation you have two options the
first option is kind of the
standard
default way of handling overflow in css
and this does not this is not specific
to flexbox itself you can use this with
any type of css display type
so if i came to the flex container
and i set the overflow property
i can set this to a couple of values but
usually you might want to set it to auto
and if you set it to auto what's going
to happen is these elements are no
longer going to break outside of that
container they're just going to scroll
so you see the scroll bar at the bottom
of our flex container now and we can see
all of our items
they're still shrunk a little bit but we
can see them all without you know
breaking out of the container but like i
said with that grid of images example if
we could imagine that these are images
we don't want our users to have to
scroll
left and right to see all the images we
want them to just wrap down to the next
line and just have like a nice little
grid of images so the second option that
you have here instead of setting the
overflow property which is just a
generic solution
we can set this flex wrap property and
if we set it to wrap you'll see what
happens is these elements go back to
their you know original size of 50 by 50
as we intended and they're going to
perfectly wrap
onto the next line now you see some
white space in here here in the middle
and you might say okay i don't really
want that i want those to be flush to
each other
so naturally what you're going to do is
come down to the flex container you're
going to type in a line items like we
had said earlier and you'll type in flex
start something like that and you won't
see anything happen and the reason is
because
the
rules of the game just changed when we
put in this flex wrap property
i know you're probably getting tired of
hearing me say that but as we go through
css certain properties set to certain
values changed the whole game just like
when we set flexbox to the container you
know it changes the behavior of all the
children elements within it
this flex wrap property changes how we
align items on the cross axis
so instead of align items we now have to
use this property called align content
so if flex wrap is set to anything other
than the default which is going to be no
wrap
you'll see it overflows again if it's
set to anything except for this no wrap
then we're going to use instead of align
items we're going to use align content
which is going to have the same
possible values for the most part as
align items but it's going to tell
flexbox how to arrange this new like
group of wrapped items within the flex
container so now we can set flex start
or we could wrap them at flex end
or even put them right in the center of
everything
so that's how we wrap items to the next
line if they're overflowing at this
point we've actually covered all of the
flex container
properties that we can use just to do a
very quick review i'll get rid of all
this extra stuff here so get rid of
these last eight
flex items and then i'll get rid of
these last two properties here so just
to review we have of course the display
flex which is going to activate flexbox
we have the flex direction which we can
set to either row or column so if we set
it to column it's going to go vertical
if we set it to row it's going to go
horizontal
we have justify content which aligns
flex items on the main axis in this case
the horizontal axis
we can set that to center
which is not going to change anything
because they're
it's as wide as the container itself but
if we just commented out
this last flex item
you'll see how this works it kind of
centers all of the content in the middle
and then we have align
items we can also put center on that to
put those in the middle next up we're
going to talk about how do we
influence the size and alignment of
individual flex items
so if you take a look at what i'm about
to do
i can say something like a line self
and i can say flex
start and you're going to see this first
item
drops out of the flow of the rest of the
flex items and we can do this with each
individual flex item for a lot of
different combinations here speaking of
this alignment let's go ahead and start
with that because i think it's the
easier
part of this discussion
so i will
let me just go ahead and comment out
the last four items here in our
container just so that we have four
and then within our rules here i'm going
to remove these justify content align
items so that everything is
top left default
settings
now if we came down to individual items
which i have css selectors here for on
the right
what we can use is this align self
property which is essentially the same
exact thing as a line items
except it only applies to a single flex
item
so
in this case we've set this to flex
start which is the default so it all
looks normal but if i take this first
flex item so the first box here
and i set this to flex end you'll see
that this drops to the bottom while the
rest stay at the top
and i can do this to flex item number
four so align self flex end and you'll
see this one dropped to the bottom and
then maybe i wanted number three in the
middle so align self
center so this one goes in the middle
you can see how we can individually pick
and choose where our flex items are
going to go and of course our container
level properties still apply so if i
came back up to the container and set
justify
content to center this whole group will
go to the middle
so these work together it's not one or
the other you use them in tandem like i
said the align self property is pretty
straightforward once you know
align items on the main container now
the last part we're going to talk about
is the sizing of flex items and this is
probably the hardest part of flexbox in
my opinion
to understand how all of these work and
what we're dealing with here is the flex
grow
flex shrink and flex basis properties
we're going to start with flex grow and
this is going to apply to
flex items when they don't naturally
fill
the entire main axis
so
in this case the main axis is horizontal
because of the flex direction row
property
and in this case we have 50 pixel wide
flex items and we have four of them so
this should only fill about half of the
total width of the container earlier we
talked about how the total white space
the total width for these flex items in
this container is exactly 400 pixels if
each item is 50 pixels wide
then 50 plus 50 plus 50 plus 50 is going
to be 200 pixels and therefore the
occupied space is going to be 200 pixels
and the unoccupied space is going to be
200 pixels when there is unoccupied
space or empty space along the main axis
of a flex container
the flex grow property is going to come
into play by default this property on
each and every single item is going to
be set to zero
and what that means is that each item by
default is going to take up
zero percent of the empty space within
the container that is why what we're
looking at here is not stretching out to
fill the container right now is because
all of these items by default are
set to not take up that extra space but
if i come down to the first flex item
and i change that default property to a
one
you're going to see that the first item
fills up all of that remaining space
so it's going to take up the original
width it had of 50 pixels
and then we also know we had an empty
space of 200 pixels
so the total width of this first
item or first flex item now is going to
be 50 plus 200 or 250 pixels now of
course with my tutorials i don't want
you to just take my word for it so let's
go ahead and verify what i just said 50
pixels plus 200 is 250.
so if we click the selector up here
select that element and go down to the
box model
you'll see it's 250 and a half pixels
and the reason it's a half of a pixel
more than what we calculated
i'm not sure that i can fully explain it
with
the utmost confidence but i will attempt
to
so if we set this back to flex grow of 0
and refresh the page because it's being
stubborn
and then if we inspect the element we'll
go to this first element
and what you'll see in the box model is
that the inner content of
this so the number itself
is 28 and a half pixels
so if we hover over this you'll see that
the box gets drawn around that
number
now if we pulled in the same exact html
in css but in google chrome so i'm going
to pull in google chrome right here
and we're going to select this first box
and scroll down to the box model you'll
see that the inner content is 28 not 28
and a half
so
browser differences are of course a big
part of web development but i wouldn't
worry about that extra half that we saw
when we're trying to make the
calculations just make sure that you
have the understanding of how these are
calculated in programming being off by
one is sometimes a catastrophic error
but when we're dealing with uh css
it's not quite as big of a deal so we
will we will stick with this and as we
go throughout you're probably going to
notice that my calculations are going to
be off by just a couple decimals but
just bear with me so let's set this back
to a flex grow of 1. so we have 200
pixels of empty space now we don't
because 200 pixels got allocated
to flex item number one
now if we came down to flex item number
two which by default has a flex
flex
grow value
of zero
and if we set that to one here's what's
going to happen if we came down here to
flex item number two
uh the default value for flex grow is
going to be zero no changes as you see
but if we were to set this to one
you'll see that number 2 element gets
part of that empty space as well so now
1 and 2 are going to be completely equal
now how do we get to this you know what
kind of calculation is happening here
i'm going to try to draw it out for you
so if we come to right over flex item
number one just make a comment
what we're going to do is take all of
the flex items within the container and
we're going to add up their flex grow
values so by default remember they are
are all set to zero
so
flex item number one has a value of one
as we set it right here let me close
this comment so we can see it correctly
so we have a value of one on flex item
one
a value of one on flex item two and then
by default the last two are set to zero
and zero
so the total of all that is going to
equal two
and what you can think of this as is two
units of empty space
so we'll say two units and you might ask
okay what is what unit are we measuring
this against well if you remember there
is
200 pixels of empty space
and if we divide that by two allocated
units we get 100 pixels per unit
so each unit that we allocate is going
to be 100 pixels
but if we were to come down to flex item
number three and set a flex grow value
of 1
that changes it because now our total
sum we're going to add a 1 in there
and now we have a total of three units
we still have 200 pixels of empty space
but now we have to divide that by three
units and that should get us to
i'm not sure if i can do that math i
think that's a decimal actually so
200 divided by 3 is going to be
66.666
pixels
but if we come down to flex item number
3 we set a flex grow factor of one
and then flex item number four and set a
flex grow factor of one now everything
changes so we have to update these
values in our sum so now it's one plus
one plus one plus one
so we have four units
and we still have 200 pixels of empty
space to allocate because
if you have four
items each 50 pixels wide that's 200
pixels empty space is 200 pixels in a
400 pixel container so still have 200
pixels of empty space to allocate over
four total units
so we'll define divide that by four and
that's going to get us to
50 pixels each per unit so what's
happening here is for each item in this
container we have an original size of 50
pixels
and then we allocate 50 pixels to that
of empty space so they're each going to
be 100 pixels
equal across the board and you can see
that if you click on here it's
100.133 pixels
forget about the decimals here but
they're all equal so that's how that
works now it doesn't have to be a flex
grow value of one you can also give it
two or three or four it's all just
dependent on how many units you want to
allocate to each
flex item let's say that we gave flex
item number two a value of
we'll say four
or maybe maybe not four let's go with
three so that we have an even number
so now our calculation is one plus three
plus one plus one
is going to be 6 units
200 pixels of empty space divided by 6
units i'm going to need a calculator for
that one so 200
divided by 6 is 33
pixels per unit so if we are giving
the second flex item three units of
empty space
in each unit of empty space is 33.33
that means that we're giving it an extra
you know
99.9999 or 100 pixels so we take the
original width of 50 we add about a
hundred so we get 150 pixels wide for
the second item
let's check that see if we're in the
ballpark and you see that it's
150.25 so that calculation worked
perfectly hopefully that explanation
made a little bit of sense just have to
think about it in allocated space
empty space and you can calculate the
two pieces by getting the total width of
your flex container
and then the total width of the items
within the flex container and then
breaking it out into units based on the
amount of empty space that we need to
allocate back out to the items now the
opposite applies when we have too many
items in our flex container
let me get rid of all these flex grow
values
so that we can get it back to normal
and then let me also uncomment
these
divs right here so that we have eight
total items
we know that that fits perfectly but
what if we put in nine so instead of
eight we have nine which means we've
added an extra one in there which means
that we have 50 pixels of overflow so
remember each one's 50 pixels wide 50
pixels times 8 is going to be 400 pixels
which is equal to the total
available space within our flex
container
so by adding a ninth we are making the
total amount of flex items
450 pixels wide
versus the 400
available space so we have 50 extra
pixels of overflow similar to how we
allocate
out empty space to flex items we can
also reduce the size of flex items by
the amount of overflow that we have so
if you look at this container you're
going to see that by default they all
fit within the container when we add
that ninth item and the reason is
because all of them actually
shrunk a little bit when we put put that
ninth item in there
the reason that they shrunk is because
by default every flex item is going to
have a flex shrink value of one
so if i put that in for flex item number
one you will not see any change because
that's already the default it's already
shrinking by
one unit
so we know how to calculate those units
you basically take the overflow just
like we took the empty space with the
flex grow
so if we have 50 pixels of overflow
let's let's change this right here to 50
pixels of overflow and then we have to
ask ourselves how many units we're
allocating that across
by default each flex item is going to
have a flex shrink value of one so that
means that each flex item should be
allocated equal overflow
in other words we have to do one plus
one plus one all the way to nine
so we have
nine total units
i'm just going to get rid of this
because you get the point here so we
have nine total units with 50 pixels of
overflow so we divide 50 pixels by nine
and that's going to give us i believe
5.33 pixels
per unit let me check that real quick
so 50 divided by 9
equals no it's not 5.33 it's 5.55 pixels
per unit in other words we're going to
take the original width of these items
which was 50 pixels and we're going to
subtract off 5.55 pixels from that 50.
so in theory each item should be 44.45
pixels
wide so let's inspect the element we'll
go to any of these here and you're going
to see 44.5 pixels wide
pretty much exactly what we just
calculated
now this is where the the firefox
devtools comes in handy so if you click
on one of these items it's going to pop
up in the layout section
exactly how this shrink operation worked
so
you can see the flexibility has a flex
shrink of one
and that's going to say minus five and a
half pixels which is what we just
calculated so it's going to take the
28.5 pixels which is the inner content
width
uh subtract off five and a half pixels
to get down to 23 pixels
and then you add back in the natural
padding and border that um is set on
these items to get your total width of
what we calculated as 44 and a half
pixels now this brings up a good point
because if you look at this model right
here
you're going to see that each item has
a minimum content width
so if you try to shrink something too
much
then it's going to make it so that it
will kind of get capped out it won't
shrink past the minimum value of its
content i'll show you exactly how this
works all we have to do is add in a few
more
a few more flex items so let's add one
more for good measure
and what we see here is that they're
clearly breaking out of that container
now just like we saw earlier
when we looked at this and we tried to
wrap them onto the next line
now from the flex shrink perspective
these are breaking out of the container
because
while they have you know calculated the
total overflow space and then allocated
that out
to each of the flex items the total
amount of overflow is going to be
greater than the um
basically it's going to make them shrink
smaller than their minimum values which
is not possible let's see if we can
calculate this just for funds we have 1
through 9 10 11 12 so we have 13 total
flex items which are all supposedly 50
pixels wide
so if you do 13 times
let's see what that is so that's 650
pixels and if you subtract the 400
pixels that the container width is you
get 250 pixels so our overflow that
we're dealing with now is going to be
250 pixels
and we have 13 units to
allocate it over
so we need to divide that by 13 and what
that's going to give us is
let's see
19.23
pixels per unit
so we're going to have to subtract we're
going to have to basically say let me
break down onto the next line just so
we're clear we're going to take the
original width
minus
19.23 pixels
and what that's going to equal
is let me see
30.
pixels
so theoretically we would just take all
that overflow and subtract it from the
original sizes
to get us to a total width of 30.77
pixels but if we inspect element and we
click on any of these here
you're going to see that this little min
property popped up so it says the
minimum size of this element is going to
be 12 pixels so that the minimum inner
content is 12 pixels and when you add on
the padding and the border of each of
these elements that's going to break you
over
that value that we had calculated here
so it's basically going to be
uh
the the content itself is going to be
too big to shrink that much hopefully i
haven't lost you here um try to lay out
this in a logical manner um and i know
there's a lot of detail it's definitely
not totally necessary but i really think
knowing this kind of stuff and how this
is calculated is is that extra step that
you have to take as a developer to
really
um understand what you're doing and be
able to debug things and understand okay
why is this breaking out of the flex
container why won't this shrink enough
you know those kind of questions let's
do one more um
practice problem here i guess you could
call it so let's go back to nine
elements which are gonna naturally fit
within this
but at the moment they're each being
allocated what was it 5.55
pixels so 50 minus 5.55 to get it shrunk
down to fit
now if we wanted to allocate it only to
certain items we can change the defaults
so
let's go ahead and say that we want the
first three items of this flex container
to keep their 50 pixel width now the way
that we would do that is we'd go to item
1 and we'd set a flex
shrink value of 0 which is not the
default
and we'll copy that down to two and
three and now you'll see that each of
these get wider and if we inspect them
they're each going to be 50 pixels wide
while the remainder are going to absorb
that overflow space by shrinking so just
a quick review if the total width of the
items the flex items in the flex
container do not equal the total flex
container so if there's not enough items
flex grow is going to be what applies
and that empty space is going to be
allocated based on the flex grow values
if the overflow happens so if there's
more items that can fit in the flex
container then the flex shrink will
apply and based on the flex shrink
values of each item
determines how that overflow space is
going to be allocated out the last
property
with all this sizing that we have to
talk about is flex basis let me get our
container
back to
a spot where we only have four so let me
i'll just comment out those just in case
we need them later
so now we have four items which are
explicitly set to 50 pixels wide each
so we set each of them to 50 pixels wide
50 pixels tall
now if we wanted to change those
dimensions we can actually do that using
a flex item property let's go to the
first flex item and set the flex basis
to equal 40
what you'll see is that this first item
gets a lot wider and it's not because
it's trying to fill the empty space it's
because it's respecting this flex basis
property
over the width property that we set
earlier
so by default this flex basis is
actually set to auto
and when it's set to auto
what that is basically saying is set to
flexbox is go ahead and look for the
width and height properties
and if you find them
respect those properties as the width
and height of the flex items if you
don't find them go ahead and size the
flex items based on the inner content
and that's the default for flex basis
but you can also assign pixel units and
percentage units to the flex bases to
override the width and height of your
flex items this unlocks a lot of
possibilities and depending on how you
use them with flex grow and flex shrink
you can get a bunch of different
combinations so if i was looking at this
flex box right here i have the four
items each 50 pixels wide and let's say
that i wanted to make them even widths
and span them across the whole container
one way that i could do that is by
coming to each of the flex items and
setting the flex grow to be equal to one
and what that's going to do is equally
allocate the empty space as we just
talked about so that's one way to do it
now we could also backtrack a little bit
and instead of doing that we can set the
flex basis
to 25
on each of the items and that's going to
equally
give width to each of the items and give
you the same exact result now if we come
in and try to set the
you know flex grow property on one of
the items it's not going to change
because the flex basis is going to take
precedence over that but in some cases
maybe you don't set the flex basis
property on all of the items to equal
100 percent
so in this case we've given each of them
25 which adds up to 100 so it's going to
fill the whole container but let's say
that we for the first item we give it 10
percent so we're going to be missing 15
percent of the container and let me let
me delete that for a second so
now we just have flex basis properties
and they sum up to what 85
if i'm calculating that correctly so
there's some empty space here on the
right it doesn't fully fill the
container but now if i put on the
flex
grow property
and set it to 1 that first element is
going to take the remaining space and
we're back where we started so
essentially
setting uh flex bases of 25 on the last
three
and 10
plus a flex grow of one is the same as
just doing flex basis of 25 on all of
them
so many ways to get to the same answer
the last thing we'll talk about is the
order of the items along the main axis
in our flex container
so
if you wanted to change
uh swap these out so maybe you wanted to
put number two in number one's place
you could do that all you have to do is
come up to the html and put number two
before number one
and that should just flip them
but if in flexbox you don't even have to
do that you can actually flip those with
css so if i came down to
the css and i looked at flex item number
one and i gave it an order of two
and then i gave flex item two in order
of one
now you're going to see that
these are flipped and hold on i think
the reason that this is not working is
because you have to set them on all
so we'll set the order on three as three
in the order on four as four so the
three and four have their natural order
but then two and one are going to be
flipped
so if you set order on all of the flex
items you can determine
you know the order that they come in
now you might ask why is this useful
well in many cases it's really not
useful you might as well just change the
order of your html and be done with it
but if you are designing responsively
which we talked about in a prior video
i think was just the previous video
as you're resizing your browser you may
want different elements on the page to
go in different orders so say you have a
nav bar at the top you've got main
content a sidebar and a footer
maybe you want to order those
differently
whether you're on a desktop or a mobile
device
and this would be how you would do that
is you'd set a media query so you might
come down and say at media
and we'd say like min width of 600 px or
something like that
and then in here you could probably set
the flex
item number four
to have an order of one
and then we'll say
a flex item 1
will be
in order of
4 something like that so as we are
getting bigger than 600 px that's how
that's going to
show but as we shrink it you'll see that
those flip so we can resize and order
them differently based on different
screens at this point you've learned
pretty much all of the main properties
of flexbox now of course there's some
shorthand properties that can make your
life easier so instead of
you know setting the flex basis and the
grow and the shrink values
what you can do is
come in and just say flex and then the
first value is going to be the flex grow
so maybe you want to set that to
one and then the second one's flex
shrink you might set that to one and
then the third one is going to be flex
basis which is set to auto
so this is a shorthand way
of writing flex grow flex shrink and
flex basis all in one line
so that's just a shorthand property but
not necessary i wouldn't even recommend
using those until you're very
comfortable with flexbox
well this is actually a brand new day
same hat same hoodie whatever but
i forgot to add the last part to this
video which is actually taking this
previous challenge that we had solved
so
as you're following along with the full
stack roadmap we solved this pricing
card challenge as a part of
the original html and css tutorials and
then also made it responsive in the
prior video on responsive web design
what i want to do to wrap up this video
is take this design and make it with
flexbox instead of how we did it before
so if i'll remind you just for a moment
what we had to do
to get these bottom left and bottom
right sections
sitting next to each other with a 50
width with something a little bit hacky
um if we come up to the html
um you'll see right here
so this line doesn't look you know all
that spectacular but
what you'll see is we've got a closing
div right here that corresponds to the
bottom left section
div
and then the starting div for the bottom
right section is sitting right next to
it which when you're looking at html
that's generally not very good syntax
and that was kind of a hack that we used
to remove the white space
and allow for the fact that we had 50
widths on both of them so if i were to
enter this down
one line just for formatting sake
you'll see that the bottom right uh
piece of the card actually disappears
and that's because it's going underneath
that bottom left card and then we're
hiding the overflow
as you'll see in the css for the main
card so we've got overflow hidden so if
we take that off you'll see it pop up
below here so
that's what's going on and we can solve
this very easily using flexbox and get
rid of all of our hacky solutions that
we had before
now to make this a little bit simpler
for us to see exactly how this is
working
let's go back to our layout example this
is what we had used to originally build
the card so that we could see what we
were dealing with
and we didn't have to confuse ourselves
with all the different styling while
we're just trying to focus on layout
it isn't pretty but
it will work for our layout purposes at
least
and what you'll see is i've come down
and added a media query this is from the
prior video if you haven't watched that
we talk about responsive design and
media queries so basically what we're
saying is in this block we want to apply
certain styles to any
uh device that is greater than 500 or
greater than or equal to 576 pixels
as you'll see when we shrink this it
changes the layout and then when we go
above 576 then these two
style selectors will apply
and you'll see that the width and the
height of the card gets applied and then
the bottom left and bottom right section
are going to get a 50 width each
now with flexbox this is relatively
simple
all we have to do is if we're looking at
this entire card here
it's composed of a top section and a
bottom section with two left and right
sub bottom sections
and what we want to do is on the desktop
device so
this what we're looking at right here
we want to have
those bottom sections in one row and
then when we shrink it to mobile
we want it to come into a column so if
you remember from just a few minutes ago
we talked about the flex direction where
we can take the main axis and change it
based on that flex direction
so what i'm thinking is that for a
desktop device we want flex direction
equal to row so that these two go right
next to each other and then on a mobile
device we want it to be in a column
so the way that we do that since we're
designing mobile first here
is we come up to all the main styles
here and we go to the
bottom section because that's what we
want to turn into a flex container we
don't necessarily want to turn the whole
card into a flex container because the
top the top section is actually fine
and it would be overkill to put a
flexbox container on it but the bottom
section is not so let's go into the
bottom section and type display flex
and what you'll see is i believe nothing
will happen at the moment because we're
in the desktop view but let's go ahead
and go to the mobile view and now we've
got some things messed up because we're
designing mobile first so right now
we're working on the mobile device
so these are still sitting next to each
other and all we have to do to change
that is set the flex direction
to column
and you'll see that they jump right
above each other
that's pretty much it when it comes to
the mobile design of this
let's see if we can find anything that
we can remove now um
i believe we can remove this
vertical line okay we're going to get to
this we'll actually get to this let's
get the design right first and then we
will worry about that so at the moment
we set the flex direction to column and
because of that because we're designing
mobile first
that is also going to apply to the
desktop design unless we change it in
our media query
so let's do that we'll say bottom
section
and we'll give it a flex direction
of row again so the default so now as we
resize
we get a very similar result and we're
actually pretty much done
but we have some redundant styles that
we can actually remove now that we're
using flexbox and this is where
the nice
parts of flexbox come in you don't have
to write as much css so we can remove
the bottom left and bottom right section
widths
and i believe that may
screw us up a bit
after we change a few things hold on
i think we need to change uh let's
remove the display inline block on the
bottom left section
in the bottom right
uh we will remove the 100
width and we'll remove the vertical
align top
so we don't need those anymore but what
you'll notice is now we've got this
screwed up and that is by design that's
not
surprising let's make sure our mobile is
still working so we're good here
mobile's still working but desktop has a
little bit of work
and if you remember the bottom section
is our flex container
which means based on the html here if
we're looking at it the bottom section
has two direct children it has the
bottom left section and the bottom right
section and we can actually enter this
down on to its new line now that we're
using flexbox we don't have to have that
hack
but anyways the bottom left and right
section are the children
so therefore
these two style
selectors are going to be the flex items
in this desktop view
we have the flex direction set to row
which means that those that bottom
section has a main axis that is going
horizontal and if you remember from a
few minutes ago the way that we resize
the flex items along the main axis is
going to be
one of two ways we can use the flex grow
property
or we can use the flex basis
so let's come in here and just try both
of them just so i can show you we'll
start with the flex basis it may be a
little more straightforward
so if you put in 50
on the bottom left section
and then you say flex basis 50 on the
bottom right section
we have completed the card it looks
great and as we resize it it's still
going to work so that's one solution
another solution
is we could come in and we could say
flex grow set that equal to one
and
flex grow
equal to one on the bottom right section
and this should work just fine too
now going directly from flex basis to
flex grow will not really illustrate
that point let's get rid of the flex
grows for just a second so that we can
conceptualize
by default these two
sub containers down here
have a natural width because we haven't
given them we haven't given them an
explicit width so they're going to take
the content with
the content sitting within them as you
can see is
filling the entire width of their
container
now these do not fill up the entire
section we've got this empty space here
on the right
and the flex grow property is what
applies when we have that empty space
and so basically what we're going to do
when we enable the flex grow one
properties
like we talked about is we're going to
split up that space just give it one
unit to the bottom left section in one
unit to the bottom right and therefore
it's going to be
i believe perfectly equal or it actually
may not be perfectly equal it may just
be a coincidence that the content is a
similar width
let me make sure that that's correct
so let's just enable these and we can
check
in the dev tools
so let's inspect
and let's see what we're dealing with so
this one is 263
pixels
wide
this is 276 pixels wide so
glad we looked at this i actually was
not thinking about this correctly
the correct solution here is probably
going to be the flex basis of 50
it just looks like they're equal when we
use the flex grow because they're
similar widths by
default like naturally the content has a
similar width in both sections
but if i close out the dev tools
and let's say i came up here and just
added a bunch of content to one of the
list items in the bottom right
you'll see that now that flex grow is
not working quite as well because we're
not giving them equal widths we're
growing them based on their natural size
so
i stand corrected that is not the
correct way to do it
flex grow at least
i think flex basis is by far the most
reliable way to
split these into equal containers
so we'll go with that and call it a day
i think we have solved this
to my liking so this is the basic layout
and then as we shrink it goes down to
mobile
so as we come over to here
back to our card
and let me
let me bring this guy back up so that we
can see
everything
working okay
so there's our card now we got to turn
this into a flex box and
we'll do exactly what we just did in the
layout example
so if you remember we came down
we didn't need
any of that
we did need a bottom
section
we wanted the flex direction to be row
on a desktop device
and then in the bottom
section we need to display flex
set the flex direction to column
and let's see what we got here
looks good
now we just wanted to remove on the
bottom left and bottom right sections i
know there's a lot more styles here
we don't need this guy
we don't need the vertical lines
we don't need the width
all we have to do is add a flex basis of
50 percent on each of these
so we're looking good there and i
believe we have solved it
i don't think there's anything that we
did otherwise
now there's just one more thing that i
want to show you with this that we can
use flexbox for as you see this 29 per
month
these are sitting next to each other and
whenever you have horizontal content
it's usually a decent
use case for flexbox
let's look at the html that we
set this up with
so you'll see that we have a price
container
that would be
the overall parent and then that parent
has two children items so
if we turned price container into a flex
container
then the price and the price frequency
would therefore become the flex items
let's find that in our css so here's the
price container we've just set a margin
on it so that's probably going to stay
the same even with the flex container
but then we also have
price and price frequency which looks
like we have styled right above it
so let me let me just
change the order of this because it
makes a little more sense to have the
container on top
and what we're going to do is set
display flex
by default it's going to be
set to row
so
it will put them next to each other
let's get rid of all the styles that we
have within these i don't think that we
need
any of them except for
maybe the font size and the opacity
because those are not layout related
properties
so
here's our starting point and you can
see that by default even after we
removed all those styles
that display flex making that whole
container a flex container is going to
still put them next to each other
now let's just back up and remember
exactly what's going on here
we have
some html where we have a price
container and then we have two items
within it so we have a flex container
and two flex items
by default we've set this to display
flex which makes the main axis on the
horizontal so in a row
and therefore if we want to align
things along the main axis we use
justify content if we want to align them
on the cross axis we use align items
as you can see
the per month is a little bit misaligned
with that 29 dollars
an easy way to fix that is to come on to
the price container
set the align items and set those to
center
you'll see that that perfectly centers
those two right next to each other and
that's a much better solution than what
we did before where we set the position
to relative
and then we set it negative three pixels
to just pull it up a little bit the last
thing we have to do as you'll notice
there's no spacing between these
and there's no
real solution here with the flexbox i
mean we could come in here
and justify content
and say something like space between but
you'll see that that's going to space it
out way too much so that's not really
going to help us
so really the best way to do this is
just come on to the
[Music]
either the price frequency or the price
item and set a margin
so we don't even need this style anymore
since this is already written the price
frequency we can just use this
and all we have to say because this is
the um per month piece all we have to
say is margin left and give it something
like five pixels and that spaces it out
nicely very easy and straightforward so
there you have it that is how we solve
this with
a mobile first fully responsive solution
with flexbox and it shrinks and gets
bigger
and it looks great on all devices
in this video we're going to be building
a testimonials grid and we're going to
be doing it with a mobile first
responsive design
solution and we're also going to be
using flexbox my goal in this video is
to not only solve this
challenge on front-end mentor but also
to apply those skills that we've learned
in previous lessons so that you can
really start to use them in the real
world lastly i'm going to be adding in a
few extra pieces to the puzzle so
throughout this series we have been
using codepen which is just a nice
environment where we have html css and
javascript all in one place all hooked
up and ready to go since this challenge
is relatively straightforward and you'll
see as we walk through it
i want to also add in the concept of a
code editor so we're going to be
downloading and using visual studio code
and then we're also going to be doing a
little bit of version control and i'm
not going to get
super detailed into it uh quite yet but
i'm gonna show you the commands that you
have to run to get your
design pushed up to github and deployed
to the github pages so that you can you
know share a url with others of what you
built but don't worry the only
prerequisites that you really need are
going to be html css and make sure
you've watched my flexbox in responsive
design videos let's get started
if we come up to front end mentor this
is the challenge that we are going to be
creating
and i've already started it so i don't
need to click here so let me go to my
challenges
or i guess profile
my challenges
and then testimonials grid section
so from here you can download the
starter files
so we'll do that
it's going to pop up on another screen
for me so once you've downloaded your
files
make sure that you have visual studio
code downloaded it's just a code editor
and i actually made a whole video on
code editors you can check it out up
here
of which ones i recommend and why
so obviously visual studio code would be
one of those so go ahead and download
that
and once you've downloaded it open up a
brand new window from here you're going
to want to click file
um open a folder and then go find the
testimonial challenge starter pack that
you just downloaded so i've got it
selected
and this is going to open me up into
the workspace as we start looking at the
starter files if you open up index html
which is what we're going to
actually be working on
you can see that there's all sorts of
text already in here
and luckily we have a lot of the
testimonials that we will need
they're not really implemented in
html elements but it's good to just have
this text ready to go now just to relate
this back to what we've been using with
codepen
this index.html
is basically the same as this html box
here in codepen it's just
um on our local computer it's in our
local file system rather than up in the
cloud now your first question is
probably well how do we actually view
this html document in the browser now
remember html and css they are only
displayed in the browser therefore we
need a web browser to look at this
the way that we do that is
you actually have a couple options i'll
show you the most bare bones option
first and then we'll go into what we're
actually going to be using to solve this
challenge to view an html document in
the browser all you have to do is go to
your file explorer i'm on windows but
this works the same on mac or linux
and just go to the folder that you have
it saved in
and then find the
index.html file
you'll notice that it does not say index
dot html as you see over here
and that is because the file type over
here is chrome html document so it
doesn't display it here in the name
if you right click
and go down to open with
you can choose a browser to open it in
so i might just say google chrome
and when we click that it should have
opened it up if i go back to my browser
it should open it up in google chrome
and there's a lot of text here and
that's because we have to actually
implement this design but this is the
html document that we're looking at
and you can see
up in the um
url bar we're actually looking at our
local c drive um now on mac and linux
this is going to look a little bit
different
but it's the same concept it's just the
local path to that file displayed in the
browser now i'm going to point out a few
things here that might be interesting to
you
the first thing you see this little icon
up here in the top left
portion of the tab
this is a little front-end minor logo or
favicon
you might be wondering well how did that
get there
well the way that we put that there is
if we come back to our files
and we look at this link tag right here
this is actually
putting in that favicon up into the
title here's some metadata about it some
sizing but here's the really important
attribute which is the href and what
we've passed in is a relative path we'll
learn a lot more about
absolute and relative paths coming up
when we start working in the terminal a
little bit more
but all this is saying is i want to look
relative to the current directory into
the images folder over here
and then drop that down and grab me the
favicon
32x32 png
and we can open that up and see the
little icon that we have and that
matches
the icon that we see up in the tab
furthermore in the index.html we've got
the doctype that's important
for just html boilerplate and then i'm
actually going to indent this for us so
we can see it a little bit better we
have the head tag which is pretty
standard for an html document here are
some meta
tags that help with displaying the site
in the browser properly these are just
pretty standard defaults that you might
put in
and then of course the link we just
talked about now the title tag
this is where we actually
name the tab that it's going to open in
so we can change this and just say
instead of front-end mentor we can just
say
testimonial challenge
and when we click save
open the browser up and click refresh
you'll see that it changed to
testimonial challenge right here we have
some styles
we haven't really been looking at this
but
if you come back to our browser and go
to codepen
the css right here there's a couple ways
that you can link that up
you can actually use a
link tag
to link up styles or you can just put
them all in a style html tag right here
now we're not going to do that because
that's not very good practice for a good
amount of css you want to break it out
into a separate file which is what we're
going to do
so we'll delete all of that we don't
need it and then finally we have all of
this text which is basically if we look
at the challenge itself
i wish there's a better way to see this
oh yeah we actually have the design here
so if we go to the desktop design
you'll see that we have all of the text
and all this text is
right here i'm going to cut this out
and then i just want to make a new file
so i just right clicked over here in the
file pane click new file
and we'll just say
placeholder
text
dot txt so we give it the dot txt file
extension it's just a plain text
document
we can paste that in and save it just
that we have it but it doesn't clutter
up our html this last part the
attribution this is just as we look at
it in the browser it's just this little
piece down here
so
you can if you want to you can go ahead
and fill this out and link to whatever
you want to your you know twitter
account your linkedin account your
github account whatever you want to do
i'm going to delete it here i don't
really
want to clutter up anything i want to
just focus on the challenge itself so at
this point we have a basic html boiler
plate and i'll actually show you a
shortcut to get to pretty much exactly
this
with just a few keystrokes let's save
i'll right click create a new file and
we're going to call this test.html
because we're just going to be testing a
few things
within this document i'm going to show
you how to use emmett and what emmett is
if we open it up this is built into
visual studio code and what you
basically can do with it is
type shorthand
you know characters in click tab and it
will extend it out into a code snippet
of what you want already so let me just
give you a brief example
if we wanted in this html document you
can see visual studio code has
identified in the bottom right
that this is an html document
so if i type h2
it's going to
pull up this box that says emit
abbreviation
and you can
click it to see what it's going to
abbreviate to
but really all you have to do is click
tab and it's going to extend it out into
the element that you want
and you can just start typing
similarly we can actually get this
entire html boiler plate
in just a few keystrokes so if you type
html
and we have a couple options here and
you can go through and see exactly what
it's going to create so basic html will
just give you the the main tag we we
want something a little better than that
oops i already did it on accident
the html5
let's let's go ahead and see
what html5 gives us
it's going to give us pretty much
everything we want here just like we saw
earlier
and then finally html xml
this is not something that you're
probably going to use very often so if
we just click html5 or scroll to it with
our arrow keys and press tab
it's going to break us out into this
boilerplate which is very similar to
what we were set up with when we
downloaded the starter files for our
front end mentor challenge so that's
just a handy way to create this and then
of course you can change the title
i don't think there's a link tag for the
favicon
setup by default but you've got all the
meta tags that are necessary
and you're all set as we go through this
challenge i'm going to be using those
emmett snippets and i'll try to mention
it as we go along but
just know that that's going on
for now i'll delete the test file we
don't need that any longer and now let
me show you our workflow so what we
could do is just write some html so h2
tab and then sum title that's just basic
html and click save and then we can alt
tab or switch back to the browser
open up the tab that we have it on and
click refresh and you'll see the new
html document
this would be very cumbersome and it's
not a great way to make
everything fast so
what we're going to do is we're going to
split the screens here
and i'm going to put the visual studio
code on the left
and the testimonial challenge on the
right now obviously we don't have a lot
of room here so you can always click
this right here to collapse that
might make this a little bit smaller for
us
and then when we're working with our dev
tools we'll click inspect we're in
chrome right now you can use firefox as
well if you want
since we've got these side by side i'm
going to actually re-dock all of this
stuff to be at the bottom
so i can do that let me remember where i
can do that
let's click
there we go you click these three little
dots and click this dock to bottom
so now
we have a much wider screen to work with
and as you resize this in the top right
corner you can see what screen size you
have
or you can click the toggle device
toolbar and now we can see it more
explicitly
where we can resize the screen up here
so this is probably going to be the
better option for us
and we can change the zoom to let's say
be 75 percent so that we can see it a
little bit better
and let me zoom out just a tiny bit we
don't need the javascript console
because we're not working with
javascript so we can close that drawer
and now all we have is the elements here
on the left so the html and then the
styles on the right or the css
and if we click this select an element
button and we select that h2
we can locate it within the html
document and then see the relevant
styles down here
so that's going to be our workflow and
as we go through this we can you know
just add new elements
some text click save come over here and
click refresh and now you see it's been
added to the document now there's just
one more thing that i want to do and
it's just going to make this whole
workflow just a little bit nicer we're
going to come into the extensions piece
let me just expand this out for us
we'll go to the extensions
tab within visual studio code
and let's type in live server
now live server is a way that we can get
automatic updates every time we click
save on our html and css documents
so let's install this
it's very easy to install
extensions in visual studio code
so you can see it's installed i think
that's all we need to do so this is just
another tab that's been opened up let's
close it we don't need it
we'll close this out
as well
and then all we have to do to get this
live server working is come down to the
bottom right
of our screen and click the go live
and it's going to pop up a security box
you need to allow access and now what
you'll see is that we've got a different
address this is actually
we'll get into this a lot more later in
the series but 127.0.0.1
that's our localhost and then 5501 is
the port that we're serving it on and
we're serving the index.html document
now if we put these next to each other
close this out and add another you know
piece of text so
more text
and once we click save
you'll see that it immediately gets
updated here in the browser
that's going to be incredibly handy for
us we don't have to go back and forth
clicking refresh every time and it's
also really nice because instead of you
know going to your file folder and right
clicking
and opening with a browser you can just
do it directly from visual studio code i
know that was a very long kind of
introduction to get us started working
on this project but
um as i've been trying to do within this
full stack series is just take you
through every single step so we're not
leaving anything out we're going through
absolutely everything
and that's why
i wanted to show you the extensions the
emmett abbreviations the favicons the
meta tags all of these little details
because as i was learning i always
wondered about them and oftentimes
tutorials would just skip right over
them but
we are finally ready to start the actual
challenge and start building that
testimonials grid very first thing i'm
going to do and this is what you should
always do is link up your css document
if i open the file explorer you'll see
that there is no css available to us yet
because we haven't created it
so go ahead and right click create a new
file
call it styles.css
or whatever you want it doesn't really
matter
this is just a convention
once you have styles.css
let's just go ahead and put in a basic
style so
we'll use the wildcard that selects all
elements and we'll give it a color of
red
the reason we do this is just to you
know verify that everything is working
correctly
when we click save you'll notice nothing
happens here and the reason nothing
happens is not because our live server
is not working it's because we haven't
told the index.html document
that we need to grab that stylesheet
so let's use an emmet abbreviation we'll
type link and you can see all sorts of
different links that you can use and if
we go down to css click tab you'll see
that we have a
css link set up for us
and since we are in the same directory
so index.html and styles.css are in the
same directory
we can just use
this exactly so it's saying style.css
and just to stay with convention i i
actually think it should be styled not
styles
let's just rename it to style.css over
here and then save the html document
you'll see that immediately
the text color updated to be read so we
know that our link to our style.css is
working if you put in you know something
like
styles.css and click save not going to
work anymore so that's that's what's
going on there with that link tag and
for those of you who have been following
along with the series if we come to
codepen
what we just did there was we
hooked up the css in the html by default
when you're in codepen you can just type
html and type css and they work together
but when you're not working in codepen
which honestly most of the time as a
developer you won't be
you have to actually come in and link
them up with the link tag
all right so let's get started here on
the layout
we'll close the file pane for just a
second and
if you look at the desktop design you'll
see that we'll have to kind of flip back
and forth or what we can do is we can
split these editors so i believe we can
split down
and now we can close this top one and we
have the index.html at the top
and our desktop design
at the bottom it's kind of small but it
will at least give us
a general feeling for what kind of
layout we need
if you're like me and get kind of
annoyed with all this text flowing off
the screen just click view toggle word
wrap and then everything wraps to our
view i kind of like that so
we'll go with that and to start us off
let's see what we're dealing with here
with the grid so the first step to
solving any html and css challenge
or just building a web app in general
is to get the layout correct and we saw
that in previous lessons and challenges
that we did where we just put a border
on each of our div containers and then
we did the layout and then we filled in
all the content and styles so we're
going to do the exact same thing here
and you'll see it's not going to be all
that complicated now the most obvious
place to start if we make this little
bigger we have one two three four five
containers
and they all have slightly different
styles
it looks like the two white containers
here
may have the exact same style but for
now let's just give them all a unique id
so that we can
select them with css a little bit easier
so to do that
with emit abbreviations you can actually
just type the hashtag and then whatever
id you want to give it i'm just going to
number these so we'll say testimonial
dash 1
and then click tab
and you see what it does is it gives an
id attribute on a div so that's what by
default if you
use the emit abbreviations to put a
hashtag and then type something or if
you put a dot and then type something
and press tab it will give you a class
so that's just a quick shortcut
so we'll go through and we'll do the
same thing here so we'll say
testimonial
dash two
and then another useful thing in visual
studio code if you go to the end of a
line click control c
to copy and then control v it will just
paste them down so there's our five
and then we can come in here and give
this a three a four and a five so we now
have all of the containers that we need
when we click save everything's going to
disappear up here because we just have
empty div containers that's okay for now
the next thing that i'm looking at here
normally i just put a border on
everything and
make a layout but this is already kind
of a grid and we might as well start
filling in the colors as backgrounds so
that we can see what we're dealing with
and then additionally we probably need
to start looking at the mobile design
because we're doing this mobile first
so
i know it's going to clutter the screen
up a little but let's go ahead and open
up the mobile design in the bottom part
here
close this back out
and here you'll just see
that every card is going to be stacked
directly on top of each other
but they're going to look relatively
similar so here's the desktop
here's the mobile
it looks like on the mobile design
the cards themselves for the the grid
items or testimonials
are going to be
the height of the content so
the items with more content are going to
be taller than the ones with less
so probably the best way
to lay this out at the beginning
is to just grab some of this content and
put a background on there and just start
getting the structure of everything so
let me pull this down i know that's
really small but we'll work with it
and here in testimonial number one i'm
just going to put a small amount of
content because i don't want our html
document getting super busy with a bunch
of text yet because that'll kind of
that'll take away from
the concepts we're trying to learn here
so
let's go to the placeholder text
and maybe we'll just grab this
really short line of text
and we'll put that in a paragraph tag so
we'll just copy it there
and click save
we still have red text i don't really
want that so let's replace this
all selector instead of color red we'll
do
box sizing
border box because that's our
basic css reset that we want to do we
want to set all box sizing to border box
so now we got the right text and all of
our box sizing is good let's resize the
screen so that we actually have the
browser on the right mimicking a mobile
device
so this isn't perfect i don't know you
know this is probably not exactly a
mobile device
let's make it even a little bit smaller
it gives us more room to type anyways
but this is close enough and this is
what we're going to
build our mobile design off of
as we talked about in the responsive
design video
576 pixels is kind of our standard
um mobile device so anything 576 or
below is going to be considered mobile
so that's roughly what we're looking at
here and if you
right click and inspect
and then you click this little icon
right here to get the full screen
you should be able to see
exactly how wide it is so if we just
typed window dot inner with
we're at 584 so if we wanted to hit that
576 number or a little bit lower it'd be
right about here so we'll keep the
screen size right here for now and then
as we
uh go up to the desktop
design we'll make it a little bit wider
i'm going to copy this same text just so
that we have something
into each of these additional
testimonial
divs
and now we're going to have some text to
work with
and then let's look at these colors here
so how do we know what colors to use
well
we have some starter files and if we go
to the style guide dot md
it's going to give you layouts and then
colors right here so this is where we're
going to find the colors that we need so
if we come down to the colors we see all
of them listed in hsl format
and you can use that in css but i just
it's not my preferred way of doing it
and honestly i haven't seen a whole lot
of developers that use hsl
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
convert these to hex codes
and that way we can work with what i'm
comfortable with and probably what
you'll see more often just as a reminder
this is how i'm doing it i just typed in
rgb to hex and then you get this
tool that google has and you can just
basically come in here
grab an hsl value
paste it into this box here and then
copy the hex code and replace it here so
that's all i'm doing
alright i've got these all replaced here
so we've got hex values a little bit
more comfortable for most people to be
using
and we've got a couple notes on the text
colors but i think these are mostly
related to the text itself so we'll get
there a little bit later i'm going to
drag the style guide down to this bottom
portion of our
visual studio code screen just so we can
have it as a reference
now it looks like the background of the
entire screen is going to be a light
gray
so we'll start with that if we go to our
style.css
in addition to the box sizing we also
want to set margin 0 and padding 0 on
everything
just so we don't have any unintended
side effects so when we click save
you'll see that everything
gets smooshed together because we just
excluded the margin in padding that's by
default set on a paragraph element in
the browser
and now we'll come down here and we'll
say on the body we want the background
color
to be
i believe the light gray
or the light grayish blue we'll see
which one looks more similar
so there's the light gray that is
definitely too dark
and there is the light grayish blue
which i think
that does match if my eyes are not
playing tricks on me
i think the background here uh matches
pretty well so i think we got that right
so we got the background covered and now
we can start filling out our containers
themselves
so each of them again has an individual
id
let's template those out so testimonial
one
and then we can copy this
5 times
we may not need all of these but we'll
just have them out here for the start
or actually of course we'll need all of
these they're all different colors so
the first one is this purple
the purple card here so we need to grab
that color from the style guide
i believe the moderate violet is what
we're looking for
so we'll come up to testimonial one
and give it a background
color
of that
and now you'll when we click save you
should see that background color
now the next one that we're looking for
is it looks like kind of a darkish gray
so
very dark grayish blue
i think that's the one that we want so
we'll come to testimonial 2
and do the same thing
and then for the rest of these i don't
want to waste your time i'm just going
to go and kind of guess and check until
i get the background colors correct on
each one of these
pieces to this grid but the one thing i
will say before i speed through this is
the numbering of these so we've got them
numbered one through five but you may be
wondering
which is one and which is five
um four
reasons that you will find out later as
we design this with flexbox
um this top one will be one then two
three
four and then the one on the right is
going to be the fifth one so just know
that as i'm going through and styling
the backgrounds on each of them
alright i've got all the background
colors filled in here
and as you'll see in this mobile design
that we're trying to make there's some
room between the edge of the screen and
these items within
the grid and what we're going to do to
create that is we're going to actually
wrap
all of these items in one big container
and then we're going to set some padding
on that container to bring all of them
inwards a little bit so we'll go to the
index.html to do that
and right now all of these divs are just
sitting within the body
but we're going to say
we want to create a
id
of testimonial
grid
container we'll just be very specific
with it
grab the closing div
down here
and paste it in so now we want to select
this testimonial grid container
and put this in our styles
so
hashtag grab the id
and now we want to set some padding
you can either set it in percentage or
pixels
for this since we're going to be making
it responsive
i'm going to start with a percentage so
usually about two percent works pretty
well
you can see that you get a little bit of
padding there
but of course when we look at the
the mobile design and make this bigger
there's a little more padding on the top
than there is on the sides
so we can actually use
the shorthand padding property
to say we want 2 percent
and then maybe five percent and we'll
save that and actually got that wrong so
the top and bottom is going to be the
first argument and then the left and
right will be the second
let's bump that up to three
see what we got this looks pretty good
so i'll stay with this i'm i'm fairly
satisfied with the spacing that we have
here
something that is really bothering me
right now is the text color on these
darker
backgrounds
so before i
get too mad let's just go ahead and fill
that out so for the first one
we'll need a white
text color so
we'll throw that in there
and then we also will just copy this
down
for
testimonial two
we're good on three
good on five but we'll also need it on
four
and now you'll see that the text is
popping out a little bit better
but it's all crammed together so we need
to space things out just a little bit as
you see in the mobile design there's not
only a little bit of space around the
inner content of each
grid component but there's also some
space between each grid component on a
mobile device like this
a simple way to add the spacing between
them is to just set a margin bottom on
each of these
and this looks roughly around 20 pixels
give or take
so
instead of trying to set that on each of
these let's create a class selector that
grabs all of them
and what we could do is we could come
down here and
grab each of them
one at a time separated by commas but
that's going to get very tedious the
better way to do it is to come to the
html
and instead of trying to grab them all
by ids let's assign a class
to each of the grid items so we'll just
say grid
item
is going to be the class name
and then we can copy that down
into each of these divs and here's a
little shortcut within visual studio
code
if you find the spot that you want to go
in
and you hold down the alt key
it's different on mac but on windows
would be the alt key
and then you click in a different place
you'll see there's two cursors so we'll
click again and now there's three
cursors and then finally four
and what you can do is now we can type
all at once and paste in those class
the those classes that we just created
so there we go we've got class
of grid item in each of these grid items
and now we can come down
and just select that
and set a margin bottom of 20 pixels
so when we click save we've got a nice
amount of spacing between the items
furthermore another similar thing
between all the grid items if we look at
our styles here
is that the padding around the content
is the same on each of them
and it looks like
i'm not exactly sure but it might be
somewhere around 20 pixels as well so
we'll start with that and we can tweak
it as we go
so we'll set padding of 20 pixels click
save and now our boxes are looking a
whole lot better than they did a few
minutes ago
so we are far from done here with the
mobile design
but right around this point once i'm
like happy with the
general layout obviously the text isn't
right in here we're missing pieces but
once i'm
satisfied and it doesn't look like
completely terrible
then that's when i go to the desktop
design and start making it responsive
because i want to get the layout correct
before i start you know adding a bunch
of other things in so what we will do
here is we're going to shrink this
visual studio code window a little bit
close the editor so we have some more
space
and then make this browser window larger
so that we can use the chrome dev tools
and when we bring this down here i'm
going to click this button right here so
we can toggle the device toolbar
and now we have the ability to see this
at different sizes really quickly
without resizing the entire screen
so that'll be helpful as we you know we
can actually see the the width up here
updating live so that'll be really
helpful as we resize on different
devices and design for that
so here's about our mobile design if you
just click this bar
you can get a small mobile device you
can click here for medium and here for a
large mobile device
so here's here's the large mobile device
and the reason it shrunk is because
we're at 40 percent
so let's go to maybe 75 you can see it a
little bit better
and then as we resize this we're getting
into the larger desktop devices
i know i've mentioned um about 576
pixels for the break point we're going
to use
and again that is because
earlier in this course when we talked
about responsive design i just said
let's go ahead and use the bootstrap
css framework breakpoints
they're right here so they go from 576
768 992
in our case we've got two designs only
so we're only going to need a single
break point for this
now we just have to decide at what point
do we break
so if you just play around with this
design
and you just look at the text
right around so we're at 708 pixels wide
right now and this is getting a little
bit wide for my liking with this mobile
design over here
so i think 576
right about here is going to be just
about the widest we'll go for that
mobile design and that's going to be our
break point then
to set that break point we come over to
our css
we write at media for a media query and
since we're doing mobile
first design we'll set a min width
of
576 pixels
so now we open the brackets up and any
styles we put here are going to apply to
anything bigger than 576 so all of this
right here and before we get too far
let's go ahead and test it this is
really important as you're coding
whether it's html css javascript or
anything else
do it incrementally don't just write a
bunch of code and then test it out all
at the end
so let's test it out by targeting a p
tag and giving it
a color of red something obnoxious
and we'll click save
right now we're at 444 pixels so
we would not expect this style to apply
but as we go above 576 we would expect
all the text to turn red so
let's see if it does and it does so that
means that our media query is working
great
remember always put these media queries
at the bottom of your css
otherwise they may get overwritten by
other styles so our goal here before we
get any further is once we hit above 576
so when this is turning red and the
reason it's doing that is because i
haven't saved yet
but once we get above here we would
expect this layout to look
like this desktop design over here so
the question is how do we do that and
the way that we're going to solve this
is with flexbox i'm just going to expand
this
vs code so that we can really look at
the design here so as i look at this
just by experience alone
i'm thinking to myself that using
flexbox we're probably going to need to
split
these into sub containers now there's a
lot of different ways that you can do it
as always there's more than one way to
solve the problem but i'm going to
choose the most straightforward and
beginner friendly way of doing this
i'm thinking that there is probably a
way that we could take all four of these
items
on the left side
wrap those in a container and then
control the overflow of the container
with flex wrap and then size them
accordingly but i'm thinking that might
get a little bit complex to try to
implement and by adding just one extra
container we can avoid all of that
so what i'm thinking
is that we split the overall layout into
two containers
so the first container is going to be
all four of these items right here
and the second container will be this
item on the right by doing this we can
take container one on the left
and container two on the right and we
can display
flex and they will go side by side next
to each other but that doesn't solve how
we lay out these items on the left so
what i would want to do
within those containers so so remember
we have one container on the left one on
the right and then the left container we
can further divide into two other
containers so we'll have a top
and a bottom container
and in each of those we will display
flex so that they sit next to each other
and then we can use flex basis to
make the dimensions of each of these
a little bit different i know this is a
little abstract so let me just show you
exactly what i mean so we'll keep that
down here
and this all happens within the html
itself so to take these four items on
the left and wrap them in a container
we just need to find them so here
are the first four and all we have to do
is go at the top of here
and set a container now we have to
decide what to name it so that we can
target it with css naming things is
always difficult i'm not going to over
complicate it here we're just going to
call it main left and make that div
and then
within main left like i said we're going
to have a top part and a bottom part
there's a couple ways i could do this
but once again i'll go very simple and
i'll just say top
and then we'll name the other one bottom
so at this point i've got everything
laid out correctly so we want to grab
items one and two
so this one and this one and put it in
that uh top container right here
so we'll do that
we'll just cut these away here put them
there
and then in the bottom
we will take
items three and four
and put them there
now finally we have
testimonial five and i said we're going
to make a separate container for that
but lucky enough we've already wrapped
our entire grid within the testimonial
grid container
and if you think about this from a
flexbox perspective we always have to
think container and direct children
doesn't matter the
you know grandchildren or
great-grandchildren those don't apply in
flexbox so all we have to know is what
is the parent
and what direct children does that
parent have
this testimonial grid container
has exactly two direct children it has
the main left
and then it has the testimonial five
which is that you know this tall card
here on the right
so now that we've got this laid out
let's save it
and i will now bring this back to the
left side of the screen so we can look
at it again
and you'll see that on the mobile device
you know nothing has changed here we've
put all these containers but since we
haven't selected them with css
there's really no change to the overall
layout quite yet
but now this is where the real magic is
going to happen and what we could do is
um since we're devi
we're now designing for the desktop we
did mobile first with all these styles
now we're doing desktop within the media
query but again remember you don't have
to put everything within that media
query there can be some shared css
properties between mobile and desktop
designs so the first style i'll add
is going to be the testimonial grid
container we want to do work from the
outside in so we'll go to style.css
and we'll put that into our media query
and the only thing we need to do here
for the moment is write display flex
and when we click save you'll see
nothing happens here because we're still
looking at the mobile device but as we
make this larger
now you see that this
the
left the main left container with all
four of those items go left and then the
last item testimonial five will be
pushed off to the right because we've
displayed them on the main axis which is
horizontal now if you look at this
design
obviously this testimonial 5 has much
less width
than the rest so we can set that with
flex
and i suppose it's probably about
it looks like
20 to 25 percent of the total width so
let's come to our style.css
and on each item
we can set the flex basis so in this
case we're going to want to grab
testimonial 5
and target that with our id selector
and then we'll say the flex basis for
that we'll start with
and see what that looks like
okay that's a little bit small i'm
thinking that we'll need maybe 25
i like that a little bit better and we
can always tweak it as we go
the next thing we have to do is look at
these four items on the left and they
obviously the top two go next to each
other and the bottom two go next to each
other as well
therefore we need to make the top a flex
container in the bottom a flex container
so you'll see the id is top and bottom
so all we need to do
is come over here and say top
display flex
and then
bottom
display
flex
but we have a little bit of a problem
here because
they're not taking up the whole
height of that main container so if we
go to the index.html
we have the main left container
and we want this right testimonial 5 to
be
equal in height to these other
testimonials
to do this we need to also turn the main
left container
into a flex container so
we'll go right here
and display flex
and this is not going to look right for
a second
because when we do that it puts
everything in a row but if we change the
flex direction of the main left to be
column now it's going to go back
and look the same but now we have
control using flexbox of how those are
distributed so if we look at this main
left container which its direct children
are going to be the top and the bottom
which are also flex containers
we can distribute those using the
justify content since we set the flex
direction to column the main axis is
going to be going vertical and therefore
justify content allows us to align on
the main axis
we also have the ability to
say how large we want these using flex
bases so
while top and bottom are flex containers
in relation to their
children html elements
they are flex items in relation to the
main left container
so if we come down and set the flex
basis
to
um
we'll start with 50
on each of them and then i'll show you
why that's not going to work perfectly
so we'll save that
and now you see that we have these
filling up the total height of that main
left container and i was actually wrong
the flex basis of 50 works just fine
because in the mobile version we set the
padding or we set the margin bottom of
20 pixels so there's already some space
between we'll obviously have to space
out
horizontally but we'll do that in just a
bit now the next question we have to ask
is how do we get these proportions
correct with these
four
containers
to do that we can work directly with the
top and bottom
and we can use the
flex basis of their children items to do
that
so all we have to do is grab
let's see exactly how we need to do this
it looks like these are a complete
mirror of each other so this first one
and the fourth one are about equal
proportion and the second and the third
one are equal proportion
so we know that our percentages are
gonna work pretty much the same
so to do this we're gonna need to grab
testimonial one through four
and put them down in our media query
which is our desktop design
so if we put these at the bottom
remember in our desktop design these are
considered flex items
we can go ahead and get rid of these two
properties because they're already
defined in our mobile version which also
applies to the
desktop as long as we don't override
them so we can get rid of all those
but now we can set a flex basis
so the first one this purple one
looks like it's got about 75 percent of
the width
so we'll go with 75 percent
and then that means testimonial 2 is
going to have a flex basis of 25 because
we want to fill up the whole
width of that container
and testimonial 3 is going to have a
flex basis of also 25
and then a flex basis of 75 percent for
that last one so when we click save you
should see the proportions update uh
pretty nicely here as we compare this
design right here to
our
desktop design
picture
you'll probably notice that it looks a
little bit wider overall and you'll see
that there's more room around the entire
container so
let's just fix that so that we are not
thrown off by these proportions in the
way that we'll do that i believe we can
just add some
we can add a max width
to the entire container so let's look at
our index.html
and our testimonial grid container is
probably what we're going to want to
select
and we've already got that selected in
the media query so on a larger device
maybe we set the max width of let's say
[Music]
looks like this might be like 600 pixels
that's just a rough guess
so that's a little bit narrow so maybe
we'll set the
max width to say
700 maybe
that looks a little bit better
let's go up to 750.
i think that's kind of in the ballpark
and then to center this we could use
like flexbox but honestly the easier way
is this little trick where you set a
margin
of zero pixels top and bottom and then
left and right you give it auto so it's
gonna automatically give the margin to
center it
so when we click save you'll see it all
goes to the middle and now we're
starting to see a little bit
more proportioned grid here now at this
point i think
this is a little bit small the
proportion we've given to that right one
so let's change the flex basis of
testimonial five to be
maybe something like 35 percent
and then of course we need to set
the left one to be the same
so we need to set the flex basis on the
main left which is all four of these
items together
we'll set this to about 70 percent i
think and then update this testimonial 5
to be 30
and i think that looks just a little bit
better for us
once we add some spacing here it should
look a lot a lot better so to finish
this off here the layout um it looks
like there's some spacing between each
of these items you know horizontally
and there's a few ways that we could do
this
actually i'm now thinking we might even
go like
65 here
and now we have these ones
which are squished a little bit
so maybe we need to update this
container
give it a bigger max width then we'll
change the 75 25 at this point i'm just
like adjusting things until we get
generally the right fit so let's try
maybe like a 70
30.
that looks slightly better but i still
think we can go a little bit more so 65
there we go i think this looks
relatively good and then now that we've
adjusted this this looks a little bit
too big so we'll claw this one back to
and 30.
and i think we're looking good here i
think the proportions between
this and our design is relatively good
and then of course this bottom one we
need to match the top so
we'll just come down and do that real
quick
so
65 35 so this one needs to be updated to
and 65 and now our grid
is looking really good
now to get the spacing horizontally
you'll see that there's these little
gutters here um so
right now we don't have any any spacing
horizontally
we could do this with margin um as we
kind of did vertically with that margin
but i'm going to try to apply our
flexbox skills to make this happen
which is a totally valid way to do it as
well so the first one we have to take
care of is the
main left container which surrounds all
four of these and then testimonial five
here on the right right now we have a
flex basis of thirty percent on this far
right and seventy percent on the main
left container so it's split in two
but if we
reduced those by a couple percentages
and then we aligned them with space
between them we could add that little
vertical gutter in there
so what i'll do is i'll take the main
left container and just bring it down to
say 68
so now we have about two percent
empty space within the container
so let's save that and you'll see
there's no there's no space because it's
kind of added at the end
it's kind of invisible here on the right
but if we come up to the testimonial
grid container
and what we do is we justify content
because remember
the main left with all four of those
items and the testimonial five on the
right
are aligned on a main axis which goes
horizontal because the flex direction is
set to row by default so justify content
allows us to
align those within there and all we have
to say is space between
and when we do that you'll see that
there's a little space added there
because we added some extra empty space
and then we
spaced them out between we can do the
same exact thing with these flex items
here too
so
the top flex container
the flex basis is 50
or actually i'm not doing this right so
the top and bottom are going to be the
flex containers so let's just set the
justify
content on here to be
[Music]
space between
to start off
all right and we'll save that and we
won't see any changes because currently
the flex basis equals a hundred percent
so there's no space to add between
but if we reduce
we'll just reduce testimonial one to
sixty three percent so we have two
percent left over
once again and we'll save it and now we
have that little space of two percent
added in there as well now of course two
percent on a large container versus two
percent on
a much smaller container is going to
equal a different pixel width so as you
see in the design
the little gutter here between this
testimonial five on the right and all
four of these on the left
that vertical gutter is a little bit
wider than the vertical gutters that we
just added to
these containers right here so you see
how to do it with flexbox if you're okay
with that fact then you can just leave
it as we have it
but what i'm going to do just for
demonstration purposes is i'm going to
undo everything that we just did
so we'll set everything back to their
original percentages we'll remove the
justify contents
and save it and now we're back to this
place where we have no space between
and a really simple way that we could do
this is we could just look at all of the
flex items or all of the grid items here
on the left we can just add a margin to
the right of say 20 pixels and it will
be equal across the board so if we look
at our index.html
we have all of these individual items
with a class of grid item
but we don't want to add the margin
right to this last testimonial so one
way that we could do that
is we could look at the main left
container which has these four items and
then we can select all descendants
with a class of grid item so it only
selects those four
so i'll show you what i mean here
um i guess we'll
we'll put this up here right under main
left and we'll say main left is the
parent that we want to look at and then
we want to grab all grid item
descendants of that
and now what we can do let me just show
you what we're selecting first so we'll
set a color of red so that the text
turns red and we'll click save
and now you can see all of these left 4
grid items have red text but we've
excluded the right one with the css
selector
that's exactly what we want
so we'll add a margin to the right of 20
pixels and you're going to see that this
just gets spaced out really nicely
automatically and that is
it's a little little much maybe let's go
with 15 pixels
and that is exactly how we would add
that spacing on the right naturally and
now it's equal between all of them
at this point
the overall structure of our grid
looks very good and now that i'm looking
at it one more time
it seems that this right one is still a
little bit too wide
and i apologize for going back and forth
here
trying to teach and uh
and see how to do this at the same time
so it's a little bit tough
so let's let's bring this back to 25 on
testimonial 5 and 75 on the main left
container
i think this looks
good and i really hope i don't change my
mind on that again
i might but as of right now this looks
very similar
and the cool thing is if we resize this
down to mobile so once we hit 576 pixels
it should break and boom we have our
mobile design so we don't have to update
anything on the mobile side of things we
just made this desktop design and it's
pretty much responsive
now the one thing you'll notice um is as
we shrink it these get shrunk a little
bit so it may not look perfect say on
like a tablet but it should work okay
you could always add an additional
breakpoint
if you wanted to to adjust those flex
basis numbers that it looks better on
tablet but i'm not going to worry about
that here because
i think it would just be distracting
from the main lessons
all right so we have got our layout done
it is responsive and now we should be
able to just go in
and look at this entire design here and
start adding in all these components and
styling them out before we do that
though i'd like to clean up our css a
little bit because
at the moment we are
duplicating a lot of our css rules so
this is what we would call kind of
refactoring so you write the code out
you don't really worry about doing it
perfectly the first time but then you
kind of edit and you you know iterate on
it and make it a little bit cleaner so
what you'll see is we've written this
rule of display flex
several different times so what we can
do is we can take all of these
ids where we're writing that display
flex and put it into one single css rule
some might say this is not worth doing
but i think it is it's nice to
nice to break out our code a little bit
so we want to select our testimonial
grid container and display flex
let me just write the rule first and
then of course we want to select
more than just the testimonial grid so
what else uses flex we have the main
left so we'll copy that in there
so main left
top and bottom
so those are all going to display flex
and now we can get rid of all of those
individual rules on each of them
click save it should look the same
down here we have these four
flex items all set with flex basis
percentages that are very similar so
let's group this together let's take
testimonial three
combine it with that rule and delete all
of this
and we'll take testimonial four
combine it with that rule
and delete this last one
save it should get the same thing top
and bottom now both have a flex basis of
fifty percent and that's the only rule
so we don't need them broken out
separately
we can just bring those together and
delete that rule
click save should be the same and then
i'm going to take all of our flex rules
and just kind of group them together
here
so let me
let me just put those here okay so now
we have all of our css grouped up a
little bit
better and we can start working on
adding the content i'm going to shrink
this screen
and we'll go ahead and close the dev
tools
and we'll just work on this first on the
mobile design so we have some more
screen real estate and then we'll
check it on desktop to make sure
everything is working so we'll open up
our file explorer and index.html
along with our placeholder text because
this is what we're going to actually be
putting in
to all of these containers and i'm just
going to look at the desktop design i
know we're doing mobile over here but
it's just bigger so we can see it better
i'll go through the first one with you
and then the rest of them are going to
be pretty much exactly the same so i'll
let you do those on your own and i'll
just speed through it so with this first
card right here now we have this big
quotation we're going to worry about
that totally last we're not going to
worry about that yet
the content itself it looks like we have
a picture we have a name
we have
this says verified graduate so they're
the status of that person
and then we have the main testimonial
and
the secondary testimonial so just
looking at this immediately we need an
image tag we need a paragraph tag
another paragraph tag looks like maybe
an h4 tag and then another paragraph tag
so let's get the picture first this
first one is daniel clifford so we're
going to need that image
and that's been provided to us if we go
to images folder
you should see
imagedaniel.jpg
so we can finally start to to replace
this so we're on testimonial one right
here
and we're first going to put in an image
so we'll use the emit abbreviation click
tab
and the source that we want is going to
be
the relative path
and then we'll say images and then we
want image dash daniel
and then the alt
attribute this is for accessibility you
should always put this in here so
daniel daniel profile picture just a
description of what that is
click save you'll see this image come in
to our first
grid item we now need to write in his
name and verified graduate so
let's do that we'll just use a p tag so
daniel
clifford
verified graduate
there we go we've got those added in
there
now we have to go find the text so it
says i received a job offer mid-course
okay so there's our daniel so here's our
first piece of text
we'll put that in the p tag right here
so there's that text and then finally
we'll just want one more p tag and
actually no this will not be p tag let's
just set that as an h4
i think that's roughly what we would
want here
that looks okay we can always switch it
later
then finally we have this last
piece of text so this is the longer
testimonial that we'll put in the p tag
right here
all sorts of formatting issues so i'm
just gonna
get this all on one line here it doesn't
really matter but
i'm gonna just do this anyway
okay so we've got our first card done
and like i said you can go through and
figure out how to do the rest of them
it's the same exact pattern for each of
the different
testimonial cards so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to just take this entire
structure
and i'm going to come down and replace
each item with it when we click save
you'll see that it's all looking the
same and then now we can just switch the
individual parts
so the second testimonial if we open up
the desktop design it's going to be
jonathan
so
based on the image names here
we have image jonathan
so we really can just come into the
find the second one here so testimonial
to
replace the link here
click save now we have jonathan in here
and then you just update the rest of the
text so i'm going to speed through this
and i'll see you when i'm done
all right we are done and you can see
that i've got all of the
text and images in here
now it's just a matter of styling these
if you look at the main design
they're all about the same so we have
the image in a circle on the left with
the name and the verified graduate right
under it and then the actual testimonial
below
so it makes no sense to try to target
each of these individually we'll just
set a
common class among all of them and then
style it one time let's start with the
image and the name to the right of the
image
the first thing that we need to do
because how i see this is we've got the
image on the left and then the name and
verified graduate stacked on top of each
other
so
to get those next to each other a great
way to do it is flexbox so the image
will be flex item number one and then
we'll make a container around the name
in the verified graduate which will be
flex item number two
to do that we just come to the html
we'll go to the first one here
and we'll come right above the image and
what should we name this
we'll just call it
a class of header
and then within header we're going to
have the image and then another
container with the other text
so i'm going to call
that container
header text
okay
so now all we have to do is drop in the
image up top
and then these two p tags
in this container down here i'm going to
split our style.css to the right here in
visual studio code so we can see both
and as we look at the header in the
header text we can come down
since this applies to both mobile and
desktop
we'll just write it up in the mobile
first section where it applies to pretty
much any everything
and we'll just put at the bottom
we want to target header
which is going to be display flex
automatically when we click save you're
going to see it jumps on the to the
correct line
and then these are lined up so if you
look at this the picture and the text
they're like on the same horizontal
axis
so the way that we get that to happen is
align items so we're aligning items on
the cross axis
to be center
so now that's going to work
and then of course we need to grab the
image so
from the header container we want to
grab all images
and we want the border radius to be it's
just a trick to make circular pictures
we want that to be 50 percent
so you see now we have a circle
picture
and then we want the margin
right to be let's call it 5 pixels
actually that's not enough so let's do
10 pixels
now you can see there's a little space
between those
lastly we need some space under this
header container so we'll come back up
to header
set a margin bottom of maybe 20 pixels
and that will space us out from this top
header container to the text under it
now of course this has not applied to
the rest of the testimonials but we will
follow the same exact process
as long as we keep the same class on
them these css styles should apply just
fine so i'm going to speed through this
so you don't have to watch me do it um
completely i'm just going to go and
create this exact structure uh below for
each of them and probably should have
done this the first time around but
whatever we'll we'll get through it okay
so i got that done and that's kind of a
good lesson there you usually want to
finish like one iteration so one card
um get it all correct and then apply the
styles to the rest i didn't do that so i
had to pay for it with some extra time
the next thing i'm going to do is space
out these two pieces of text so the
first one is in h4 the second one is a
paragraph tag
so we can select that with our our
styles pretty easily
all we have to do is look at any
grid item class and select the h4s and
add a margin bottom
so we'll say grid
item
h4
and we'll set a margin bottom of 20
pixels maybe
i think that looks okay
so 20 pixels yeah it looks pretty good
we're getting close to the finish line
here
the next thing you'll notice is there's
rounded corners on each of these cards
that'll be pretty easy to apply
so let's go find our grid item style
which selects all the grid items
and we'll set a border radius of around
5 pixels maybe
that'll make those rounded corners so
that looks good
there's also a little bit of a drop
shadow on each of these
or at least the white ones but we'll
just go ahead and put it on
each of them just for simplicity
so any grid item is going to get a box
shadow
you can go to a box shadow tool online
this is just the standard that i always
put in there
is a black color with 20 opacity
and then i kind of tweak these
values right here until i get roughly
what i want
so you can see there's a little box
shadow there i might spread this out a
little bit more
it's not exactly what we're looking for
but it is it's pretty close and i'm not
too concerned about getting this
verbatim to the design the next big
piece to this is the font so
in the style guide
if we go here to the style guide it's
going to tell you what font you need to
use
so for typography the body copy is 13
pixels
we haven't set that yet
um actually let's let's do that really
quick so for grid items
you could set this at multiple levels
but for grid items
we'll set the font size to be
13 pixels
makes it a lot smaller here for us
and then for grid item h4s
we'll set the font size back up so we'll
say maybe 1.2 rem
so that's
the root element is going to be
[Music]
the html which i believe is set default
to 16 pixels
so that will make it a much bigger
text
and i think that looks relatively good
decent proportions there so i'm okay
with that
and now we have to actually change the
font itself
so in the style guide
it says that we need the barlow
semi-condensed font from google fonts
i happen to have this open already let
me expand the screen
and all you have to do is select the
styles that you want
so we will do that and it looks like we
need 500 and 600 font weights
so we will go grab
medium which is 500
and 600 which is semi bold
now it's saying that we just need to put
this link in our html document so we'll
copy that
should be good on this so let me
resize the screen real quick and now all
we need to do with this is put it into
our html
so we put this in the head
and we can put it right by our style
sheet link
so i think usually
you're supposed to put this after your
stylesheet so that this applies i'm not
entirely certain if that is
that matters a ton let's save it
by default it's not going to be using it
because we haven't enabled it
so we'll have to come back to our
styles.css
and in the body
this might be where we put the font
family
and this is where we'll go to the rules
here and we can just paste in the css
rule actually
so we'll be using barlow semicondensed
with a fallback of sans serif
save that and you can see all the font
is is looking a lot closer to our demo
here
you'll notice that these white cards
have a gray text rather than the black
text we're giving it so let's update
that
i believe we have a rule for this
already
so we can actually condense testimonial
five and three
into one because they have the same
styles
and then the font color that we need if
we go to the style guide
is probably this light gray i'm thinking
nope that's a little too light
so we'll try the dark grayish blue
and i think that's a little bit closer
may not be exact but i'm i'm thinking
it's close enough it's it's better than
the black that we had before
now the
smaller text has a little bit less
opacity than the main text
and then we also need to send the set
the font weight so let's look at the
style guide
it says for the typography or
note for the text colors the verified
graduate okay we're not ready for that
yet
review paragraphs inside quotes have the
same color but are 70 percent opacity
so
in our design here we have a couple
different p tags so we have the name
verified graduate and then the
testimonial down here
so if we just
set the
font weight of a p tag and the opacity
of a p tag
for all of them that will
apply to mostly what we want because we
want
this testimonial to have 70 opacity and
probably verified graduate as well
and then we can specifically override
that opacity style to be a hundred
percent for the name uh later so let's
let's go ahead and do that
so we'll see if we have something for
this already
so we have grid item so
we'll just set the
grid item p tags so any
any p tag within the grid item we want
to set the opacity to
70 percent
and then for the name
let's just add a class so we can use the
alt key to
come into all of the p tags with the
name
just holding down alt
and we can give it a class name
and then we can come down into the name
selector and give it an opacity of 100
maybe not the most effective solution
but it works
and we probably need to select it with
header to be more specific
than our grid item p
because header and name
that's two class selectors is more
specific than grid item
p which is a class and a tag selector so
this one takes precedence and we'll
override it
now i think we just need to
tweak a few things with the text here
not a whole lot we might want to make
the name just slightly larger than that
default
13 pixels
so we can come to that rule that we just
created
so the name
and we'll say the font size is going to
be
[Music]
1.1 rem
actually that's going to be way too
large
um
how about one rem so 16 pixels
that looks better if you open this up
you might see a little border around
these pictures too
so while we're here
we can look at the header image and we
can give it a border of one pixel
solid maybe purple i think
some of them are different but let's
just go with purple on all of them
you can see that little
border that we have around there you can
tweak that how you like it lastly
i think the font weights look okay but
they did tell us to import
weights of 500 and 600 so
we should probably explicitly set those
so on the grid grid item h4s will give a
font weight
of 600
looks about the same so not a huge
change
for the most part i think i'm happy with
the design we have
it's not absolutely perfect but it's
pretty close and more importantly we've
gone through a lot of the concepts we've
covered in the previous videos which is
always fun to apply those leave a
comment if i missed anything i think the
only thing remaining is this big quote
up here and there's a couple ways you
could approach this
i do not believe there's any
assets for this like this is not an
image
actually it is so this is an svg
and we could use this svg
i don't want to get too far into
css and svgs it's like a whole other
topic but i'll go ahead and just quickly
put it in and show you how to do it so
what we can do is this background
pattern quotation svg if we click on it
it's just a bunch of numbers
but we can actually put this into an
image i believe
so if we come to our index.html
let me get this css collapsed a little
bit
and it's obviously on the main card the
purple card here so number one
we can pretty much put it wherever
we would like here within this main card
so let's make an image
and then the source is going to be
images and then background pattern
quotation
so now you see that quote is already in
there that's nice now we just need to
absolutely position this because it's in
that weird spot so it's like kind of
randomly up there in the top right
corner
let's give it an id so we'll give it the
quote id
and then we come over to our css
and we will select quote
and we'll say position
absolute and what that is going to do is
position it relative to i believe the
viewport by default
um let's see how that works so from the
right we want it to be 20 pixels roughly
okay yeah so it's relative to the
viewport we want it relative to this
container itself
so to do that we need to set the
testimonial one container
to be position relative and once we do
that that quote will come in correctly
come down to quote it should be probably
more like
30 pixels from the right and then from
the top
it is pretty much flush with the top so
we'll do zero
you can see that gets us a little bit
closer
um
and as we resize this it's obviously
going to
change that a little bit so maybe from
the right we go like
three percent i'm just going to
experiment around with this until we get
it right
maybe like seven percent
that's closer let's just ramp it up to
15. okay
i like that i think 15 is pretty good
and
like i said it's flush with the top so
that's good
and then finally
as we resize this i know this doesn't
look amazing we're just kind of in that
middle state where it's like
this is like bigger than a mobile device
but smaller than a tablet so you're
really not going to see this on any
device
for the most part so like here is about
where you're starting you're going to
start seeing it
and
it looks like the quote is like a little
bit above that text and in our actual
design here
it's showing it as behind the text like
overlapping that's partially because of
the spacing that we've given it so i'm
not overly concerned about it but as we
resize it and it does kind of overlap
text we want that to go behind
everything
so to do that we need to go to the
styles
we need to set the
z index
equal to like negative one
actually let's let's set this the index
to one
and then on the
[Music]
testimonial
one we will set the z index
to be
uh zero
so it's above the testimonial card
but then we want it to be below the
testimonial text so we'll set the z
index of the header to three
i think that might get us there maybe
not there we go we just need to set it
to position relative so that the z index
applies
and now
it should be going behind any text and
stuff like that so
should be good there
and i think our design is pretty much
complete so as you can see like we could
spend the next hour or two hours trying
to get this to look exactly like
the example here
just if you're curious i took a second
to try to figure this out fully
exactly how we can get it to look like
this and
didn't come all the way there but i did
get it
somewhat close
so
i put a max width of 1440 according to
the style guide here where it says the
desktop is 1440
and then i set the
testimonial five and main left
containers to eighty and twenty percent
respectively
so
this looks okay i think there's it's not
exact like i said but it's a little bit
closer
let me know in the comments if i missed
anything but as we resize this it should
be responsive we have this like middle
state where it's a little bit weird but
honestly trying to perfect that is just
going to be a lot of tedious tweaks that
you can kind of do on your own if you
want
but the main goal here has been
accomplished on desktop it looks like
this and on mobile it looks like this
where we have everything stacked on top
of each other
so now at this point we're going to take
this local host
that nobody can see
and we're going to deploy this to github
pages so that you can pass it off as a
link and show off your project
so the way that we'll do that let's
close out everything here
so we have a clean workspace
so what we can do is we can open up
source control this is embedded within
uh visual studio code
and what we can do is initialize a
repository and this can be done on the
command line too but i think we should
you know since we haven't learned git
yet
and i don't expect you to understand any
of this quite yet
might as well use the visual interface
so from here it's we initialize the
repository and
it says control enter to commit on
master
so we can write a message just say first
commit and then control enter
we're going to stage all our changes and
commit them directly yes
and i'm i'm actually set up with github
already so it may ask you to go through
some authorization where you have to
sign in to github so go ahead and do
that if you have to
now what we have to do is create a new
repository so on our github so if you
don't have an account sign up for github
you'll need it uh
for the rest of your developer life
click new repository
and we'll just say testimonial
grid
front end manner
challenge solution
very long
repository name you don't need to make
it that long
and we'll just create the repository
make it public
not too worried about
initializing all this stuff
now from here you're just going to copy
the
https link
come back to visual studio code
click these three dots
click remote
add remote
and then
we're going to put in that url
from there we should be good i think
we want to
push it to the main branch so let me see
what we're working with here
yep so we need to push to main
but this is just the name we're giving
it so origin we're just linking up our
code here to the github repository again
you don't need to understand this we're
just trying to get it deployed here so
um now we're going to click push
okay
then let's check it out here we'll
refresh
and you'll see that we have
all of these uh files that we just
created from visual studio code here on
our
repository right now we don't have it
deployed to github pages
the way that we can do that we can do it
here
or we can do it within visual studio
code but quite honestly doing it within
the repository is is relatively
straightforward since we already have
index.html in the main root of the
directory
so we'll go to master
find or create a branch and type github
pages
and it says create branch github pages
from master which is exactly what we
want to do this is master what we're
looking at right now
so we'll create that branch and now
let's go back to our main repository
and i believe it should publish this to
github pages in the next minute or two
it doesn't happen like instantaneously
because
what it's actually doing is
taking our code files and putting them
on github pages which is just another
server and then serving them over our
github url
let's refresh the page
looks like our environments has been set
up now so we can click
on the main repository we can click
github pages
and then view the deployment
and you can see that what we just
created is now live
in this link up here you can copy and
share with someone else
and as we resize it it of course is
going to resize to that mobile
mobilely responsive
width and then desktop responsive all
right that is the end of the front end
web development foundations course
it was a long one
i applaud anyone who got through every
minute of it
hope that you enjoyed it be sure to give
free code camp a like on this video and
subscribe to their channel
once again there is a link in the
description with some additional
resources
for each of the topics that i covered so
that if you want to take it to the next
level you can while this is a long
course 20 plus hours it's only the
beginning if you want to be good at
front end web development or even extend
yourself and get into full stack
development you're going to need to
practice there's going to be a lot more
learning to come but hopefully this
course gets you on the right foot it
gets you started in the right direction
on your career to becoming a web
developer i wish you the best of luck in
your journey
to stay connected with me i'm pretty
active on twitter at zg underscore dev
dev so feel free to connect with me
there i've also got a youtube channel of
my own would really appreciate
you hop over there and check out what
i've got on that channel so long and
happy coding